if you want to learn css this is the
course for you
dave gray teaches this comprehensive css
course for beginners we've already
published a popular html course from
dave and this course is a great next
step after you learn html hello and
welcome to over 11 hours of css
tutorials and instruction this video is
made up of 24 tutorials that build upon
each other much like the chapters of a
book
throughout the lessons in this video i
will mention links being available in
the description below i've compiled all
of these links into one github resource
that you will find in the description
hi i'm dave gray and i'm the creator of
these css tutorials you can subscribe to
my youtube channel for more tutorials
like this one you can also follow me on
twitter and if you're feeling generous
you can even buy me a cup of coffee a
quick thank you to boa free code camp
for sharing this video and to everyone
at free code camp for providing such an
outstanding resource that helps people
learn how to code for free it's truly my
honor to contribute this video let's get
started learning css with chapter one
what is css
css is an acronym that stands for
cascading style sheets so css is a style
sheet language that's used to describe
the presentation of a document it's most
known for being used with html although
it can be applied to other media like
you see here i've got xml spg mathml
xhtml and other things listed here for
on paper in speech other media but we
will be working with html now when we
think about the difference between html
and css consider html as the foundation
and structure so if you think about a
new building or a house that is being
built and you see that structure go up
that is the foundation that's everything
that holds it together however the css
is the
paint and the carpet and the wallpaper
or anything any decorations anything
that makes it look good so the structure
holds it all together it's the
foundation the css is really what makes
the appearance that actual presentation
of the building or in our case we're
working with documents okay now before
we start writing css let's get the tools
we need and first of all i will be using
the chrome browser in this course so you
can download chrome if you don't have it
from google.com slash chrome
and it should be available for every
platform and it will probably identify
what platform you have here as well
after that we're going to use an
integrated development environment
really a code editor and what we will
use is visual studio code so that is at
code.visualstudio.com it should also
recognize what platform you're on
already but if it doesn't you can click
other platforms and you can find it for
all the different platforms that we're
probably using okay go ahead and
download the version you need and if you
need chrome download that as well
install the software and then come back
to the video okay at this point i'm
going to assume you've got everything
downloaded and installed and now i've
got visual studio code open right here
you may have a welcome screen i closed
that out already but what you need to do
if you haven't already is create a
folder on your computer for your project
for this lesson you'll probably want to
create a new folder for each lesson or
at least build upon the lesson in the
same folder either way you need a folder
and the first thing we want to do is
create an index.html file because once
again
we will apply
our css to html
now if you're not familiar with image
shortcuts we can take an image shortcut
here to quickly create an html document
just type the
exclamation mark and press
enter
and now this gives us
a very basic html document and of course
it has a title just of document it has a
couple of meta tags up here you might
not have seen but they're handy to go
ahead and leave in the page for now what
we want to do is just put some content
so let's put a paragraph here and let's
say
i'm learning
css with an exclamation mark and save
and really that's all we need in our
html document right now now there are
three different ways to apply css to our
document there is an external style
sheet we could have an internal style
sheet or we could apply css inline with
an element let's look at each option and
i'll start out with the external style
sheet so i want to create a link element
here and i'll press tab and visual
studio code helps us out it already
gives us the rel attribute that says
it's a style sheet and we need to link
to a style sheet but we haven't created
one yet so over here in the file tree
let's create a new directory and name it
css
now inside the css directory let's go
ahead and create a new file named
style.css
and now we have our stylesheet file and
inside of this let's put a p for our
paragraph element a curly brace
now one return and we'll go ahead and
put a style here this will be a rule
actually or a declaration if you will
and let's just change the color of our
paragraph and let's make it purple and
end with a semicolon and save this is a
very very simple style sheet right now
and now back in our html we can go ahead
and link to that style sheet by putting
in the css directory and you can see
visual studio code wants to help us out
so we'll click on that and then it knows
the style.css is in there so we can
click on that
and now that should link
you may see
some older code that has a type
attribute here
but
mozilla now points out that this is no
longer required and is actually kind of
frowned upon so we do not want to
include that but you may see older code
with it it doesn't break the code if
it's there it's just
not the modern way of doing that so
there is our link to the style sheet and
now one thing we haven't done yet is add
the live server extension so if you
don't have that click on the extension
icon over here on the left and then in
the search extensions type live
server
and when those options come up we should
see one from ritwik day and you want to
select that and then you want to go
ahead and install
and i already have it installed so i
don't need to do that but this will let
us not only launch our html and css but
anytime we make a change in save it will
immediately reload just as if it's on a
web server you don't want to load these
files into your browser directly from
your hard drive you want to
really kind of have a development
environment that simulates a web server
and that's what live server does for you
so go ahead and install that
once you have that installed and i'll
click on the explore icon over here to
look at our files again but now you'll
have some options in visual studio code
you could click go live down here at the
bottom right
and it says
click to run live server when we mouse
over or you can right click just in the
file and you can choose open with live
server and i'll go ahead and do that now
and there we have our very very basic
web page but we can see it is super
small i don't know if you can even see
that i would have to zoom in and enlarge
that but it says i'm learning css so we
could add another style in our style
sheet
and let's just go ahead and put it above
the color style and i will put font dash
size and i'm going to change this to 64
pixels it should be pretty big now so
i'll save
resize visual studio code
much better so we've got a purple i'm
learning css with large font now let's
go back to the html file
and i'm going to expand visual studio
code again so we have a little more room
now in this head section
directly underneath our link element i'm
going to type style and press tab and
there is such a thing as a style element
now inside of the style element here
between the opening and closing tags
that is we can write css so i'm also
going to style a paragraph
and here i'm going to put the color
as lime green
now i'll save this and let's go back and
look at our page and see what we've got
now we have i'm learning css and it is
lime green notice it's still large font
though so the other style sheet i'll
press ctrl b to hide the file tree for a
second so we can see this better the
other style sheet is still being applied
but we have overwritten the purple rule
for the color with green
now does one take precedent over the
other does the
internal style sheet which is what we
just built right here with the style
elements that's the internal does it
take precedence over the external
not really
just it's interpreted as another style
sheet either way now normally i use
external style sheets but there is no
difference as far as the browser is
concerned what is the different is the
cascade or the order in which they're
red so it read this style sheet
first
and then it read this one last so the
last color that it saw for our paragraph
was lime green we can further highlight
that
by highlighting our link element and
cutting it with ctrl x
and then pasting it with ctrl v
underneath
our internal style sheet
and so now our external style sheet is
read last and i will save
and now we've got a purple i'm learning
css again and the final way to apply css
inside an html document is with inline
css this is really not the way to do it
though you really want to avoid inline
css if you can i just want to
demonstrate what it is because you can
use style as an attribute
and now we don't need a selector which
is what the p is up here this is
selecting the paragraph we already know
it's being applied to a paragraph so
here i'll just say color
and i'm going to say blue i really don't
need a semicolon because i don't have
any other declaration here if i had more
than one i'd have a semicolon in between
now if i save this
notice it's now blue over here
this does take precedent over either
type of style sheet internal or external
because it's applied directly to the
element itself but what we want is a
separation of concerns so the best way
the way that is commonly
used is the external style sheet it
keeps your css
code completely separate from your html
okay let's remove our inline styling
from the paragraph
and let's also remove the style element
because we will be focusing on using
external style sheets for the rest of
the course so we can save that
and let's go ahead and scroll up to the
top of the html document and now let's
move over to the external style sheet
and then in the browser notice of course
this is already back to purple now
let's go to another mdn page that's the
mozilla developer network and we get an
anatomy of a css rule set so let's break
this down and we can look at our own
example to the left as well but we have
our selector that means we're selecting
the paragraph or paragraphs if we had
more than one
now we have a property and a property
value so the property being the color
the value being read
and then the declaration is the property
and the property value together so we
have the same thing over here just color
and purple and the full declaration is
both now it says the whole structure is
called a rule set but also notice it
says the term rule set is often referred
to just as rule so you could consider
this a css
rule if you will okay let's go back to
our html document in the browser and
something i need to note here about css
is it's using the american spelling of
color there could be other english words
that are different but notice how visual
studio code knows there's already a
problem here and if i save this
purple is not applied to our document
it's back to the default black text so
we need to spell things
with american english i guess is the
best way to put it our dialect
without the u in color and there could
be some other words as well but notice
we didn't get an error or anything if we
do put in color the wrong way
it's just ignored and that is something
about css
and sometimes it's hard to detect when
you've done something wrong because
you're not getting an error thrown like
programming languages the rule or the
declaration i should say not the entire
rule but this declaration is just being
ignored because we didn't spell color in
the way css expects so if i change that
back once again we have purple text now
one way we can detect problems in our
css is to validate our css files so
let's pull up a page that will do that
and we go to css validation service from
w3c that's the world wide web consortium
and we want to choose file by upload
where we can select the css
style.css from our folder and you need
to choose file and then browse to the
folder where your css is which should be
in the folder you created and then if
you created a css folder it would be in
there here's my style.css so i'll select
it and choose open
and now we'll just click the check
button and this page will show us if
there are any errors but if there's not
you should get this congratulations no
error found message just like i did so i
will put a link to this css validator in
the description of the video or with the
resources and then in the next video
we're going to learn all about css
selectors
today we're working with css selectors
and there are three levels of selectors
that are the most common now i've got
visual studio code open here on the left
and i have a blank style.css file that
is linked to our html file and the html
file is open in chrome already i'm using
the live server extension with visual
studio code so we will instantly see our
changes in our page
the structure of the html page has an h1
heading and after that we have three
articles each article has its own h2
heading and paragraph inside
so as we talk about the three different
types of basic selectors in css let's
start with the most common which is an
element selector and i'm going to select
the body element now there is only one
body element per page but we have some
very small font and i will get into more
properties for each of the declarations
as we go through tutorials but i'm going
to use a few today just for examples
and i'm going to set the font size to 22
pixels and save now we can see this made
all of our text on our page larger and
this is due to inheritance so these
other elements actually inherited from
the body element and we'll get more into
inheritance in just a little bit too but
this
in itself is an element selector now
there's only one body element per page
but say i went ahead and selected the
paragraph using the paragraph selector
and now i can set the color of the text
and i'm going to set the color of the
text to purple
and i'll save and notice it changed all
three of our paragraphs to purple so
element selectors select all of the
elements of that type so just specifying
p for the paragraph element selects
all paragraph elements and now the
second type of selector is a class and
so let's define a class selector i'm
going to call this class gray
note that a class starts with a period
before whatever you name the class and
you can choose the name of the class but
make sure it makes sense and remember
your writing code for others to read not
just yourself okay inside of this i'm
going to set the color to gray that
makes sense to me
now i'll save that and notice paragraphs
2 and 3 turn the gray color and if we
look at our html which is a little
crowded over here but if i scroll down
to the second paragraph here we have a
class
set equal to gray on that paragraph
likewise we have a class set equal to
gray on the third paragraph as well so
classes can be used more than once and
they're very useful that way you're
creating styles that you can apply
throughout your project or throughout
your page
and then they can be reused with more
than one element and note classes are
more specific than selecting all
paragraphs for example and because
they're more specific they overruled the
purple setting that we had for all
paragraphs and now gray applied to these
last two paragraphs here and we will
also discuss specificity in more detail
in just a few minutes as well now
classes are the most common type of
selector with css
but the more specific
selector yet is an id selector and i
have an id named second an id attribute
inside of the html and here i'm going to
apply a font style and we'll set that to
italic
and i like to have a space afterwards
now i'll save and notice the second
paragraph
became italic as well so it specifically
addressed the second paragraph now ids
should only exist once in an html
document they should be unique in other
words however it is not good practice to
really use ids inside of your css now it
will validate your code has no problem
using an id
however typically you should use classes
and sometimes element selectors but
rarely if ever should you use an id
selector inside of your css they do have
other valid uses if you remember from
html linking a form input back to a
label element and then as you learn
javascript you may have some other uses
for id attributes as well but we try to
keep them out of css and now that we've
covered the three basic types of
selectors let's discuss what you can do
with some of them just a little bit more
so let's have our h1 here and let's set
the color for the h1 to blue
and we'll save and we can see it only
selected the h1 we only have one h1 on
our page
but we can also group selectors so let's
set all of the h2s as well to blue and
you can see i just put a comma between
and then
this declaration or this rule set the
entire rule set if we had more rules in
here more declarations i should say
it would apply to both the h1 and the h2
so you can go ahead and group selectors
with a comma in between now notice what
happens if i remove the comma and save
this declaration or our full rule set
especially if we had more declarations
none of it would apply to the h1 or the
h2 now what's going on here this
selector is looking for any h2s that
exist inside of an h1 it's not looking
for an h1 or an h2 it's only looking for
h2s that exist or are nested if you will
inside of an h1 so that's why that
didn't work that may be useful to know
in the future but what we need is a
comma in between and then we can select
both the h1 and all h2s on the page with
this rule set so let's look at an
example of where we would select an
element that's inside another element so
let's start with our paragraph elements
again and now we'll look for any span
element inside
any paragraph element and here let's set
a couple of values so we'll set
text dash
transform
and i'm going to choose
uppercase here
and then i'm also going to set a
background
color
and let's set this to gold so it stands
out we're essentially highlighting what
we want to see and now we can see
we have set this word whatever this word
is this is latin from our lorem epson
we've set it to uppercase and same with
epsom and then we also set gold behind
each of these words with this however
this doesn't make a lot of sense this is
a much better example of where we should
use a class we might name our class
something like
highlight
and then apply that to our span elements
inside
of the index so we've come in here and
find our span
and i'll select both of these
and then
we can add the class highlight
and that makes it reusable if i spell
highlight correctly there we go and save
and now it's once again applied but this
would keep our css much more organized
and actually more reusable it's more
flexible this way because we might have
some span elements doing other things
that we didn't want to apply
this rule set to and now one last
selector to discuss it exists we
wouldn't use it that often but it is the
universal selector and this means it's
selecting everything on the page you
typically only see this for what is
called a css reset that we will cover in
the future but just so you know it
exists this selects everything so let's
think about what we could apply here
that would be applicable to everything
so let's change the font
and we'll set it to this mono space font
and save and now you can see all of the
text on the page
turned into this monospace font instead
of the default font that we had now this
is not how we would use this again in
the future we'll learn about a css reset
that would use that selector but
typically that's the only time you see
that universal selector used okay let's
discuss the cascade
css is an acronym for cascading style
sheets and essentially that means css
works like a waterfall it works from the
top down and that means if i were to put
in another definition i'll just copy
this down for paragraph and where we
have
the color purple on our first paragraph
it really applies to all but then of
course the gray class overrides that on
the final two but if i came here and
said
red
instead of purple notice how this
paragraph
turns red and that's because
it read this rule set last so first css
looked at this at the top it starts at
the top and it works its way down and so
it read this last essentially this is
the last rule and that means whichever
definition it reads
at the last will be applied now
specificity can override this and that's
where we talked about elements and then
classes classes are more specific for
example
than just an element selector so we have
our class here that has the color gray
and it is overriding the red now if we
remove this class and we save
now they're all red but even though
we're looking at the cascade and
starting from the top down even if i put
this class above
the paragraph selectors and save
it still applies to these last two
paragraphs because it has more
specificity
than an element selector and the element
selector here purple of course is
overridden
with the last rule being the element
selector here for red so we start out
with a red paragraph and it's really
applied to all paragraphs except
that then
css sees there is a gray class applied
to the second and third paragraphs and
that has more specificity so it
overrules whatever is set by the element
selector now a problem you can have is
when you have a large css file and maybe
you have set this gray class on these
paragraphs and later on let's say you're
way down a couple of hundred lines and
you're setting a color on a paragraph
and you can't understand why it's not
being applied so let's go ahead and
expand chrome here and you can right
click and choose
inspect and once you inspect your page
then you can look at the different
classes and css rules that are applied
so here's a good example of that we have
got our third paragraph highlighted up
here in the elements tab
and then we're looking at the styles and
we can see we've got paragraph rules
here these element selectors but color
purple is crossed out and then color red
is crossed out so css knows these rule
sets exist for paragraph but it also
knows it should follow what is the most
specific using the rules of specificity
so here we have a color gray that is
being applied so you can see
sometimes when you're struggling with
your css and you have written a rule and
you're not understanding why it is not
being applied you should inspect your
code with dev tools and once again you
right click and choose inspect to do
that and then just go to the correct
tabs elements
highlight the element that you want look
at the styles and you'll see how it is
being read by css in the browser or how
the browser is reading your css and then
see how those rule sets are being
applied which ones are being overridden
and which ones are actually being
applied okay i'm going to close that out
now and i'll resize chrome so i'll come
back over here to our style and as we go
to the top let's talk about inheritance
as i got into specificity a little bit
already but inheritance
that is where
another element inherits the settings
from or the properties from its parent
element so the body element is parent to
every other element here and so when we
set the font size all of these other
elements inherited that font size now
typically anything related to font or
typography
is inherited and that can include things
like color line height alignment all
sorts of settings dealing with the font
and the typography however any
properties that are not related to those
things
are not inherited and i know that'll
just take a little bit of getting used
to as you learn more about css so for
example this font size was inherited but
another setting we could put is a border
and i'll put three pixels so it's easy
to see solid black and i'll save this
now notice the border only went around
the body element it didn't apply to all
the other elements inside of the body so
that's an example of something that is
not inherited and i'll go ahead and
remove that again now we did briefly
talk about that universal selector let
me go back to that and show you that
this is not inheritance this is actually
selecting all elements so here if i said
a border
and i'll put one pixel solid red
and save notice it does apply to all
elements that's because we selected all
the elements here so
setting something here with the
universal selector is not going to cause
inheritance really because it's actually
selecting all the elements itself okay
i'll remove the universal selector again
but getting back to just the inheritance
overall this can be very handy because
it keeps us from writing repeated code
in other words it keeps our code dry
which is an acronym that stands for
don't repeat yourself so we want to
write less code and be more efficient
and inheritance helps us do that now
some things are not inherited like i
mentioned the border would be one of
those also form elements do not inherit
say the font size and other typography
settings so it wouldn't be that unusual
to see something like this that would
take a button and let's say an input
a text area and let me see if i'm
leaving anything else out maybe a select
anything like that and we might see then
font and set it to inherit and that
would go ahead and make those elements
inherit the font settings because
just a mental note that form elements do
not typically inherit those font
settings but now to take advantage of
inheritance and write dry code we can
use the body element which appears only
once per page or we could use the html
element
and either would work
oftentimes if you're just starting out
and just remembering it might be best to
just use the body
oftentimes i use the html element
because once again the inheritance
applies there so we can save here
without see the difference now i'll go
ahead and apply it in html and once
again
we have the larger font because there
are for me at least some specific
settings for the body and i like to see
those separate so i often put all of my
font settings in the html selector but
again either would work one other
element selector that i do use at times
is the main element it is a semantic
element and it should appear only once
per page but then you have to be aware
that you're only selecting the things
inside of the main element so if we look
at our page i've got the h1 inside of a
header element and not inside of the
main element so if i were to change
the font family inside of our main
selector and i changed this to mono
space which is easy to see the change
with
go ahead and save you can see
all of the articles switched to mono
space but our h1 heading is still using
the other font okay coming back to
specificity just something we talked
about so a quick review that element
selector is the least specific and then
a class selector is more specific and
then although we don't want to use them
in our css an id selector is even more
specific than that sometimes something's
not working out and you're wanting to
figure out why it's not working out or
you just can't figure it out and you get
frustrated i'm going to show you
something that will work but i'm going
to recommend that you do not use it it's
kind of the nuclear option if you will
and it's to put an exclamation mark and
put important now see how red should be
applied to this first paragraph but with
the important flag right here after our
purple setting and now i save
notice what happened
it turned the first paragraph purple
notice what else happened it also turned
the second paragraph and the third
paragraph purple
now why is that well this important
essentially ruins everything else it
overrides everything so
really when you see it in code it's kind
of an indication that it's not well
organized or it's sloppy there's only a
few reasons you would really want to use
this and i feel i mean i'm hesitant to
even show it because i feel like
beginners could abuse this however
you'll see it somewhere i just want you
to know it exists
don't use it don't use it you need to
learn how to organize your code and
apply it correctly and only after you've
learned css well enough to understand
when to use that important flag that's
the only time you should use it you
should really not give up the struggle
you will learn more by struggling and
learning how to apply these selectors in
the proper way without using that
important flag i do want to show you one
thing that will help you learn and that
is the specificity calculator and i will
give a link to this in the resources you
can see they've got some basic values
here that are already fairly complicated
but you can zero these out and you can
compare two selectors to see why they
are working and why they aren't working
or why one overrules the other you can
see an element selector here for an h2
has a score of zero zero one
but if i put in my class of gray it has
a score of 0 1 0 in other words 10
which is a higher score
than 1 so the class overrules
the element selector and likewise if we
put in an id selector like we had second
it has a score of 100 over 10 so
that is better now you could apply more
than one class for example to an element
so let's see what happens if we had a
second class and we had our highlight
class
now
this has a score of 20 but it's still
not going to be as high as a score of
100 so this specificity calculator will
certainly help you understand why one
rule is being applied or why one
selector i should say is being applied
over another
today we're learning about css colors
i've got visual studio code here on the
left and our web page on the right it is
a basic web page and i'm using the live
server extension so when we make changes
in our css and save we'll instantly see
the changes here in our page i've got an
h1 heading and then i've got three
articles and each article has its own h2
heading and a paragraph
okay and that's really all there is you
can see it's got the default colors a
white background and black text and
that's usually what browsers default to
i've got just a few declarations over
here for our page just to make it
readable i've got a larger font size
i've declared the font family and line
height and we'll learn more about those
when we get to typography in this series
right now i want to show you just how to
set a background color first
and the first declaration we'll look at
is setting background dash color and
then notice visual studio code instantly
wants to help us it pops up a list of
color names and there are 140 color
names available in html and visual
studio code recognizes all these names
and notice it's going alphabetical so if
i type something like the letter p
it suddenly shows us all of the color
names that start with the letter p
and so on so we can just pick any one of
those i'm just going to go ahead and
pick something like blue and i'll go
ahead and save
and you can see visual studio code also
shows us a little square of blue beside
the name blue
and now if we look at the page it has a
blue background now that's not nearly as
legible because we also have a dark font
so we also have to consider the contrast
when we pick colors to make it legible
and readable for our viewers and it also
needs to be accessible and there are
contrast ratios that are specified and
we'll look more at that here in the near
future
right now besides just setting the
background color with the background
dash color
declaration we can also go ahead and
just say background that's shorthand and
it also allows us to set other
properties that we won't learn about
today but we can just set a color by
saying background and that's often the
case because it's shorter to type than
background dash color so you'll see this
often
instead of blue let's change our
background color to an interesting color
name i like papaya whip so i'll save and
that's much easier to read as well so
our dark text looks good on this
background okay now that we know how to
set a background color let's change our
font color as well and we do that just
with the color property so in the
declaration we can once again name a
color so i could just say black
and that looks okay let's see if there's
a dark color yep a dark blue let's see
how that looks on top of our papaya whip
background
well not too bad it is definitely
legible so we have determined two
different color names and we chose those
through visual studio code there the
color palette just popped up and we'll
go over that in a minute too but this is
where you'll typically see color set
background and font color and you can
set the background color to a lot of
different elements and we often have
fonts on top of those elements or inside
of the elements but on top of those
colors now let's discuss another way to
set colors instead of color names we
know we can look for color names and
visual studio code will help us
also we can use rgb which stands for red
green blue
and then we put parentheses and now this
takes three values a red value and the
max value is 255
then a green value
and a blue value notice i put zero for
both of those so this is all red and you
can see visual studio code even tells us
it's going to be red before we save our
file if i go ahead and save now all of
our text turned red
likewise i could change this and say no
red all green and no blue
and we have green text and that looks
absolutely horrible on top of that
background let's try blue now and there
we have blue text on top of the
background which is okay if we wanted
black we would go back to
all zeros and likewise if we wanted
white we would have 255 for each value
now as we previously learned about the
cascade we can go ahead and define a
color of text on the body but then we
can override it inside of some of the
elements so let's say our paragraphs
here and we want to override that with a
different color so maybe we want
a blue text for the paragraphs and we
can put that here and style all of our
paragraphs now with blue text but i
don't think that looks the greatest i'm
going to go back to black but then also
there is something called rgba which
adds an alpha channel and that alpha
channel guides the transparency now
instead of 0 to 255 it has a value from
0 to 1.
1 is just like the alpha channel wasn't
there that's normal and so that would be
the full black color and it matches the
headings that we have on the page so you
don't see a difference
but 0 would make it completely
transparent and all of our paragraphs
have now disappeared however we could
put it at fifty percent
and we should see the difference so the
paragraphs are not as dark as the
headings because they are fifty percent
transparent now that we've looked at rgb
and rgba let's go ahead and look at
hexadecimal which is a common way to
specify colors here the color palette
keeps wanting to help me so we will be
using that very soon hexadecimal also
works like rgb and it has its own way of
coding the values though it goes from 0
to 9 and then also uses letters a
through f
and now 0 just like we learned with rgb
is the absence of color so six zeros is
once again black and you'll notice our
paragraph text is totally black
likewise the highest value being the
letter f
that is full red green and blue and so
now we have white paragraphs because we
set those all the way to the highest
value so two fs in the beginning
position
means red then zero green
and zero blue and we should have a red
paragraph
and we do likewise we could say two
zeros two f's and two zeros
and we get green
and finally if we did four zeros and two
f's
it should be blue so we can kind of code
those in the same way once you learn hex
now if you noticed earlier when i was
typing color names
like dark blue and everything else here
that starts with dark
look at the hex codes over here to the
right visual studio code is already
helping show you all the different
hexadecimal codes for these
so we can of course get those codes by
typing color names if we want the code
of a name
but there are many more colors than
there are color names and you can really
expand your palette by using rgb or hex
codes now we can also type shorthand
when the color codes match so two zeros
two zeros and two zeros is black but it
could be represented just by saying zero
zero zero
because each pair matched likewise
two f's two f's and two f's is white so
we could just say fff and each single f
represents a pair
so if we had
two f's two zeros and two zeros for red
we could just say f zero zero and we
still have red so our shorthand for
green would be 0f0
and then our shorthand for blue would be
0 0
f but they have to be pairs so a hex
code like 80 80 80
doesn't have shorthand it's gray but
the 8 0 isn't a pair so it's not a 0 0
or an 8 8 so you can't really do a
shorthand for a hex code like this so
not all hex codes have shorthands just
the ones that have
pairs for the red green and blue values
but i can save this and we can see kind
of a dark gray color here as well so
those are the ways to provide hex values
okay let's look at the color palette the
visual studio code has had popping up
every now and then all you have to do is
mouse over the little color square and
we get a color palette now when i grab
the circle and drag it around notice
what it's doing it's giving us all these
different hex codes up at the top
and here if i come all the way to the
bottom right you can see it's all black
all the way to the top right it's red
and that's because we have our hue over
here set to red as well but we can pull
this down into the blues
and we can get different colors that way
as well then we could drag this around
and if you click the bar at the top you
can switch this to hsl which we haven't
covered yet and there's rgb as well so
you can go through those different
values i'll leave it on rgb here and we
can pull
down our transparency and it immediately
goes to rgba notice we have that alpha
channel now so i'm pulling this down and
we're setting a transparent value on
there as well so now
when i leave it there and go back to
visual studio code it's already changed
our code to represent that rgba value
and i can save our file and now that is
the color of our paragraphs now that's a
little light so i want to go back
and i probably don't want it to be that
transparent so i could bring this back
up here closer to the top and save and
now we have a much darker color we would
still want to check the contrast on that
i'm not sure if there's enough contrast
or not and we'll look at a contrast
checker in just a few minutes let's go
back to the visual studio code color
palette and as i talked about hsl here i
clicked again and we had hexadecimal i'm
going to take this all the way up hsl
also has hsla which adds the alpha
channel but hsl stands for hue
saturation and lightness so i'm going to
pull this over here kind of to the
middle
and that looks good and there we go
and i'll take this all the way to the
top so we're back to zero there for red
and overall i'll maybe try this in the
top corner there we go that's what i
want so we've got zero 100 percent
and 50 50
means it's right in the middle for
lightness so there's 50 percent more
lightness available or there's 50 we
could take away 100 percent would be
white and 0 here in the third value
would be black
likewise
100 percent here for saturation gives us
the full color and 0
gives us gray if i can pull this in here
we get the color gray no matter what
once we get down to fifty percent here
there we go fifty percent is totally
gray
and then if we were at a hundred percent
there on the right that's white
and zero percent
that's black so we want to be right in
the middle which would give us the gray
there but likewise then we don't have
the saturation so we'll come back across
here to the right
and try to get back up to 100 in the
middle and 50 percent there that went
away and now the zero we have here for
the hue well that's represented over
here on the right with this slider
notice at the top and the bottom we have
red
and the max value here is 360. and that
means this is usually a circle it's
usually represented as a color wheel you
may have heard of a color wheel before
and we can drag this
all through the different hues so
we get all the different colors there
and once we get to about 360 we're back
to red it went back to zero so you can
see that takes through all the hues all
the different color ranges we could have
there so hue
saturation and lightness and this is
worth playing around with as well and as
you get a little bit more advanced and
learn about css variables you may decide
you really like working with hsl but
most beginners start out working with
hexadecimal rgb and color names so it
doesn't hurt to learn about any of those
let's switch this back over to rgb
switch it back to hexadecimal or you
could just switch it back to a good old
color name
like red although red is not going to
look that great
as far as our page goes so i want to
take this over and pick a color i like
to use which is not quite
solid black but it is a dark color and
there we go for the paragraphs i used
use 333 which as you know is the same as
saying
3 3 3 3 3
3 and we save and we still have the same
color it's just that shortcut can be
used for those pairs okay we've covered
a lot of different ways to pick colors
and we've covered the visual studio code
color picker here that really helps us
out but we also need to look at some
tools so let's look at the tools we've
got here coolers
dot co that's c o o l o r s dot c o this
is a great
color palette picking tool and you can
start the generator and start picking
your color palettes as you go here it
takes it just a minute to fire up but
then you can choose these color palettes
or press the space bar to generate all
new palettes tell it which color you
want to keep and which ones you want to
get rid of
and then you can just copy these colors
here's a copy right here to copy the hex
that it shows there
and so on so this is a great source for
picking colors but what i really like on
this site is the contrast checker now i
also have the web aim contrast checker
this is web accessibility in mind and
this is really a great site for checking
accessibility features and as much as i
like their checker the one on coolers.co
is even a little bit better for me so
i've got a background i want to go with
i'm going to put this hex code in here
and now it's dark and now i'm going to
put in
white for the text color and you can see
it checks out a 7.2 which is considered
very good and if we scroll down just a
little bit it talks about the web
content accessibility guidelines so a
minimum is a double a minimum contrast
and there you want to have a contrast
ratio of at least 4.5 to 1 for normal
text and you can see we've got 7.42
so that is good you want to have 3.1 or
3 to 1 for large text
and it shows here we've got 3 stars for
large text as well so we're doing good
there but a triple a requires at least
seven to one and we barely made the cut
there with or 7.4 here and then
four and a half to one for large text so
this will just grade your color contrast
for you and make sure it works out so we
could go back to our code and check out
another one so let's go back to papaya
whip and here's the great thing about
visual studio code now i can click here
find the hex and it changes my papaya
whip color name to the hexadecimal code
so i'm going to put this in as the
background
and then for the color i'm going to put
in
my hex for the 333 and it just changed
it to the full hex code but you can see
this is great contrast with 11.17
and it gives the example of it here up
above as well legibility and
accessibility are very important
considerations as you pick colors for
your web page now i'm going to give
links to these resources in the
description below this video as well and
what i suggest you do as a beginner is
just play around with the different
colors play around with the visual
studio code color picker or color
palette here as well
and just kind of get comfortable with
setting colors on your page and of
course always come back and check the
contrast ratio and make sure you're
meeting those minimum requirements for
web pages
let's move on to css units units
determine the size of everything in your
page today we're going to cover the most
common css units on the left i have
visual studio code on the right i have
the chrome browser it has an h1 heading
on the page and we have one paragraph on
our page and we're displaying this page
with the live server extension so
anytime we make a change and save our
css file we'll automatically see the
changes over here on the page i'm going
to start out by just putting in a
paragraph selector
and then i'm going to put in the font
size
and after that without even typing
anything look what visual studio code
gives us a lot of suggestions there are
so many different units we could choose
from so today we'll cover only the most
popular ones as we don't need to cover
all of them just the ones that you'll
see and construct your pages with most
frequently so i'm not even going to put
in a definition right now let's just
delete that and switch over to the mdn
page for values and units and we can see
a chart here of absolute length units
and really the only absolute length unit
we will use commonly is pixels and you
can see here is the equivalency it's one
pixel is equal to 196 of an inch and
really one pixel as you might guess
means one pixel on your screen we
abbreviate that with px and i say it's
the only absolute value we're going to
cover because as mdn says it's really
the only value that you will commonly
use as far as absolute units go
so let's switch back to our page and now
here in our css page i'll once again
select the paragraph
and we can set a absolute size to the
font in our paragraph if we want to the
default in any browser is usually 16 so
if i set it to 16
we don't see a change but if i set it to
we definitely see a change it gets twice
as big but i don't usually want to use
an absolute value like pixels for a font
size and let me show you why
normally
we have a default browser size as i
mentioned that's usually 16 pixels
however if i set that on the root
element
font size
16 pixels we don't see a change here but
if i go into my settings in chrome which
you can do with the three dots and then
choose settings once you launch that
you'll be on a settings page and then
you can choose appearance
you go to a font size user preference
and medium is what most are on but
there's also other choices from very
small to very large i'll choose very
large we definitely see a change on the
settings page right when i do that back
in our document
we don't see a change it didn't change
at all i can refresh and it won't make
any difference it did not change our
font size with the user settings and
that's because we took that choice away
when we said no these absolutely must be
16 pixels here that's our root size but
if i delete this
and we just let the browser handle the
default size
instantly all of our font gets bigger
and our user settings take over we don't
want to take that choice away from the
users so we don't want to use an
absolute font size such as a pixel
setting so i'll go ahead and delete that
so where would we want to use pixels in
absolute value there are other settings
that we might want an absolute value for
so i'll select the h1 that i have here
and i'm going to set a border on it and
i'll set it to 2 pixels
and then just so we can see it better
i'll set it to dashed and red so it
really stands out and save and now we
can see this border around our h1
element and we have this absolute value
for the pixel width and no matter what
happens to the page on a small viewport
large viewport whether it's a mobile
device
or a large desktop screen this will
remain as two pixels and that's okay in
this instance let's go back to our mdn
page
and now that we've covered the only
pixel size that we were going to cover
and that was down here on our pixel
chart
we're going to now cover percentage and
we see that up here in a different chart
this is a numbers links and percentages
chart here
so we're going to use percentage and it
says it represents a fraction of some
other value so 50 of something else
percentages are always relative to
another quantity so that's a
consideration as well now when we set
percentages we wouldn't normally do that
with a font size either so let's set a
percentage for a width
on our h1
and now by default an h1 is a block
level element and so by default it has a
width of 100 so if we do that we're not
really changing anything and now it's
just 100 percent as expected so let's go
ahead and change that it looks at the
parent though it's taking up 100 percent
of the parents with or whatever was
given to it so whatever it has available
to it it took up 100
and now this is only taking up 50
so let's look at the parent for the h1
it is inside of a header element so if
we take this header element and we set
it to a width
of 50 percent
then we should see a difference and yes
it's even smaller so we're taking up
only 50 percent of the header element
which is taking up 50 percent of the
page so really this h1 would be 25
percent of the page likewise if we
change this to a hundred for the header
then we'll see our h1 takes up
50 percent of the page so that's the
thing to remember about setting a
percentage for the width
is that you are putting it relative to
the parent it's only using what it has
available to it if the header is a
hundred percent
then the h1 that is the child has a
hundred percent of the page available to
it however if the header is smaller
let's put it at eighty percent
then
we're only using up fifty percent of
eighty percent of the page and once
again if you want an element that is a
block level element to take up 100
of the width of the page you don't
really need to set it because that is
the default value already so now we're
taking up half of the page by setting
the h1 to 50 percent because it is 50
of the full 100 width and you may see
other uses for percentages as well but
you commonly see them to set the sizing
of different elements as far as the
width of the page or sometimes the
height but also we don't need to set the
height because it will grow as the
content grows i'm going to go back to my
settings and set it from very large back
to medium which is where most have their
browser default to now when we look at
our page the font is smaller but let's
talk about another relative unit and
this one does show on the mdn page in
the chart down here under relative
length units and it's the rem this is
the unit that we'll typically use for
font size and it relates to the font
size of the root element now i already
suggested we shouldn't set a font size
on the root element so for our html
element we typically wouldn't set a font
size in here because we want to let the
browser handle that and set the default
font size so let's not do this for the
html element i'll just go ahead and cut
this i'm going to put it below the h1
and i'm going to set a font size for our
paragraphs instead and this font size if
we set it to one ram
that's already the default so it
shouldn't change anything and we see the
size is the same so it says one root
element which the root element is the
default font size set by the browser the
em doesn't stand for element by the way
that's m so we have one root em or one
root m but that means the root size that
is defined and in our case when we don't
set it then it's set by the browser so
hopefully that clears up some confusion
but if we put in two m's then it's going
to double the default size
and now we're probably at 36 pixels
right here because most browsers default
to that 16 pixel size
so you can see how this relates back to
the root now if we set a font size on
the parent because our paragraph is in a
main element
we set this font size to to rem also
it doesn't change the paragraph font
size at all because the font
set here is not relative to the main
element it's not relative to the parent
it's relative to the root which is
defined by the browser so it's always
going to look back to that default root
size if we had set a font size in the
html element it would be looking at that
but without setting it it's the default
size
so what happens though if we switch
these units if we're not using rem
if we're using
m just em so now
i'll delete the r there and save
oh boy that got a lot bigger well here's
the problem that we would have if we
were using m's for our font size it gets
amplified so our main element was
looking at the root so it doubled that
to 32 pixels
and then using two ms
is looking at the main element which is
the parent of the paragraph and so then
it doubled that so now we're at 64
pixels so that's what happens and you
can get unintended consequences if you
just use m's and that's why using the
rim and always looking at the root
definitely helps because the way we can
get confused for example is if i remove
this setting on the main and i save
well now this is also looking at the
root because there's no other font size
saved and so we think okay we're good to
use just m's but the problem is
if somewhere along the way in our
project and we have many elements we're
styling
we set another font size on a parent
element suddenly it's amplified when we
use m's so i'm going to switch this back
to two rims and get closer to the size
we'd want and it's going to look at the
root so when would we use
ms instead of rims we know we want to
use rems on font size well when we set
the font size on an element
m doesn't look at the parent it looks at
the element itself and so we could use
it for something like margin or padding
which i know we haven't covered and we
will in more detail when we look at the
css box model but i'm going to go ahead
and do that here for the h1 so if i set
a font size for the h1 and let's make it
bigger let's make it three
rem here and we save we instantly have
a bigger font size on the h1
but now i can set
the padding
to
m
which is the equivalent
of the font size of that element so now
this would also be 3 rims so it should
be a pretty good size padding yes we
have a lot of padding so i probably
don't want that much maybe i want to
drop it to
0.5
and now that's that's more reasonable
that looks pretty good for a heading
there so we added that padding which is
inside this border it added extra
padding and that is essentially half of
three rims which would be one and a half
and if we relate all this back to the
default 16 pixel size
one and a half of those would be 24
pixels whereas three rims would be
48 pixels another instance where we may
use m's instead of rims would be for the
padding or margin setting on say a
button if we created a button we would
have text in the button we could set the
font size for that button with rem but
then we could go ahead and set the
padding and or margin with the m units
let's go back to the mdn page and look
at our chart one other relative unit i'd
like to look at today is the ch that
stands for character and we have the
advanced measure width of the glyph zero
which essentially means the character
zero of the elements font so whatever
font we're using it's the measurement of
0 and that helps us determine the
character width and that kind of comes
from print
magazine newspaper layout and those sort
of things where you only want to have a
certain width based on the character
size so in this example we have a font
size here for our paragraph i'm going to
go ahead and set the width of the
paragraph and let's say we don't want
any more than an estimated
40 characters per line before the line
wraps in the paragraph if we set that
width notice it now has approximately 40
characters before the line wraps and
that kind of helps us define columns if
we're doing that in some type of layout
now we've acknowledged that the browser
sets a default font size but it actually
sets a lot of different default styles
as well so let's go ahead and right
click on this h1 heading and choose
inspect or you could press ctrl shift
and the letter i
either way what we're doing is opening
up the dev tools it may scrunch our page
here a little bit but that's okay if i
highlight this h1
now it is showing several things about
the page it's showing that there's a
large margin that's going to be the
orange when i highlight over
it's showing the green area and that's
padding that we set
and then the blue area is the h1 itself
right here so we see all of those things
in dev tools when we hover over these
elements and by the way i'm on the
elements tab of dev tools
and then if you don't have your dev
tools on the right you can click the
three dots here and there's a dock side
setting maybe it's on the bottom for you
but if you want it on the right you can
choose dock to the right just like i
have here so we can really see more
about all of these elements in dev tools
what we can also see as we come down
here are the styles
and then we see the h1 and the styles
that i have set on the h1 element but
underneath that we see some others as
well and it says user agent stylesheet
this is what the browser is setting on
the h1 element by default that we don't
have to and you can see we have put in a
different font size so we have
overridden the font size for the h1
element so it has crossed that out
everything else here the display block
and the different margins and even the
font weight are applied from that user
style sheet so those are default styles
and we can override them just like i did
with the font size and before we get
into these next two relative units we
are going to override some of these so
what i want to do
is start a css reset which i'll talk
about more in the tutorial of the css
box model as well but i'm going to use
the selector that selects all elements
again our wildcard selector and here i'm
going to set the margin to zero
the padding
to zero and one other setting that says
box
sizing and i'm going to set that to
border box and when i save
notice all the padding and margin is
gone now
our h1 is right up in the left corner we
don't have any space between the
paragraph and the h1 we got rid of all
of those default margins and paddings
that were creating that extra space but
that's important when we go back to the
mdn page and we look at these next two
relative units we have viewport width
which is one percent of the viewport's
width
and viewport height which is one percent
of the viewport's height so let's look
at how we can apply those but if we had
that extra margin and padding there we
wouldn't be able to see the detail that
i want to show okay i'm going to take
our main element here and set a width on
it with our viewport width units
just so we can see
what it is capable of and so i'll do
that i also need to set a background
color just so we can see what we're
doing better
and i'll set this to let's say sky blue
and save so now we can see the width of
our paragraph is actually wider than the
width of our main element and so it is
overflowing that main element but we
have actually set the main element to 50
of the width of the full page and you
can see that's matching the 50
width that we have up here but i'm using
the viewport width units right here
there may be times when you want to use
the viewport width but most of the time
i find myself using the percentage and
getting the same result and i'll give an
example where the percentage is actually
a better choice so let me remove that 50
percent and i'll remove this background
color that's making our page look bad
and we'll come back up to the top and
underneath our select all i'm going to
choose the body element here and as i'd
said before we don't need to set a width
of a hundred percent but i'll put this
in and i'm going to set this to
100 viewport with units instead and save
now we don't really notice a change and
i have seen this on pages and i've even
done it myself but i figured out the
problem if we have a width of 100
viewport width units we do have a
problem when the content out the
vertical content outgrows the page and
i'll show you why so i need to go back
to the html
and in the html i'm going to quickly add
some more content so i'll say
paragraph times 10 and we'll do this
with some just sample lorem text that's
an image abbreviation so when i press
tab it adds all those extra paragraphs
and save now we've got lots of content
here
and now we have a problem and here's the
problem
our scroll bar showed up on the right
which is good we need that to see all of
this content but what also happened is
we had a scroll bar show up down here on
the bottom
and that is because our viewport width
when we set it to 100 as we did on the
body right here does not account for
this scroll bar on the right so as soon
as this scroll bar on the right shows up
and it shows up when our content
outgrows
our height
so when we need to scroll to see the
content is when this shows up as it
should
but then
that little extra bit that we can't see
creates this scroll bar so we can see it
and that's annoying and most developers
don't like that horizontal scroll bar
showing up
so if you were to set the width
100 would be much more desirable because
now we still get the scroll bar here
where we can scroll up and down
vertically we do not have a scroll bar
on the bottom and we don't usually want
that but overall as i've mentioned
before we don't even need to set 100
width on the body as it should default
to that anyway i'm going to jump back to
the html and go ahead and undo all of
that extra content we added
and save so we're back to our normal
content for the page
let's go back to style as well
and let's right click once again on the
page and i just kind of i think i
selected the paragraph here so when
devtools opens up it should be on the
paragraph and we'll see that here in
just a second
yep i'm on the paragraph now let's
highlight the body notice the body is
not the full height of the page it only
grows with the content but sometimes we
want a body element that is the full
height of the page even if we don't have
enough content to do that and we can do
that with the viewport height unit and
i'm going to do that over here
in our code i'll choose the body element
but i don't want to set height because
that would also limit it to 100 vh and
then we could outgrow that if our
content were to outgrow what i want to
do is set the
min height to 100 vh
and save and now that will still allow
the body to grow with the content if it
outgrows the viewport but at the same
time it's now the full page and there
could be instances where you want that
let's move on to the css box model today
you'll learn that everything in css is a
box but before we finish i'll show you
how to turn a box into a circle if you
want to so let's get started on the left
i have visual studio code and i have the
code from the last tutorial we'll modify
that in just a second on the right i
have a basic web page once again with an
h1 header and a paragraph and i'm using
the live server extension so any changes
i make in the css and when i save the
file will immediately show
then in the web page okay so everything
we have over here except the h1 has got
to go so i'm going to delete everything
above
and below
and leave the styles for the h1 and we
can now save and we see those changes so
our paragraph
text has gotten smaller
and everything else is pretty much the
same except we do now have the default
styles from the browser again and we'll
get back to that css reset in just a bit
but right now we want to look at this
box model and we've already drawn a box
by putting a border around our h1
element we can see this border here
defined with shorthand and we'll get
into what all of that means in just a
second too but what i want to do first
is drag
our visual studio code over as far as i
possibly can and give us some more room
in the browser because we're going to
open up dev tools so once you do that
you can press shift alt or i'm sorry not
shift alt it is control shift i believe
and the letter i
to open dev tools
and if that's not working then you
should be able to no that is going to
work it just took a second here on my
computer
and if that doesn't work you could right
click and choose inspect as well once
you have it open you may not have your
dev tools on the right and if you don't
you can click the three dots and choose
where it is docked i like to have mine
on the right and then you can select any
of the elements in the html here and you
see it flashing over on the web page
because it highlights what element
you've selected and i am in the elements
tab that you can choose as well
after that i'm going to select that h1
so it's inside of our header element
here
and after i select it i've got h1 and
notice the colors changed on the web
page this is already showing us the box
model right here so what we have for the
orange is the margin and then we can
clearly see our border that we put in
with two pixels and it is dashed and
then inside of that we see green and
that is the padding and then inside of
that we see blue and that's actually the
content and now if we go down here where
we have a styles tab let's choose the
computed tab and we actually see the box
model inside of our dev tools so we can
highlight any aspect of this so i'll go
to the content first and now we only see
the blue highlighted on the web page and
that is our content and it's showing us
the actual size of the content in pixels
here as well and then we go to padding
which is the next layer the padding is
once again inside of the border and it
just wraps around our content it gives
some extra space inside of the border
gives our content a little room to
breathe if you will so here you can see
it's 24 pixels then we have our border
which it shows it as
1.993 pixels we set it to 2 pixels hey
close enough right and after the border
we have margin and you can see we didn't
set a margin so this margin is just
showing the space that is left
after our element is there so on top we
have 32 pixels and then we have 32
pixels on the bottom as well and that's
probably just because of the default of
the h1 we didn't set a margin on the
right but we do see a big margin over
there and that's just because
we have set that 50 percent width on our
h1 so it's not taking up the full page
space and what's left is occupied by
margin so it's important that you
remember how to get here in dev tools
we're on this computed tab below and you
always want to be able to bring up the
box model to see exactly what's going on
with your elements after that it's also
important to just memorize the different
layers of the css box model so starting
on the inside we have content then we
have padding then we have border and
finally we have margin on the outside
and now concerning our h1 and the margin
that i have highlighted notice it's 32
pixels actually
32.16 pixels and we didn't set that so
that's a default style on the h1 we've
got the h1 selected let's go back to the
styles tab instead of the computed tab
and we can see this if we scroll just a
little bit there's the styles we set and
then here are the default styles from
the browser this is a user agent style
sheet that's assigned by the browser and
here you can see they assigned some
margin settings here it's
0.67 em so that's essentially two thirds
now if we remember about our units an em
responds to the font size of the element
and we set a font size of three rim
which would essentially be 48 pixels so
two-thirds of that is coming in right
around where we see it on our box model
here at
32.16 pixels so now that we know our
font size is impacting the default
margin let's go ahead and change our
font size and of course it will also
change our padding that we based on em
units i'm going to change this to
2 rim if i can type here to rim and save
and now things have changed notice our
margin got smaller it's
21.44 because our font size got smaller
and this is based on an em unit an m
as far as the browser is concerned so
once again it's still 0.67 em
but the actual size is smaller it's
21.44 pixels now changes like this can
be really hard to keep track of and so
that's why sometimes we just want to
reset the browser settings for all the
margins and all the padding and just
take control of them ourselves and
that's why we use a css reset and a very
basic css restart starts with the wild
card at the top and then we set margin
for all elements because remember this
wild card selects all elements so we set
the margin to zero
and we set the padding to zero
and we can save and now all of that
margin and padding that is set by
default is taken away and you can see
the body actually had a little bit of
margin set to it as well because now
we're right up to the edge of the body
here on our page and this border we set
around our h1
is right up to the edge of the page as
well and there's one more setting i
always put inside of the css reset and
that is box
dash sizing there we go
and now the default
is content box and if we save we won't
really notice a change here it didn't
really change anything because that is
the default
so what the content box does is it says
okay the size that we're setting is this
for the content and the content only it
doesn't include calculating the size of
the padding or of the border or of the
margin at all so instead of 50 percent
i'm going to set an absolute width on
here so we can compare and i'll set this
to say
400 pixels and save now let's look over
here in our box and we can see the
content is 400 pixels but that doesn't
account for the padding what we have
here is not the 400 pixels we were
expecting we took up more space than
that but if we set this to border box
instead of content box
then we'll get what we expect and it's
much easier to calculate so now notice
our content over here is not 400 pixels
is 348
and then we can add in
24 pixels of padding on each side and
two pixels of border on each side and
then we can get our total of 400. so
what borderbox does is it really helps
us calculate
the sizes that we are assigning because
it goes ahead and includes the border
and the padding it does not include the
margin the margin is on the outside
of our css boxes that we create
whichever elements that we're styling so
the margin is not included in that
calculation however the rest is so the
border and the padding and the content
all add up to that 400 pixels that i set
right here okay now that we've broken
down how the border box setting works
and looked at the css box model let's go
ahead and close devtools and let's just
style our page a little bit with some of
these properties i'm going to resize the
page a little bit so we have some more
room for visual studio code over here on
the left i'll pull this over
there we go and now let's make some
changes so one thing i have thought
about is our h1 right here has some
settings i normally probably wouldn't
put on an h1 i'm just more concerned
with the font there but the font size
that would be assigned by default is
okay too so i'm going to get rid of that
and now these other settings i would
actually be more likely to put on the
container than i would on the h1 itself
and the h1 is inside of a header element
so let's go ahead and save that and it
changed just a little bit but that's
okay i'm going to change these ems back
to rims because now i'm not setting a
font size on the header so i'm going to
use 1.5 rim here and save and now we've
got our padding back to about where it
was but now what if i wanted to assign
these same settings to the container
that our paragraph is in and that's in
the main element so maybe i don't want
this on the header maybe i want to
assign a container class so i can
provide these same settings for more
than one container so i'm going to
quickly go over to the html
and in the html we'll set a class called
container on each of these elements so
we have the header element
and we'll set the class equal to
container
and i've got one extra
quote there there we go and now i'm just
going to copy this and i'll paste it
into our
main element as well
and save that
and there we go so now we've got dashes
around both of these boxes here let's go
back to the css and make these bigger so
we can see them better on the page right
now i'm going to get rid of this 100
pixel or 400 pixel width let's go ahead
and let them take up the full 100 for
now okay let's go ahead and add a font
size to the container and it will apply
to both of these differently but we'll
set it to 1.5
rim and save
now our fonts a little bit bigger but
notice how the edges of the border are
right up against the page so on the
outside of our box we can set a margin
and also set that to 1.5 ram and save
and now we have our two boxes and the
margin has pushed them away from the
edge the margin has also provided space
between the two boxes here and now that
we have a font size on our container we
could go ahead and switch this back to
ems and remember
one m one e m would be the same as the
font size so it would be equal to the
1.5 rim so if we make this change we
just change it to 1m
and our sizing should stay the same and
it does if we change this to 1.5 it will
get bigger yes and now we have more
padding we could add more margin by
doing the same if we want to so let's go
ahead and do that
and now let's go ahead
and experiment with the margin and the
padding because we don't have to have
the same setting on the top right bottom
and left and i did say that order
specifically for a reason because for
the margin we could just say margin
top and here let's go ahead and say 1.5
em and save
and look what happens to our other
margins the left and right margins are
gone and you can't really see that we
lost the margin on the bottom but we did
the only thing separating these
containers now is the margin on the top
so now let's go ahead and add some
margin on the right
and here we'll set this to 2em and save
so it's just a little bigger and now we
do have margin on the right but still no
margin on the bottom and no margin on
the left i'm going to press shift alt
and the down arrow
and now instead of the right i'm going
to switch this one to
bottom
and save and now we have some more
margin here on the bottom so the
separation between these two boxes got
bigger that's the only thing you could
really see right there
and now on the right let's go ahead and
switch i mean on the left let's go ahead
and switch this to two ems as well and
you can see we got the same thing as if
we just said
margin 2em except we wanted a margin on
top of 1.5 amps so there is shorthand
for this so i'm going to comment all
four of these out and i'll press shift
alt and the letter a to do that
there you can see a css comment so it
commented those out so right now there
will be no margin once again now the
boxes are next to each other no margin
on the left and right but our shorthand
is just saying margin and when i say
this 1.5
em
that applies it to top bottom
left and right and it actually goes in
the order top right bottom left so now
we can put in different settings with
the shorthand if we wanted to so 1.5 on
top
and then
2 m's on the right and the left and then
2 m's on the bottom and i can save
and that is the same thing as when we
had all four of these right here now if
i just wanted to have
1.5 on the top and the bottom and two on
the left and the right i could delete
this third setting right here
and that's what we get so now it will
take 1.5 and apply it to the top and the
bottom
and 2 and apply it to the right and the
left however you can provide all four
settings so we could go 3
and four
and then we would have the shorthand
notice the left margin the final value
here is much larger twice as large
actually as the right margin and then
the bottom
is definitely larger than the top margin
because here you can see only the top
margin as it applies to the first
container and now you can see
the top margin and the bottom margin
here combined to create the space
between the two boxes now this same idea
for shorthand also applies to padding so
i will copy these actually cut them and
just go back to the one setting for
margins so that looks a little bit more
normal again but now let's apply the
same thing to the padding and we'll see
how that changes so now we have a much
larger left padding of four twice as
much as we have on the right
and then we have a larger bottom than we
do on top this is easier to see because
it's inside of our container and
remember if you're ever having a hard
time seeing all of this different white
space i guess i dragged visual studio
code i meant to grab the edge of chrome
here i'll pull this over
right click choose inspect
open up the dev tools again and we can
see all of this hidden white space much
clearer when we look at the box model so
once again in dev tools choosing the
computed tab
but we also need to highlight what we're
going to look at so i'm going to choose
this main container and now we can see
the space as it's applied here so here's
the content
here's the padding and see we have 48
pixels on the right but 96 on the left
twice as much we have 36 on top but 72
on the bottom which is twice as much
also so we can definitely see that our
padding settings over here once i drag
this over are being applied as we
specified them in the shorthand okay
back to visual studio code i'm going to
resize chrome once again so we can see
our code better
dragging this over
dragging visual studio code back over
here there we go and we can do the same
thing you might expect with border
actually first worth discussing you can
just delete the two pixels
and then when we save it actually gets a
little thicker because the default is
more like three pixels
for the size here i'm going to delete
this odd sizing for the padding that i
used just to
indicate the different
sides for the padding and we'll go back
to kind of a normal look here we've got
two containers and they have equal
padding and equal margin around them
these settings also apply to the
individual border sides so that means we
can say border dash top and here we
could say
5 pixels
solid and then i'll go ahead and press
shift alt and the down arrow and then
instead of border top i'll go ahead and
say border
right and i'll say
10 pixels and here i'll say dotted
and save
and now we can see we had some major
changes here and we didn't specify a
color so these settings
were to override what we had set with
shorthand above and so the default color
is black but we have a dotted right and
we have a solid top so we could have
specified different colors here as well
so we could say
green
and then of course over here we can say
something different like
yellow
and save and now
that is ugly that definitely changed our
borders though so i'll switch that to
blue and save our eyes just a little bit
and if we wanted to specify these
individually we could even say border
top
width and then we wouldn't specify the
solid or green here so you can break out
each
individual setting as well so now you
can see we just changed the width of the
top one likewise instead of width
there's also border top let me switch
that there we go style and this is where
we're specifying dotted or anything else
here's ridge is another value we'll save
that and so now the top is a little bit
different it looks pretty much like the
solid setting does and then of course
there would be border top
color
and we could turn this to any color we
want so i'll choose blue here as well
and now we have a dashed blue line
across the top of our border so so many
settings for the border when you break
them out individually we had border top
but then we also specified border top
width border top style border top color
and then of course you can do that
instead of for top you can do right
bottom and left as well
often because of this because there's so
many i'll delete this i just use the
shorthand i usually want my borders to
have the same width all the way around
so previously i'd had two pixels here
and then i chose dash let's choose a
different one here let's use
outset
and we'll save and we can see it changed
our frame around the box another one
that i like is called double
and i'll put a link to the border page
from mdn in the description and you can
see all of the different values there
let's make this larger so we can really
see
the double what it does here we'll save
and there you go we've got our double
lines now around each container while
we're covering border one other setting
to cover is outline outline is not part
of the box model because the difference
between it and the border is that it
doesn't take up space but you style
outline much like you would the border
so here i'm going to choose 5 pixels and
i'll choose solid
and then let's make the outline a
different color entirely let's go with
purple
and if i save this now we can see purple
wrapping outside of our border but again
the outline is not calculated because it
doesn't take up space so it's not
calculated into that box model equation
another property that the outline has
that is very handy
is outline dash offset so instead of
being right up against our box we can
say we want the offset to be 5 pixels
and save and see how we pushed it now 5
pixels further out from our border so
it's offset 5 pixels from the rest of
our box and something worth considering
sometimes is using a negative value so
if i put in negative 10 pixels
we'll now see the outside the outline
is inside of our box here and so let's
go ahead and change this some more so we
get it a little further inside maybe
even 20 pixels and save and we can
clearly see the outline is now inside of
our box model okay in the beginning i
promised to show how to turn a box into
a circle before we were finished so
let's do that i need to go back to the
file tree
and find our index html and hide the
file tree with control b
and i just want to put a div down here
i'm going to keep it in the side of the
main element so i'll just type
div and then i want to give this div
a class and set this equal
to
there we go to circle
i still didn't spell circle right i'm
having a rough time today save there
we've got a div with the class of circle
okay we can close the html and now let's
style our circle class
so we'll start with circle definition
here for the class
and let's give the circle a background
color
of gold but we haven't given it any size
yet so let's say a width
of 100 pixels
and a height of 100 pixels
and that doesn't look like much of a
circle yet but it will let's go ahead
and add a border now of 2 pixels
we'll make this solid black
and now we see our border applied to our
square
and let's add an outline as well well we
need a new line for that outline
now the outline can be 2 pixels let's
say solid and let's go with red for now
so it'll match everything else a little
bit and stand out now let's give it an
offset also
and we'll make this 0.25 round
and save so yeah we've got just a little
space there now let's create some
separation from the other content and so
i'll just leave this at the top but i'll
make the margin
three rim
and save and now it's pushed itself away
but something we didn't cover with the
margin if you set the margin this
doesn't work for top and bottom but if
you set it for
left and right notice we've got three
ram for top and bottom now we can use
the keyword auto for left and right
and this will center it horizontally
that means in the middle left and right
so now we put what will be a circle our
gold square inside
of our main element and it's at the
center horizontally not vertically but
at least it is horizontally and now to
calculate our circle we essentially just
need to set one other border property
and we set it to half the value of the
width and the height so this border
property is called border radius i'll
put it right under border
and we'll set it first just so you can
see how it works let's set it to 20
pixels and you'll see what border radius
does look how it rounded the corners
of our square so now we have more like a
cool button kind of like you would see
there and we can continue to round that
but if we set it to 50 pixels which is
half of the width and half of the height
and save
we've now got a circle now there's
always more than one way to do things in
css and typically in programming in
general so if you've got other ways you
like to make circles in css go ahead and
leave those in the comments below but i
hope this has helped you learn about the
box model today so we have the content
on the inside then we have the padding
then we have the border and finally on
the outside we have the margin and when
we apply our basic css reset and we set
the box siding to border box the box
sizing to border box
then the calculation includes the
content the padding and the border
instead of just the content
let's move on to css typography and i'm
going to paste a definition here
typography is the way that text is
arranged and presented so today we'll be
working with text and font in our css
you can see i've got a css folder with a
style.css file and i have an index.html
file today
i'll save the style.css file and for the
index.html file let's just take a quick
look we've got a basic web page here and
inside the body of the web page we have
a header element and we have a main
element inside the header element we
have an h1 and inside the main we have a
paragraph
and then we have a simple form and our
form has a label input and button we'll
be working with all of those today let's
go back to the style i'm also going to
press ctrl b to hide the file tree and
now i'm going to resize vs code here so
it's only on the left of our screen and
on the right we'll have our web page and
i'm using the live server extension so
any changes we make in the css will show
immediately over here in the web page
you can see the simple web page that we
just went over in vs code it's got our
h1 it's got our paragraph with some
lorem epsom text and it's got our simple
form here with the label input and
button i'm going to start our css by
selecting the body and inside the body
i'm just going to set a padding of 25
percent and if you remember the css box
model setting padding of 25 sets that on
all sides top right bottom and left so
you can see it put our text right here
kind of in the middle of the page not
exactly centered but it lets us work
with it and see it in that regard now
we've covered a few things about text
and font already in this series and one
of those was setting the font size and
we already know we want to let the
browser set the default font size so
that enables the user to make a choice
as far as their settings and it also
helps accessibility and then when we do
set a font size like i'm about to here
on the body we want to use root ems that
is referencing the roots font size or
that default font size that the browser
sets which is usually defaults to 16
pixels so if i say two
root ems here rem this will probably set
it to about 32 pixels and there you can
see we have a much larger font size and
now i can see the padding is a little
too large for what i want to do so i'll
put this back to 10 percent in there
it's kind of in the part of the page
where we'll see it the best and we'll be
able to reference the different things
we're going to do to the text and font
today now also notice and we learned
this as well in the past
that through inheritance font and text
settings are usually inherited so the
children of this body element would
inherit the font size of two realms
unless we set a specific one on those
child elements however
they do not
inherit the size here inside of a form
so notice the label has that font size
inherited but it did not get inherited
in the input or the button so after the
body here we could also
select both the input
and the button
and then inside of this we could say
font
and inherit
and now they will both inherit that font
size that we put on everything else one
other thing we've already learned is
that we can change the color of the
different text on our page and we can
just do that through the color property
so i'll change this to purple so it's a
noticeable change we can see everything
changed here to purple i really don't
want to do that today but it is one of
the things we've already covered so i'm
going to remove that but now we do know
how to change the different colors
of our text on the page now i want to go
ahead and remove this form as we're not
going to use it for the rest of the
tutorial so just quickly back inside of
the index.html
i'll select the form and i can press
shift alt and the letter a to just
comment that form out so we don't see it
on the page but it's still there in the
source code if we want to go back to it
and we can do the same here inside of
our css so i'll highlight the input and
the button style press shift alt and the
letter a and vs code will comment out
the style in the css so we've removed it
essentially from our html and css but
it's still there to reference if you
want to go back and work with form
elements now when i'm speaking sometimes
i will say font when i mean text but
they are really two different things
notice i'm creating a little extra space
here in our css so we have some text
settings that aren't impacted by the
font choice at all and let's go over
those first so let's select our
paragraph here on the page and we'll set
some text settings for that and the
first one we should go over is text dash
decoration and we can see the different
choices we get right away
when we choose text decoration because
vs code wants to help us one typical
text declaration to set would be
underline so let's go ahead and save
this and now we can see our full
paragraph text is underline another
choice which is just the opposite is
line
and when we set that you can see now we
have a line above the text instead of
below it
and then there's also
line dash through and if we save that it
does exactly what you expect it to it
puts a line through the text maybe you
just have a few words you want to cross
out and you surround those words in a
span element and then you set this line
through property for that specific span
element and that would probably be a
class you would create to do that
so after we've gone over those text
declaration settings the other one you
may see is none
now that is the default for a paragraph
text like this but what if you had a
link text links are usually underlined
by default and so setting none would
remove the underline on a link and those
are the typical settings i'm not going
to go over every setting today because
there are so many for text but i'll go
over the most common the next text
setting we'll look at is text
transform
and after that you can see our
selections pop up here in visual studio
code again so if we choose capitalize
and save now it capitalized the first
letter of every word in our paragraph
likewise we could choose lowercase
and now every letter is lowercase not
just the first letter but every letter
and then we could choose uppercase and
we'll get the opposite as well and now
we have all upper case okay now after
text transform another very common text
setting is text align
what we normally have
is a line left so this is typically the
default for paragraphs and you see this
and look to the right this is not
uniform over here each line has kind of
a different ending point and this is how
we typically see a paragraph when we're
looking at a paper or something like
that like a a school paper however a
newspaper might choose to justify or a
magazine paragraphs and now notice
the right hand column is uniform here
where it all ends at the same place just
like the left side does and then of
course we can text align right which is
the opposite of text align left and now
it's uniform on the right but it is not
on the left and sometimes when we write
a paragraph we want to indent that first
line so let's remove this and save so
you can see the default settings so
here's our paragraph we have no indent
up here at all but we can choose text
dash
indent and here is a good spot to use
em units so i'll say 2em
and save and now we have an indent of
two m's that's em units and it just
indents that first line of course we can
set it to a bigger number and you can
see it go over even further so you can
really see it
go into action however two seems about
right here so if we need to indent that
first line we can do that with text
indent and of course there are more text
settings that you can pull up as well
and
refer to mdn the mozilla developer
network where they have great
documentation for all of these another
way to find out about text properties
besides mdn is to just type text and
then you can see visual studio code
start to make suggestions here for some
other settings you may want to look up
but i've gone over the ones that i
believe are the most commonly used okay
i'm going to save again so we get back
to the default for our paragraph and
there's a few other properties that
impact typography that do not start with
text or font so let's quickly go over
those and one is line height
line height accepts units just like we
went over in our unit and sizes tutorial
so we could use different percentages
and things like that however it also
just accepts a number and the default is
usually right around 1.2 so we probably
won't see much of a change to our
paragraph when i set the line height to
1.2
however it starts to look much better
around 1.4 or 1.5 so i'll go with 1.5
and i think that really increases the
readability of our paragraph not that i
can read latin but just the line height
increase here made a big difference so
i'll go ahead and cut this and save and
you can compare see how it looks much
more crowded and it's a little more
jumbled to my eyes at least but if i
paste this in
and save
that would make it much more readable
especially at a distance and on a screen
sometimes my eyes get weary so i believe
that helps okay i'm going to leave line
height there because i believe that does
help the readability but i'm also going
to add letter dash
spacing
and this does exactly what you'd think
it would do it increases the space
between the letters of the words so if
we put in
oh let's go with
1 m
and save
it really spaces those letters out
doesn't it we probably don't want to
stick with that unless we're going for
some kind of special effect
maybe down to 0.25 well it's definitely
more readable but it looks kind of weird
to me still maybe 0.1
and you may see text like that somewhere
some time in a heading or something to
draw attention to that looks like it may
work but i wouldn't use letter spacing
too often because it seems normal to me
when it's just at the normal setting
presented by the browser and in addition
to letter spacing there is word spacing
so let's go with
2m there and notice the difference it
really spaced those words out so we
could come back maybe 0.5
and yes we've got some extra space
between the words once again it's an
effect more to me than it does anything
to really increase the readability
however maybe if we got to a much
smaller size maybe it would help let's
see
well it's noticeable still i don't know
if i like it better but it is an option
so we have letter spacing and word
spacing but i do believe
increasing the line height just a little
bit from the default that's around 1.2
to more like 1.4 or 1.5
depending on the text you're working
with could really help that readability
okay moving on to some font properties
now that actually start with the word
font and i can put in a dash
and let me do that again put in a dash
in visual studio code starts to suggest
some things the first one it does is
font size which we've already gone over
let's skip font family for now and go to
font weight
so for the font weight that's
essentially whether it's bold or not in
normal or the default is right around
400 so if i save this we won't notice
much of a change well i noticed a bit of
a change let's see what 300 is like
and yet maybe normal was more like 300
for this particular font but overall
for 300 to 400 is kind of normal let's
go back and see what visual studio code
offers for values that we could choose
from so now you see we've got 100
through 900 900 being
very bold and 100 being not bold at all
and then there's also just some words we
could choose bold bolder lighter and
then of course normal so let's go with
normal
and see what that looks like well normal
looks more like what we had at 400 there
let's go with
lighter
and save and
it's not too light but it's noticeably
lighter than it was let's go with
bolder
and that's very bold we can definitely
see the difference there so
100 would be very light
and 900 would be very bold and if you
don't set the font weight you can expect
it to be somewhere right around what
normal was to begin with now let's look
at font
dash style
and if we set font style we're setting
possibly
the italic
setting and if we save that's exactly
what you expect we have italic text
there is also
oblique which essentially is a stronger
italic it just has a little bit more
emphasis there and as you might expect
after learning about font weight it also
has a normal setting so that is the
default and it's basically that without
setting a font style as well okay now we
get to the big settings something we
typically set not on an individual
paragraph unless we want to change the
font specifically for the paragraph but
let's set this on the overall body of
the page
this is the font family property notice
visual studio code is providing lots of
suggestions here that we'll go over in
just a minute but there are some main
generic families and one is serif
and if i save
it's pretty much what the browser
default already was and this is the type
of font family that we see in academic
papers
newspapers
papers you'd see in school overall
however on the web it's much more
popular to use the sans serif family
if i save that you can definitely see
the change here
and this text is more like you would see
on many popular web pages even though
there may be variations of
then another generic family is mono
space
oops i didn't spell that right i need
mono space there we go
if i save that you can see mono space
has the same spacing for every character
so
this looks much more like an old
typewriter or something like that where
it gives each character equal spacing
then there is also the cursive family
and that looks a little different as
well you may have seen fonts like that
before
and i believe there's the fantasy family
save that yes and that also looks
different here
i would possibly think about using just
a little bit of letter spacing it looks
a little crowded to me but overall those
are the generic families but those are
usually used as a fallback because we
have more specific fonts that make some
changes so when visual studio code was
suggesting these font family values
let's go with this first one we see here
courier new
and then courier
and i'm going to press alt z so the code
wraps over here on the left so you can
see this full font family setting so
courier new is the first choice and then
the second choice is a fallback so if
our computer whether it's windows mac or
whatever and they do have different
fonts installed
if our computer doesn't have courier new
then it's going to look for courier and
finally after that it's going to look
for mono space so it doesn't
necessarily use all three it uses the
first choice if available if not it uses
the second choice and if not the third
also notice the courier new has a space
in it and anytime the font name has a
space in it you need to put quotes
around the name to handle that spacing
the names that don't have a space do not
need any quotes at all so let's save
this
and here we are using courier new i
believe on the page which looks a little
different
now let's choose something else from a
different font family so we had the
monospace family right there let's go
with
ariel and you can see visual studio code
instantly suggests a full font stack
which is what these are when you have
multiple choices
this suggests ariel then helvetica and
then finally the sans serif generic
family so let's save that
and this is a font you see much more
often on the web overall and arial is
fairly commonly installed on both mac
and windows and probably linux any other
type of computer okay after that maybe
verdania is another one in that
sans-serif family you would see and here
this font stack has four choices
actually for dania geneva tahoma and
then eventually sans serif also notice
that sans serif does not need quotes
around it because it has a dash it does
not have any spaces so if we save that
this looks just a little bit different
than when we had arial now if we did
want to choose a serif font instead of a
sans serif font a very popular one is
times new roman and you can see the
suggestions here from vs code we've got
times new roman in quotes again then
times and then serif so if we save that
this is more like what the default
browser font looked like and i've got a
couple of good links about what are
called web safe fonts and that's
essentially what is being suggested here
by visual studio code when you use these
stacks they're fairly web safe they
don't need to be installed from an
external source typically the computers
would already have these available to
the browser i'm going to switch this
back to arial
choose that and save and i'll leave the
page like this now okay i'm going to
grab the browser and take it to full
screen now
and now that we're there i'm going to go
to my next tab which is
fonts.google.com and now we're going to
choose an external font from google
fonts and this is very common practice
and we can load this in and then use it
on our page so here's a very popular
font roboto so we can select it and it
says it has 12 different styles so now
it takes us to the ribato page and you
can see the different styles
notice this says thin 100 here for this
style
now this means that that
font weight is 100 essentially here's
light 300 light 300 italic so you can
choose some of the styling right here at
google fonts i typically choose not to
and just get a generic font and then try
to apply my own styles as well but you
can see the different ways the font will
appear and that's really nice to look at
like that so i would typically just
choose the regular 400 and see if i
could modify it with my own css now
there are different ways we can link to
this
google fonts lets us choose a link that
we can put in the head element of our
html
or
it lets us choose an import let's look
at the link version first so if i were
to do that i would be choosing this link
section here and it says i have more
than one link selected so i previously
had selected another font here i'm going
to click the minus symbol remove it so i
only have roboto
and now there is still this link section
i would need to copy all of this and
then i would do that with control c for
example now i would need to go back to
my code so let's do that
and here inside of the code i'm going to
need to go to the html
and then let's make this take up the
full screen for a little bit
and inside of the html in the head
section
before the link to my style sheet
because it needs to use the fonts i need
to paste in
these extra link elements that google
provided so it's going to get the
information from google fonts loaded in
and then my style sheet can read it but
although we're loading it in here we're
not quite finished because we haven't
applied it to our css so they will not
be used yet at this point i'll drag this
back over and now google is also saying
we need to apply this line in our css to
use it notice roboto has a sans-serif
fallback so it's part of that font
family
i'll copy that
go to the css and where i had ariel
helvetica and sans serif here
i will replace it with what google
suggested and provide roboto and sans
serif now note they put quotes around
roboto and that won't hurt anything
either so we'll leave it as they suggest
now let's go back to our document
and notice we're using the google font
roboto now now you can choose more than
one font from google as well the more
you attempt to load in from google
though the longer your page will take to
load so i suggest grabbing no more than
you absolutely think is necessary i do
want to show you how to use the import
in your css instead of the link in your
html so let's click
the at import here and now you can see
it's not quite as much code and what
else i like about this is it goes right
in your css if you want to notice they
put it between the style element which
could still go inside of the head of
your html if you were to copy all of
this i'm not going to select the style
element tag the opening or closing just
what's in between because i'm going to
put this directly
into my css file so now that i've copied
the at import statement i would normally
put it right up here at the top of my
css
and you want it before it would load
anything in now of course this is
wrapping the code because it's a longer
line with the url
but i'm going to save this i'm going to
go back to the html
i'm going to remove all of those links
that we had of course leave our own
style sheet
and now we'll still be able to use the
roboto font even though i've removed
those links from the head section of the
html i now have the import statement at
the top of my css and if i go back to
our document i can even reload and we
still have the roboto font ready to use
because we've imported it at the top of
the css
let's move on to styling links with css
you can see i've got visual studio code
open i have some basic styles in from
the last tutorial where we have some
padding a font size and a font family a
small font stack set on the body element
we're also importing in a font from
google fonts you can do that if you want
to and the starter code is available or
you can set your own font family stack
if you want to as well
also over in the file tree you'll see i
have an
index.html and in this index i have not
only a header with an h1 heading i have
a main element that has about five
paragraphs and at least four of those
paragraphs have links in them and then i
have a couple of other html files
very very basic they just contain an h1
element in the body that's because i
needed something to link to so i created
a couple of those files as well
so let's go back to the style and i will
resize visual studio code to pull it
over to this half of the page and i'm
going to hide the file tree by pressing
ctrl b
and we'll pretty much be able to see our
styles here the only thing is a long
line like this import of the font will
wrap now over on the right you can see
i've got chrome open and i'm using the
live server extension so anytime we make
an update to our css we'll automatically
see it over here on the right styling
our hypertext links
is really an extension of the typography
that we just covered in the last
tutorial in this series because it's
still text so a lot of the things we
learn about typography we can apply
to our links but also these links have
their own default styles that are
different from the rest of the text on a
page and when we talk about links in
html we're talking about an anchor tag
and usually that links to something with
an href attribute so these first two
links that i have linked to google
searches they're different searches one
searches for web links and one searches
for hyper text links
and then i've got a couple of links that
just go to the other two html pages we
created guitars and javascript although
those pages actually do not have that
content
just went ahead and created links that
would hold that content so let's note
the default styles of these links
they're underlined that's the first
thing to note
also if the link has not been visited
it's a blue color but notice the
hypertext links link that we have here
and it is purple so we know this is a
visited link and we can tell all of this
just by looking at the page
also when we point at a link it changes
our cursor from this arrow
to a pointer it's a little hand pointing
its finger at the link so that is called
a pointer cursor and then there's
another default style that we can't even
see yet and that is when we click on a
link so i'm going to click and hold down
on this link
and it turns red so this is when the
link is active and that is another
default style that is set
so i'm going to go ahead and let go and
it goes back to purple without visiting
the link
and if we did visit the link and come
back it would still be purple as visited
so now that we know the default styles
let's look at how those are set the
first one being text decoration
that we would set and that is what
controls the underline so the default
would be underline and if we save we
shouldn't see any difference
but oftentimes developers want to take
away that underline and style something
different you do want to make sure that
it still indicates somehow that these
are links you want them to stand out in
some way and an underline is a good way
for that to happen but if you want to
take that away you can but you have to
do something else to make the link stand
out okay we also mentioned the cursor so
we can set a cursor
but really cursors have semantic values
and i'll see what visual studio code
pulls up there's lots of different
choices here but let's look for example
at a not allowed cursor and it has a
semantic value it tells us something
just when we see it so when i point at
javascript you can see we get the little
icon that says this is not allowed and
we know what that means so really we
don't want to change that from a pointer
most of the time there is
not really a reason to do that so let's
keep that as pointer but i'll leave that
here so you know the cursor can be set
to different values and of course the
starting color before the link has been
clicked is just set by color and here we
see blue is the default color and i
believe that is the actual default color
and not some variant of blue let me save
again and see if i see a difference
and no it really looks the same to me
but it may look different to you
but once i set this to blue notice what
happens to the visited link it's changed
because it overwrote the default value
and then we haven't set anything for the
visited link so we need to learn how to
do that as well so what i'm about to
show you is called a pseudo class so
we'll once again select the anchor
element but now we put a colon
and now i can put
a definition after here that defines
which pseudo class that i want to select
and right now i want to select
the visited pseudo class and pseudo
classes represent the current state of
the element because a state of an anchor
element can change it is either been
visited or it hasn't and there are some
others that will cover as well so for
visited let's go ahead and put this back
to the default
and save
and now you can see our hypertext link
is once again purple now our other links
haven't been visited so they're still
blue now let's look at another pseudo
class that we can define and this pseudo
class is called hover when we hover over
the link it doesn't have a default value
right now if we hover over a link it
doesn't change at all either the visited
or the not visited link both of them
still just stay the same so let's go
ahead and change this
and for now let's just choose a
different blue and i'm going to show you
a trick or two where you can choose
something kind of in the same range of
the color you have selected for your
link but first let's just
choose a blue randomly here so now when
we hover
notice javascript is changing colors
when i hover over it and even the
visited hypertext links will change
color as well because now when we hover
over the link we have changed that state
it's now in the hover state and it is
changing the color of the link and then
remember we still have the active state
as well but
right now that's not working either
because that was a default style and we
have overwritten that what has followed
has been visited and hover
and really we don't have the default
style applied anymore so let's go ahead
and put in that active link
and we can change it to something like
what it was i think it was red so that
will definitely stand out
select that and now when i click hyper
text link it definitely turns red and i
think i visited the link and now we're
searching for hypertext links so i'll go
back to our page
and we can see that this link was
visited but if i click and hold down we
can see that it's active and now i'll
just pull away and not visit the link
now we have to consider specificity and
we also have to consider the order these
are in for the cascade so if we put
visited
above
our anchor selector
visited will still be applied here even
though the anchor selector comes
afterwards in the cascade and that's
because this visited pseudo class has
more specificity than just an element
just the anchor element and we can see
that if we go to the specificity
calculator and i have this linked to in
the resources and now if i just put in
an anchor element you can see the score
is just 0 0 1 but if i put in an anchor
element with a visited or any other
pseudo selector now the pseudo selector
here is a class i said pseudo selector a
pseudo class i'm selecting the pseudo
class classes attributes and pseudo
classes so this has more specificity and
that's why the visited link continues to
stay purple even though the anchor
element comes afterwards in the cascade
but that's not usually the order we want
things we usually kind of want to think
about it in the order that we would have
them so i'm going to put that visited
back
but now visited hover and active all
have the same specificity and one can
overwrite the other so we really have to
think about the order we put those in
let me save this and right now they're
all working because this is the proper
order have your anchor tag and then have
your visited pseudo class your hover
pseudo class and finally you're active
and they should all work so when we
hover it works
visited of course is working and if i
click active it is working however if i
rearrange these they may not so let me
go ahead and take hover
and put it above visited and so now
visited comes after in the cascade and
when i hover that still works it hasn't
been visited but let's check our visited
link
the hover doesn't work anymore so it's
important to have these in the correct
order i'll take hover
and put it back where it belongs in this
order so you want your anchor tag
then your pseudo class of visited
then your pseudo class of hover and
finally your pseudo class of active
and there's one more very important
pseudo class and you usually see it
added to the same style as the hover and
we can do that here
just by putting a comma
and then putting in the focus pseudo
class and this really makes your page
more accessible because
if a visitor or a user of your page is
using a screen reader and instead of
using a mouse they are tabbing through
your page
notice that right now we've selected the
first link here and it has the outline
around it i am tabbing through the links
and by doing that
when it has focus it is changing the
color of the link just like we did with
the hover and that's important to make
your page accessible as well okay i'm
going to take the focus off of that link
and i'm going to remove all of these in
the anchor tag all of these styles
because they're the default styles
anyway and what i do want to put in here
is a different color
we often see
a color of black we already have black
text
but notice
now the links are underlined with the
black text and i commonly see this on
web pages as well so we don't always
take away the underlines sometimes we
use the same color as the rest of the
text but we add the underline to make
them stand out notice you can still have
a hover you can still have a visited
color if you want to but oftentimes you
don't see a visited color either so we
can just comment that out and leave it
in the code
and now we don't have a different color
for a visited link and that's okay if
you want to do that
but we still have a hover color and we
still have a focus color as well
so now let me back this up just i wanted
to show a different version of that i'll
go ahead and put the visited color back
in
and up here let's go ahead and put in
blue
let's do a different color though let's
do steel blue i like that color
we'll save and now we have steel blue
links
and when we mouse over it looks okay but
let me show you a couple of things you
can do to stay within the same color and
yet make it noticeable that you are
hovering going back to when we covered
colors in the different tutorial we
learned how to use the vs code color
selector so i moused over the color here
and it pulled up the color selector and
i can click on the color bar
and go to hex from the rgb and i can
also go to hsl and i'm going to choose
hsl here
and now let's leave it at that and
notice it's 207 44 and 49.
now let me just copy this
and i'm going to take it to our hover
instead of the dodger blue and now right
here this number is the number we want
to change it changes the color and so
that pulled it up
and now we can just make this a little
lighter
choosing something different on the
color wheel if you remember the way
these numbers work it's just something
different in the wheel i'll take it down
to 189 notice the other numbers are
still the same 44 and 49 so we've just
changed the shade just a little bit on
the color wheel and when we mouse over
it kind of goes with the color theme and
that is a good way to change that so in
hsl you're really only changing
the first number and you're selecting a
number
close to what you had and that is one
way to get a similar color that
complements what you originally had
another approach and i will go ahead and
comment out the color
but another approach is to use an
opacity property which is making
something transparent
and remember with colors we could add
that right inside of this hsl as well
but i'll show you how to do it here with
the opacity property and let's put this
to
1 would be the max and 0 would be
completely
invisible transparent so let's put this
around 0.9
to just give it a little bit of
transparency when we mouse over
and you can see the color changes it's
keeping the same color but it just gets
a little bit lighter and maybe the 0.8
would even be more noticeable let's try
that
and that also works but when you learn
about this
note that opacity will change everything
so if you use this on something else
let's go up here
and let's put in the main element
now if i put this in
it made everything on the page a little
bit lighter i'll make it much more
noticeable here
now that made all of the paragraphs
much more transparent so you want to be
careful when you use that now remember
also
in the hsl and also in rgba there is a
channel that allows you to add a
transparency value so here we could also
do 0.8
and now when i mouse over we'll still
get a transparency
as well
and it's also changing color there so if
we wanted to we can put this back to the
exact same color but now we've added the
transparency
so if we save and mouse over we still
get a little lighter color and it's
really the same exact shade we're just
lightening it up with a little bit of
transparency there okay before we finish
i just want to emphasize that these
pseudo classes are not just for changing
colors you can adjust other things
although changing the color of links and
the visited hover focus active all of
those pseudo classes that's a common
application of this
but we could do other things as well one
thing i've seen is changing a background
so let's change the background here to
gold and it will be kind of like a
highlighter so when we focus and i'm
tabbing through we're kind of
highlighting the links of course you'd
want to choose a complementary color
there as well
but that is something else i have seen
before is kind of adding a highlight to
each link as it has focus or as it's
hovered over
let's move on to styling lists with css
you can see i've got visual studio code
open and the starter code has an
index.html file and in this index.html
file we have a header inside the body
that has an h1
and then we have a main element and this
main element has two articles in it the
first article element has an ordered
list and we can see that with the h2
title and then the ordered list
underneath the second article has an
unordered list and we can see that with
the h2 title and the unordered list so
the only difference between these two
lists
is the beginning element the ol or the
ul ol being ordered list and ul being
unordered list so i wanted to take a
look at the html first
the css that we're starting out with
just has a couple of basic things an
import from google fonts where we're
using the roboto font that you see here
and then just a little bit of padding
and setting the font size to two rims in
the body so the default for the browser
is probably 16 pixels so when we double
that with two rims we're now at 32
pixels for anything in the body let me
pull visual studio code over to the left
side of the screen and here in chrome we
can see this page and so we have our
ordered list here on top
our unordered list underneath you can
see the ordered list has ordinal numbers
here one two three the unordered list
just has bullet points
now i'm going to go ahead and hide the
file tree so we can see our css a little
bit better also press alt z so anything
that would be longer like this url for
our google font wraps to the next line
also worth noting that we're using the
live server extension so
any change we make here in the css will
automatically see over here in the
browser as it will update immediately
let's style the ordered list first and
the first property we want to look at
for the ordered list is list dash style
dash type and here we get a list from vs
code and we can choose different things
to appear to the left where we see the
numbers so for example let's choose
lower alpha and i'll save and now we can
see we have
lower alphabet letters here so abc
otherwise we could choose some other
things that i don't even recognize they
have in here like
let's get this reference again let's
look at
oh georgian
and maybe somebody else would understand
these symbols i certainly don't but here
we see symbols to the left that
represent whatever georgian is
usually the default here is
decimal and so if i save that we're back
to our numbers that's the default value
you could also see
i believe it said decimal leading 0.
there we go so if we chose that we would
get a 0 in front of each of the numbers
so you've got lots of choices to make
and by the way list style type and all
the properties we'll look at can apply
to unordered lists as well we're just
looking at this first with the ordered
list
so i'm going to go ahead and choose
something here that will make this look
like an unordered list at first so let's
look at
bullet i believe it was bullet let me
check the selection
and did i see bullet here
not bullet it's disk there we go i call
it bullet points but they're actually
disks is what they're referred to
so this looks just like our unordered
list now so the only way we could tell
that this is an ordered list is to
actually look at the html code at this
point so we can make one look like the
other another choice i often see
is circle but because it's an ordered
list let's stick with something that is
in order so i believe i saw an upper
roman let's choose that one and save and
so now we see roman numerals one two and
three now while we're mostly focusing on
the css primarily let's go to the html
quickly and there's a couple of
attributes we can add that will change
how our list appears one is the start
attribute so let's tell this to start
at three and when i save now you can see
we get the numbers three four and five
and then we can also add a
reversed attribute
and as you might guess now it counts
down three two one because it starts at
three so if we started this at five
knot would count down five four three
it's also worth noting that if we are
not using numbers over here such as the
roman numerals or decimals we still need
to use a number value here for this
start attribute so if i switch this back
it's just going to be what references
that so i will switch this to
lower alpha once again and save and
you'll see it references the fifth
letter of the alphabet the fourth letter
and the third letter as it's counting
down from five to three let's also
consider that we could not have any kind
of bullet or numeric out to the left so
let's just put none here and save and
you'll see that that's eliminated but
notice it's still indented and that's
because we have some default padding so
we would have to set the padding to zero
if we want our list items to go all the
way back to the left let's take a look
at that unordered list now so i'll put
ul here in our style sheet and let's set
the list style type on it as well i'm
going to set that to square instead of
the disks and if we save we can see we
have square bullet points now now the
next list property to look at
is list style position but first let's
look at an issue that might get caused
with list style position so in our
unordered list if i set the text align
to center and save
notice what happens to the bullet points
i've centered the text but the bullet
points are still to the left
some browsers have been known to handle
this differently
and send the bullet points to the middle
and some leave them to the left and the
difference is the list
style
position default value some browsers
have a default of outside such as chrome
and some have it inside or at least they
have at one point i haven't checked
browsers in a while instead of chrome
but right now i have to set the list
style position to inside to get the
bullet points to align
with the text
but if we set them to the default
outside they stay out to the left i'm
going to scroll up for some more room as
we look at this unordered list and now
notice if i set the color to
a blue here with hexadecimal
and save
it changes
all list items to blue so that is worth
noting as well if you set the color
property it changes the bullet points
and the text to blue we can set other
text properties to or typography
properties such as line height so i'm
going to set this to 1.6 and you'll see
some extra space between each of the
list items now the last list style
property we want to look at is list
style
image and we can set an image to use
instead of the bullet points now let's
quickly look at the file tree notice
i've got an images file and in that i've
got a check mark image it's check mark
dot png and we're going to use that as
we set this i'll hide the file tree
again but now we have to specify url and
then parentheses
and then navigate the file path to the
image so we're going up out of the css
folder with two dots
now we put a slash and go into the
images folder and then we choose our
check mark and i will save
and notice those bullets have now got
changed to these green circles with a
check mark in them and that's our check
mark png and there's also shorthand for
all three of these list style properties
i'm going to press shift alt and the
down arrow to copy down our list style
image
and then i'm going to remove the image
and we just say list style and we can
put all three properties here with
shorthand so i'll quickly
cut this with ctrl x and first we'll
just set this to square and you'll see
how it overrides
the list style image so we're back to
our squares here for the bullet points
but then we can also supply an image and
when we do that the square becomes the
fallback in case the image would not
load and so now when i save we've once
again got the image and then finally we
can provide the position and so i'll say
inside and now the images are over with
the text of each list item so this is
called shorthand we just say list style
and we can provide one two or all three
of these values that would be the list
style type the list style image and the
list style position we can also override
styles from the unordered list for
example on each list item now this would
apply to all list items even in the
ordered list because i'm just saying li
and not specifying the unordered list or
the ordered list as well but we can
override styles because this comes later
in the cascade as well but it's also
more specific
because we're down to the nested list
items so if i wanted to change the color
of all list items
let's do something obvious here to red
and there i put a hashtag first there we
go just the word red now they've all
changed to red however if i just wanted
to change the unordered list items i'd
have to put the ul first and then save
and now it just applies to the unordered
list items however what if i just wanted
to make the second list item read now we
can use another pseudo class i'll put a
colon and then nth which is nth des
child
and then parentheses and now i'll just
put the number 2 inside the parentheses
and notice it only changed the second
list item in the unordered list to red
so we were more specific and we just
changed one list item likewise our nth
child pseudo class also accepts the
words
odd so if we pass in odd now the odd
numbered list items are red and likewise
we could pass in even and do the same so
now we're back to just number two
because it's the only even number and it
has turned red and of course you could
apply other styles besides just the
color here as well if you wanted to
as you select each individual line item
or all line items in any specific list
okay from that i want to move on from
the pseudo class of nth child to a
pseudo element which we have not
introduced any of those yet in this
series this pseudo element is called
marker and it starts with two colons and
then the word marker and all pseudo
elements should start with two colons
instead of one like a pseudo class now
we can change some things about the
marker and that's usually what we would
have here for a bullet or letters
outside of an ordered list or numbers so
let's go ahead and comment out the list
style image and i do that with shift alt
in the letter a and then it comments
that out here in visual studio code and
i'll save now we're back to
blue and red
squares which we specified up here in
our unordered list so let's say we want
to change all of those back to a black
color but keep the text in blue and red
so here we can specify a color for the
marker and specify the hex code for
black and save and now you can see once
again we have black squares out here as
markers i'm going to scroll up for some
more room because there's a few other
properties we can add here as well i'm
going to change this to red actually
because
we'll highlight something like we would
on a sale page i'll change the font
family of the markers and here i'll put
fantasy
and might change the size a little bit
but they're currently still squares
we can set the font size if we wanted
bigger markers like 1.5 m and save you
can see those markers got quite a bit
bigger i think we'll just go with one m
for now
and then we can also provide content and
this is where it gets interesting so
imagine we had a page
selling sub sandwiches or pizzas or some
food item whatever was on sale and we
said only five dollars and put a couple
of arrows
and now if we save you can see that
applied here but notice we didn't
specify a list either so it also applied
to the un or i mean to the ordered list
we have the unordered list down here but
before we had told the ordered list to
have a list style type of none but when
we provide content it's still applied so
in that regard you want to be more
specific and we could say just apply
that to our unordered list and this is
just like above where we supplied the ul
we could also actually say
li here and it would be the same result
as well but it's all markers in our
unordered list so we don't have to put
the li there and it identifies the
unordered list and changes now what if
you want a space well currently we have
set the list style position to inside so
when we centered the text this kind of
threw that off a little bit
but also
we didn't allow a space so maybe we just
put a space in our content and save and
that did create a little bit of space
you could do it that way you could add
left padding
but since these are positioned inside
the left padding would be to the left of
the markers so that wouldn't work if you
did have your markers over here on the
left and provided left padding and of
course that would be by setting this to
outside i could do that really quick and
you would see what happens
now the padding would come after the
markers but really we're going to have
it
inside
and now we just provided that space with
a little bit of space right there now as
you learn more about web development you
can get creative with this content you
can put in what is called an spg and
those are often used for images and
icons you could also put in something
called font awesome icons and other
types of icons as well so this does hold
different types of content but it's easy
just to type in here and show an example
like that now before i finish there is
one other html attribute that can be
helpful although it's rarely used i do
want to show it before we're finished so
let's go ahead and switch this back
to something like
lower alpha there we go for our ordered
list and now our edc shows up and if you
remember that's because
we are starting with the number five and
it's reversed so if these were numbers
it would be five four three it
corresponds to the letters but we can
also specify a value so
if we say value here and we put in 26
this will definitely make a difference
now notice
z is the 26th letter of the alphabet so
the number corresponds still to whatever
the order is and we're going in reverse
order so instead of x y z it went z
y right here but this remained as number
five because that's where this started
so this value attribute
may come in useful in rare occasions i
definitely wanted to cover it i almost
forgot to but there we go i hope you
have learned a lot about styling lists
let's build a mini project for beginners
after completing several lessons in this
css tutorial series i think it's a good
idea to bring all of these different
pieces together and apply what you've
learned
i've got visual studio code open and in
the starter code you can see i have an
index.html file
and when we look at the body of this
index file you can see it has a nav
element and inside the nav element we
have an h2
and
a unordered list and this unordered list
has several list items all have their
own anchor links and it doesn't really
matter where they're linking to today i
just have it linking to our
other pages one and two that were there
just to link to in previous tutorials
but what we have is a list of appetizers
entrees desserts beverages and then it
just says about things you might
actually find on a menu in a restaurant
as well as a menu on a restaurant's
website and then at the very bottom here
we have one paragraph that says learn
more about amazing foods and i just
linked to an article on amazing foods
that's because we want to have one link
that is not in the list so we can select
it separately or avoid selecting it if
we want to so what i'm going to do now
is drag visual studio code to the left
and we can see chrome on the right i'm
using the live server extension so we'll
immediately see any changes and here is
our basic page really no styles applied
yet i'll press ctrl b to hide the file
tree and click on the style.css
you can see we're importing the roboto
font from google fonts like we learned
how to do in the typography chapter but
we're not even using it yet so really no
styles applied to the index.html so
let's start now and if you remember from
the box model chapter we covered a small
css reset so the first thing i'm going
to do is apply that reset so a margin of
padding of 0 and then we'll set box
sizing to
border box and when we save this will
eliminate some default styles and now we
can see everything is way up here in the
corner so any of that default padding
and margin
is gone
now let's select the body and we'll add
a few styles to it
that will be inherited throughout the
page however the first one will not be
it just applies to the body and that's
to put just a little bit of a margin
there i actually want rem
and that way when we save it pushes the
text away from the top and the left just
a little bit okay after that we're going
to go ahead and set the font family so
we start using that roboto font and
we'll set it to
roboto with a fallback of sans serif and
we can save that change and instantly we
see the the
font change over there to the right
after that i want to go ahead and align
the text for everything on this page to
the center normally we might put that
just inside of one area we were building
but in this case in this example
everything on the page will be centered
for a menu and now you can see that
centered over there on the right okay if
we look back at our html notice we're
using a nav element inside the body so
the next thing we're going to select in
our css is the nav element i'll scroll
up just a little bit and select the nav
let's put a border around the nav so
we'll say border 2 pixels solid and then
we'll choose
333 which is just a little bit lighter
shade of black instead of 0 0 0. so if
we save that you can see the border
around our nav now now let's add a
border radius
and that will let us round the corners
off just a little bit we'll set that to
two ram and when we save you can see
those corners now change to rounded
corners we learned about border and
border radius in our box model lesson we
also learn about margin i'll set the
margin for the top of the nav to zero
i'm going to set the margin for the left
and right to auto which will center it
if our page is wide enough and it needs
to be in the center and that means the
margin will eat up the space that's left
on the left and the right and then we'll
also have a margin on the bottom of one
rim now we won't notice that auto
spacing because right now the nav is a
block level element so it has a hundred
percent width except for the little bit
of margin that we provided on the body
here so we have some space but if we set
a max width
for this to let's set it to 600 pixels
now if we expand the page
the nav element won't expand to the full
100 width so let me grab this and drag
it over so it takes up the full page and
we can see now that our nav
is not the full width of the page so we
have limited it to a max width of 600
pixels and setting the margin to auto on
the left and the right has
resulted in centering the nav on our
page notice we also haven't
styled the list item yet so we see these
bullet points here outside of the nav
we've centered our text but as we
learned in the list
tutorial that the bullet points here are
set to default to be on the outside if
we want them at all and i think we're
going to remove them so i'll pull this
back over to the right and we'll
continue styling the page i'll scroll up
just a little bit but before we move on
from the nav we can set some typography
here that will be inherited so let's set
the font size now to three rim
and let's set the line height
to
seven rim and when we save things should
be much bigger looking back at our index
html again now inside the nav we have an
h2 before we get to the unordered list
so let's style that h2
the first thing we'll do is give it just
a little bit of padding so we'll set
that to one rim
and now let's set a
well let's set a background color first
and we'll set this to gold so if we save
now we can see we have a background
color on our h1 and it has the full
width of the nav because it's a block
level element so it has a hundred
percent width of what's available to it
but notice our border radius is not
being respected up here the gold
continues to look like a square although
we set a border radius on the nav
to have those curled or rounded corners
so now we need to adjust the border
radius here on our h2 as well and what
we'll do is start in the top left we'll
set this to
two rim and now the top right is also
two rim because that's where the curved
corners are then we'll have zero on the
bottom right and zero on the bottom left
because that still needs to be
the square corners so we'll save and now
notice the gold matches the curve of our
menu on the top left and top right okay
i'll scroll up for some more room and
we're ready to start styling our
unordered lists we'll put a ul here the
first thing we want to look at is the
list
style
position i mentioned those bullets
before if we put them inside
we can now see them but we don't really
want them do we so we don't really need
the list style position i just brought
that in so we can see that yes they are
still there what we want to do is say
list style type and then just set that
to none
and they will disappear now we can apply
a style to each list item so we'll say
li
and here we're just going to select
the border top we'll set this to 1
pixel solid and 333 to match the outer
border of the nav and now we have some
nice separation here between each of our
list items okay next we want to style
the links that are inside of our list
but notice we have a link that is not
inside the list down here it says learn
more about amazing foods so we do not
want to select this link so in order to
select the links that are only inside
the list we'll start with list item and
then the anchor tag and note we also
want to select list item the anchor tag
and the visited pseudo class and then
here we're going to say
text
decoration
set that to none and we'll set the color
to that 333 color so we have a dark
color and so now we have a dark color
here for visited links and links that
haven't been visited so let's quickly
visit one we just have our simple page
two we go back and it remains the same
color let's scroll up for some more room
again and now we'll go ahead and style
some other pseudo classes here so we'll
have the hover sudo class
and we'll also have
the focus pseudo class
and for those we'll set the background
to the 333 so just the opposite and here
we'll set the color
to
white smoke which is just a little bit
of an off-white color and let's set the
cursor
to pointer
and now
when we select that or save that now we
should see
the mouse over changes and so now
the text is that white smoke color and
we get a black background but that's not
really what we want we don't want it
just on the words we want it on the full
list item so we're going to have to make
a change to make that happen so above
where the styling began on the different
anchor tags in the list item
i'm going to say
li with the anchor tag and only that not
the visited pseudo class so this is a
separate selector we'll set this to
display block which displays a property
we haven't covered yet in a previous
module but we did if you took the
beginner's html course as well we did
cover block display and inline display
so this is a block level element
normally the anchor tag is an inline
level element so we are changing it to a
block level element the bonus here is
the block level elements have 100
percent width so when i save this
this will change and now when i mouse
over any one of these
this anchor tag has the full width and
is filling the entire space here of each
one of these list items
so now
this makes a big difference so i don't
even have to click on the text i could
click just over here to the left
and we still go to page one so
everything works there as expected but
there's still one change we need to make
can you guess what it is here's a hint
it's right here look at those bottom
corners they're not rounding either
they're not respecting that border
radius that we set on the nav so we need
to make a change to help enforce that as
well i'm going to scroll up so this will
be the last thing we put in our file
this is a little more difficult than
when we rounded the corners for the h2
because the h2 is easy to select it was
the only one on the page
but what about
this bottom one we have five different
list items so how do we just select the
last list item we're going to do that
with a pseudo selector and this will be
called last dash
child
and then we can go ahead and i guess we
need to put the a there
and then under that we can say border
dash radius
and now it will be zero on the top
because that still needs to be a square
zero on the top right as well so top
left top right now this is bottom right
needs to have that same
two rem setting
and then bottom left as well so let's
save and now let's mouse over
and you can see
that the border radius is respected here
as we mouse over the list items so there
is our basic menu and we selected all of
these without changing the link that we
had here in the bottom so again a
beginner's project but it certainly
showed you how to apply some of the
different things we've learned up to
this point we'll be learning more about
that display property that we introduced
and there's a lot more yet to learn
about css too let's move on to css
display types you can see i have visual
studio code here on the left and i have
an html file and in the html file i have
a body element a main element then that
is surrounding the other elements and
inside this main element i have two
paragraphs and in the second paragraph
i'm using a span element and that span
element has a class on it of opposite
around the word another you can also see
i've commented out a nav element that
contains an unordered list that we will
get to later i've also got a basic css
style sheet here and inside this i'm
pulling in a font from google fonts as
we learned in the typography lesson and
i've applied a basic font size and font
family then to the body element here in
the css so that's what we see over here
in the right in chrome and i'm using the
live server extension so you'll see our
changes automatically over here in the
browser as soon as we save our css
now the display property in css relates
back to something we learned in the
beginning html course and that is about
block level elements versus inline level
elements now the paragraphs that you saw
we've included in the html are block
level elements and they have some
default properties so let's look at
those first i'm going to apply a basic
style here to the paragraph element and
we'll say background
dash
color
and set that to let's do a light gray
and when i save you can see the light
gray extends
all the way across the page so
it has a hundred percent width by
default automatically block level
elements have a default 100 percent
width and they stack on top of each
other as we see here now they've also
got some default margin as well which is
why you see space between the paragraphs
but this is important to know so every
time we use another block level element
doesn't have to be a paragraph it could
be any element that is a block element
then they will stack on top of each
other now when i say 100 percent width i
mean of what is available to them it's
not always 100
of the viewport here that we see so
let's look at an example of that and
that's why i have a main element that
the paragraphs are inside of the main
element is also a block level element so
let's set the background color for it to
a different color so we can see it get
something kind of ugly that stands out
here just for this example so let's go
with aqua
we set that you can see
we are covering part of the main element
with the paragraphs but the part that
you can see where there is margin it
turned aqua so now we could take away
this background color and you can see
aqua across the whole thing so now that
we've done that let's also go ahead
and change the width of the main element
so let's set it to a width of 50 percent
and now you can see the paragraphs do
not extend all the way across our page
they are limited to their container
their parent element which is the main
element so they do have a hundred
percent width default setting but it's a
width of what they are given so i say
they have 100 width of what they are
given it's not necessarily 100 of the
page and of course we could return this
background color once again so we could
see exactly how much room they're taking
up and let's say light gray again
and save and once again we see they're
taking up 100 percent
of that main element with block level
elements we can also apply margin and
padding and height or anything like that
to all four sides so let's say margin
and i'll say 100 pixels on the top and
bottom and 50 pixels on each side and if
we save that definitely changed
everything because now this has a 100
pixel margin up here and then we've
added more extra margin in between the
paragraphs and then you don't even see
the margin that's underneath as well but
we can do that to block level elements
but this is where some of the change
comes in when we switch over to an
inline level element so i'm going to
remove that and let's remove the main
styles as well so we're back to spanning
the full page and remember i put a span
element around the word another which is
an inline level element
and that doesn't cause a new line break
so let's go ahead and style that
opposite class that was applied
to that span element just to make it
stand out we'll start with a different
background color
and i'll make this a flat black and then
we'll use a color that is
not quite full white white smoke and now
you can see we've styled this element
and it is just surrounding the word
another so our span element has a class
of opposite and we change the color for
the background and the text
but let's see what we can and can't do
with an inline element and so now let's
go ahead and try to put a margin
on the top of 100 pixels
and you can see nothing changes we can't
apply a top or bottom margin to a inline
element likewise we'll try a different
one let's go with
height
200 pixels
it doesn't change once again height
cannot be applied
and padding applies just a little
differently so let's look at that and
let's go with
one rim
and it looks like everything is as as
expected here where we have
a one rim padding top bottom left and
right however
if we go ahead and increase that let's
say 4m look what happens it overlaps
the above paragraph and we probably
wouldn't want that so now let's apply
the display property
and we've talked about this being
already as a default
inline
and then of course paragraphs default to
block and many other elements as well
like the main element we talked about
however there is another option and that
is inline
dash block and let's see what happens
when we apply that to our opposite class
now our padding is still applied but
it's not overlapping the other paragraph
so it is now respecting the top and the
bottom
likewise if we come back
and apply that margin and let's just say
margin dash top it could be bottom as
well but we'll just put 100 pixels for
the top
and that worked as well now you can see
we have extra space here and again this
is applying just to that span element so
not to the full paragraph itself and now
we could even add the height that we
applied earlier that didn't work and we
say 200 pixels and now
our span element just got a lot taller
so the inline block
property value is kind of a hybrid here
because we stayed in line in our
paragraph this didn't create a new line
like block would and at the same time it
now allows some properties to be applied
that normally wouldn't apply to the
inline display so to quickly recap block
level elements stack on top of each
other and always create a new line
inline elements do not stack on top of
each other and do not create a new line
block level elements automatically have
a 100 percent width of whatever they are
given if they're not inside of something
that is limiting their width they will
be the full width of the page inline
level elements only take up the width of
their content of course unless we put
extra padding on them and then it has a
little bit more width here because of
that padding and then when we switch to
inline block we get kind of a hybrid
here where we can keep the content in
line but we can go ahead and apply a top
and bottom margin or a height and other
things that typically only block level
elements have so when would inline block
be handy this could be handy if we were
trying to turn a link into a button and
sometimes people do style links as
buttons and then you can of course have
a row of those
and likewise it could be something like
turning a list into a row instead of a
vertical list so it would be horizontal
so let's look at an example of that and
i'm going to go back to the index.html
i'm going to select our paragraphs and
press shift alt and the letter a to
comment those out
and then select our nav element with the
unordered list in it once again shift
alt and the letter a to uncomment that
and now i'll save
and now we see a basic list with three
links over here to the right they say
intro portfolio and projects something
that we might use as a menu on a
portfolio website
so here we have the nav element and then
an unordered list and three list items
inside and then of course each list item
is an anchor link so a hypertext link
and those are inline elements however
the list items themselves are block
level elements and each one is taking up
one hundred percent width of what they
are given right now let's go back to the
css and apply some styles here so i'm
going to select these styles the
paragraph and the opposite class and go
ahead and delete those and save once
again so we can start fresh
and now let's apply something to the
unordered list first and we'll start
with a list
style
type and then we'll say
none and that removes those bullets that
we have after that you can see we're
still moved over to the right so we do
have some default padding on the list so
let's say padding dash left and we'll
just set that to zero
and then we'll save again and then after
that let's go ahead and say
text dash
align
right well what happened to my
css i've got an extra line in there you
can see what happened now so we know we
have 100 width and if we change the
background color here we can really see
that in action so let's say background
color let's go back to our light gray
and you can see we've got 100 width
going on once again and when we set the
text align right we sent all of our
links or all of our list items over to
the right and finally let's apply a
margin of 0 to the unordered list as
well
and now you can see it pulled it up
closer to the top of the page we could
actually apply a
css reset as well so let's do that
and that will put everything flush with
the edges of the page so we have margin
of zero
padding of zero and then
box sizing will set to border box and
save and you could refer back to our box
model module where we covered all of
this and setting a basic css reset but
now you can see we are flush with the
edges of the browser and our links are
once again all to the right now let's go
ahead and change this background color
and let's just change it to black and
save
and now we don't see the links as well
but we'll change that in just a little
bit for the list items let's change
those now and we'll say
display
inline dash block instead of their
default of block
and now when we save
you can see they are all side by side in
horizontal order instead of top to
bottom as they would be with the block
display now let's apply some margin
between each one of them and what we can
do here instead of saying top right
bottom left as we typically would with
the shorthand for margin we can just say
margin
inline and this will just apply to the
left and the right so i'll say 0.5 rim
and let's see how that looks
that looks okay
and we need a little bit of extra space
maybe over here on the right so let's
change the padding setting here we had
padding left of zero for the unordered
list
and that's okay but maybe we just want
to apply a little padding all the way
around so maybe 0.5 rem
everywhere on the unordered list top
bottom
right and left oh and that is just set
to padding jack's left right now so
let's go ahead and make that shorthand
for padding and apply it to all four
areas top right bottom and left now that
looks a little bit better so what we
need to do now is just apply some color
and maybe some hover styles for our
links so let's say
link and then the anchor tag so this
will only apply to anchor tags inside of
the list item i said link list item in
the anchor tag and now we'll say color
we'll make them white and then we'll
have a text
decoration
of none and when we save we now see the
words in white with no underlines
after that let's scroll for a little
more room
and we'll say
list item anchor tag
hover sudo class and once again list
item
anchor tag
focus pseudo class
and for that let's just change the text
decoration instead of the color
let's just go back to the underline
style so when we hover over they now
show as links now there are other
display values that we could use and
we're going to have separate modules on
the display type of flex and the display
type of grid and when we do that we'll
learn how to complete our menu bar that
might have something over here on the
left as well but before we go there's
one other value i do want to cover and
instead of inline block
block or just inline
you might have a value of none and look
what happens all the list items just
disappeared so let's go ahead and change
that back so they show up and maybe we
want our entire bar to disappear and
right now that is an unordered list so
let's say display
and none up here
and now it's entirely gone and that is
exactly what happens it completely
removes it from the document now we
would still see it over here in our html
but as far as the browser is concerned
when it interprets the code the
unordered list is not there now we
rarely want to use this and that is
because it removes it from that document
flow and that means anyone using
assistive technology screen reader would
not be able to read anything there there
are other ways to remove something from
being visible from actually being viewed
on the page but still have it in the
document flow where accessibility
might be still available and so we'll
cover that in the future as well but
right now just know that display none is
a possibility
let's move on to css floats you can see
i've got visual studio code open i have
an empty frame for a page we have
absolutely nothing in the body of the
page and then the style page the css has
an import of our roboto font from google
fonts and we've only set styles on the
body so far we've set the font size to
1.5 ram and we're using the roboto font
family so quickly if i pull vs code over
to the left you can see our page is
completely blank i'll let vs code take
up the full size of the page again
and let's start by creating some
elements in the body of the html that we
can style so i'm going to start off with
the div and give it a class of block
after that we can just put in the word
float for now because we will apply a
float to it and then we're going to
create some paragraphs so i'll use an
image abbreviation here and type p for
paragraph and then say times five then
the greater than symbol
lorem and 20 which means each paragraph
will be lorem epsom which is just
generic verbiage we can put on a page
for generic text content and each
paragraph will have 20 words so when i
press tab it should create five
paragraphs
and there we can save now let's go back
and look at our page and see what we
have so far
you can see our div has the word float
in it and there's nothing remarkable
about that div and then we see five
different paragraphs here on our page so
that's a good start to having some
content but now we want to apply some
css and explore what this float will
actually do with the class of block
so to
give that example let's go back to our
style and i'll hide the file tree by
pressing ctrl b
and now we'll be able to see most of our
css here so let's style this block class
that we created for that div i'm going
to apply a width first and i'm going to
set it to 30 viewport width units
and then i'm going to set a height and
i'm going to make that also 30 viewport
width units now you might wonder why i
didn't use percent but that wouldn't be
the same i wanted to use the exact same
units for the width and height and
create a square and we'll be able to see
that if i apply a background dash color
and then set that to black and i save we
now have a square that is 30 viewport
width units wide and it also has the
same height which truly does make it a
square
okay after that i'm going to go ahead
and apply a color so we can see that
word float and i'll make that white just
the opposite so there's the word float
now let's give it some padding maybe
one rim of padding and
there we have just a little bit of
padding that pulls the word float out of
the corner but now our div and all of
our paragraphs are block elements and so
they stack on top of each other but when
we float
this div element that we've created here
it will take it out of the normal flow
of the page and we should see our text
wrap around this and you could picture
this as being an image if you want to
but whatever content we would float and
we can float it left or right the text
will wrap so let's create another class
and i'll just call this class left
and then inside of this we'll apply the
style float and we'll say left
and when we save we don't get a change
yet because we haven't applied it to our
html so let's go ahead and apply this
second class to our div and now save and
we can see the text has wrapped up
around the div
so now it's more like you're used to
seeing in a newspaper where you would
have an image or something
over to the left or the right and the
text would go around it but now notice
this is flush it's right up against it
we might want a little space there and
we need to talk about how to do that
because your first instinct may be to
apply
some padding or margin to the paragraph
and i'll scroll for some more room let's
just look at the margin
left for the paragraph and say i applied
10 pixels
look what happens it still is flush here
you see it moved 10 pixels over here
this float is not
inside the normal flow so
the margin is applied from the left over
here and not where we would expect it to
be
at the left edge of our text and we can
see that even more so if i do something
greater like say 20 percent
and now yes it moved this way over but
it didn't move the text here at all so
we can't really apply that correctly by
applying it to the paragraph instead
we can apply some to the actual block
itself so let's do that and we can say
well let's do it to the left because we
might do it differently for the right so
let's do it to our left class here so we
would have a margin
on the right side of let's say one rim
so we should be able to see that and now
that makes the difference that we wanted
right here and also it makes our text
once again flush with
what would be our image or our div that
we currently have here on the left now
i'm going to highlight our left class
and then press shift alt and the down
arrow to copy it down
and i'm also going to create a right
class i need to select that correctly
there we go it's a right class so
instead of float
left it will be float right
but then instead of margin right let's
put a margin
left on it
and i'll save but we don't have it
applied once again to any div so we need
to come back into our code and let's say
after we've gone down three paragraphs
we want to have one more so we'll say
div
dot block
dot right and that should apply those
classes and it did so now we can save
and we have another div and it's floated
right and of course it is after
the first three paragraphs and we see
that one two three
and then it begins here with our fourth
paragraph and it's floated to the right
now i didn't put the word float in there
let's go ahead and do that just to make
them alike and this is the basic use
that we would have to float things to
the left or the right but there could
become some instances where we want to
handle this a little differently maybe
we want to
wrap this first paragraph and this div
that i've floated to the left in a
container and kind of highlight that at
the top and then have the second
paragraph start afterwards we might have
to handle that differently or let's say
we didn't even have the container but we
didn't want this second paragraph to
wrap and in the past it was handled a
little differently than it currently is
so let's create one more class and i'll
show you something you may see once
again i would say in more legacy code
let's call this a clear class
and then inside of this class we'll say
clear
and we can say
just
right
or just left if you want to clear
something that is specifically floated
left or right but it's very easy to just
say both and then it will clear both and
you'll see what this does in just a
moment here so what i need to do
is come back
and then after the first paragraph if i
wanted to clear that the old way would
be to apply another div to the page
and give it this class of clear and just
leave it empty and we would save
and then you can see the second
paragraph doesn't start
until after this div so it is cleared
and that allows us to go ahead and start
the second paragraph after both of these
but this could still be a problem if we
had this in a container and i will show
an example of that so let's apply a
container to the div and the first
paragraph and i'll just make it a
section element
and wrap it around those
so i'll
cut that closing tag
and put it here after the first
paragraph and save well i want the
formatting it didn't do it for me
tab that in and save and then we can
style our section to make it a little
more obvious what's going on i think
i'll scroll up just a little bit more
there we go and so now we have a section
and inside the section i'll say
background color
and we'll give this a color of bisque
which is kind of a neat color
and after bisque let's go ahead and
apply a border so we'll say border
one pixel solid
give it a flat black color and a little
bit of padding
one rim
okay and let's save and see what we get
well this looks okay right now i don't
see a problem but what if we removed
this div with the class of clear
and save well still no problem let me
shorten up this paragraph by several
words and then see what we get
and now when i save i just had too long
of a paragraph to actually highlight the
problem before but now when i say we can
see the problem this float is once again
not in the normal flow of the page so
the container is only expanding based on
the text content and when i had more
text content it looked okay but you can
really highlight the problem if you
don't have enough text content to push
the container down so we can definitely
see a problem that needs to be rectified
and that is because
we don't want the container to just go
halfway we want it to
go ahead and contain the full item the
full element that we have floated left
or right so we think why not go ahead
and put that div back in place that had
clear well let's try that
and see what happens i've got the clear
div there now and you can see it clears
the paragraph but it doesn't help the
container so let's once again remove
that div i'll just press ctrl z to undo
those changes
and control s to save so now the
paragraph is coming back up and i will
show two different ways to fix this one
past approach that you may see in code
is to set the overflow
to auto
but this is in more legacy code once
again but notice it does work so i
wanted to show that overflow auto is a
possibility to go ahead and get the
container element to extend all the way
down and contain the full element that
is floated either left or right however
the correct current way as
noted by mdn is to say display
and then say
flow dash root and if we save that we
once again have fixed the problem so if
i remove that
save we have the problem i'll put the
display flow root back in
and the problem is fixed so this is
considered the current modern way to fix
this problem in the past floats were
also used to create columns on a page
but that was because there was no other
method available and now with modern css
we do have other methods available
including display flex and display grid
that i will be covering
very soon in future modules but right
now just remember floats are used to
float things to the left and the right
really any element that you want to and
you can wrap text around it and then you
can also use floats inside of a
container if you want to but remember to
apply
display flow root
to the container so the container
contains the full floated element and
doesn't shrink based on the text content
alone
let's move on to css columns you can see
i've got visual studio code open here
with just an empty frame of a page once
again i've got the title of css columns
nothing in the body of the html at this
point and if we look at the style.css
you can see i'm once again importing in
the roboto font from the google fonts
and then i also have a couple of styles
on the body we're applying the roboto
font with font family and we've set the
font size to 1.5 rem and that's it so
far so let's go back to the html and the
first thing i want to do is create five
paragraphs so i'm going to use an emmet
abbreviation i'll type p
times five and then i'll just say lorem
20 and press tab and we should have five
paragraphs now so i'll save that much
i'll go ahead and press ctrl b so we can
see a little more i'm not going to wrap
the lines as it would just
clutter and of course wrap each one of
these lines down just a little bit i
don't need to do that right now what i
do want to do now is add a section that
will be a container for the first four
paragraphs so we'll take this section
and after the fourth paragraph we'll put
the closing element right there the
closing tag and we can save it didn't
auto format for me so i'm going to
select these and press tab so it comes
over and now i've got the first four
paragraphs inside of this section
element as a container and then the
final paragraph is outside of the
section element i'm also going to apply
a class here let's call this class
columns i want it inside the quotes
and now we're finished with the basic
html so far so now let's move on to the
css i'll click the file tree again go to
style.css
now with all of this saved i guess we
could quickly look at it in the browser
and we just see our five paragraphs over
here so we're going to make some changes
now and i'll drag vs code back over to
fill the full screen as we apply the
columns okay let's create our columns
class so dot
columns and inside this class i'm going
to set a column
dash count and let's set it to four
columns so far and save and now let's go
look at our code or our browser and look
what we have here in the browser now
i've spread it out a little bit so the
first four paragraphs are in four
columns and we can see of course this
fifth paragraph that's not inside of
that section element that has the class
columns is not split into columns at all
but it automatically split the first
four and just as it would resize here as
luck would have it with the browser
there's actually one paragraph per
column right now however i'm going to
right click and choose inspect so we can
open dev tools and resize this and
notice what happens here we can scrunch
it down and now it's not necessarily
paragraph per column it just adapts to
whatever the screen size is now we can
change this as well so i'm going to go
back
to vs code and then we'll make a change
here instead of this column count being
just four let's go ahead and add a
column width as well so let's tell it
that our column
width should essentially never be less
than
250 pixels per column so that should
change things a little bit now you can
see we only have two columns even though
we told it four it's going to add here
to that width and never go below that
now once it can support three columns of
250 pixels then it switches to three and
it will go up to four columns if that's
available to it however if not it will
stick with three let me see if i can
squeeze this just a little more to get
all four columns to show now we're back
to our four columns but as we resize the
browser width
it only supports what it can for the 250
pixels and once it can't support that it
should condense down to just one column
so that makes it very flexible as far as
the design goes because if it can only
support one column it will never make it
smaller than that 250 pixels we set but
if it can support two it does all the
way up to the column number that we
specified which was 4. i'm going to pull
vs code back up and there's shorthand
for this so we don't always have to type
column count and column width we can
just say
columns and there we could specify 4
250 pixels and it would be the same so
i'm going to comment these out
and now save and we shouldn't really see
any changes in our page because that
should mean the same thing just in
shorthand we can also provide dividers
so this would be with the column
dash rule property and here we can say
we want three pixels and i'll press ctrl
b to hide the file tree so we can see
all of this but three pixels let's say
solid
and now let's just give some kind of
color here i'll just go with that flat
black and save and notice this column
rule is just like when we provide a
border and the values go in the same
order so
when i have provided a border in the
past around any kind of element you have
seen the size and then the type of
border and then the color and that's the
same for the column rule now let's see
what it does to our page and here we see
the rules between each column now and of
course they will disappear when the
columns disappear if the sizing dictates
that and so once we get down to one
column even though we've said column
rule should exist it won't if there's
only one column but if there are columns
to separate that's when the column rules
start to show up and this will once
again
divide up to how many columns we've
created so if we say a max of four
columns we could have up to three column
rules and we can also provide some
spacing between those columns so let's
say column
dash gap and i'm going to choose a
larger value so we definitely see the
spacing so three rounds and let's see
how that spaced everything out
now we only have three columns because
we have some extra spacing so it
wouldn't fit into the four columns as
before but it does look a little bit
better with that extra spacing between
the columns and with dev tools open now
is a good time to draw your attention to
a problem that exists right here i'll
squeeze this over so we can see a little
more and i want to pull this down so we
can see some of the html above now as we
get into our columns section and you can
see it highlighted on the page as i
highlight the elements here in devtools
notice we have margin at the top and the
bottom of each paragraph we didn't use a
css reset so far so those margins have
not been set to zero and that's okay we
want spacing between the paragraphs but
notice here in this first paragraph we
also have spacing above the first
paragraph so it's not setting flush with
the top as the other columns are and
then as we come down notice each
paragraph is going to have its own top
and bottom margin
but there's one thing to consider here
we need to remove
that top margin from the first paragraph
but let's see if we can just remove it
from all of the paragraphs and what
happens notice our margin spacing
between the paragraphs as we see between
the first and the second for example
just is the spacing for that one margin
essentially so here we see it again
between the third and the second we just
see that top spacing but if i highlight
the second we just see the bottom
spacing and they seem to overlap let's
also discuss what's going on there so
we'll go back to the code and i'm going
to set another rule here and we want to
say just our paragraphs that are inside
the columns container so we'll say the
columns class and then p
let's say margin dash top
and set that to zero and save now we go
back to the browser
and our first paragraph is flush at the
top with the others but notice our
spacing between the paragraphs did not
change and that's a good thing it
automatically happens in css and i don't
believe i've discussed this before but
that is margin collapsing so it's not
going to double up the margin between
the second and the third paragraph just
based on having a bottom margin on say
the first one and a top margin on the
second one however now we've removed
that top margin but the spacing remained
the same but previously it wasn't twice
as much because of margin collapsing so
that's a good thing and it's worth
noting so we can actually just remove
the top margin from each paragraph and
not change the spacing of the others but
it does fix the top alignment here
making it flush with the other columns
as we want it to now let's go back to
our html and add another element inside
of this file so we have a couple of
paragraphs inside of our columns
container now let's add an h2 and inside
the h2 let's just say
next topic just some kind of generic
header here and we can save that now
let's go to our style css and let's go
ahead and style that header as well
we'll once again be specific so we'll
say columns and then any h2 inside of
our columns container
let's set the margin top to zero just
like we did for the paragraph so there's
not an issue there
let's set the background color
to that flat black 333 and then let's
set the color
to white
which is fff as far as hexadecimal code
goes
then we can provide some padding let's
say one rem
and let's save and let's take a look now
at our web page and we have our next
topic right here but let's see what
happens as we resize
that looks a little weird we have part
of the padding at the top of the second
column and the rest of the header here
at the bottom of the first column that's
kind of strange we might not want that
let's get some more room and drag it
over and see if anything else weird
happens well not with the room we have
but as this resizing occurs strange
things could happen but we can prevent
some of those strange things by applying
another property inside of our h2 so now
let's say break
dash inside and we'll say avoid
we'll save that come back to the page
and now as we get to our two columns we
notice it's on the second column which
may not be the best thing that we want
we might want that at the top of the
second column but it's not splitting the
header into two different pieces with
part of it at the top and then part of
it to the right and once we get down to
one column it's just the one header
there now we can apply one other
property let's bring vs code back up and
here we could say
break dash before
and we'll set this to column
and there's good and bad with this so
let's look at this overall so now notice
we're at the top of the second column
and that's fine and as we scroll and we
have two columns now we're at the top of
the second column again which is what we
want instead of being at the bottom of
the second column as we were before the
problem comes when we want to size down
to one column notice what happens
instead everything shrinks and we got
three columns and that's not maybe what
you would expect but this break before
actually forces a column break so it
forces there to be more than one column
and the browser is trying to fit all of
that in which is why it shrinks so
probably
not a great idea to use this break
before column property if you know
you're going to be shrinking your page
down to that one column however the
break inside with the avoid
will keep your header that you might
create or something else from being
split between the two columns now let's
go back to our html
and here's the html file i'm going to
remove this header for now i'll leave it
in the code so
you can see it there but we've just
commented it out but what i do want to
provide is a quote so let's provide a
quote that we would have maybe something
we would be highlighting on the page so
here's one more paragraph and inside
this paragraph i'm going to say
where's
my rug
and then man which is course from the
movie the big lebowski and then we can
say that was from
the dude who is the author of that quote
now let's provide some things here that
will make this stand out a little more
so we can say class
equals
quote and we'll style this class
and here let's go ahead and fill the
page right now as we see this code so we
can see the full quote here but then
there's some other things we want to
apply as well so i'll save this much and
actually just as i filled the page i
want to go back to the browser
and now on the browser we'll go ahead
and open up this page it's unicode dash
table dot com and it lets us look up
other characters like html entities that
you may have learned about when you were
going through my html course or one like
it but there's also unicode characters
and there's different way to provide
there's different ways to provide these
different characters so it says popular
character sets we want quotation marks
kind of the fancy ones so let's just go
to this page full of quotation marks and
you can see we want these opening
quotation marks right here the left one
i'll click on that it gives us several
different codes we can use in our page
so here's the html code for this opening
quotation mark there's also an html
entity here so we could probably use
either one i'm just going to select this
ampersand pound sign 8220
and the semicolon and that's going to be
our opening quotation mark so i'll pull
visual studio code back up and inside of
our quote right here it looks like i've
got an extra quotation mark there for
the class okay our class quote is
correct now i'm going to paste in that
code and now we should have that opening
quotation mark here to go along with our
quote likewise if we go back to the page
you can see they're saying with this
symbol these are often used let's click
on this other quotation mark
and oh it just took us back to quotation
marks so here was the opening one now
let's get the closing one so we'll click
on this
scroll down and as you might have
guessed it's just the next number
instead of eight two two zero it's eight
two two one i'll go ahead and select all
of that again we'll go back to vs code
and inside of vs code i'm going to
expand this just a little bit so we can
get to the end of the quote
and after that we have got this wrapped
in these fancy quotes with this html
character that is kind of like an html
entity but it's also kind of unicode in
a way and this is just another way html
handles these characters and we can put
this in to wrap the quotes and there's
many other symbols you could use and
find on this website and one of those
symbols that we want to put right here
beside our author is a long hyphen so
let's see if we can search for that
above i'll type in
long
hyphen and we'll see what comes up well
there's the hyphen minus soft minus
not seeing it right now well maybe this
one maybe not but i know what the code
is so let me see if i can just search
for that and it will come up it's eight
two
one two
and here we've got the em dash is what
it's called i wanted to call it a long
hyphen
and there was a copy right there in the
search results but i'm just going to
once again get the code here from the
html code
and this again is called an em dash so
we'll go back to our visual studio code
html code i'm going to put that right
before the dude so we'll have that
longer dash or hyphen before the author
is attributed and now before we look at
our html or before we look at our web
page i'll save that and let's go to the
style once again and let's style this
quote class so we'll say quote dot quote
actually and then
we'll apply several things here so the
first is a font dash size and let's put
three rim
now let's put text align
center because we want this quote
centered and now we can provide a color
let's do something we'll adjust this a
little bit let's do that flat black
color again and now for the main thing
that we want to highlight here is the
column span property and we can say all
so this will span all of the columns
that we have on the page okay now let's
go back
and look at our web page
and we see our big quote and it's
spanning all three of the columns and we
have a kind of our fancy quote symbols
here that are wrapped around it as well
and we have our em dash or long hyphen
after are actually before the author and
this is kind of like you might see in a
magazine as well where they highlight a
quote as you're reading the article but
something doesn't look quite right does
it we've got all this space underneath
but no space on top that's because this
is a paragraph that's inside of our
section container and remember we set
the margin top to zero for all of those
so let's go back to our code
and now that we're inside of this quote
class let's set the
margin dash top
to to rem and go back and take a look
and i think you'll be surprised at what
we see
there's absolutely no change
so what's going on
well let's once again look at our code
and see the problem
what we have here is columns the class
columns and then an element columns p
where we set the margin top to zero
that is more specific than just having a
class so let's go ahead and look at our
specificity calculator
and we can see how this is calculated so
i'll put our first one here at the top
and that is columns which gives it a
score of 10 as a class and then p
as an element so it's got a score of 11.
and as you might guess if we were down
here
and just said quote
we only have a score of 10. so even
though quote comes after
this column's p definition in the
cascade it's not as specific so that
margin is not applying what we could do
is say dot
columns
dot quote and then notice we have a
score of 20 so that would work let's go
back and apply that in our code and i
bet we see the margin change so instead
of just quote
we'll say
columns quote
save
go back to our page
and now we have a margin on top as
expected so there's another learning
experience about specificity now let's
resize the page a little bit and we're
going to see something else we might not
like
i don't like how this breaks our author
down to the next line we've got the on
one line with his long dash and then
dude on the second line so we want to be
able to control that break we just
definitely don't want the long dash on
the first line and then the author on
the second
eventually it kind of catches up but
those breaks in between aren't what we
want and we can fix that with css back
in vs code let's go back to our html
first and let's wrap our author in a
span element which is an inline element
and let's give this a class equal to
no wrap
and of course now we'll need to take i'm
going to wrap the code here with alt z
because we'll need to take this closing
span
and put it
after dude right here so now we can save
that and our html is taken care of now
we just need to style our no wrap class
so underneath our columns quote let's
put
no wrap
inside of no wrap we're going to use the
white dash space property
and set that to no wrap and so now when
we go back to our browser and we resize
our quote should not break the dude our
author should always stay on the same
line including
that long dash and that's exactly what
happened it all went down to the second
line at the same time so we're no longer
breaking the dude
with his long dash into separate lines
and that's the way we want to style that
so overall i hope this tutorial has
helped you learn how to apply columns to
your content on a web page the simple
way really without even using flexbox or
grid which will be covered in upcoming
modules as well
today we're going to discuss the css
position property you can see on the
left i've got visual studio code on the
right i've got chrome and we're using
the live server extension so any changes
we make in our html or css today should
immediately show up over here in the
browser now first let's look at the html
page that i have here on the left in
visual studio code and you can see it's
a basic layout and i'm really using more
divs than i'm normally comfortable with
all of these div elements they are block
elements but they are not semantic they
do not provide any additional meaning to
a page and they don't really help
accessibility at all so in a typical
project i wouldn't use a lot of divs but
they are good for today's example so you
can see we have an outer container and
this outer container in the browser
is a dashed black border that outlines
this container and then we have an inner
container and it is a solid blue line
here in the inner container and then
inside of this inner container and you
can't see them right now we have four
other divs they all have the class of
box but then each has an individual
class absolute relative fixed
and sticky and those are possible values
for the position property and we'll look
at each of those let's jump over to the
style.css file you can see i'm importing
in that roboto font as i have been in
the last several tutorials for this css
series and then i also i guess i have
the lobster font here too although i'm
not using it right now i've also got
this css reset already in place with a
margin of zero padding of zero and box
sizing equal to border box
for the body we're using that roboto
font family and then we also have a font
size of one and a half rims and then a
min height of 200 viewport units so that
means besides what you see here we've
got another full page that we can scroll
down to and we'll need that in just a
little bit
then we have the styles for the outer
container already here you can see the
dashed border it's three pixels we've
got a width and a height set on it just
for this example and a top and bottom
margin of 40 pixels the auto for left
and right centers the container and then
we'll see something very similar here
for the inner container of course the
different styles just sizing it a little
differently and the color and size of
the border and then we have the box
class that applies to the four divs that
you cannot currently see
you can't see them because their font
color is white other than that they are
a box with 150 pixels width and height
and a little bit of padding in there
okay with all of that said let's go
ahead and style our first class and that
was the absolute class
so what we'll do for it is set a
background color that's different than
the others so we can tell them apart a
little better let's just set that to a
blue we'll use hexadecimal there and
then let's go ahead and set the position
but the first position value we're going
to use is static and that is the default
of all elements they're
static just already when you put them on
the page so essentially it's not going
to change anything i just wanted you to
see that value to know that's the
default even if you don't set it so now
let's go ahead and set a position of
absolute and see what we get when we
save it really didn't change anything
and that's because we didn't set any
other value when we set these values we
need to go ahead and set
a top
left right or bottom we don't have to
set all of them but it needs at least
one to change where it's at so let's set
the top to zero see what we get
it moved it all the way to the top of
the browser now what if we set
left to zero now moved it all the way to
the left so it's in the upper left
corner so absolute positioning needs a
relative parent
and if it doesn't have an ancestor
element that is positioned relative
then it takes the initial boundary or
the initial box which is essentially the
browser window and so that's why it went
up here to the top and then the left
when we set that position but now we can
scroll up and we can set a position on
this outer container
you see i'll set the position to
relative
and now look what happens to our
absolute box it now has an ancestor that
is positioned relative so this
positioning is no longer relative to the
browser window it's relative to this
ancestor that has the position set to
relative
but what if we set the position to
relative on more than one ancestor
i'll do that here if i could spell
relative again
and i'll save and now you can see
this is back where we started inside the
inner container and that is because it
picks the ancestor that is closest to it
and so
our box started inside of this inner
container so with the outer container
set to relative and the inner container
set to relative it picks the closest one
the nearest one and that is the inner
container so we're back here now as you
might have guessed the zeros are
essentially the default choices there so
if we save we don't really see a change
from position absolute with the top and
left 0 to where they are now of course
if we change
which ancestor it was relative to we
would see a change as it would move to
whichever ancestor it was relative to
however we can put in other values so
let's do something like 100 pixels
and then we could also do left 50 pixels
and see what happens and now it moved
it's once again absolutely positioned
but it's relative to this inner
container and it moved down 100 pixels
and it moved to the right essentially 50
pixels from the left that's how you want
to read that and you would say from the
top so that's a good way to read those
from the top from the left so let's once
again change the position relative and
put it on the outer container only
and save and now we can see the same
thing we have moved 100 pixels and 50
pixels as we set right here okay i'm
going to switch these values back to 0
to get our absolute box out of the way
and now we'll look at the next box which
is the relative one that we have inside
the inner container so here we'll say
relative for the relative class
let's set a different background color
let's go with red on this one
and then after that
we can save that much and we see it
already after that we're going to say
position
relative and we already know that won't
change anything by just setting that
much
but now if i were to say
top and here say 100 pixels
and then say left and here i could say
100 pixels also
it's going to move
100 pixels from the top and 100 pixels
from the left so much like we saw the
absolute do when it was relative to its
parent container and now relative here
means it's going to be relative to its
parent container already without having
to define that relative
on the parent so inside of here by
setting it relative it's always going to
be relative to its parent container
let's scroll up for some more room and
let's change that top by a few more
pixels maybe 300 pixels and get our
relative block out of the way as well
and now we can pick our fixed class
and here let's give this a background
color
of green if i did it with hex i don't
like the bright color i get there so if
i say green
i get a darker green color so that's
what i'm going with
position is going to be fixed
and here
not absolute we just want fixed and then
here
we're going to say
well let's just not put anything yet and
we'll save and there we can see our
fixed box but now let's say something
like
top and this will be 100 pixels and if i
save notice
now it just moved 100 pixels from the
top and we can confirm that by removing
our position relative here to make sure
it's not responding to this outer
container and if we save
now we have our absolute up here in the
corner but the fix stayed exactly where
it was so it's only 100 pixels from the
top
and then after that
what will happen is it will just stay
right there even if we scroll so that's
what it means to be in a fixed position
so i scroll
and that's why we have that 200 viewport
unit height so i can scroll down to a
second page our fixed block is staying
in a fixed position the entire time and
so it's out of the flow of the page
just like our other blocks are
but
it is never moving even when we scroll
the page and this is a good time to
point out that the fixed block is over
the absolute block right now
that is decided by what element comes
first and what element comes last in the
html so if we go back to the html and i
took this fixed div
and i put it before the absolute div and
now i save
absolutes on top but that's not always
convenient
when we're working with pages to go and
change the structure of the html so we
can also do this with css if we want
that absolute block on top we would just
come over here
and change the z dash index you might
call that z
but it's i call it z the z dash index
and the default value is zero so that's
not going to change anything but if we
give it a higher value and we don't need
to go 10 or 20 or 100 higher we can just
go
one higher and save and now our absolute
block is on top of the fixed block but i
can scroll and the absolute block goes
away our fixed block is still there okay
we've got one more left and that is
sticky sticky is just a little different
than fixed
and that's because it will stay in its
normal flow until it reaches a spot that
you have defined so here we're going to
say
background color and let's just make
this black
and then we'll say position
sticky and we can save
and there it is and now we haven't put
any spot essentially say a top where it
would stick so right now if we scroll it
just scrolls right off the page
but we could say
top 0 and save and now let's see what
happens when we scroll i scroll our
sticky block
stays at 0 momentarily but it's running
out of the container notice when the
container that it is in
reaches the end and begins to scroll off
the page
then the sticky block goes ahead and
scrolls off the page unlike the fixed so
now when we scroll back down it stays
and so maybe we could push that down a
little further
or something but overall or i could make
this a little longer but overall you see
it stick at the top
and then
it moves again when the container
catches up to it and scrolls off the
page okay it's good to see all these
examples but it's better to even put
some of them to use and you will see how
they're used in page construction so
i've got a quick example coming up for
that before we do that i want to go back
to something we talked about a few
lessons ago and that's how to make
something disappear we covered display
none
and we covered the opacity where we
could make something fade all the way
down to being not only see-through but
completely disappearing but i said both
of those were not good for accessibility
display none completely removes it from
the page a screen reader would not read
what we were doing
opacity makes it invisible and it might
not be the best way to do what we're
talking about but what if we had
something
that needed to still be part of the
document but we wanted it off the page
well position absolute is great for that
so i'm going to
go ahead and comment out well we don't
really need to comment this out i'll
just change this value because we would
take the left value
for example and i'll set it to minus
10 000 pixels
and save
notice
it's gone but it's still part of the
document it's still in our html
and when it's processed by a screen
reader it would still be read say it was
a paragraph or the label for an input
and that's important to accessibility so
often times when i need to remove
something visibly from a page but i
still need it to be part of the page for
accessibility reasons i position it
absolute and i move it say a random
number here but minus 10 000 pixels is
kind of my go to
way off to the left where it will not be
seen but it will still be red so i'll
change this back but overall just
remember that trick for taking something
off of the page okay now let's move on
to our second example so what i'm going
to do is grab everything we see here
from line 13 down to line 28
if i can get to the right spot line 28
and comment that out i do that with
shift alt and the letter a in visual
studio code now i'm going to grab the
rest of the html i have here and
uncomment it and i do that the same way
shift alt and the letter a
and now you can see
i have a button element with a class of
social and it just has this little
rocket emoji on it after that i've got
some sections one two
three sections each one has an id one
two and three inside each section there
is a header with a class of blue
header one
header with a class of red header two
and a header with a class of green which
is header three then you can see each
one has an h2 heading inside of it just
to have a little bit of text one two and
three as well and then there is a footer
and inside the footer we have anchor
links to those different parts of the
page one two and three if you remember
from learning basic html you don't just
have to link away from a page you can
link to different parts of a page with
that anchor link and we're linking back
to each id
for each section so i'm going to save
this now and we see the basic html over
here to the right
now i'm going to jump back to the css
i'll leave all of this here because it
won't hurt anything but i'm going to put
in a dividing line and a reminder for
you that will be available in the source
code that says remember how to make
things disappear that we just talked
about now after that we can apply some
new styles to what we now have in our
html but i'll leave these old styles in
there as well as well as
leaving in the commented out divs from
the first part of this tutorial okay now
we're going to take each section element
and we're going to set the height of
each section to 100 viewport units so
now you can see on the first page we
have header 1 and the rocket is here too
then we have a second page with header
two and a third page with header three
and eventually we have a footer with
three links in it as well
okay let's scroll up a little bit and
then after this section we can go ahead
and define a let's say a blue clasp
because we need one for each color that
we had this would be background color
and i'm going to choose blue here
now at the end of this line i can press
shift alt and the down arrow to copy
down a couple of times and then i'm
going to change this one
to red and i'll change this hex color to
red
and then this last one will be green
and i'm going to change this to the
keyword green because i like that green
just a little bit better so now i'll
save and we can see the header colors
have changed for each page after that
let's put in some styles for the header
and the footer they can share these
styles so we have header comma footer
and it will apply to both so i'll say
color
and we'll set the text to white
then we'll set the text align
to center
then let's set the height of the header
and the footer both to 100 pixels and
let's pick a big font size so let's go
with like five rims here and save and we
can see that got very big for each one
okay time to scroll just a little bit
more and now a couple of styles just for
the header
we'll say position
this will be sticky or i should say
headers because there is more than one
header element
and then the top will be zero so that is
set for all three header elements that
we have on the page now now we'll set
some style for the footer
say background dash color let's make
this one black
now let's set the
position to fixed and this will give us
something to talk about and compare to
sticky
and we'll set the bottom to zero and
we'll see what we get with that okay so
what we have so far
is a header one now we still have this
rocket button above
and then it's stopping at the top notice
we scrolled now the word one disappeared
but header one stops at the top here
comes header two
now it stops at the top
and the text scrolled on up and now
here's header three
now our bottom here it looks like we got
maybe a little bit of a large font issue
there so let's pull this font size five
out of the definition for both
and let's just put it here
in the header if we save now we get more
what i wanted to see down here and
notice
since we used position fixed it pulled
it out of the normal flow of the page
what would normally be a block element
and span the full width here is not
spanning the full width now so what we
would need to do if we were going to use
position fixed is set the width to 100
percent
and then our footer would work but there
is a fix also
even though it's not really going to
scroll or move that we just always want
it to be in place we could just set this
to position sticky
and
set bottom to zero and it's always going
to be there so now let's just set a
little bit larger font
for the footer as well so let's say font
size maybe three rims and all the links
will stay okay that looks good so
one two three links and we have each of
our pages as well you can see how this
is coming together already as an example
let's scroll down just a little bit more
and under the footer i'm going to put a
visited
pseudo class here for the links
and say that's going to be
white so our links there in the footer
change to white much easier to see
and now our rocket here at the top our
social link
so for that we'll set the background
color once again and here let's use a
royal blue
after that
we'll set the color to white
and let's say a font size because it's a
button and it will not already just
inherit everything that we would
normally inherit in paragraphs when we
set that font size
at the top of the page so here we're
just going to say inherit so it catches
up to the font size of everything else
padding of one ram again
now we'll set a position
of fixed
and we want this to stay in the same
place all the time so let's say
30 percent from the top and then the
left is going to just be zero
now this looks more like a social button
and maybe you're used to seeing several
buttons over here for different social
media but it should stay in place as we
scroll so let's check it out
and it sure is it's staying right there
as we scroll past each one of our pages
so we have header one two and three now
if we wanted it always on top we could
go ahead and set that z index
and set that to one and now when we
scroll we should see it on top of each
header as goes by and we do so an ugly
example but an example nonetheless where
each page section say this is a single
page application or a spa if you will
each page section has its own header and
sticky allows those to scroll up and
then stay in place until the content for
that particular section is gone
and then we have our social media button
over here with the rocket to the left
and at the bottom i showed you how to
use fixed or sticky and you've got links
to each section okay now let's check out
these links so if i click three
it instantly shows three
two we're at section two
one we're at section one there's one
more thing we can do that will make that
look just a little cooler if we want to
when we are choosing those different
sections
of our single page application and we
need to put this back up here i'll put
it at the top of this new example but it
needs to go in the root element this
won't work in the body element but we
can set the scroll dash
behavior
to smooth and if we save that
now let's click number three
and notice how we get that little scroll
action that's kind of nice
so
that one setting makes that scroll go
from instantaneous to just a smooth
little scroll between the sections so i
hope this example has showed you how you
can apply the position property with css
and i hope the previous example gave you
some pretty good differences between all
the different values that you can use
let's move on to css flexbox
fundamentals we'll be learning the css
properties that you'll use most
frequently when working with flexbox you
can see i've got visual studio code here
on the left and it's in a smaller window
today i've got a larger browser window
here on the right and i'll quickly look
at the html file as well that we're
starting out with and this will be
available in the source code that you
can download but we've just got six divs
right here and all of them have a class
box and then they each have their own
number as we see on the page one two
three four five and six
divs are block elements and so they're
spanning the full width of the container
and they're stacked on top of each other
and you can see we have a main element
with the class container as well
okay back inside of our css file we're
starting out by bringing in the roboto
font from google fonts we've got a very
basic css reset here at the top
on the body we're setting up that roboto
font we've got a min height of 100
viewport units so it's the full screen
or the full browser window and then
we've got padding of 20 pixels so you
see it pushing down
our main container from the top that 20
pixels here it's also on the left right
and bottom it's just harder to see that
and then we have some styles on the
container so it's got a max width of 800
pixels a minimum height of 400 pixels
margin in line set to auto so it is
centered horizontally here and we should
have the same amount of space on the
left and the right we've also got a
black border going around the main
container but you really can't see that
right now because the contents are black
as well
and then the boxes they have a min width
and min height of 100 pixels and
remember the boxes are the six divs
it's got a background color of black a
color of white that we see on the
numbers font size is two rims so the
numbers are a little bigger and just a
little bit of padding of 0.5 rim and
that's what we're starting out with for
our code but we're going to apply flex
and the area that we'll apply that to
first is the container we'll make our
container a flex container and as soon
as we apply flex
i need to spell display properly
things will change on the page so i will
save and now we see some big differences
over here we've got one two three four
five six going horizontally instead of
vertically and they're not stacked on
top of each other so the divs are a min
width of 100 pixels so they're about 100
pixels wide each and then their height
is filling out the full 400 pixels we
have for min height on our container you
can now see the border over here on the
right side of the container at least
but they are now considered to be flex
items and so they're starting out at the
position flex start and that's where
they default to in this alignment so
they're just all over here to the left
so let's look at how we can align these
horizontally first
we're going to do that with the justify
content property
and the place they're starting is called
flex start so we'll say flex
start and yes i'm already wrapping the
code i pressed alt z and visual studio
code to do that so we don't see any
change but what if we switch this to
flex
end and save well now they're all over
to the right instead of being all the
way over to the left
likewise we can set this to flex center
and now they're all in the center
you know let's go ahead and add another
property here called gap
and we'll set this to one rim and now
look at what happens we get a one rem
gap between each flex item so that helps
us see each individual one just a little
bit better now continuing with the
justify content there are some other
good values worth looking into center is
often used but there's also space around
and now look at that now this isn't used
as often and maybe you can see why we've
got
some space between each one
but look the space at the edges before
the end and beginning of the container
aren't quite as big
and also if we remove the gap now at
this point we should still see that
space around evenly space everything out
except at the beginning and the end so
what if we did the other one that we saw
space between
well now there's no space at the
beginning and no space at the end but
it's evenly spaced between all of the
flex items and then there is a little
newer value that is much better to use i
think it was probably requested and that
is space evenly so not only between the
items but also at the beginning and the
end we have evenly spaced the items
throughout the container okay i'm going
to change this min height on our boxes
to a height of 100 pixels so we can
clearly see each box and some space in a
vertical way because now we're going to
align the items vertically as well so we
use justify content for horizontal as
things are currently set to a row and
that's why we use justify content for
the horizontal now let's go ahead and
align the items
so this would be the other axis
and that's going to be vertically so if
we align the items to
flex start
they're where they are by default right
at the top but likewise we can say flex
end
and now all of the items are at the
bottom
as you might guess
we could say flex or align items center
and now they're centered vertically as
well now we don't have the other options
with the line items like space around
space between because if you think about
it it's only one item at a time when
we're aligning the items
horizontally here we had six items in
this row but if we look vertically we've
just got one item for each alignment so
that's why we don't have the space
options now we can change the direction
as well so let's look at flex
direction and by default we're in a row
so we could say
column and now if we save we've got all
of our blocks stacked once again as a
column and remember i removed that gap
that we had so there's no longer a space
between them and they're also taking up
the full height of our container
remember our container has a min height
of 400 pixels but we've got at least 600
pixels worth of divs right here so
they're filling this up so there's no
extra space to space out as well
now if we go ahead and change something
let's change the align items and we'll
see if you think we're going to get what
we get i will save and now everything's
to the left because our align items
became the horizontal alignment again
just one item at a time instead of all
six all six are now on the vertical
alignment so by having flex end they
will all go to the right
and of course we were back at center and
that put everything in the center so if
we change our justify content we not
might not see much of a difference right
now because we're taking up all that
space so if i said flex start for
example
it didn't really change that's because
we're eating up all of the space of the
container already so there's no real
change to notice
when we have this set with 600 pixels
inside of a container where we're taking
up all of the space but if we change
this to row
now we'll see our center where they're
all together once again with no gap
whatsoever if we wanted a gap
we could put our gap property back in
and say one rim and now we have that one
rem gap between each one of these but
they're centered now of course if we
change this back to space evenly we
might not want that gap property at all
now since we have the flex direction
property in here there's more that we
can do than just row or column what
about row
reverse and if i save
notice now
six that was to the far right is now to
the left we reversed the order of the
elements here so row reverse is an
option and as you might guess column
reverse is also an option now let's look
at one other property here i can leave
the row reversed for this for now but
what i need to do
is drag this all the way over to take up
the full screen and open up dev tools
and once we have devtools here we're
going to notice something as i resize
the window
the flexbox row our row of boxes
it's
really not changing it's outgrowing it's
not resizing or shrinking to stay inside
of the container or the page so that is
considered an overflow so there is a
setting for that let me bring up visual
studio code again and the setting that
we could use is called flex dash wrap
and so we would want to set that to wrap
and now if we save and we have our dev
tool still open in the window you can
see it wrapped into two rows
and we have it reversed now you might be
surprised at this because 6 isn't at the
top now but our rows have reversed so 3
is to the far left and 1 is to the right
6 is to the far left of row 2
and 4 is to the right now we could
change this back of course to row
see everything in the order that we
would normally see it in one two three
four five six
and then there's also shorthand that we
could use instead of flex direction and
flex wrap and that would just be called
flex flow so let me just select both of
these and now we'll have flex flow
and then the first is the direction so
we'll say row the second value
is wrap and now by default
you noticed our row did not wrap so the
default value is no wrap but we want it
to wrap so we'll set that and now
nothing should change about the page the
way we had it see if i can resize just a
little more here
and yep we've got
wrapping of the rows as it needs to and
it will even get down to just one column
and now we'll bring it back to two
columns or
three rows is what we should consider
that since we have it set to rows and
there's
again back to two rows and
still two rows with this width because
we've just got one square that carries
down i'll bring it back to about even
here
and now that we've got that this is
shorthand so remember the first is the
flex direction the second is the flex
wrap with flex flow okay there's one
more property to consider on our
container remember we're putting all of
these properties on the flex container
right now that i've outlined here with
our one pixel black border i'm going to
scroll just a little for some more room
here
underneath let's put align
content
now this aligns the rows so you can see
by default we have two rows and they're
spaced out here there's some room
between them now this will take values
just like justify content but it's
aligning the row so we'll put in flex
start first and if we save
notice both our rows move up to the top
likewise flex end
move them both to the bottom
and flex are not flexed just
center
has them both in the center so that
wasn't the default either what about
space
between that we could also use on
justify content yep it puts one on the
top one on the bottom
space around
so that's a little different as well
and then space evenly that we might like
if i could spell evenly once again
and save and yes that changed the
alignment just a little bit as well okay
now we're ready to move on to the
individual flex items because we can
also set properties on the flex items
instead of just the container and that
will also change how flexbox handles the
layout so the first thing we can do is
apply some of the things we learned from
above let's go ahead and make each one
of these flex items a flex container now
once again we will be applying
properties as a flex item soon but if we
make these a flex container
then we could go ahead and display those
numbers
centered right in the middle of each box
so if we say display flex
justify content
center
and then align items
and save now all of our numbers are in
the middle of each box
and yes as you might guess you could use
these three properties to center any
element inside of a container or you
could center an element inside of the
body which would be considered a
container the body element of a page so
now you essentially know how to center
something in the middle of the page if
you want to okay now we have a few
properties to look at four flex items
again these three properties made each
item a flex container of its own but
they are still flex items
inside of the larger flex container as
well so what i want to do besides create
some extra space here is go back to the
html i'm going to select the last four
divs there that have the class box and
i'm going to comment them out for now by
pressing shift alt and the letter a
and then saving and now we'll just have
two divs with number one and number two
that we can work with in the css so
before we put a min width on each box a
min width of 100 pixels and i'm going to
go ahead and comment that out as well
again shift alt in the letter a
and now no width will be set and you can
see they're only
getting the width of the content
essentially here on the page right now
but we can set a property called flex
basis and you can give that an absolute
value or a percentage if you want so
what i'm going to do is give it
three well now let's go with 100 pixels
again just to compare to what we had so
if we'll save now that's essentially
giving it a minimum width right now now
that could change it it's not the same
as min width but that's essentially what
it's doing in this case and now another
property we can provide is called flex
dash grow
and we'll set that to 1 and that's
setting this
the same value and it's a unitless value
but we're setting the same value on both
boxes which is essentially saying if
they need to grow to fill out the page
they will grow the same amount so if we
save you can see now our items both grew
and they are filling out the page they
do have that gap in between but other
than that they grew as much as they
needed to to take up the rest of the
container i'm going to scroll up just a
little bit and we're going to use a
pseudo selector to select just one of
these elements now so i'll say
inf
i'm sorry not inf i need the class first
and class was box and then it's in
child
and let's select the second element here
and let's override
that flex grow and set it to two so now
this second one should take up more than
the first but it's not going to be
double and i'll tell you why notice it
did grow more than the first but they
both have a flex basis of 100 pixels so
what we're telling the elements to do
here with flex grow
is after the 100 pixels so each element
gets their 100 pixels then whatever is
left
the one that has flex grow 2 is going to
get twice as much of that extra space as
the element that has flex grow 1. so
it's saying whatever space is left you
take two for every one that i take
essentially now the other one to
consider is flex shrink now before we
get to flex shrink notice we currently
have
flex wrap still set so once they get to
where they can't fit in
that 100 pixel size they essentially
wrap down to two rows here with our
current setup we're going to have to
really remove that wrap setting so we
can see what flex shrink does for us so
i'm going to select grow here ctrl d to
select the second grow and then change
them both to shrink
so now we have flex shrink in place i'm
going to scroll back up to our container
and instead of wrap i'm going to set
no wrap
so now
with the larger value here of shrink 2
our second box is set to shrink more
than the first box and this might be
easier to see if we make the boxes
larger as well so let me come out here
as far as i can for the page with dev
tools open and maybe set these to
let me try
250 pixels and see if that fits inside
the screen we have yep so that works
right now they look like they're
basically equal size
but as we shrink the page down we should
see the one on the right and we do
number two is getting smaller than
number one so that is because number two
has a larger value of flex shrink than
number one so it's the same concept as
flex grow except now we're shrinking and
that's preventing the overflow out of
the box that shrinkage is what that does
so i wanted to eliminate the wrap or it
would go ahead and wrap instead of
shrink at some point so there we go for
flex grow and flex rank flex basis is
giving that size basis but notice over
here we are now shrinking below 250
pixels here for number two so just like
flex grow lets something extend above
the basis flex shrink lets something
shrink below the basis so either way
now that we've covered all three of
those different properties we can put
all of them into a shorthand as well so
here
with the 250 pixels i guess i'll keep
that we can just say flex
the first value is grow
the second value is shrink and the third
value is basis so we could do that
remember we could also put something
over here like a percentage let's say
maybe 40
percent see if that works out for us
that's about the same and then we could
do the same here so we could
say flex two
for grow two for shrink
and forty percent here as well now when
we save they look the same size
but if we grow
number two is going to get a little
larger than number one and if we shrink
smaller than number one although they're
both shrinking quite a bit right there
and that could be because i'm using a
percentage as we get down it's still
just taking up 40 percent let's go back
to a
set value an absolute value we should be
able to see this example just a little
bit better for the shrinkage so number
two gets smaller than number one yep it
was because i was using that relative 40
before so when it grows number two still
gets a little bit larger let me close
dev tool well if i close dev tools i
won't be able to pull it over at all
but number two is larger than number one
here it's just a little harder to see
maybe if i change the absolute value
again
to 150 pixels
yup number two got even larger there but
then as we shrink it down number two
does get smaller than number one okay
with that complete i'm going to go back
to the html and uncomment those other
four divs shift alt and the letter a
once again to uncomment after we
highlight them
now you can see number two shrank more
than the other divs because we have it
set up to shrink more if it needs to
right here with our nth child
so we could remove that or we could just
leave it for now but there is another
property i want to cover and it won't
impact it so i will just leave that and
this would be order so let's go ahead
and change the order of this second
child as well and let's say
order is going to be
and save
now look what happened it has the
highest number so it went to the end it
didn't go to where the fourth element is
it actually went to the end
however if we say order zero
it's going to be right back where it was
but if we want it at the beginning we
could say order
minus one and now two is there now if
you are using this order property on
individual elements
and then you're also using something
like row reverse that we had available
up here and let's change this back to
wrap as well
and now if we switch this to row
reverse
you might be thinking you were going to
move number two to the very beginning
but we didn't
we moved it to the right and it's to the
right of the first row
and that is because we reversed it so
essentially it was here at the beginning
and then we reversed the row so if we
went ahead and set this back to its
normal position with zero
then we would see it's in the middle
because it would normally be one two
three and that's three two one so that
would just be the same
but we that is all because we have row
reverse at the top so minus one would
take it to the right instead of the left
likewise a larger number say one
totally switched it around and now it's
down here at the bottom left and that is
because of row reverse again so if we go
ahead and remove the reverse up here
it may be where we would expect it to be
and that's at the very end of the list
now because all of the rest of these
would be where they were placed
essentially with a value of zero so that
one makes it a larger value than all of
the rest of them so we would give it 0
to put it back in place
a higher number above 0 to put it at the
end and a number like -1 something lower
than 0 to put it at the beginning we've
covered a lot of flexbox properties
today and we will be building some
things with it in the future but right
now i think the best way for you to get
some practice with it besides just
playing around with it in your own html
and css is to go to this website called
flexbox froggy and it's got 24
challenges to help you learn flexbox and
if i expand it out i think it looks a
little bit better in the full screen
there we go and you can work through
these 24 challenges and learn how to
place the frog on the lily pad with
flexbox and there's some good challenges
in there and it will get you thinking
about the different ways to use the
different properties that we've just
reviewed for flexbox
let's learn about css grid layout
fundamentals we'll be learning the css
properties that you will use most
frequently when working with grids
so for starter code we've got html here
and inside the body we have a main
element with the class of container and
we have six divs
labeled box one two three four five and
six by their content they all have the
same class box
if we look at the style that is
currently applied you can see we're
importing in the roboto font from google
fonts we have a basic css reset
inside the body we are just setting the
roboto font and setting the body to a
min height of 100 viewport units and
then we have the box class for those
divs background color of black
a white font color and font size two ram
padding of 0.5 ram and that's all we
have to start so i'll drag vs code over
to the left
and we're using the live server visual
studio code extension so any changes we
make to the css we should see
immediately here in chrome on the web
page so here are our six divs now we
haven't set any size the main element is
a block element so it automatically has
100 width and then so are the divs so
they're stacked on top of each other and
all six of them have a width of 100
percent so they're filling up that main
element we're going to cover several
different ways to apply grid to our page
into these divs so let's start out by
styling that container class that we
have on the main element and we'll say
display grid now instantly when we do
this and save we don't see a change but
all of these divs instantly become grid
items now within the grid after that the
quickest way to apply a grid is to use
grid dash auto dash flow
and you can say row which
essentially leaves it as it is because
they're stacked on top of each other
which now makes six rows
or we could change this
to column and we will have six columns
one for each of the six divs now many
times we want more control than just
setting the auto flow to column and
letting all the columns be defined just
automatically like that so let me go
ahead and remove grid auto flow and in
its place i'm going to put grid dash
template
dash whoops there we go dash columns
that's what i want and now we can set
the columns and the width of each now
notice i'm wrapping the code so it will
wrap to the next line but i'll say 200
pixels then i could say
100 pixels and then i could say 200
pixels and when i save we now have three
columns and you can see the first column
is 200 pixels the second is 100 and the
third is again 200 but we don't have to
use absolute values like pixels we can
use fraction units which is a unit
that's specifically used with css grids
so let's say we've got
two fractions for the first column and
then one fraction for the second and one
fraction for the third now when we save
you can see
it used all of the available space but
it made the first column twice as big as
it did the second or the third call and
we can also mix so we could say 200
pixels and then one fraction one
fraction and you see our first column's
200 pixels then the next two columns
since they're equal both have one
fraction a piece they're splitting the
available width that is remaining and so
they're eating up all of that so it
still has 100 width for the row
but
the five and six here or the two and
three are much wider than what we see
for the 1 and the 4. and now something
very useful instead of specifying every
column especially if many of the columns
have the same value you can use a
shortcut for that and so we're here
we're going to say repeat i could spell
repeat and let's say we have four
columns and each one is one fraction and
now when we save you can see we have
four equal columns each being one
fraction and then when we get to the
second row that is automatically created
by grid we've got two columns here
because we only had six total grid items
so a grid can have empty space and
that's what we have here to the right
now while this value does not always
have to be equal it does have to be a
pattern so we could say instead of just
one fraction let's say we start with one
fraction and then the next column is two
fractions and instead of repeating four
let's just repeat this twice because
it's going to repeat this pattern so
with this pattern we're going to have
four columns because we've defined two
different columns here with the pattern
so when i save you can see the first
column is one fraction the second column
is twice as big two fractions the third
column again one fraction and the fourth
column following that pattern is twice
as big with two fractions now while
we've defined our columns here we really
haven't applied anything to the rows so
everything about the rows is currently
implicitly created by css grid we
haven't explicitly defined anything for
those rows but let's go ahead and do
that and to do that we'll use grid dash
auto dash rows and let's say 200 pixels
to start out
and you can see
now each row became 200 pixels tall but
once again we're not locked into just
using 200 pixels here with grid auto
rows so we could say
min max which is a function and this
lets us say the minimum first so we'll
say a minimum
of let's say 150 pixels tall and then
we'll say auto for the max so it could
allow it to be taller so now both rows
are essentially 150 pixels tall but we
have auto here so if our container
was taller right now we've got 150 and
150 so that would be a total of 300 but
if our container was taller this auto
would let it grow so let's set
a height
or let's set a min height i like that
better let's set a min height
of 400 pixels
and save and now you can see they got
taller they should be 200 each so
200 height on the first row 200 height
on the second row and that's because of
this auto but they will not get smaller
than 150 pixels a piece per row now
while i'm giving this example of grid
template rows and grid our grid template
columns pardon me and grid auto rows you
should know that the opposite also
exists so you could have
grid template
rows and you could have grid auto
columns so i'm giving one example and
i'll let you play around with the
opposite of those now what else we have
are gaps between the rows or between the
columns so we could define a
row dash gap and we could set that to 1m
and save and you can see we now have
that gap between the rows
likewise there is a column dash gap so
instead we could say
column gap and save and now we have one
em as a gap between each of the columns
now these spaces are essentially called
gutters that's the space between the
cells so it could be a column gap
a row gap or we could just define it as
gap and as you might guess
gap combines both and it will define the
row first so if we say row
1 em and just to show the difference we
could say 0.5 em for the column and save
and you can see the column gap
is smaller so you can define each of
those separately many times we want them
all to be the same and we just leave it
all at one size and while i've got em
there i kind of want to make that rim
instead so i know i'm going back to my
default font size there okay now let's
look at the individual grid items which
we have applied the class of box to all
of them so let's use pseudo selectors to
just select the ones we want to change
and i'll start off with the box class
and then i'll use the pseudo selector
first dash child
and after first child i'm going to set
the background color first so background
color there we go and i'll make this
blue
we can save and make sure we have
selected the correct grid item that
first child and after that let's go
ahead and define how many columns this
child takes up and this is based on the
lines of the grid which i will explain
after i set this definition so let's say
grid
dash column
yeah there we go column then we say dash
start
and we'll start at 1 and then we'll say
grid dash
column dash end and let's end at four
and now if i save
well that looks way different doesn't it
so what we have done the first line is
here on the left hand side of the grid
the second line
is here
when we get to the second column the
third line
is here when we get to the third column
and the fourth line is over here after
the third column and before the fourth
column and so you can see we told it to
start at the first line and end at the
fourth line so it really spans the first
three columns we can do the same with
the row so let's say grid dash row dash
start
and we'll go ahead and start again at
one then we'll say grid dash row dash
end and let's end at 3 and save and see
what happens when that happens
we took up two rows so the starting line
was at the top and then the second line
was between the first and second row
and the third line is between the second
and third row so when we told it to stop
at line three it stops before the third
row now we can see this better with dev
tools so i'm going to drag our page over
so it takes up the full window and then
i'm going to press ctrl shift and the
letter i to get to dev tools
and then i want to go to elements i
believe yep and i'm going to drag this
up
and no we don't need the console let's
look at layout there we go so i don't
need to drag that up i need to bring
this down maybe i can close that there
we go so
now we're in layout here not styles not
computed but layout and we can scroll up
and we can overlay the grid
on our main container and look at it in
the browser so now we see this and the
lines are labeled so you can see one
two
three
four
likewise at the top we have one and then
two and then three coming down so for
the row we start at one and we end at
three
for the column we start at one
and end at four and you can always do
this in chrome dev tools just make sure
you open it up go down to this second
area here and not styles not computed
but choose layout and then you can go to
grid overlays and there are some other
things that you can apply as well it
should default to show line numbers and
that's what you definitely want when you
see the overlays okay with that said i'm
going to close this i'm going to drag
our chrome window back to the right so
we can see our code and let's apply just
a little bit more to this grid i'm going
to scroll up for just a little more room
and i'm going to show you what i do
instead of typing all of these out
because this gets to be a little bit
much so instead of grid column start and
end and grid row start and end i would
type
grid dash
column and then i would specify start at
the first line then put a slash and end
at the fourth
and if i save you can see that's what
happens likewise i can do that with grid
dash row and say start at the first line
and at the third line and save and we're
back to where we were with fewer
properties as long as you understand
that these are shorthand and this
essentially is the starting number
and the ending number for both of these
properties let's go ahead and select one
more of these grid items so once again
use the box class and now i'll use nth
dash child
and we'll select the second item now for
the second item we'll change the
background color once again and i'll
make this one purple so it stands out
and we save we can see that it is now up
in the top right
after that we'll come down to the next
line
and let's put our grid
dash column
and let's say it starts at the first
line but ends at the fifth and that
should make it span
the entire row or the entire container
if you will so when i save
that made a big change right there
then let's use grid row say grid dash
row
let's have it start
at the third line
and end at the fourth line and when i
save you can see that made some changes
too now instead of three and four being
below it
they came back up here by default in the
grid so again that's implicit the grid
is calculating where to put everything
that we do not explicitly tell it to and
now just like flexbox where something
that was a flex item could also be a
flex container we can do that with grid
too so we can nest a grid inside of a
grid item so i'm going to take this
first child and put
display and set that to grid
and now inside of that i'm going to say
align dash content
and just to change it up here i'm going
to say end to begin with and we save
and look what it did it took the number
one down here to the bottom so it
aligned the content to the end as you
might guess you could choose
center
and you could have start as well
so what i'm going to do is say center
and then after center i'm also going to
say
justify content and we could say for
that it could be start and if we save
you can see that's to the left
and end
all the way to the right and if we say
center
it should be right in the middle so now
we have centered both vertically and
horizontally so that's how you can
center with grid but we can shorten this
up by using the place content shorthand
and then we could say both properties so
we could say
end and center and i'll get rid of these
other two
and you'll see what happens the first
one is the align content so it's at the
bottom
but then horizontally it's centered
because that is the justify content and
this is the align content but if we just
put one value it takes that value for
both so we can just say place content
center and center anything we want to
inside of a grid so now we've looked at
how you can quickly use auto flow to
create a grid or how you can place grid
template columns and rows and then
assign different starting and ending
points to put the grid items basically
anywhere you want them in the grid but
there is another way to set up grids too
and that is with named grid items and
grid template areas so let's do that now
but we'll continue to keep this on our
page as part of the page so i'm going to
go back to the html and i'm going to
drag visual studio code back over to the
full window to start out okay we want to
add a header element first and it's
going to have two classes we'll give it
a header class and then just an el class
for element i'll put an h1 element
inside the header and i'll just say
header for that
after that we'll have our main element
then we'll have an aside element that is
going to have a
sidebar class and also the el class
inside the aside element i'm going to
use an h2 and we'll just say sidebar
inside this h2
we'll do much the same for the footer so
a footer element with a class of footer
and a class of el for element and then
inside of that we'll use h2 and we'll
say footer as well so let's save our
html and you can see we've now outlined
more of a traditional page with a header
a main area and a side and a footer i'm
going to jump back to the style page and
drag visual studio code back over to the
left
and now you can see this on the page
we've got a header at the top a sidebar
and a footer they're not much to look at
you can just see the text not really an
outline of the elements at all they are
block elements so they are expanding 100
across the page right now i'm going to
scroll all the way back up and we're
going to make the body element of the
page a grid container so we'll start out
by saying
display
grid
and then we'll say grid
dash template
dash columns
and let's set this to repeat and we'll
have nine columns and we'll use one
fraction for each column so let's save
that and boy did we see some changes on
the page this is going to drastically
change from here though as well so now
let's say
grid dash auto dash rows
and we'll say 75 pixels
and then we'll say auto and then we'll
say
75 pixels again and let's save and that
didn't change too much but it will here
in the near future because we're going
to say grid
dash
template dash areas
now this is where we can define names
of our items on the page but we're also
going to have to apply these to each
item we're going to call our header hd
so i'm going to tab in just a little bit
and this would be hd now we have nine
columns and this is where we can really
visualize our grid and i may need to
pull visual studio code back over to get
some more room but i'm going to type hd
nine times once for each column so
there's two three four five six seven
eight nine yep i'm going to go ahead and
bring visual studio code back over
and then once we have the full page
we'll be able to visualize this better
and then we'll come back and look at our
browser afterwards so now we've got main
which will be named mn i'm going to use
it
and we're putting it in for each column
but when i get to the last two i'm going
to put an sb for sidebar that will be to
the right of the main element and then
as you might guess at the bottom oh we
need quotes first
i'm going to put ft for footer
and now this is kind of visualizing how
our page is going to look this is going
to be the header
this is going to be the main area
the sb will be the sidebar
and then the footer will be across the
bottom
but with all of this it won't apply yet
because we haven't defined those areas
we haven't really named them on the
items yet i'm going to save this much
and now let's scroll down and define the
rest of this so after
the body definition let's go ahead and
define that el that we applied the class
that we applied to these new elements
and we'll give them a background color
of rebecca purple just a little bit
different than the other purple we used
a color
of white
we'll set each one of these to a display
that's grid and we'll just center the
content that we put in which were
essentially the labels
okay after that we need to go ahead and
identify each class that we applied so
we'll have our header
and this is where we can define our name
so we'll just say grid dash area
set that to hd is what we have in our
template
for the header okay so now let's do the
same for the sidebar so we'll say dot
sidebar because we have a class for that
this will be grid dash area this will be
sb but let's go ahead and color the
sidebar as well so background color
here is going to be blue
and then we also have a footer so we'll
say dot footer for the class
and here we'll say grid dash area
set that to ft
so now we should be good except we
haven't named our main area yet so you
can see everything else in the grid so
let's just come down to our container
and that is the main element and here
we'll put grid dash area and we'll name
it mn for main and save
now let's go ahead and pull visual
studio code back to the left and see
what we have well that looks pretty good
we've got our header across the top
we've got our sidebar on the right we've
got our footer at the bottom and here is
our main element the container that we
were previously working with that still
has our grid so now this is a nested
grid and then inside of this nested grid
we created this grid item and made it a
grid so we could center the content so
it's nested once again i think the only
thing i may want to add would be some
space for our grid that's on the body so
after we've defined this and you can see
it's scrunched now with the lines
wrapping
but here i'm going to put a gap
once again say one rim
and so now well now i have an error
because i didn't put a semicolon at the
end of our template areas which is very
easy to do so let's save that bring it
back and now i'll say gap
and one rim
and now we can see this gap now it
pushes our page down here just a little
bit when we did that so we might need to
change that resize something but overall
we've got a gap of one rim between the
header and the main element and the
sidebar once again we see that gap
between the sidebar and main element and
footer and then we see that right here
with the column as well so let me drag
this over to take up the rest of the
page and once again i'm going to press
ctrl shift and i to open up dev tools
we're going to look at the layout
scroll up and do the overlay here so we
want to overlay the body now and now we
see the body has nine columns
and we can see each one of these columns
defined but here's the only one that we
really see the gap on for the column
which is right here around line number
eight now we do see the gap here around
line number two for the row and then
once again around
i can see a line number down here but
right right here as well no not right
here here it is line number three down
here between the footer and the main
element as well so we had a similar
sized gap here inside of our nested grid
which was throwing me off so we could
change that as well we could change
pretty much anything we want to
so for that let me go ahead close the
dev tools just to get everything to fit
a little bit better let's bring this
back
change our gap to
0.5 ram and let's also go ahead and
change the size we're using here
from 75 and i'll select both of those to
50 pixels
and yeah it's fitting on the page a
little bit better there's no scroll up
or down now and we might even just want
to have a column gap
instead of a row gap so if we save and
do that
you can see now we've got a small footer
a small header and we have this small
column gap here and it doesn't match the
column gap inside our nested grid so
there could be other styles we want to
change and play around with but overall
i hope this has helped you see how grid
can be applied in many different ways
and give you a good start and much like
flexbox froggy that i recommended at the
end of the flexbox module let's go ahead
and look at grid garden which is a game
that will help you learn how to use css
grid as well i'll link to this in the
description it's at
cssgridgarden.com but once again 28
different challenges here that will help
you master css grid or at least learn a
lot more about it
let's learn about styling images with
css we'll be looking at foreground
images and background images today
foreground images are the images on the
page and as you might expect background
images are in the background so let's
look at our starter code we have a basic
html page here with nothing in the body
right now and then for the style.css
file we're importing a font from google
and i have changed this from roboto that
i've used in previous lessons to nanito
i believe that's how that's pronounced
and you can see it is used right here
you can use that or you could still use
roboto or really any font you want to
that's just a preference thing and you
don't have to go back to the google font
site to do that you can just change it
in the string here where family equals
and puts the font name and then of
course
match that here now if you choose a
different font of course make sure it
matches up with everything you have
chosen that the fonts
google.com site recommends okay so then
we've just got our basic css reset and
on the body we are applying that font
family and a minimum height of 100
viewport units we've got a lot to learn
about images today so let's get started
inside of the html and we'll add some
content that we can style we'll start
with a section and i'm going to apply
the class example because i'm just going
to give this as an example for now then
we want a paragraph
and then inside the paragraph let's go
ahead and put an image element and you
can see it automatically gives us a
source and an alt attribute for the
source you can see inside of our image
folder we've got several images and
we're going to use this pat1.png
i'll click on this you can see in visual
studio code it is just a square with a
pattern on it
and then you can see at the bottom it
has 200 width by 200 height that is the
dimension of the image now as we learned
in the html lesson we'll want to apply
that width and height to let the browser
reserve that space to prevent content
layout shift but what i'm going to do
right now is type the image folder
because we need to look inside of that
folder for the image press tab and then
it gives us a list in vs code of the
images we can choose i'm going to choose
this pat1.png
and then i'll just say
pattern1 here as the alt text which you
always want to provide for images but
then let's go ahead and apply the width
and set that equal to 200 there
shouldn't be pixels or any type of unit
on this we just apply this intrinsic
value and you can reference that in mdn
as well as it suggests to do that
and this is just once again reserving
that space in the browser it's not
really going to use these settings we
can override that with css but in case
of a failure of the css file to load or
anything else we are telling the browser
to reserve this space so let's go ahead
and set that and then i want to put some
text inside of this paragraph as well
and i'll just say
yeah this is a
paragraph and we'll look at what gets
rendered on the page with this so i've
already started the page with live
server and you can see it is running
down here i'm going to drag this to the
left as we'll split the screen and we
can see what we have on the page now we
have got our image and we have got the
paragraph next to it but we need to
apply some styles to what we have put on
the page so i'm going to drag this back
over and let's go look at the
style.css let's start by styling our
section element that has the class of
example
and we'll put a margin at the top just
to push it down just a little of one rim
and then we'll say padding dash left to
give it just a little padding from the
left
and we'll give that 20 pixels and now
let's give a border i often do this just
to see or highlight what i am designing
and remove it later so one pixel solid
red border that's fairly common to see
what we're working with on the page okay
after we've applied that class let's go
ahead and apply something to the image
so we'll choose that class and the image
within
and now we'll say width
but that's not where we'll stop because
we did apply a height in the html and it
will not ignore that height now i have
heard others say do not apply a height
because if you just apply a width then
the height will respond that's true if
you have not set the width and the
height
inside of the html but as currently
recommended we are doing so so since we
have done that we need to go ahead and
set the height to auto and then it will
respond to the width so let's just save
this now once again know this width is
not 25 of the image size is 25 of the
container size so i'm going to drag this
back to the left and now we can look at
this and we see we have got a red line
around our section
and then we have our image
and then we have our paragraph now
there's several things i want to look at
here one since i've talked about the
width of 25 percent we have made that
image responsive so i've drug this over
to the full page now and i'm opening up
dev tools so i can resize the window now
notice how the image shrinks as i resize
the window and it expands as i make the
window bigger that is a responsive image
we have given it a percentage width and
we have the height responding by setting
to auto again we have applied the height
because we applied the height in the
html as recommended by mdn and the way
to make it responsive then is apply the
height of auto in your css as it will
respond to the percentage of the width
that you set okay i'm closing devtools
now and dragging this back over to half
the screen and what we really want to
look at now
is this paragraph
notice the y
and also the p here and the g and
another p
these are the letters that have
something that sticks down below the
line we're typically writing on now
notice what happens over here with the
image
it's the same way also notice it's on
the same line as it was even before we
highlighted the container that's because
images or image elements are not block
level elements they're actually in line
and this was the original specification
with html but we often don't want this
behavior so even if i removed this
paragraph right here
you would still see this space we didn't
apply padding or margin or anything to
create this space here but it's often
wondered how do we remove the space
below an image well that's because an
image is actually an inline element
and it allows that space because it was
originally envisioned as being used with
paragraphs or with text overall so you
get this space you don't want here even
though you don't provide a margin or
padding i'm going to show you how to
remove that first so let's go back to
our css and this is part of a reset that
you can just typically do now it doesn't
go inside of the asterisk because that
selects all elements so just at the top
we want to have image
and then display
block
and we can save and now let's go back
and we can look and with a block element
of course it wraps down to the next line
because you know a block element takes
up the full width of the page so let's
go ahead and go back to our
html
and i guess i need this full page once
again so we can see what we're doing but
i want to remove this text right here
and even though it's inside the
paragraph and we could remove the
paragraph if we want to i guess i'll go
ahead and do that too
but just inside this section i'll save
and bring this back over
you can see there is now no space
underneath and i'll switch back to the
style here if we did not have this and
i'll comment this out with shift alt and
the letter a
and save
even without the paragraph we have this
space underneath the image so you want
to set those to block because they're
originally in line
and then you remove that space that you
weren't expecting now let's move on to
our next example so i'm going to pull
visual studio code back over to full
screen
go to the html and i'm going to comment
out what we put in for our first section
i'll leave it in there for you so if you
download the code though you can see
that example so now the next thing we
want to do is create another section i'm
going to give this a class
and i'll set this class well not class i
typed class i should have typed hero
there we go so i'll give it a class of
hero
and now inside this
instead of just an image i'm going to
put a figure element because that's what
we usually put images in and i'll give
this a class of profile dash pic
dash figure so we know exactly what
we're talking about there now inside the
figure i'm going to put
the image element and then we don't
really need to apply a class there we'll
just use that profile pic figure to
reference the image inside of it and
you'll see how i do that
now we once again want to look inside of
our image folder for the source and then
pick one of our images and you can see
i've got a profile dash 800 by 800 and
if we look at that image in visual
studio code you can see the image here
and you can see the dimensions below
that's 800 by 800. i'll go ahead and
close that out let's give it an alt and
i'll just say
profile picture
and then we need to apply the width and
height again we could also apply a title
if you remember that attribute from html
and there we'll just say my
profile picture and that shows up when
we mouse over the image
okay after that let's apply the width
and that would be 800
and then let's apply the height and
that's also going to be 800. i'm going
to press alt z to wrap the code that way
we see it without scrolling over to the
right like it was now if you remember
the figure element we also need a fig
caption element so let's add that
and inside the fig caption i'm just
going to say
jane doe so the name of the page that
this image belongs to or the name of the
person in the image if you will so we
want to add that it helps accessibility
and i'll show you how to hide it if we
don't want it on the screen
so let's save that much and now we can
look at our page and see what we've got
so far it's pretty big it's filling up
the whole page isn't it so we can
definitely change that with css i'm
going to hide the file tree by pressing
ctrl b and we can make our changes here
i'll make them below the body but above
the previous example let's start with
the profile dash pic dash figure class
and there we'll just say a width of 35
and that would be the width of the page
it's referring to because that is
currently the container actually it's
that hero that we created so that
section and it should be the width of
the page so after that let's go ahead
and apply the next to the profile pic
figure
and then the image within and here let's
give the image
a width of 100 because it's in a
container
and the height once again auto and this
does make it responsive we've got a
percentage for the width and the height
set to auto remember we set the width
and height once again in the html to
avoid that content layout shift
okay now we've got min
width
let's set that to 100 pixels we just
don't want the image to get any smaller
than that when it does shrink
and then let's put a border around it so
let's say border
five pixels
double
gray so it's not just one solid line it
should be two
and now let's go ahead and save first
and you can see what we've got here is
our fig caption we're only taking up 35
percent of the width of the full page
right now because that section container
element
is a hundred percent and so the figures
35 and then the image fills out a
hundred percent of that figure that is
of the page then we've got this double
line around the image and you can see
the fig caption underneath one more
thing i want to do to our image though
is make it round and since we have a
square image this wouldn't work if we
had a rectangle but with a square
we can do this and let's say
border
radius
say 50 percent and when we save we now
have our profile image in a circle let's
go back to the html and add just a
little bit more inside of our hero
section that we have right here so after
the figure
i want to add an h1 to the page i'm
going to give this a class of h1 as well
inside the h1 i'm going to go ahead and
give a span element and give a class of
no wrap because i won't want what's
inside the span to wrap if you remember
a span element is an inline element i'm
going to say hello and then i'm going to
paste in a little wave emoji here so
i'll just paste this over
and you can get those wave emojis from
different places i use
emojipedia.com i believe to get that one
after that i'm going to provide another
span element and once again give the no
wrap class
and here i'm just going to say
i'm jane
as that's who's in our picture and now
we can instantly see that on the page as
well so we've got our h1 we've got a
couple of no wrap classes here and we've
got the h1 class on the h1 element let's
go back to the css now okay let's start
below the body but above our profile
pick figure class and if you remember we
have a hero class
and that is the container that is that
section element let's put a border on
the bottom only so we can see it we'll
say 2 pixels
solid we'll give that a color of black
when we save we can see that change
instantly
let's add a few more styles to our hero
let's give some padding here of 20
pixels to push everything a little bit
away from the edges
there we go
and now let's give this a display of
flex and by default flex is a row so
we'll already have our content in a row
then instead of stacked on top of each
other now let's say
justify
dash content and let's say flex start
here
and then after we put that at the start
let's align
the items to center
and after we align the items to center
let's apply a gap between the items of
about 30 pixels and save
and that's what we've got now we've got
our image over here on the left and
we've got the hello i'm jane on the
right now let's go below the hero
section and add our h1 class
and inside the h1 class let's make this
font a lot larger let's say font size
500 percent
and we'll save and see how big that gets
nice and big that works okay what i'd
like to do though is make the page full
screen once again and look at dev tools
so we can resize the page and see some
things right now even though we put
those classes on we haven't defined
those yet so we're getting the text to
wrap in some strange ways that aren't
always the way we want here but notice
our image is shrinking nicely but it
stops at the 100 pixel
minimum width that we left it and we
still have that fig caption on there
that we'll want to remove as well so
just checking out the resizability of
everything at this point let's close
devtools move chrome back over to the
right and let's define those utility
classes so if we come up to the top we
can put some notes in here
and we can say
begin reset
with our comments and then after our
image we can say
end reset
and there we go and now let's go ahead
and put
utility
classes
just organizing this css a little bit
and then we'll say
end
utility
classes
okay so we can define these utility
classes right in here the first one will
be
no wrap now these are things we've
covered in previous lessons but it's a
good review so we'll set white space
to no wrap
now when we save notice what instantly
happened on the page i'm was over here
but we've got it to where i'm jane
should not split that should not wrap
the same with the hello and the wave so
now they're on the lines that they
should be on and we don't want to see
the word i'm and the word jane break and
we don't want to see the hello and the
wave break and that's why we applied
those
classes of no wrap the way we did now
let's go ahead and apply an off-screen
class also so this off-screen class will
still allow the fig caption to be read
for accessibility but it will hide it
from the visible page so we'll say
position set this to absolute
and then let's just send it left minus
10 000 pixels and save
and it looks like it's still on the page
maybe we don't have that on our fig
caption yet and we don't i forgot to put
it on there so let's give it a class
equal to
off screen
and save and now our fig caption is gone
as i expected it to be we've got the
basics of a hero section here a header
for our page but it's pretty plain right
now so let's start working with
background images so now that we have
put our utility classes here let's
scroll back down below the body and back
to the hero section now after this gap
for our flexbox display i'll put an
extra line so we can see these new
properties we're going to work with the
first one is a property you have seen
before and that is background dash color
we want to put a fallback and that is if
the background image doesn't load we at
least want to have a color behind it so
let's put rgb and i'm going to go with
the color i discovered that i think i
like
and just put these three values in there
you can see it's kind of a peach or gold
i'll save this
and there you can see the background
color that we now have for the hero
section but that's a fallback so let's
go ahead and put in a background image
that is background dash image now you
would think we might specify image here
but actually we need url
and inside of the parentheses then we
put quotes and now we need to go inside
of the image folder again but remember
we were doing that in html simply by
typing image but we're not in that
folder now we're in the css folder so we
need to go up out of the folder that's
two dots to go up
then a slash and now you can see visual
studio code says our image folder is
there and now let's pick this
pat one that we looked at before it has
a pattern on it
and i guess i need to put a semicolon
there where that ends that was right at
the end of the line and now let's save
and of course our text is black so that
doesn't look too good there but
otherwise you can see this pattern
behind
everything and it's a repeating pattern
and we'll talk about that too let's go
ahead and quickly
add a color to our h1
so we can see our text again so now
we've got hello i'm jane in white
but
what is happening by default is our
by 200
image is repeating both on the x-axis
and the y-axis in both directions and
it's filling this out and the pattern
looks pretty good you can't see where it
starts or ends really so what we can do
to control that
is the background
dash repeat property and we can just say
no repeat and now let's look at what
happens
now we just have our 200 by 200 image up
here in the top left by default
likewise we've already seen what happens
with the default
repeat value and it repeats everywhere
but we can just say repeat y for the y
axis
and it just stays all on the up and down
essentially the y-axis or repeat x and
it's all on the x-axis which would be
horizontal or across let's just leave it
to repeat for now even though that's the
default i'll just leave that property in
there and let's change out this image
let's look at another pattern that i
have saved in there which is pat two we
can save that now our white font doesn't
look as good on top of it and it's
always important we want to emphasize
this the font is the most important
thing so you have to work with that to
be visible because if it's not the
background image is essentially that
it's just background it's not really
what's important you can see the lines
if you look closely to see how this
image repeats just a little bit more
often so if we set this to no repeat i
believe it's once again 200 by 200 or
something like that you can see the
image by itself there
and if i save you can see it repeat
across now if you have a transparent
image and i set up a transparency of
this image as well
and you save you can see now this kind
of looks cool because we have some of
that color that's underneath
coming through the image
and i'm not going to show how to create
transparencies in this tutorial that
would be more like a photoshop or other
image editing tutorial however if you do
have access to images that are somewhat
transparent like this it is a cool
effect to do that of course i would
probably switch this text back to a
black font or something that would show
up better on top of it at that point now
let's also look at some more images like
you would use and once again i want to
emphasize how important it would be to
make your text visible no matter what
image you're using and we're just seeing
the clouds right now but this is a much
larger image if i go over to the file
tree and click on the scenic image drag
visual studio code back over where you
can see it all we've got a waterfall
lots of things in this image that we
might want to see so we can change that
let me bring this back over
hide the file tree so we have some room
underneath our background repeat let's
put in background dash size and set this
to cover when we save
now we see much more of that image
but it still might be a little
concerning how readable this text is so
you might want to work with that of
course to make it stand out some more
but that does look good now let's drag
this over as well
and if we open this up you can see it's
definitely bigger here and looks
different let's open up dev tools and
once i have dev tools open you can see
how the image resizes with that cover
setting and there are other settings for
background size as well you could put in
an absolute or percentage or other
things you might want to but cover is a
very nice one to use i'll go ahead and
close this and move this back
another word that you might use in there
besides cover is contain so let's at
least see what it does it's not what we
want to use but since it's repeating you
can see that we have two of the image
now because it does repeat if we set
this to no repeat
and save you can see cover or i'm sorry
contain
fits the full image in here and contains
it but it doesn't make it cover the
space that we want it to so let's put
this back to cover for our use
and we can leave the no repeat there as
well because that's what we want but
let's say we showed this to jane and
she's not quite liking it of course the
text isn't popping out and she wants to
be more about discovering things not
just about an image of some cool scenery
so we're going to change this scenic
image and let's change it to an image of
a map and you can see it's a rather
large image which is something else i
didn't discuss now this would be a
different tutorial to talk about image
optimization a lot of times you want to
shrink images down and this is a rather
large image but that said you also have
to be careful because some devices have
different amounts of pixels and if you
use too small of an image
then it will look blurry on the devices
that possibly have more pixels so
one rule of thumb i have heard is always
use an image that's twice as big as what
you plan on displaying and that would
help it
up size to that extra pixel setting
essentially and still look good without
looking blurry because otherwise you're
essentially stretching an image to
increase the size of it and that does
make images look blurry so again
optimization would be something to
consider but jane likes this image a bit
better it gives maps and she's talking
about exploring and taking pictures and
so here we've got a background image
with maps on it but still the font isn't
popping out quite as much as we want so
there's some things we can do there
let's go back to the css and i need to
scroll back over here a little bit we
can add some more to our h1 so this
color
the
white looks good i mean it does pop out
a little bit but let's do something
that's not quite white let's give
alice blue a try which is kind of a
different
white you can see it's not quite the
same white but it does look white it
doesn't really look blue to me at least
and after that we can apply a text
shadow to make it pop off the page just
a bit
this is applied to the x-axis so we'll
say 2 pixels y-axis 2 pixels and then
there is a blur value and that makes the
shadow not as crisp but a little blurry
so i'll put that at 5 pixels
and then we say what color we want the
shadow and we'll just make it black when
we save you can see that text pops off
the page just a little more so that's
something you can do to help your text
stand out as well don't abuse it though
you can do way too much with that but of
course it's set to preference then after
that we could put a background color so
let's talk about that if we put in
background color
and we just set it to black
that's not going to look that great but
let's go ahead and do it for the moment
and now if you remember from our color
lesson we can click on this square
open this up i'm going to go over to hsl
and then i'll drag the transparency down
here and i'm thinking maybe let's go to
40 percent and see what we get
if we leave that and now we save well
now we can see the image because it's a
transparent color and that helps a
little bit now we could add and again
this is to preference complete
preference here
we could go ahead and add some padding
so let's do that try it out we'll say
padding
and let's go 0.25 round
and then after that we can also add a
border radius
to that background and let's just go
with 10 pixels to round the corners and
so now you see this kind of contained
here but
i don't know if i like that or not but
there is another trick we can do that
kind of applies the same thing but it
does it more broadly so you don't really
see this box around there so i'm going
to comment these out but once again
leave them in the code for you because
that is to preference now let's jump
back to our html and what i'm going to
do
is put a container around our hero
section and here i'm going to use a div
and i'll just say class of container
i'll take that closing div control x to
cut it out come down to the bottom of
the section paste it in with control v
and save and now we have a container
around our code i guess i could
highlight this and tab it over to make
it a little more uniform there we go
and now that we have the container we
can style that container so we'll go
back to our css and again this is a work
workaround only if you're trying to make
the text a little more legible you want
a little more control
and to get that separation between the
background and the text so this is
nothing that is required it's just
something that you might want to know
how to do and what we're going to do is
essentially create a filter or a mask by
having this extra layer so it's just a
little bit more of an advanced concept
but it's not too difficult to do i'm
going to take everything we have here
for the background of the heroes section
and i'm going to put it in the container
and now that we have that we can save
and we shouldn't really see any
difference because the container is
going to be the parent of the hero so we
would still see all of this behind it
and now instead of in the h1 where we
had this background color here let me go
ahead and just copy this
and we might want to use a different
color but we'll try out the black at
first
we can put in
that background color that we were
putting just on the h1 but now this will
apply to the full hero so let's go ahead
and save this and see what it looks like
and you can see everything got darker
we've essentially put a filter that we
can lighten or darken as we choose so i
want to put a different color here and
try this out so let's make this
100 percent right here and save again
that lightened it up now you see more of
a light filter on it as well so you can
experiment with this and of course you
can go into the colors and choose
anything you want to as well here in
visual studio code i'm going to press
alt z just so we can see that wrap down
here so if we didn't want that maybe we
want a little more transparency
consider that 35 percent and maybe you
liked the darker color instead of the
light color so if we went back
and made that a zero that's essentially
working with black there so now you've
got a darker color but it's a little
more see-through maybe make it 25
i think i liked the lighter color myself
so i'll go back to 35
and then i'll put the 100 percent here
in the third value and yeah that kind of
pops off but it still has that filter
and you can see the maps i like how that
looks just personally but you could
change any way you want to maybe you'd
want to make the double circle around
jane here in black instead of gray now
that we'd have a darker color and that's
something you could do as well but we've
made a nice hero section overall now
let's talk about one other property that
i didn't bring up for the background yet
and this would be background position
i'm going to put it after the repeat
and it's background dash position there
we go and now it has an x and a y as
well so you might see this adjust and
it's how it moves the image so if we put
center center
you can see yeah the map moved a little
bit so
even though we're working with one image
that's covering the whole span you might
see it move so you could say top right
just see how the map moves around for
you a little bit and top left
and not really noticing a change there
what if we said
bottom right
and move it yeah the map moved again
because now we're seeing the bottom of
the image that's the biggest change
right there now if we switch it to top
we'll see the top of the image instead i
like that a little bit better because
it's a little darker up there towards
the top i believe
and you could just provide one value i
think as well
and if we did center
yep it's somewhere right in the middle
now we're not seeing the top or the
bottom
but if we went back to playing around
with a smaller 200 by 200
pixel image you would actually see that
one image
move around the page as well so this is
just something worth checking out to see
what part of the image you want to
display for the background so i'm just
going to leave this as top now because
that makes it a little darker
and looks okay to me it's time to move
on to another example i'm once again
going to leave this css in the code i'll
just come to the html i'm going to bring
this back to full page and i will
comment out what we currently have here
as well and leave it in the code for you
again pressing shift alt and the letter
a to make that
comment after i selected all of that and
so now we're ready to add something new
to the page so we'll come back over here
so we can see the page again and it
should be blank and it is
let's add something to the body itself
let's start with our fallback background
color so we'll say background color oh
that just said background which is
shorthand we'll get it to in a minute
but we've got our background color and
just so we know it's changed let's go to
this alice blue again which isn't quite
the same as the white default and now
you can see it's a different shade here
and after that let's provide an image so
we'll say background
dash image
and here we'll say url once again and
inside the url we need quotes and
remember we're in the css so we go up
out of the css folder and then into the
image folder and now i'm going to go
ahead
and well you know what instead of this
image at first let's do a linear
gradient first and then we'll see how we
can put an image on top of that so let's
go with linear gradient and let's talk
about this this is how we can switch
from one color to another so i'll supply
the first color
steel blue it's a color that i like and
the second color let's go with white and
when i save we'll see the default
behavior it's starting at steel blue at
the top
and going to white at the bottom of the
page and we could put other colors in
here as well so if we wanted purple in
the middle
we can provide purple as well and now
when we look it goes from steel blue to
purple to white so you can use
pretty much as many colors as you want
to and you could have a veritable
rainbow i should say going from top to
bottom or as we'll find out here any
direction you want so i'm going to say
to left and save and you can see it's
white on the left
and it's blue on the right so it starts
at the right and it goes to left we
could do the opposite of that
to right
and there you got blue on the left to
white on the right
you could go to bottom which is
essentially the default or you could go
to top as well
so nice changes there i'm going to go
to
well let's go to left and leave it like
that so now we have this background and
imagine we were typing
paragraphs over here on the left and we
stopped somewhere and it gets darker
over here on the right and that would
work for us now let's look at how we can
apply a second background image and you
can apply more than two if you want to
but i'm just going to do an example with
two
so now i'll say url provide the
parentheses here
a comma after that so we clearly have
our two images defined and i want to go
ahead and space this over if it will and
i may need to go ahead and drag this to
the full page and now we've definitely
got some space there so let me remove
those spaces i just wasn't seeing them
before
bring this down to another line and i
like to have the images lined up like
this when i set it so or a gradient and
an image if you will
so now i'll put in the quotes we need to
go up out of the css folder
into the image folder and now i'm going
to pick bubbles so we have a bubbles
background image and a linear gradient
both let's save and drag this back over
to see what we've got well now we have
bubbles all over the page and that may
not be what we want as well
this isn't responding like i want it to
when i drag this back over so i'm going
to put these back to back so we just
it's one long line essentially is what
this is for the background image we
supply the first one
and then a comma
and then the second one and a gradient
qualifies as a background image as well
so now when we define our background
repeat
we can put in a value for both of these
images so the first one i want to repeat
on the y-axis that's our bubbles they're
going to go from top to bottom but not
left to right then we put a comma and
the second one the gradient i'll just
put no repeat and when we save
now we only have bubbles on the left but
we can change this as well so let's go
ahead and put in a background
position so we'll say background dash
position
and now we'll say
we want them on the right
and
let's use the center so now when we save
there we go our bubbles are on the right
and they show up much better this is a
transparent image that i have over here
so if we just look at the image
and i pull this over you can see it here
in visual studio code it's originally
300 by 300 has a transparent background
with white bubbles
okay we'll drag this back over and that
looks good with this steel blue
background that we're seeing on the
right with everything we've set up i
can't see the code too well going to
press ctrl b to hide that so our
background position has moved the
bubbles much like we want them to be but
the bubbles still look a little too big
so let's say background dash size
and now this first one will be for the
bubbles so this stacks in this order the
bubbles go on top of the gradient so
they come first in the background image
and the gradient comes second likewise
with repeat y applies to the bubbles no
repeat to the gradient background size
20 for the bubbles and then we'll put
auto for the gradient when you save we
have smaller bubbles now over on the far
right now we've wrapped up our example
of linear gradients which are fun to
play around with and also layering
background images so we've got one more
example to look at today and once again
i'm going to comment out previous code
we're using as you can see we don't have
any other in the html but i'll add a
little here
and then i'll comment out some of what
we have in the css just so we don't have
that bubbly background for this new
example so i'm going to provide another
section
and i'll give this a class well this
doesn't need a class but just inside the
section let's go with a paragraph that
has a class of clip and now inside this
paragraph i'm just going to type jane's
name and save and we can see her name up
here in the top right for now let's go
back to this style once again i'll
comment out this background that we
currently see here i'll leave the
background color but everything else but
i'll leave it in the code for you again
shift alt in the letter a to comment
that out and if i save that should all
be gone we still have jane's name so now
i'll scroll down here all the way to the
bottom below our first example
and i'll provide this clip class
and there's several things we want to do
here we want to give this a very heavy
font weight so i'm going to give it 800.
if we save that you can see it's very
bold now but it's still very small so
let's make this big we'll say font size
let's go with 18 rim we want to fill the
page for the most part and i think that
will do it after that let's say text
align
and set this to center and now we've
centered jane's name as well
okay after that let's provide
a background
and
we could just say background once again
with this shorthand or we could say
background image so i'm going to go
ahead and say image
we'll provide url and now we go up
into the image folder and then let's
take that scenic image that we
previously had and save and now of
course we see the clouds we haven't
changed the position or anything else of
the image but we'll do some of that here
let's at least change the size so
background size is going to be
and now we can see that full image
behind
jane's name
so now let's go ahead and text dash
transform
set jane's name to uppercase
and it's really filling out the page now
now the property i want to talk about is
background clip so let's look this up at
can i use dot com
because there's something specific about
it background dash clip we'll select
that and you see background dash clip
text and it says a non-standard method
of clipping a background image to the
foreground text
so
it says unprefixed is only supported by
about 19 of browsers
but
there is a prefix that we need to use
with this so we can see the support for
edge not explore and we're not really
going to worry about explorer ever
probably but for chrome you see the
little yellow here and it says supported
with prefix
webkit firefox doesn't need that
but just about everybody else does so we
need to use that prefix when we apply
this property so what we're going to do
is say dash
webkit
dash
background dash clip
and now we'll say text
now this won't do everything that we
want but it did take the background away
here in chrome as expected let's set the
color and we want this to be transparent
so first i'm just going to choose this
black color and now we'll do the work
here by clicking on the color
getting that pop-up i'm going to switch
this over to hsl
we'll pull this down to about 20 percent
right in there and take a look
at what we get now
so now it's a little dark because we can
still see 20 percent of the black but
essentially
we're seeing the image inside the text
only which is kind of a cool way to do
that we'll go ahead and put this to zero
and see if it makes much of a difference
and yeah it might have lightened up just
a little bit so you could make this a
little darker by adding about twenty
percent and there you can see the
difference and you could do this with
other colors too we're essentially
creating that same mask
over the image or you could make it
totally transparent and i believe to do
that you could just say
transparent
and save and yep that works too so if
you want it totally transparent you
don't even have to put a color there at
all now
this will not be working in firefox you
would need to of course use that as a
fallback
for when
it is not supported in browsers and
otherwise you need to have this will
this impact chrome by putting it there
no but now this would also make it work
in firefox and now every other browser
that needs this webkit prefix also works
so we just have to have both there and
before we wrap up i am realizing we
didn't really cover that background
shorthand which can be very confusing
and i like to use the individual ones
like background color and background
image when possible but let's come back
up to what i commented out on the body
and uncomment that so we'll see
jane's name over the bubbles and we can
save that much but now what we
essentially want to provide here when i
do use the background shorthand is just
a few of these properties three
specifically so we'll start with the
repeat we'll say
repeat
dash y
and then we'll say right
center
for the position and then we'll have our
url
which was
dot dot slash image slash and then we
had our bubbles selected and then we can
put a comma and we can supply the values
for that second image as well so now
we'll say no dash
repeat
and then we'll have our linear
dash
gradient if i could spell once again and
then we'll say two left
we had steel blue
and then we had
i believe just our regular white yep
there we go
and then we can go ahead and put the
semicolon there now let's put size after
that because we didn't attempt to
include the size in the background
shorthand however you can it's just
fairly complex and it gets confusing so
you could look that up on mdn if you
want to i'll provide a link in the
resources
but this is about as complex as i like
to get with that shorthand or it just
starts get to get too confusing so what
we've done is eliminate the background
image background repeat and background
position properties that were
individually there so i'll just comment
those out we save we have the same
result using the background shorthand
let's move on to css media queries media
queries allow you to modify your site
based on specific characteristics and
parameters and most often we look at the
browser viewport width
this is key to responsive design as our
web pages will respond to the width of a
device viewport
so let's look at the starter code i have
got some basic html here and i have a
page outline that has a header a nav
inside the header element
a main element and a footer element and
so we're just going to outline a page
and see how it changes based on viewport
changes and then in the css i've got
some basic css here we're importing the
nanito font from google other than that
we have the basic css reset and a basic
style a change you may notice is i'm
using the font shorthand property now
that sets both the font size
and the font family all in one right
here in the body other than that min
height of 100 viewport units okay before
we do anything with css we really need
to look at the html there is a meta tag
here that enables responsive design and
that meta tag has the name viewport and
you can see the content is width equals
device width and then initial scale of
1.0 this is necessary to enable our
media queries and allow responsive
design in our web pages now do you have
to memorize how to type that out not
really because vs code helps us a lot
i'm going to just select everything
quickly with control a
cut it out of the page with control x so
i have a blank html page
and now in vs code if i type an
exclamation mark you can see it says
emit abbreviation when i press tab
it fills out the basic skeleton of an
html page and you can see
it includes this meta tag with the name
viewport the content with width equal to
device width and the initial scale set
to 1.0 it's very important to have that
as we work with responsive design and
visual studio code helps you do that i'm
going to press ctrl a now to select all
of this and then ctrl v to paste over
and just go back to the page outline
that i already had with the header nav
main and footer ctrl s to save and we're
ready to move on to the css okay before
we add any actual css to what we already
have let's just talk about the syntax of
a media query first so i'm going to
paste this in and look at the syntax
that is how we write it so we start out
with at media
and then we give the media type and then
we specify a condition or conditions as
we can link those with logical operators
and and or
and then we specify a break point and
that depends on the condition as what
type of break point we'll use there's
lots of different types of break points
and conditions we can apply and then
just like we do with anything else we
put the css rules between the curly
braces so now that we've looked at that
syntax let's go ahead and write a media
query and see how that applies so we can
start out with at media and instead of
media type here
we can say
screen that is the most common one
you'll see you might also see all or
print or even speech for screen readers
and devices that read the screen back to
you and then after condition or as the
condition i should say you often see min
width and you should read min width as
starting from so whatever the width we
specify is these styles will start from
that width when we say min width
likewise max width would be up two so
the styles would apply up to the width
we would provide if we said max width
there we usually do this with min width
and that is because we design from the
smallest to the largest and that is what
is called mobile first design and
responsive design
and the reason we do that is well think
about it this way as an analogy when you
get a box you unpack something it's
often hard to put everything back in the
box the way it was packed and get the
lid to close it's kind of like that when
we design a page it's easier to start
with the smallest and work our way
towards the largest rather than start
with the largest and then try to squeeze
everything into a smaller and smaller
box if you will so that's kind of the
analogy i used to explain that so we'll
start out with a mobile device screen
usually that's a one column design and
we can spread things out as we go so for
this first min width for the break point
let's say i would put and remember this
is starting from
so i would put something like oh let's
go with 481
pixels so all of our styles before this
media query
would be applied until we got to 481
pixels and then they would still be
applied
unless we were to overwrite them because
the cascade still works so here we could
change something maybe about the body
maybe the font maybe a background color
and that's what we'll experiment with
today because it's so easy to see those
background color changes
and
then we can overwrite the previous style
we had other styles if we do not
overwrite those they will still apply if
they were applied before the media query
now as always i'll give a link to the
mdn references in the description below
but let's talk about some of the other
conditions and break points we could
have although as i've said min width and
max width with pixels as a breakpoint is
very common but you could also have
something like
orientation and then you would set that
to uh possibly landscape which would be
kind of turning your phone to the
horizontal instead of the vertical
orientation something like that there's
also something like
min dash aspect
dash ratio and there you can actually
set a ratio and there are many different
sizes of phones so while landscape would
actually apply to anything that was
wider than it was tall
here we could set something more like
specific like 16 by nine or say
seven by four something like that then
when the aspect ratio reached that size
so the width would be
7 and the
height would be 4 in that ratio or 16 by
9 or whatever we put
that is when that would apply now
remember we can also put more than one
rule here and we'll look at that very
soon as well so how do we decide what
breakpoints to apply and what values to
use well there are some common ones and
we can also look at some css frameworks
and see what they have applied because
they have probably researched that and
worked with it a little bit more than we
have so let's look at what some others
have done i'm going to open up the file
tree here you can see i have a notes dot
md that i'm going to include in this
repository dot md means markdown so it's
a markdown file when i click on this
you'll see the outline here but i'm
using an extension and if you want to
get that extension it's called markdown
all-in-one you can search for that in
the visual studio code extensions area
and then you can install it if you want
to use that as well so when you have
markdown all in one
then you can go ahead and preview the
markdown and that's what i'm going to do
with control shift in the letter v and
now i've got a markdown preview and this
is how github would read our markdown so
i've provided a table here so some
common media query breakpoints you can
see
mobile devices are often considered to
be
pixels width or less
and then from 481 to 768 usually ipads
tablets
769 to 1024 small screens and laptops
1025 to 1200 desktops and large screens
and 1201 and greater extra large screens
and tvs now that's just kind of a common
general guideline of course there are no
standards so you can set these how you
want but let's look at what the
bootstrap css framework does
and i tend to like these
and i'm i guess maybe i'm just used to
these but
576 instead of 481 as we saw referenced
above
is considered extra small and then
anything greater than 576 is small
768 and above is medium 992 is large
1200 is extra large and then they have a
sec extra-large which is double xl at
1400. now tailwind is another css
framework that is very popular now in
recent times and you can see they've
also differed somewhat they consider the
extra small to be less than 640.
maybe that's because in recent years our
devices have seemed to have grown into
larger sizes after that 640 and above is
small now we meet up and agree at 768
and that is where the ipad
is usually at the traditional ipad and
then we've got 1024 here which is a
little different than 992 as far as
bootstrap was concerned then 1280 and
1536 so you can see even professional
opinions vary and you can set your
breakpoints how you want to as your page
needs to respond so it can respond to
the content you can work with your
content and set the breakpoints
according to that you could target
specific devices or just use some
general guidelines as well let's go back
to the css now and start to write some
code and we'll see how this applies okay
i'm going to drag visual studio code to
the left and we can see our page on the
right it currently has very little
applied as far as styles just our css
reset and our basic body styles right
here
and then we have our media query i'm
going to hide the file tree with control
b so we have a little more room to write
code i'll go ahead and remove this media
query for now just so we can start out
with our basic page first and remember
we're designing for the smallest screen
first and we'll work our way up so we'll
just put in some basic styles here the
easiest thing to see as we're learning
about media queries is to change the
background color and let's do that by
first setting a background color here on
the body i'm going to set it to four
seven five five six nine
kind of a nice grayish color if we save
that we can see that doesn't highlight
our lettering as well but we'll change
this of course as we change media
queries
and now after that we can change a
little bit about how this displays as we
learned in the last lesson about images
so we'll set background image and now
instead of linear gradient that we
learned about before there's one other
one i would like to show and that's
called a radial gradient
and now this starts in the center and
works its way out instead of top to
bottom bottom to top left to right or
right to left or any direction that we
would send a linear gradient this will
always start from the center
i'm going to use
white smoke as the first color and then
we'll use that color that we specified
as the fallback background color
for the second color and when i save now
you can see it lightens up here in the
center and it works its way out to a
darker color on the left and the right
top and bottom now let's make well i'll
put a semicolon there let's make
our body a flex container and then let's
set the flex direction
and we'll set that to column because
row is the default and we want our
elements to stack instead of being a row
i'm going to scroll for a little more
room and now let's go ahead and identify
each piece here we have a header
a nav
a main and a footer and we will apply
this style to all of those elements so
we'll set each one of those to display
grid
and then we'll center our content by
saying place content center and when we
save now we see that has been saved in
the center of each one so this really
means we've stacked our elements and
nothing is below so we want this to take
up the full page and we'll take that on
here very shortly so i'll scroll for
some more room here on the left and now
i'm going to put a style on just the
header
and the footer
and here we'll say position
sticky as we want these at the top and
the bottom
let's identify these with a different
background color
and here we'll say 1
e 2 9 3 b there we go a little darker
but then let's give the font the color
of white smoke as well
we can save that and now we can see our
header and footer and remember the nav
is nested inside the header and now
we've applied position sticky but we
didn't provide the other value that we
need to stick the header or the footer
in a
specific position so here i'm going to
say header now because it will have a
different position than the footer we'll
say top 0 and now that is in the same
place but after that we can come down
below and say footer
and here we'll say
bottom 0 and save and now right now it
looks like it's in the same position
because we haven't expanded the page but
the footer will be stuck to the bottom
and the header will be stuck to the top
and we can see the difference in that
i'll scroll for a little more room
and in our main element and it is a flex
item right now as it's inside the body
that is a flex container we can say flex
dash grow set that to a value of 1
and now the main element has grown to
fill out whatever space was available
now before we move on to a media query
let's go ahead and style the nav just a
little bit more to make it stand out so
let's give it a background dash
color
set that equal to white
after that we'll set its color or font
color to black
let's give it just a little bit of
padding here 0.5
rim and let's give it a border
bottom and let's set this a little
thicker two pixels
solid
black and let's see what we get
well that looks good except we don't
quite have the width we want yet we can
easily solve this by going back to where
we place the grid on each of these
elements the header nav main and footer
we've got it centered but we don't have
block elements at this point that are
100 percent width so let's add grid dash
template columns and set that to 100
percent
now when we center
those or actually give them 100 width
and we've centered them and you can see
main is centered here vertically but
it's not horizontally now but the
elements do have 100 percent width and
this is text content
text content pardon me so we just need
to say text align center
and now we get everything where we want
it but we actually have 100 percent
width for each of those elements once
again and now we have our basic page
layout so let's go ahead and add a media
query now that will change things up a
little bit
so underneath our footer we first want
to indicate that's what we're doing so
i'll put a comment
and here let's say
small that's where we'll start out with
our media query i'll say at media
and then we'll use screen
and
i'll say min width
and here we'll say
576 pixels so the styles we have put in
are valid up to 576 pixels and they will
still be valid if we do not overwrite
them here so now let's go ahead and
style the body here
and the first thing we'll do is set a
background dash color
let's just set it to green something
we'll definitely notice a change on and
then we can go ahead and use that same
background image
style that we're using with a radial
gradient
and inside there we'll start out with
white smoke once again and then we'll
just switch to green
okay besides the body let's do one other
thing let's take the nav
and let's just set the display to none
so it will disappear
and now look what happened we're already
past that 576
width so we see those changes instantly
we no longer have a nav on the page and
now our background for the body is main
now we still have our background color
on the header and footer that we set
because we did not overwrite those with
a new style here
so that is what has changed based on
that width now how can we go back and
forth this is interesting and something
you should learn how to do so i'll drag
this over till it's full screen
you want to go to dev tools and there's
certain ways to do that one is to right
click and choose inspect at the bottom
of the pop-up menu another is to press
ctrl shift and the letter i which is
what i tend to do and now devtools
opened here on the right it's fairly
small and i have got the console here
for javascript right now but yours may
open to elements and you can see and
highlight these elements here and that's
really what we want as we style things
and you can see layout but now let's
look at some details about this layout
and how we can adjust that notice the
little mobile devices icon up here let's
go ahead and click that it says toggle
device toolbar
that gives us more tools now we can
choose dimensions and we see the
dimensions here we see the percentage
that's showing so i'm going to set this
to 100 and now i can see that these are
the dimensions for an iphone 6 7 and 8.
we can change this to a responsive
screen or choose different devices so
i'm using the responsive screen now and
i can drag it to make it
narrower or wider and you saw that
change and there we went past our 576
we're now at 602 pixels wide and we can
see the change likewise we can look at
devices like i was talking about before
so i'll choose iphone five slash se one
of the smaller devices
now not every device has this available
but some do you can go to the three dots
here
in our
new responsive menu bar that popped up
and here we can say show device frame
and now i have a frame that looks like a
phone around my page and now we can once
again change that i want to make it so i
can see the whole phone so there we go
and now we see how it looks on the phone
you can even change to the horizontal
display as you would turn your phone or
back to the normal display here and we
can do that for several different phones
i'll choose the iphone 6 7 and 8 for
example or we can just go back to
responsive and drag the page around
which is what we'll do now because now
up until 576 and we can even type in
here i can say
we're going to switch over so if i said
yep we're back to the original
background color so we can check our
breakpoints right there also there are
break points here that are suggested by
chrome and you can click on these to
change your width as well and see how it
displays and these are a little bit
different than what we reviewed in our
notes markdown file as well so you might
check those out okay let's drag this
back over to the right and then let's
take visual studio code and fill up the
page let's put in some more break points
and then we'll come back and check all
of those out what i'm going to do now is
highlight all of this code then press
shift alt and the down arrow to copy it
down and now let's make our next break
point and we'll label this one
medium
and we're not going to change the nav
anymore it is gone for now so we'll just
leave it gone so all we really want to
do is change the color here for our next
break point and of course the break
point value itself so here i'll switch
this to gold i could have changed those
both at the same time i'll try to
remember to do that next time
so min width instead of 576 this is our
medium let's set it to 768. we want the
pixels behind that to indicate that
after that let's copy this down again so
shift alt and the down arrow
and now this would be our large break
point
we'll relabel that
i'll highlight gold and press control d
to select the other gold i'm going to
change this to fire brick
and so that will give us a nice color
change as well we'll set this to 992
pixels much like the bootstrap framework
does
now let's select our large
shift alt and the down arrow
i'll give another line break there and
then this will be our xl setting
and for that let's go ahead and switch
to another color that will be noticeable
rebecca purple i didn't select that fire
brick i'll do ctrl z to go back to
firebrick
highlight the first one ctrl d to select
the second one and now rebecca purple is
what we want
save that and let's do one more but this
will be different so i'm going to copy
this down but we'll make some changes
just to give an example of how you could
do something differently and look for a
different type of breakpoint as well so
this is still at media screen
but let's go ahead and label this
here we go i can type there we go mobile
and i want that all caps mobile
device
landscape
so now let's combine some things here
instead of min width
let's say
lowercase max height and we'll set the
max height
to 425 pixels and after that let's do
another and
now let's say min aspect ratio you might
have thought i would have said
orientation but i want to
actually be a little more specific here
and say the min aspect ratio of seven to
four so it's noticeably taller than it
is wide
and let's change our rebecca purple
to
dodger blue
and save that as well now inside of this
we'll also do a couple of other changes
so let's say
h1 and h2 that we have for labels we'll
make the font size just a little smaller
to 1.5 rim
and then let's also set that nav
to display none and we need to do that
again because
we didn't hit our other min width when
we hit our max height here so that's a
little different but we'd just be
looking at a different size so we need
to go ahead and switch that to display
none or i believe it would show once
again
so now that we've made those changes
let's drag visual studio code over and
see if they all take place in our page
so we'll drag chrome back over
we'll start down here at the smallest
and there we have our original color
we get a little wider we've got green
a little wider yet we have gold
a little wider yet we have rebecca
purple
it seems like maybe we skipped over the
fire bricks so let's see what happened
there we'll bring this back over
and look at our fire brick and maybe all
it takes is one typo to get something
wrong maybe i did something wrong and i
sure did i did not change
the min width for the rebecca purple for
the xl so we had 992 here and 992 here
again so this essentially was overriding
this so we wanted to change this 992
here and set it to 1200 pixels and now
we should see all of the changes we
expected and here's purple there is our
fire brick color
gold green and back to normal there so
we might see those changes in different
devices as well
so let's go ahead and check that we'll
see our iphone
and we can choose maybe a larger setting
here that's too large let's go with 75
percent there's the iphone
let's go with the ipad and yes it's gold
let's go with the ipad pro
yes that's the fire brick size and you
can see a device frame is not available
for it and then we could even switch up
to say well let's go back to a small
phone first there is that iphone 5se
now let's go ahead and change the
orientation
and now we get our dodger blue color as
we switched because the aspect ratio and
the max height were both met it meant
most both of those conditions and now
you can see how those media queries
apply and we can change the page based
on what the device is the viewing
orientation and of course you're not
going to have someone that typically
changes their screen size as they're
working with your application so you
don't really need to worry about these
smooth transitions in between changes
and that's because nobody will be
changing their device or really their
screen size as they use the application
so you just need to make sure
it appears as you want it to at each
separate break point
today we'll use css to apply responsive
web design as we create profile cards
for the staff of a small company it's
time for another css mini project and
we'll be applying many of the concepts
we've learned from previous lessons in
the css for beginners tutorial series
let's look at our finished project first
this is our end goal i've already got
dev tools open i'm already showing the
toolbar at the top and you can click the
little mobile icon at the top of chrome
dev tools to toggle that device toolbar
and if you click the three dots you can
also show or hide the device frame if
it's available and it is available for
the iphone five slash se which is
currently probably the smallest mobile
device we would design for as of the
making of this tutorial at least and
it's got 320 pixels with
568 high and you can see the project
right here and we can scroll through the
cards for each employee now if we choose
this drop menu and choose responsive
there you can see the page definitely
changes we can see all employees at once
and we see the new width and height at
the top and we can type in here too and
i'm going to actually highlight the
width and change it to 1920
by 1080 and we can see what our page
would look like on a full 16 by 9 or
1920 by 1080 widescreen so this is our
end goal i can grab the side now and
squeeze the page back and we can see how
it adapts to each width all the way back
to our 320 pixels of course we've got
more height than we did in the iphone
right now
but we can see how it adapts to all of
these different sizes and changes as i
drag it all the way back to above 1920
now so now let's look at the code our
starter code today is the finished code
from the last lesson that we had on
media queries but don't worry if you
don't have that you can download it in
the description
or i won't move so fast that you can't
follow along and add the other styles i
will cover all of the styles and as we
see in the file tree over here we've got
a notes.md in the last lesson we
discussed breakpoints and i included
those that's a markdown file
we have our index.html but i've also
added an image folder img and we see
three different profile pictures here so
those are also available for download
with the source code from github and
here's our css once again let's make our
changes to the html first because we
need to add more here so let's switch
the title first from css media queries
to css mini dash
project and then put a colon and we'll
put
let's do profile cards
okay now that we've changed our title we
can change more of the content so
instead of saying header here we're
going to say
our staff
and then inside of the nav we're going
to put some other details instead of
that h2 so let's just put links here and
we'll have an a
with an href attribute and we
automatically get that in there now this
is going to be an anchor tag we can put
the hashtag and i'll put profile1 and
we'll match that to an id later and here
let's just put the first employee's name
so we'll say joe
we're making a nav menu here the next
one will do the same and actually i'll
just go to this line and press shift alt
and the down arrow to copy down twice
and that will save some time for sure
okay after i get rid of that line i'm
going to switch the profile to two and
the next one to three
and then after joe i believe we have
matt
and then we have jane so now we have our
nav menu and our title for our staff
page let's move on to the main element
and we can remove this h2 as well
and now we're going to add an article
and this article element will have an id
equal to
profile
of one and now inside the article we can
put several things but first let's also
add a class and set that equal to
card there we go
now inside the article let's add a
figure and if you completed my html for
beginners course you know we'll probably
put an image inside the figure as well
as a figure caption so let's start with
the image and now we have a source
attribute and an alt attribute so for
the source we're going to look in the
image folder then put a slash and now vs
code gives us the options of what we
have in here and we'll pick the profile
picture
now we'll also put the employee's name
under the alt attribute so there's joe
coder but then if you also remember our
discussion in the images lesson we need
to put a width and a height and this
prevents a code layout shift or i should
say a page layout shift or i believe
the proper term is content layout shift
but as long as you get the concept that
it already reserves that space in the
browser essentially and i've got links
to that in the description with all of
the other resource links okay so we have
a width
equal
500 and we're also going to have a
height equal to 500 there we go we need
that on all images now let's go ahead
and add the fig
caption
and this big caption is once again just
going to be the employee's name so now
we have joe coder in the fig caption
and then underneath our figure is where
we want to put
actually not underneath just the figure
this fig caption goes in that's what i
was doing wrong the fig caption goes in
the figure there we go now underneath
the figure we're going to have a
paragraph but inside the paragraph we
want to use another element we haven't
talked about before we talked about how
to add quotes with html entities
and unicode but we didn't talk about how
to add quotes just with the quote
element itself so i'd like to add that
to this series and hopefully your
knowledge that you can also add quote
symbols with the quote element so here
we put i code stuff this is basically
joe's statement about what he does very
simplified but there we go for joe okay
now that we've got the profile card html
here i'm going to highlight this
and i'm going to copy it down
twice with shift alt and the down arrow
so now we just need to make some changes
for each one of these so now it will be
profile two we've changed both of those
the images are all the same but the next
one is going to be for matte designer so
let's highlight everywhere we had joe
coder here so one and then control d to
select the next one we can put matte
designer
and imagine instead of i code stuff he's
going to say
i design stuff
and then the final employee profile
number three and really i can highlight
one and press ctrl d to highlight it
again and switch that to a three instead
of joe coder so i highlight that ctrl d
again this is going to be jane
devrell for short for developer
relations of course but we just put it
as somebody's last name for what they do
and after that
here we want to put i
teach stuff again all over
simplifications of every job but we just
have a small example now i have prettier
enabled also and notice it just
wrapped all of these attributes down to
different lines if you don't like that
you don't have to use prettier or you
can go to your vs code extensions and
you can search for
prettier
and then you can click on prettier and
install that and it does some auto
formatting and i happen to have it
enabled as i'm making this video so that
when i saved that is why you saw that
auto formatting it put each one of these
attributes on a separate line which is
fine too it still works out the same
okay we're finished with our main
content let's just move down to the
footer where we're not going to say
footer here and we're not going to have
an h2 so let's just put a paragraph and
inside this paragraph now we'll use an
html entity we'll put and copy it's an
ampersand
the word copy and then a semicolon and
that's the copyright symbol and then
we'll just say acme co
if you're a fan of the old looney tunes
this is the company that made all of the
stuff for the coyote and now we've
completed our html so let's shift over
to the css and then i'm going to press
ctrl b to hide the file tree and then
i'm going to drag vs code over to the
left half of the page and we'll look at
our page here on the right now we can
see we've added some content but it is
not conforming at all to the size of
screen we have we need to make some
changes in the css to apply this
correctly to our page i'm going to press
alt z to wrap the code so we can see it
all on the window so if the line is too
long it wraps down to the next line such
as this import from google fonts where
we have
the nanito font here we have our basic
reset with a margin of zero padding of
zero and box sizing border box and now
i'm going to add to this reset something
that we cover covered in the image
lesson
was adding an image reset where we need
it to say display block and that removes
the little space that is by default
under images because they are inline
elements
but then instead of width 100 which you
would often see here i just want to say
max width of 100
and that means
it will not overflow its container and
at the same time we need to add a height
of auto now you'll see many say do not
add a height to images however
we're doing this because we added a
height in the html to prevent that
content layout shift and that is the new
approach so i recommend following that
at this point and if you don't add the
height it will stick with the height
assigned in the html which would be the
original 500 pixels so this height auto
then will adjust according to the width
as well so if we save that we have
completed our basic reset now so we have
our asterisk which selects all elements
and then our image selection here for
the full reset we're applying and we can
already see a change our images are
actually now fitting into the design
even though the design isn't the way we
want things yet it does look a little
better than it did okay we'll scroll for
some more room and i'm going to select
this general styles comment and i want
to make another comment in between
and instead of general styles here i'm
going to keep it all caps and i'll type
utility
classes and after that i'm going to add
a utility class and it's going to be
called no wrap
and then inside the no wrap class we'll
choose the white space property it's
white dash space and there we'll say no
wrap i'm going to use this because jane
has a last name that has a space in it
and we don't want her name to break in
half if the text wraps so let's go back
to the html
and hear
jane's name in the fig caption and we'll
put a span element with a class
of no wrap
and now we still need to scroll over or
i could wrap the code but since we're
only doing this one thing i'll just
scroll i'm going to collect the closing
span that was automatically added and
put it after the end of her last name
we'll save that you won't really notice
a change but now if the text wraps it
will not break her last name into
okay back to the style css now we're
going to move on to the general styles
section
and here we have the font shorthand
which adds a font size and a font family
all in one then we have a min height of
100 viewport units we'll keep all of
that and get rid of this blank line
we have a fallback background color
and then we have a background image set
with a radial gradient which starts in
the center at white smoke and works its
way out to this darker color
and then we have display flex and flex
direction column and that is what stacks
our header on top of the main on top of
the footer and keeps it in that order
okay after that we have a section where
we applied grid to the header nav main
and footer and we're just going to
delete that so if you are following
along with the starter code go ahead and
remove that if you're following along
without it well you don't need to do
anything there now we have the header
and the footer position sticky because
we have the header at the top the footer
at the bottom and we want them to stay
there especially if the page scrolls
and then a background color of a darker
color and then white smoke for the font
color but what else we would like to add
here
is a text dash align
put center so we'll go ahead and add
that so we can center this text okay
just below we have the header with a top
of zero and that keeps the header at the
top notice we also have a footer down
here with the bottom of zero
in between we have the nav and the main
so for the nav we're going to keep the
background color of white we can remove
this color of black for the font color
the padding at one half rim that's fine
and we still want the two pixel border
on the bottom but now let's add some new
styles here let's put the font dash
weight and make that bolder
there we go bolder and then i'm going to
put display
flex here
and then we'll say justify content and
we'll space dash
evenly to spread out
the employee names in this nav menu and
now you can see they are in bold and
they are spaced out evenly here in our
nav menu i'm going to scroll up just a
little bit more and after the nav and
before the main we're going to style
these links so let's add
nav and then a for the anchor element
and also nav
and then a with the visited pseudo class
for after a link has been visited and
let's just shift that color back to the
black color that we had before so when
we save we should see those change to
black now now after the nav anchor and
the anchor visited we also want to style
nav anchor with the hover
and nav
anchor with a focus
and you might even want to add an active
in there or you might like to see it
flash a different color which is another
pseudo class you could do i'm not doing
that one right now but let's put a color
here
and i'll go with hsla which you can also
of course
pick by navigating through the visual
studio code color picker but i've
already got this picked out it's zero
zero percent here
20 in the last one that's easy to
remember and then 0.6 or essentially 60
transparency and then i'll put the
semicolon there at the end and save and
we're not going to see this in mobile
mode because we're not really going to
hover but as we get to a wider design if
we were to show that we could notice
noticeably see that change as we hovered
over now if they had focus here we could
possibly see that so let me tab through
there we see the lighter color as we tab
to each of the names so we can test that
in mobile view
by tabbing through and setting that
focus
okay we're ready to style the main
element now so i will scroll up for that
we want to keep that flex grow so it
does fill out the page no matter what
but after flex grow we can add a few
more things here so let's put
display of flex once again and then
we'll have a flex dash direction
and we'll set that to column
and then we're going to align
dash items and we'll set that to center
now let's put a gap which is shorthand
essentially for column and row gap this
is going to be 1.5 rim
and a padding
of one rim and if we save we should see
some changes there we do a little bit so
the images aren't to the full edge of
the screen and it moved a few things
around for us but we still have more
changes to apply directly to the cards
themselves i'm going to copy the comment
we have here for the small media query
and i'm going to create a section for
the profile card class so here i can
just switch this from small to
profile card
and underneath that we will start to
style the card class so i'll scroll this
up as we continue to grow the styles and
here it would be a card class now inside
this class one thing i'm going to put is
scroll dash margin dash top and you
would have to experiment with this to
get the right size i've played around
with a little bit and i believe eight
rim is the right size what this does is
when we scroll to joe or matt or jane
when that is scrolled then it pushes
down from the top so it doesn't scroll
underneath the header so you want to
have a little margin on the top from the
scroll and this property will do that
after that let's set a width and we're
going to use the min function now the
min function says hey at a minimum
use this width and we'll set it to 100
percent so it can grow to 100 width of
the container but it also takes a max so
it says do not grow any larger than and
we'll put 350 pixels here
so we'll fill out whatever the container
is up to 350 pixels and we can specify
all of that in one line
for the width if we use the min function
after that let's go ahead and put
another background color for this
area of the page which will be the cards
i'm going to go with cbd
5e1 that i've previously picked up more
of a gray or a lighter gray
and then we can go ahead and put a
border and i'll go 2 pixels
solid black
and then let's add a border dash
radius and we'll go 15 pixels here let's
save that much and see the change
there's some definite change there now
let's add a padding
of one rim all the way around
and that changed that up a little bit so
now we have some space in there once
again
now let's add a display of flex for the
card itself
the flex direction
is going to be column once again
and then we'll also say align items
there it is and we'll choose center and
save now something you may notice right
away is the employee name didn't center
that's because it's inside the figure so
this paragraph is outside and it became
a flex item however the fig caption did
not become a flex item because it's
inside the figure which is the flex item
so we'll still need to make a change for
that so underneath the card now we can
select
the card class and the figure element
within
we'll also set it to flex
and then we'll set the flex flow
and that will be columns so that's
column direction and then it's also the
flex wrap property and we'll set it to
no wrap and if we save we don't really
see a change at this point but it will
be good to have that there okay then
let's set the card
image element itself and now we can say
border and let's put a thick border on
that five pixels
double
and a flat black with the 333
hexadecimal code
and then a border dash radius of 50
because it's a square so we can turn it
into a circle and now finally before we
move on to media queries or different
sizes let's add the card
fig caption styles
and for the fig caption we're going to
say font dash weight input bolder
put a font dash size of two rim
a margin of one rim and now we need to
text align
center
for that fig caption
and there we have joe's name in bold and
it's centered and really we're finished
with our smallest screen design before
we get to our first media query so we've
applied all of the main
general styles and then the specific
card class styles
and now we have our design here there's
one more thing i would like to add
though
because right now if i click on joe
of course he's right there if i click on
jane
it just jumps to her automatically and
if you remember i believe it was our
flexbox lesson we allowed that to scroll
and just have a nice little feature and
we need to add that actually under
general styles but it will be under the
html element and there we should put
scroll behavior
there it is and we'll put smooth
then we can just leave that all on one
line but i would like to put a space
between the html and the body styles oh
and then of course using prettier it
auto format it for me so now with that
scroll behavior of smooth and if i click
on joe
it just scrolls to joe and we've got
that scroll margin top set so he didn't
stop underneath the header
and then it scrolls to matt and it
scrolls to jane all like it should now
we're ready to go to our first media
query which is at
576 pixels for the small media query
that we have here let's go ahead and
delete the styles we were using before
in the previous lesson that just
displayed the changes for us and let's
apply what we're actually going to
change so we'll select the main element
and here we're going to change the
justify content
and it's going to be center and before
if we look at the main element and what
we had before this will overwrite that
property and we didn't have justify
content here before so that's okay it
will be set now when we get to this size
after justify content we're going to set
the flex
flow and it would be row
and wrap so now we do want them to wrap
if they will take up more than the width
that they have we'll have two rows of
profile and finally let's switch the
padding to one rim
and then after the main element we're
going to adjust something about the card
class as well and this will be the width
and the min will still set at 100
percent but the max will now let go up
to 400 pixels and then let's rearrange
the order so it'll be easier to see our
break point so here we'll take the card
and the last child which would be jane
and we'll make her first by setting the
order
to minus one
so now let's grab chrome i'll make it
full screen and we'll switch over to
responsive and if we do that
we'll drag this down to where we're at
576 right now we're still not at that
break point so this was our mobile phone
that we had and now we just passed 576
and you can see jane's at the top so it
just got a little wider it doesn't
change much but it changes changes a
little bit we can make the cards a
little bit bigger
just because
of where they're at and then if we get
bigger before the next break point well
we hit it there so it didn't wrap yet
but changing the width might allow them
to wrap because we did switch that to
allow wrap at this size okay i'll bring
chrome back to the right and now this
switch because our width once again
switched but we'll go ahead and tackle
the rest of the media queries and then
we'll see the changes at each breakpoint
as we go so now for medium let's go
ahead and remove these styles as well
and here we'll put the nav
and the first thing we'll do is set it
to display of none at this point because
we're at ipad size and they should all
fit on the screen now without scrolling
the next would be a card once again
we'll put a width
and as you might guess we'll use the min
function we'll say 100 again but now
we'll make them smaller so we definitely
fit a couple side by side and they all
fit on the page so after that let's
select the card figure element
and there we'll set flex flow
and we'll say column dash
reverse so we'll notice a change there
as well
in the order that would appear and then
we'll set the card
fig caption
and now let's set the margin to very
very small here 0.1 em
and then just zero and maybe we'll want
to keep that maybe we want we can play
around with that then card and the
paragraph for the card i'll leave that a
lowercase
and i'll set that to margin dash top
one rim
and save let's see if we can make this
any larger here so we're at 594 we made
our first break point
but we're not making it to the next one
unless we make vs code a little bit
bigger again so we'll drag this over
and now as we get a little larger
there we go now let's switch this to the
ipad size itself and you can see they
all fit on the page for the ipad and if
we get smaller than that we're somewhere
in between maybe a surface duo there
we're at 540 so we didn't hit the first
break point yet so it's just kind of a
weird spot in between where we are there
but it does work it's just a little bit
larger view
of the mobile view
as we look at it that way so now we've
covered our first two break points as
well as our starting point let's go
ahead and add the third at the large
stop and that's
992 pixels let's delete what we had here
for the body from the last tutorial and
once again select the card class
we'll select the width again and we'll
use the min function we'll say 100
and then 400 pixels here and if you
remember we made it smaller so it would
all fit on an ipad we were at 325 pixels
so even though previously before that we
were at 400 pixels we need to switch it
back because it hits that break point in
between
okay after the card selection there
let's switch the order around again so
we once again know this has changed so
we'll say card and now we'll say nth
child and we'll select
the second child element and we'll give
that an order of minus one and it should
switch the order for us again those are
the only changes we're going to make
there so let's go on to the xl size as
well
and we'll select what we have there and
delete it from the previous tutorial
we'll select the card class
now we'll set width again use the min
function but now i'm going to use a
function inside of the min function and
that is the calc function
calc function is great because it lets
us mix
other units together or different units
together i should say so i'm going to
set the width of each card to 33 percent
minus
one rim
and then we'll have a max of 500 pixels
because that is the size the images are
and we don't want the images to get any
larger than their original size or
they'll start to get blurry so we'll
leave that as the max but this will
allow them to grow dynamically with a
percentage value so let's stop there and
save our file i'll once again take this
to the larger screen now something else
we can do is click the three dots here
and say show media queries so now we can
see our media queries here so there's
768 we're only seeing the width we're
not seeing a good height
992 and finally
1200 so now let's switch this to some
sizes we might normally see such as 1920
by 1080
and then i'll just
make this smaller and smaller as we go
notice
we have got joe's name and jane's name
and matt's name all on top of their
cards now because of that column reverse
that we did so that was a nice change to
let us know we have made something
different now this is using the
percentage size that we used with that
calc function so notice how they just
gradually get smaller
until we're at the next break point
which is 1200
there we go now this is at 50 percent so
it looks a little tiny here but overall
we're squeezing it down because of these
two but overall we can see what is
happening
and so now they're stacked on top of
each other with two rows
and now they're stacked on top of each
other again and we're kind of in that
larger ipad size getting a little
smaller
now we're at that larger mobile size and
now we're down to finally underneath 576
which becomes definitely a mobile device
so
we really have identified several
devices or sizes along the way that we
could target and you can specifically
target more than that one we haven't
talked about yet though is taking
something like an iphone i'll go ahead
and remove these media queries now i'll
hide them
and turning it
horizontal right now this isn't going to
work so let's make some changes for this
as well i'll leave the phone like this
and drag vs code back and we can make
some changes for our final break point
which is the mobile device landscape
scrolling all the way up here let's look
at this break point you can see we're
selecting a max height of 425 pixels
and a minimum aspect ratio of 7 to 4 so
the width would be 7 units and the
height would be 4 in comparison so let's
select everything we have here now
except this display none for the nav we
want to keep that
and let's go ahead and put an h1 here
with a font dash size
1.5 rim
and we can leave that all on one line
but when we save it will get formatted
if we're using prettier like i am that
prettier code extension or vs code
extension
now i'll go ahead and put some styles on
the main element we'll go with flex flow
which will set the direction to row
and then no wrap so we should have only
one row
then justify content we'll set this to
space evenly
and after that let's align items
and let's set this to stretch to give
them all the same height in case the
content would make them different
heights
and then we can go ahead and style the
card just a little bit so
under here i'll type the card class
and i'm going to put a width
use the min function
and now instead of 100 width right away
i'll use that calc function again
i'll say 33
this time minus
0.25 rim instead of one rim and we'll
put the max for any card
at 200 pixels
okay then we can set something more
specific on the card let's do the fig
caption
looks like i need to scroll up for some
room here so i'll do that as well
and for the fig caption let's put the
font size
1.25 round
and then let's go ahead and select the
paragraph below
and we could put these on the same line
actually so let's just go ahead and put
a comma here
and put
dot card paragraph and we're going to go
ahead and set that same style on both
and save
okay now that we've made those changes
let's drag this back over
and then we'll turn our phone
horizontally
and we fit all of the cards right in
here together which is nice let's see if
we could do that in a different size as
well maybe the iphone plus
yes it works as well too it may not work
as well in the smallest screen i have a
feeling these will be just a little
taller than we would want probably let's
see
yeah they're a little taller but it's
not too bad you might expect to have to
scroll when you have one of the smaller
phones so that wouldn't be
really a breaking thing to me but you
could work with that if you really
wanted to target this specific device
but overall for most phones i believe
this would work well in the horizontal
mode so there's some nice changes you
can go back through and tweak a few
things one thing i want to check is that
very very small margin that we set
and let me find what size that was on
again because i wondered if we even
needed that or if i was just playing
around with that back when i was working
with the code that is such a small
margin on the top and bottom and this is
at the ipad size so let's see what it
looks like if i comment this out i'll
select it all press shift alt and the
letter a
comments out that code
bring this over so i can switch to an
ipad
and there's the ipad size
and let's make it a little bit bigger so
we can see everything there we go yeah
it looks good without it so i would
probably remove that as well and i'll
drag this back over
and then we'll just take this out of the
code
and the rest i think i'll leave as is
and of course you can play around with
this i do not do this perfectly myself
everything is trial and error basically
as you go so mess around with this code
don't accept it just the way it is see
what you can change what you like better
one way or the other
let's move on to css pseudo selectors
pseudo selectors include both pseudo
classes and pseudo elements so the
obvious question is what is the
difference between a pseudo class and a
pseudo element well a pseudo class is a
selector that selects elements that are
in a specific state so if we look at our
starter code and this is the code that
wrapped up the mini project in the last
lesson so we're just starting with that
and if we scroll down to the links we
can see some of these different states
we're styling for the focus state
the hover state the visited state and
then just a basic link which we actually
could have added on
the pseudo class link here as well if we
wanted to because that is the unvisited
link so there's different states there
there's even an active one that we could
have styled
and for all of those those are different
specific states of the element so a
pseudo class now a pseudo element is
similar but they act like you've added a
new html element into your document and
also pseudo elements use two colons
instead of the one we see here with
pseudo classes so we'll look at those as
well but we're going to look at pseudo
classes first and again this starter
code is what we have from the previous
tutorial the mini project that created
this small staff page of three employees
for the acme co that we see here and
created profile cards for each one so
that link will be available in the
description if you want to download the
starter source code we're not really
going to change the project for the
better today i'm just going to use it
for some examples that you may not want
to keep in the project at all but i'm
going to show you how pseudo classes and
pseudo elements work now we're already
familiar with the different pseudo
classes here that we've applied to links
and we've looked at a couple of other
pseudo classes along the way during this
css for beginners tutorial series one
other one that we could add here is
active so let's go ahead and put a nav
and an anchor
and then we'll put
active
and let's just style this so we can
really tell the difference so we'll say
red so it'll just really stand out this
should be when we hold down on the
button on the link and then it turns red
i have my mouse button for the click
held down right now when i let go of
course it goes ahead and completes and
scrolls to the id for the employee that
we expect it to but that is the active
state now let's refactor a couple of
these for the better with things we can
learn about new pseudo classes today so
notice here we have a descendant
selector and that means we have a nav
and then we're selecting any anchor
element inside the nav element and then
we're applying the state but then when
we choose focus besides hover we have to
say nav a again well we can stop some of
that by using the is pseudo class so if
i put is here
and then put a parenthesis after it
then i can eliminate repeating this nav
element here
and then just once again say anchor
focus so we're just putting the one nav
but now we're saying inside of that if
it is an anchor with hover or anchor
with focus
then style accordingly so this should
give us the same results and as i mouse
over here on our page we see that it
still works and we've made our code a
little drier and dry is an acronym for
do not repeat
so we managed to write just a little
less code and get the same result by
using the is pseudo selector now
sometimes we can discover a pseudo
selector and again these are pseudo
classes i say pseudo selector
synonymously but we are making a
selection but make no mistake we are
using pseudo classes right now
sometimes we can discover a pseudo class
that will also save us some time and
that is the case here besides link and
visited where we're styling both let me
remove all of this
and then i can just put any dash
link
and the any link pseudo class selects
both the link and the visited pseudo
class so now when i save we should once
again have the same results now this is
unvisited or
if we click jane now we visited jane and
she still has the styling that we expect
that we had previously in the project
but we have once again made our code
just a little drier by learning more
about pseudo classes now just for an
example i'm going to scroll up where we
have our header and footer right here
and we're choosing both of those in a
list of elements essentially to apply
the same styles now i will not make this
code drier by applying this but i just
want to show the example we could use is
here
and then list these elements inside
and
there's really no reason to do it other
than this example right now but i do
want to show the difference so i'm going
to go ahead and save right now this will
be the same as what we had before but
we've just added this extra code but
notice when i mouse over here in visual
studio code we get the selector
specificity and it is displayed it's 0 0
1 so it's not high specificity we could
override it
just in this header area here we can
overwrite what's on the header or we
have a footer area down here just a
little bit lower and we could put
something there and it would overwrite
what we have in here
but if we put something else in here
like a class and i'll temporarily do
this it won't make our project look good
but now we have put a class
inside the is as well
and notice our specificity selector is
going to pop up and it's changed instead
of 0 0 1
now it's a whole level higher it is 0 1
0 so it has higher specificity and now
if i were to put a different color here
in the header for example so i will go
ahead and do that
and
i'll just give it red so we would
definitely notice and save notice the
text in our header is still the white
smoke color it is not red and that's
because this has a higher specificity
even though it comes first and it's not
down here in the cascade
the higher specificity keeps these
styles however if i remove
this class
and it goes back to the lower
specificity
now it turned red so that's something to
note about using is it's going to adopt
whatever has the highest specificity
within its parentheses now one other
thing we can do let me put card back
is instead of using is
there is another pseudo class that works
almost identically and it's where it
will accomplish the same thing except
it does not have any specificity so
notice when i mouse over it the
specificity is 0 0 0 or basically a lack
thereof it does not have any so you can
overwrite whatever is inside the where
pseudo class so that's also worth
knowing so i just wanted to use this to
demonstrate we're not really going to
leave these here
for your finished code but just remember
those tips about the specificity when it
comes to is
and where pseudo classes now i'm going
to scroll down to the card class so we
have that right here is the profile card
right underneath the card class i'm
going to type card once again and then
i'm going to give it
a target pseudo class
inside the target pseudo class i'm going
to say border 2 pixels
solid and give this rebecca purple
and save now let's see what this does
you can see jane has a purple border now
two pixels solid purple all around her
profile card
she is the last profile card that we
selected here so if i choose joe instead
now he has the purple border because he
was the target if i scroll back up jane
no longer has that purple border so what
we're saying with the target pseudo
class is whoever is selected whoever is
the target
of our selection will have that purple
border and now matt has that purple
border so that could be a useful class
if you really want to highlight whatever
was selected and if you remember in our
html how we're doing that is using the
anchor tag but then it is a page link
it's not going to a different page it
just has the pound sign or the hashtag
if you will for profile 1 or profile 2
or profile 3 that matches up with the
ids
of these cards which are in article
elements so there is the id of profile 1
and then if we come down to the next
article profile 2 and so on so these are
just on page links with anchors and
whoever is the target gets that outline
now i'm going to scroll down just a
little bit further under the card class
once again and then the image element so
after that let's add another card
and then let's add an image and first
let's go ahead and just put in
alt now if you haven't seen this yet
this means i'm selecting
any image with the alt attribute so we
can base our selectors on attributes
inside this i'm going to once again add
a border let's make this really big so
10 pixels
solid red and if i save we should see
that around all of our images because
they do all have alt tags or alt
attributes added to their image tag
actually is how i should say that so
what if we wanted to say
just let us know which images we forgot
to put an alt attribute on well we can
do that with the not pseudo class so
after image
we'll say not and then wrap the
attribute
in parentheses so this would actually
serve to help us check our page to make
sure we've remembered to add alt
attributes to each image so now
none of the images have the red border
because we did provide alt attributes
for all of them so let's just go here
temporarily
to our html
and let's remove the alt attribute from
one of these images so here we have
joe's alt attribute we'll just go ahead
and delete and save and now if we look
at our page
joe has the red border because we forgot
to put an alt attribute there for him
now i'm going of course fix that with
ctrl z
put that back and save and that fixes
our page but that could be very useful
and you could use not the pseudo class
not for other things as well remember
it's going to select whatever does not
have what you specify and now let's look
at the nth child selector which we have
used a little bit in previous tutorials
so we'll say card and then no space
we'll say nth dash
child now this can be confusing and it's
somewhat because of the way it's worded
you would think we were looking for the
child
of the card class but that's not really
true
we're going to be selecting the cards
themselves so if we say nth child and
the second one we would be selecting the
second profile card so now let's go
ahead and change the background color so
we can really see which card we've
selected and i'll say papaya whip
and we'll save
and
here's the thing to consider now we've
got matt
selected but he's the last profile card
and we said we wanted the second but if
you remember from the previous lesson
we've used media queries to rearrange
the order of our cards however if we
look back at the html
matt truly is the second card in our
html so this nth child selector is going
to be based on the actual original order
within the html and maybe not what we
see on the page if we have reordered
the order that was in the html with
media queries or even without media
queries we could go ahead and reorder
them if we wanted to but the nth child
will not be based on that now we could
put in other selectors here too so let's
put in odd and save
and now notice
matt was the second child
so the first and the third are odd and
that would be jane and joe
likewise we could put in even instead
and it will probably select matt once
again and not select jane and joe
because matt is the second which is even
and of course joe and jane first and
third are odd so i think you get the
idea for pseudo classes so now let's
move on to some pseudo elements that we
can add right underneath the card class
and the fig caption element
and this would be a descendant selector
so we've got the card class and the
descendants are any fig captions within
the card class so now after that let's
specify
card and fig caption once again
but now we'll use two colons
and then let's say after
and what we'll do after is create a
pseudo element that will have content
and then we can specify what content
goes inside let's just put hello to
start with
and after that well i'll just leave it
at that to begin with here i need to get
rid of that extra quote there we go and
save and now let's look at our page so
now we've got jane devrell hello it says
hello right at the end
after joe's last name coder hello is
immediately after so maybe we should put
a space and we could highlight that and
now we'll see the hello at the end of
each last name a little easier but it
was added to each one of the fig
captions now we could notice something
else about this too i can select all
that text but i can't select the text
that here that is our pseudo element
content again it's not really an element
it was just added in
with this after pseudo element selector
so now instead of hello i want to go
ahead and remove that and i'm going to
put in an emoji just some sparkles here
and then
i'll put display and block so this will
be on its own line and save and now
we've got an emoji following each name
on each of our profile cards and
likewise i could switch this to before
and what it would normally be on the
left side or before their first name but
now because it's a block display
it's above each name so i'm going to
scroll for a little more room and let's
add some more new content here for our
fig caption as well actually for our
paragraph now so let's say card
and then the paragraph
and we'll select the before sudo element
and for content here we can type a
specific value say open dash quote
and now if i save this
we will get a double quote added to the
left as we see here it's actually
probably a single quote that's added
after our other single quote but we can
also add a close quote so i'm just going
to
copy this down with shift alt and the
down arrow
and i'll switch this to an after
and instead of open quote we'll have
close quote
and save and now they've turned into
double quotes and they're wrapping
around the single quotes that we already
had but we've added quotes here without
having that quote element that we were
relying on here inside of our html
notice inside of each paragraph we have
the q element which is a quote that we
were using for quotes so we could remove
those because one handy thing here is we
can style these however we want to so
let's look at an example of that we
could say font dash size i'll put it 3
em so that's going to rely on whatever
the font size is of the paragraph
element to get the em size
and then let's say position
absolute if you remember when we learned
about positions
we'll say top and we can make this a
minus so minus
0.25 em
and then left minus 0.5 en
now something else to remember about
position absolute it always needs its
parent to have position relative so here
we need to select the paragraph
itself and give it position
relative
we can save that and notice our quote on
the left got a lot larger so we were
able to really style this quote
separately
from the rest of the paragraph now let's
do something similar for the after quote
so once again
give it a font size of 3 em
position
absolute
give it the same top as well so that
would be minus 0.25 em
but now we'll say right
minus 0.5 em and save and now we have
matching closing quotes on the right
again we're adding these as pseudo
elements so let's go back to our html
quickly and remove those other quotes
that we had so that would be
the q element i'll highlight that press
ctrl d twice to get the other two
hit backspace and now i'll select the
closing queue
ctrl d twice to get the other two
backspace and save so we remove those
other quotes that we had and now we have
our big quotes in place of those and we
can see they've applied to each one of
the profile cards with our pseudo
elements just a couple of more pseudo
elements to look at before we're
finished so for the fig caption let's
once again
say card and then fig
caption
two colons and now let's say first dash
letter
and here inside of this we'll say font
dash size
once again go to
three let's say rem here because we're
applying it directly to that letter and
we should get a larger letter to start
out with but we don't
and why don't we that's because
this got larger itself let me go ahead
and comment that out and save and now
notice our emoji is back to a smaller
size so this first letter actually
applied
to the emoji so let me uncomment that
and save and you'll see the emoji get
larger again so what happens if we put
this
after instead of before
now the first letter of each name got
larger so that's something to consider
too if you use the first letter pseudo
element it's going to apply
to the before pseudo element
if the before pseudo element exists now
instead of just the first letter you
could also choose first line if i
remember correctly and yes we just made
the whole name larger by choosing the
first line
let's move on to css variables
css variables are very very useful
imagine a large project if you will and
we have a hexadecimal color code as you
see here for our body element and i've
had to use this code twice just inside
of this body element but imagine in a
large project where we have had to apply
this color code many times throughout
the project and then our boss says he
wants to change that color in the
project we would need to go through and
find every instance of this hexadecimal
code and change it but when we use css
variables we would only need to change
this hexadecimal code in one place and
that's what makes them so useful let's
see how this is accomplished you can see
we just have a basic page here with a
header nav main area and a footer and
we're going to refactor some of this
using css variables so let's start out
by putting in a comment for our
variables so i'm just going to copy this
reset comment
and right underneath it i'll paste it
and change this text
to variables
and now we're going to put our variables
inside of a pseudo class that you may
not have seen yet and that is the root
pseudo class
everything inherits from that that is
referencing the document root so the
html tag would even inherit from this
root pseudo class so we put it at the
top and now we can define variables
inside that will apply everywhere in the
project we're going to start out with
color because if you do not use
variables for anything else in css it
makes much sense to use them for colors
now we start out by naming a variable
and they all start with two hyphens or
two dashes if you will now you can name
them in upper or lower case i prefer
uppercase
i am a developer and overall we usually
name
static values in javascript and other
programming languages
with uppercase they're referred to as
constants so i kind of like to see them
in uppercase and that tells me as a
developer the definition for this
variable is probably near the top of the
file as a constant and so that's how i
remember it you do not have to do it
that way but i'm going to use
all uppercase today for these variable
names so for our background color let's
just pull what we have inside of our
project already we have this hexadecimal
code i will copy
and then i'll put in
the hashtag and put in the code
and now we have created a variable for
the background color now to apply this
in the rest of our css instead of the
code here
we're going to use a small function
that's available in css called var and
then parentheses
and then we put in
our variable name
and it's as simple as that now we will
still have that background color and we
can copy this
and we can also use it here or anywhere
else in the page that we're using that
color code and once we save
i'm going to go ahead and go live i did
not have live server serving this page
so we should see it again and now it
looks the same because we applied this
variable you will see if i remove this
ctrl x just to cut it out temporarily
and i guess i didn't change our
background color here i should remove
because that is the fallback so let me
switch this to
black just quickly and now i'll go ahead
and remove this
and apply and we can see it's black and
that's all i wanted to show you was that
the variable is applying and so we're
using the background color actually as a
fallback to this background image
statement that's using a radial gradient
but we want both there so i'm going to
replace black once again with our
variable
and save and that's how we're applying
now the background color saved in this
variable okay now let's do the next one
so i'm going to name this
alt
once again capitals here alt
bg color
and now let's find our alt bg color
where we had a little darker color down
here and here it is our background color
for the header and the footer
so i can go ahead and control x to just
cut that out notice it doesn't take the
hashtag so we'll have to put that back
but now i'll put the hashtag
the color code and now we have our alt
background color so we can just copy
this variable
and we can scroll down to where that was
for the header and the footer i believe
there it is
and we'll put in
of course it needs to be in the var
function and put parentheses around it
and save and we still have that same
background color now notice we're using
white smoke in more than one place and
then we used white down here but white
smoke would also be sufficient so if we
wanted to go ahead and replace this
with white smoke it will still look
about the same and it does
so now we should create a variable for
the white smoke as well but we're using
it in two different spots we're also
using it as a radial so if we want to
remember that it's okay to go ahead and
create two variables that have the same
value and that's what i'm going to do
right now so i'll have a radial color so
anywhere in my project that i will use a
radial gradient
i might want to use this white smoke but
then i'm also just going to have a
light color for parts of the page
and i'll use white smoke there too but
it would be weird if i put radial color
in another part of the page i might be
able to get away with putting light
color in as part of that radial gradient
but i just wanted to show this example
that you could use two variables and
they could have the same value and it's
okay to do that so let's go ahead and
copy this radial color variable first
and actually before copying that i want
to show you something else about using a
var function
and how we can type this out and how
visual visual studio code will help you
so now we have our var with the
parentheses if i start to type the two
hyphens notice vs code gives me a list
of the variables that we've created
already so that's very handy and it even
gives you their values over here to the
right i'm just going to choose radial
color and use it in my radial gradient
and once again nothing is changing so if
we're making the conversions right and
refactoring our page we shouldn't see
changes it should continue to remain as
it is over here
now let's go ahead and replace
any area that has white smoke and i can
press ctrl f and just search for white
smoke
and it says there's three or four three
of 4 so we have 4 actual instances so
now
i'm going to say
var
parentheses dash dash and choose
light color
and that will also be our white smoke
value so now i can select white smoke
press ctrl d
to select the other instances but notice
two of the instances are
the value that we have
in our variables so we don't want to
replace those so let's just find the one
that we do want to replace which is the
background for the nav
and now paste that in and save our
project continues to look good and now
you can see we're also using the color
black here for text in the nav for the
bottom border for the nav and maybe in
other places in the project as well so
let's go ahead and create one more
variable and that will just be our dark
color for the our color theme
and that's what i'll name it and here
we'll just put in the hexadecimal code
for black
and now that we have that we can find
other places that are using that code
and replace it
so we'll once again do control f
i'll paste in that value and it says two
of three so these are the only two
actually the third one would be our
variable above
so we need that then type far now dash
dash and it is our dark color
now i'll copy this and simply replace
the code down here with that
and we have replaced it as well now
notice for the border we still have two
pixels solid and then we're just
providing the var for the color value we
can also use css variables for far more
than just colors so let's scroll back up
to the top
and look in our body element and we see
a font
property here first and this is a
shorthand because we're supplying not
only the font size but we're also
supplying the font family so let's
define a couple of variables and we can
use both in the same definition here so
as we come up to the top again inside of
our root i'm going to put slash and here
i'm going to put
font
for our comment and now for the first
variable i'll do two dashes and ff for
font family
and then we can just copy the value we
have here
which is nunito with the fallback sans
serif
so i copy that i'll bring it up to our
variable
and we've added that now i'll do two
more dashes and in fs or capital fs for
font size and here i'll put 1.5
rim and then in case we want a larger
font size somewhere i'm going to put in
an fs
dash xl for an extra large font that we
may use somewhere later and i can put
three rim for it
and save and now we've defined our font
family font size and font size extra
large so let's put the font family and
font size to work right away and we can
do that here so we'll put a
var variable or a var function actually
and now we can pull our variable from
our list and this is font size
then we'll highlight the font family
put another var
two dashes and we'll highlight the font
family variable there and save and it
should look the same now as you may be
gathering we're not limited as to what
we can put in these variables so it's
not limited to the font or the color we
can also use it for other things let's
quickly scroll down and take a look at
our nav area here you can see we have
the light color the dark color
and the dark color again used as a
border but then we have a padding here
of 0.5 rim and we could possibly also
add a property or two here so let's
start with the padding and let's define
that above as a general style because we
could give this padding to other parts
of the page as well in a project
so i'll just put general here
and then we'll do two dashes
new padding
and we'll put in our 0.5
ram
lowercase rim there we go
save that quickly scroll down to the nav
and apply that as well so instead of the
0.5 here we'll be using a var
parentheses two dashes
choose padding from the list
that's good now what if we wanted to
apply a shadow so let's look at how to
apply a shadow we'll use a box
shadow property
and here we're looking at an x offset
for the first value which i'll put in a
a y offset for the second value i'm
going to put in 6 pixels for that
and then there is a blur value which
i'll put in 5 pixels
and then there is a spread value and i'm
going to put in minus 5 pixels here and
what this does is essentially creates a
shadow right underneath you could
provide an x and y and have the shadow
off to the right and underneath or
coming from another direction if you're
picturing the sun overhead essentially
that's what this shadow is going to
create because it should come straight
down
okay after supplying that then we also
need to have a color and we already have
a dark color so let's put in the var and
dash dash
dark dash color
and save and if we look at our nav now
it has a nice little shadow right
underneath the bottom line i could try
to make this bigger so it stands out let
me put it like 15 pixels
and there we see the big shadow
underneath but that's not what we want
we want just a subtle shadow and we can
save that but what if we wanted to use
this shadow in other parts of the
project also so maybe we should just
highlight
that or we could highlight all of this
and that's what i'm going to do and i'll
copy that
and then bring it up here under our
general styles that we have for our
variables not the general styles
underneath
and here i'll put
shadows because it would look kind of
strange to have the shadows coming from
different directions as if there was
more than one sun looking at your
project so having the shadows fall all
in the same direction makes sense
and then
we can define shadows using
another variable and that's okay we've
defined this variable above it and it
knows what it is and there we're putting
it in and this definition is completely
legitimate so we'll save that and then
we'll scroll back down to our nav and
just bring in our shadows variable for
the whole thing so i'm going to delete
that much
and then change what we have here
to our shadows variable
and save and the shadow still applies
now we could use this same concept for
our borders as well so this is a border
bottom
but we've also just defined borders
before and it uses the same structure so
let's just take this value which is two
pixels solid in the dark color copy that
and create a borders variable above as
well
just underneath shadows
and i want all caps again
and then we'll put in that value and it
uses the dark color variable
we can save that and then come back down
once again to the nav and where we have
the borders
we'll just put in that value and it will
only apply to the border bottom as we
define it here so here's our borders and
save now let's move to the html file i'm
going to close our find window as well
it's time to add some extra content to
our main area of the page so i'm going
to scroll down to the main area
highlight the h2 we have hit backspace
to remove that and i want to put in 12
divs so i'm going to type div i want
lower case here div and then dot and i'm
going to name the class that applies to
all 12 divs square
so now we have div dot square and then
with an emmet abbreviation i can type
times 12 and press tab and instantly
have 12 divs
now that i have that i have no content
inside the divs so i'm going to select
the last one which is just the closing
tag
for the div and then we can go to i
believe the edit menu
and let's find no it might be the
selection menu there it is and let's
find select all occurrences and that is
control shift and l control d selects
the next occurrence but the combination
of control shift and l will select all
or you can just select it here from the
selection menu so now we've selected all
of those
and i'm going to press the left arrow
key to go to the beginning and i'm going
to paste in an emoji i have of a laptop
and i want that in the last
well i guess the last 11 number 2
through 12. the very first one i'm going
to put in a paragraph and just put the
word hey in so we see something
different and if we save that you can
see we have hey and then 11 laptops
after that i'm going to come down to
let's say the eighth one right about
here and i'm also going to put in
square dash dash
not important let's do
highlight because we just might want to
apply another class to one of these divs
and you can see i have my code wrapping
so this line wraps down to the next line
but that is the change we are making to
the html we'll make all other changes
now back in the css i'm going to scroll
up just a little bit if you'll notice
the header nav main and footer all have
these values and the display is grid i
no longer want that for the main element
so i'm going to remove the main element
from that and save and you can see our
content is now stacked on top of each
other as divs or block elements one on
top of each other on the far left so now
let's move down to the main area and
apply some more styles here
right now main is just a flex item in
the larger
flex container that is the body element
but we're going to make it a flex
display as well or i should say display
flex
after that let's justify the content and
space dash evenly
and then after that we can align
items and we'll align the items to the
center if we save we have definitely
seen our flex items inside the main now
change
let's change flex dash flow
to row
and then wrap if it needs to
now let's add a gap and i'm going to use
the min function here that will pick the
smaller of whichever of these values so
i'll say
4 viewport units or 15 pixels so
whichever would be smaller it will use
for the gap and remember gap is
shorthand for row gap and column gap as
well okay now let's put a padding value
and i'll put it up here above
and i'll just say padding
and i want 10 pixels on the top and
bottom but 0 on the left and right and
this is different than the padding
variable we applied you could have other
parts of your project that have
different padding but if you know
there's a value you will reuse more than
once then it's also a good time to
declare a variable for that okay now
that we've defined those things for the
main we won't see a huge change here
because we haven't defined our class for
the square yet now what we have done
previously is take the code that i had
and extract those values
into variables and i often do that when
i'm designing something however now i
know what variables i want to use so i'm
just going to write them at the top for
the square and then we will come down
and define the class for the square but
just know this is a little backwards
typically i would probably define them
first and then extract them like we
previously did for these other variables
okay for the square we have a couple of
variables to create and the first one is
going to be dash dash
square we'll start all of them out with
that and let's do the background
color here i'm going to choose papaya
whip
and that's kind of a cool name for a
color after that we will go with
square once again
and then
dash not a space just a dash and size
now we're going to have the same height
and width when we create a square i'm
going to use the max function now and
this will pick the larger of these two
values either 150 pixels
or 20 viewport units so it will continue
to grow as the page window gets bigger
okay with our variables now defined i
want to come down to the class
and let me highlight an area here we had
general styles i'll take this comment as
well
so we can comment before we begin the
square and if there were other features
for our app this is the area that i
would put them and i might say features
right here you also might comment each
individual feature if you wanted to i'll
just say features for now and we'll put
in our square class so we'll start out
with a background dash color
here we can use our var
two dashes and we want to pick square
background color
after that we're going to have a width
and that would be a var
two dashes and it looks like we have
enough variables now we need to scroll
which is okay we'll choose
square size now i'm going to do shift
alt and the down arrow because we want
the same value
for the height of the squares as well
okay after the width and the height
let's create a border we've already got
a variable for that so we'll stick with
the same border that we had previously
defined
and after that border we want a border
dash radius here we have not defined
anything so we'll just go with 15 pixels
then let's use a display of grid
and let's place that content in the
center so this will center our content
let's save what we have so far
well that's a big difference so now we
have our squares we have the content in
each one centered and we have a
different color background as well just
a couple more properties now for the
square so let's define a font dash size
use our var again
and now we defined an extra large font
size let's use that and when we save our
emojis get larger and so does the text
okay let's apply a box shadow here too i
need lowercase there we go box shadow
and let's once again use a variable we
created for shadows
there it is and if we save we'll get a
little shadow under each square also now
if you remember inside of our html we
also added this square highlight class
so let's go ahead and create it also
and underneath our features i'll type
square dash dash
highlight again in lowercase
and now i want to show an example of
when you might redefine a variable so
we want to apply this square background
color and imagine we had all of these
squares
and now we just want to overwrite one
rather than having to go in and change
different things about our definition
for square
so this will only apply to the class
square highlight and we can change the
value
of this variable so let's choose
background color once again and let's
make this corn flower
blue
that is an interesting name as well when
we save
this only applies to the one square we
added the square highlight class to but
we have redefined this variable
for that class now let's add a feature
that css variables makes very easy to do
and it's in high demand let's add a dark
mode
in addition to our light mode that we
have here so to add a dark mode we're
just going to define a separate color
theme but we're going to do it inside of
a media query so just underneath our
styles we can put this media query
towards the top so we'll say at media
and then parentheses we have prefers
dash color dash
scheme
and then we'll say
dark
and then inside of this media query
let's put our pseudo class once again
and now we can define our dark mode
inside of this class so for
the bg color and notice we're using the
same variable names that we did here so
we don't have to go and change those
anywhere else in our code so we're just
redefining these variables
we'll put black for the background color
then for the alt dash bg color
let's put a flat black
and then for the
radial color
we'll go ahead and put in kind of a gray
let's see if we can lighten this up any
i don't know if it will take the caps
yep it will so let's try to lighten up
the gray just a little bit but we still
want a gray color
something like that so we'll just go
with that for now and we'll see how it
looks
after that let's put in
the square
background color
and here let's go with more like a
purple and then we'll try to lighten it
up
so after we get the purple
let's come over here towards the light
and something in that range and i'm just
kind of guessing but we'll see what we
get so when we save
it switches to the dark mode and that's
because i prefer the dark mode and have
my system set that way and i'll show you
how to do that now if you do not prefer
the dark mode this won't go into effect
so if i just put prefers light here just
some other value it doesn't really
matter i could put prefers dave for all
that
for the anything else that would change
essentially it's going to ignore what's
inside of here so
prefers light and we're back to this
because
we prefer the dark mode and
we're already using the opposite of that
so again like i said i could put my name
here it doesn't make a difference but if
we put prefers dark
then it does switch to this dark mode so
now just to show you let's look inside
i'm on windows let's look inside of the
settings i right click on the desktop
and choose personalize
and then i go to colors and it says
choose your color so if i actually did
prefer light mode
then the dark doesn't apply and you can
see how it even changes my window here
but i am going to set it back to dark
and our web page responds so that is how
you set up a custom dark mode
with your css as well so you've got your
app media prefers color scheme and dark
and then just define your dark mode
theme inside of here by overriding the
other color
variable values that you've already
defined
today we're going to look at css
functions
our starter code is much like the ending
code for the last lesson however let's
quickly look at the html and as you can
see our page over here on the right i
have added an h2 heading a paragraph
and then a link inside of a section
element that is inside of the main
element and i have commented out the
divs we previously had in the last
lesson but we will come back to those so
i wanted to leave those in our css
remains the same from the last lesson
and we can look at some functions we
have already used in previous lessons if
we just scroll down there are color
functions and we can see here inside of
our prefers color scheme this is one
change i've already made because i
wanted the light theme to show up but if
you remember if we put dark here i need
lowercase or prefer lowercase if i save
i get dark mode because my system
preferences
are for dark mode but you can switch
this to light
and then this dark mode will not apply
so let's look at this we've got rgb
which is a function and if i were to
click here inside the color for vs code
and then we click the bar at the top as
we've learned about colors we can see
other values in hsl it has parentheses
as well and a value or values inside
that's also a function hwb is a function
so these are color functions and that's
what you see here we've also used image
functions and if i scroll down just a
little further and we get to the body or
the main element we should have
something yep there in the body we've
got a radial gradient function and as
we've learned in the past we can also
use linear gradient but those are
functions they have the term radial
gradient or linear gradient and then
parentheses and then something is passed
inside some value and then as we see
here we're also using a reference
function which is var and we learned
about var just in the previous lesson as
we're using css variables so we use var
and put the variable inside to get the
value from that variable another
reference function we learned in the
past when we were working with images
was url with parentheses and that's how
we loaded images into a background image
spot and there are many useful css
functions so many that i can't cover
them all but i will put a link in the
description and the resources to the mdn
page that does list all of the css
functions today i want to cover some
that i think you will use often or
frequently
and a few of those are math functions
and we've used some of those too but i
want to dive just a little bit deeper so
let's scroll back up to where we have
defined our font size right now it's
currently 1.5 rim which one ram would be
16 pixels so 1.5 is currently 24 pixels
if we were to select our paragraph here
and look at what was applied inside of
dev tools we would be able to see that
but now let's talk about the min
function first so instead of 1.5 we can
type min
and then let's put something like 2.25
rim
and then we'll put 3 vh which is
viewport units but it's also
specifically referencing the height not
the width and that is very useful when
you're working with fonts now let's talk
about what this min function does it's
always going to select the smallest of
the two available and notice one of
these is an absolute value so it
wouldn't make sense to put in 2.75
ram or something like that here for the
second value because it would then
always select the smallest so we've put
in one absolute value and one value that
will change based on the height of the
page so let's save this
and then we don't see a whole lot
changing here right now but we will when
we look at the height of the page so i
will bring this over to take up the full
page
and then let's inspect to open the dev
tools you could also do control shift
and the letter i whichever you prefer
then i'm going to choose the computed
tab here inside of devtools and we'll
scroll till we see the font size and
that should be coming up here shortly
there it is 36 pixels so that is 2.5 rim
which we set
as one of the values and remember it
will always choose the smallest of the
two the second value was three viewport
units of height so if we start to shrink
the page we'll notice our font is
shrinking now let's look at the font
size again and i'll have to scroll but
it's 28.632
you can always tell it's being
calculated when you get a decimal
afterwards because we're not usually
going to enter that in ourselves so the
font size is changing now the three
viewport units of height are smaller
than the 2.5 rims so it's choosing that
instead but then what we should consider
is the absolute value is actually a
maximum it will never get larger
than that 2.5 rim so if we scroll back
at some point it should stop growing and
we noticed it stopped growing now
if we come back to 2.5 rim we have 36
pixels and i said 2.5 ram i believe this
is actually
2.25 rim which would be 2 2 rim would be
32 pixels and then 0.25 would be another
4 for 36. let's look back at our code
when i close devtools pull this over and
we can verify yes 2.25 rim and then
three
viewport units of height i'm going to
quickly scroll down to the main element
because having this centered is just
bothering me a little bit so i'll scroll
down and make some changes here so we
won't keep what we have right here let's
comment all of this out that we were
using previously in the last lesson with
those divs
and now instead let's say
display
flex
and then we'll say flex
flow and we'll make it a column and say
no wrap
and then justify content and there we'll
say flex
dash start and we can save and now it is
all pulled up towards the top let's pull
in some padding though but not the 10
pixels that we had here let's pull in
our padding variable i can put the
comment after that so for that
we'll say var and then dash dash
padding
and save that now let's go ahead and
remove the padding from our nav because
it has a little extra padding compared
to the header and footer
and then let's change the value of the
padding just a little bit as i scroll
back up to the top let's look for that
padding variable we see 0.5
rem so let's make this
ems and then it's based on the font size
of the element it is applied to so if we
save don't notice much of a difference
but that's what i would prefer to do for
that padding okay as i scroll back up
we've looked at men and we've decided or
learned
that it will select the smallest of the
two values it's given it doesn't really
matter which order you provide these
values but because of that there are
some things to consider when we provide
the values one you should only provide
one absolute value or you know which one
it will always choose so the other one
should be relative and it's better to
choose viewport height units for fonts
than it is viewport width so we're
keeping a certain size in there and you
can play around with it but i think
you'll see why
i lean towards choosing viewport height
units and i don't put a percentage here
because
really that percentage is really easy to
just kind of equal
what the rim is as well so 100 percent
would be 16 ram uh which would be army
not 16 ram 16 pixels which would be one
rim so two rims would be 200
so this would be the equivalent of 225
percent so i choose to put in the
viewport height units as my relative
unit when i'm applying this to font now
you can use this min function for images
and other things and i believe we did
that just a little bit in the past but i
wanted to explain more about that so now
let's move on to the max function
which is essentially the opposite of the
min function so max is always going to
choose the larger of the two values we
provide so just so we can better see a
change i'm going to switch this from
2.25 to 1.75
now it's always going to choose
whichever is larger either three
viewport height units or 1.75 rim so
let's once again take a look at our page
and i'll open up the dev tools once
again as well go over to the computed
side
and now i'm going to inspect this
specific element so we can see
that the font size is currently 37.68
so that's fairly large but it's based on
the height will it shrink if i bring
this down yes it's instantly shrinking
now it's down to 34.56
but at some point it will stop shrinking
as well and now it has and as we look
that's 28 pixels which i put
1.75 rem if i remember correctly so that
would be 16 would be one ram and .75
would be 12 and that gives us 28 pixels
so now we see the opposite in effect and
it continues to grow as the page gets
taller but at some point it stops
shrinking
and that's what we have there for the 28
pixels okay so let's close this and go
back and look at our max once again now
the same applies here you should have
one absolute value and then you should
have a value that is relative that
adjusts itself and the viewport height
units again for font makes total sense
to do that so just like with min the
absolute value we provided was the
largest it would ever get well now the
absolute value that we provide inside of
max is the smallest it will ever get and
i know that is like contrary to what
they're named so remember max actually
provides a minimum absolute value and
min actually provides
a
maximum absolute value so which of these
would i use well actually i won't use
either one of these there is a third
function we can use and it is called
clamp and it's a newer function it
hasn't been around as long but it has
good support now and there we can
provide a minimum so i'm going to say
1.75 just like we used in our max
and then we put in the ideal size which
i'll put in our relative units of
viewport height of 3 units and then we
can put in a maximum so i'll put in our
2.25 that we used inside of our min
function so this lets us provide both we
had
a maximum inside of the min function and
that's right here and then we had a
minimum that was inside of the max
function and i've got it right here and
then we always use the viewport height
units of 3 for that relative and it's in
between so you've got minimum ideal and
maximum so now if we save and bring this
back once again we should see some
changes but it will stop growing and
stop shrinking at different points
okay so we're
on the paragraph we'll inspect that
specifically go to the computed tab
and now we'll look at the font size is
currently 35.376
so that is somewhere in between now we
can shrink this down and we're noticing
the font size is shrinking but it stops
shrinking now at 28 pixels now we can
bring this back up and i believe we said
2.25 so 36 pixels would be the largest
it would get and we achieved that now so
if we scroll back down there it starts
to shrink
so clamp works with both the minimum and
maximum and we'll choose an ideal size
in between when necessary let's close
dev tools again and bring the browser
back over to the right and now let's go
ahead and apply clamp to one more
variable that we can create here and i'm
going to create a font size dash
sm for small and here i'll change this
to 1.25
and then instead of three i'll use two
viewport units and then instead of 2.25
i'm going to make this
one
well then i've still got the two
1.5 rim for the maximum and save so now
we have a small size as well now let's
add just a little more content to see
how this can apply so i'm scrolling back
down to the main area
and we'll take our padding that we have
inside the main i'm going to cut that
out with control x and underneath main
i'm going to style that section that we
have so i want lower case though
main section
inside the section i'm going to say flex
dash
grow set that to 1 and then i'll put in
our padding and then we're going to add
an aside variable
underneath that section i said variable
a aside element underneath that section
element in our html so i'm going to say
main aside
and now let's go ahead and style this
choose a background dash color
and i've got a color picked out and
we'll use this hsla function here i'll
say zero
zero percent
twenty percent and remember the last one
is the opacity which is the transparency
say zero point eight
and then we have a color that we'll use
and this will be for the font and we'll
just use our light color variable that
we've already constructed
then we'll use our font size
and here we'll say vr and then our var
dash dash fs dash
sm for that small size we just created
let's make this font italic so we can
really tell the difference
and then the padding
will once again
be that padding variable we created
there it is
and save
now we also want to provide a media
query and this will help adjust our
aside because when the screen gets too
small we should stack them so underneath
all of our current css let's go ahead
and add at
media screen
and then we'll say min dash width
and we'll choose our small break point
that we had in previous lessons of 576
pixels
and now for the main here
we'll say flex dash flow and we'll
switch it to row
no wrap so now they'll be side by side
and we'll say justify content
space
between
okay after we've styled that main
element let's go ahead and add the main
section here
and now we'll adjust the width of the
section and we'll use another css
function to do that and that is calc and
for calc we'll say 70 percent and you
can mix different units so we're mixing
a percent
and a pixel
and then after that we'll go ahead and
provide a width for the aside as well so
we'll say main aside
and here we'll say width we'll use calc
once again and we'll say 30 percent
minus
5 pixels so
what we have here is actually 10 pixels
that will be between the section and the
aside on larger screens anything larger
than
500 or as large as 576 pixels or greater
i'm going to jump over to the html and
scroll down here and this will be in the
starter code as well or the at least the
finish code but i'm going to paste in
this aside here so it also has an h2 and
a paragraph
and that's it so we save and now we can
see the column over here on the right
because we are larger than 576 or we are
at least 576 pixels wide so we have our
section
and our aside and we can see that font
let's see how they both resize now as
we've applied the two different font
sizes so i will inspect open up dev
tools i want to go to computed
and i'm on the section or we could
choose the aside either one and see how
those font sizes apply so i'll look at
the content here
and now they look fairly small because
we're at 50 percent inside of devtools
just to get it all to fit let's go ahead
and start to shrink and notice the text
shrinks for both but then it eventually
stops for both as well so we've reached
that minimum
and now it starts to grow in the main
and now it's growing in the aside and at
some point they both stop growing as
well so clamp is working well for both
of those and again remember if this
looks a little small it's because we're
at 50 percent here when we have dev
tools open so i'll close that now we see
the full page and now i'll drag it back
over to the right let's go back to our
css those paragraphs that we have are
both content so just underneath the
aside i'm going to put in a content
class and that's what we've applied to
those paragraphs let's just say margin
top
of 20 pixels and see how that looks yeah
that gives a little space from the
heading down to where the rest of the
content starts i like that just a little
better okay now what about this google
link here let's talk about that so just
underneath the footer we'll go ahead and
style this and as we learned in our
pseudo lesson
we can choose any link and that should
apply to both the non-visited and
visited links
so let's color this
fire break
that will look a little better on the
colors that we have
but after that
let's go ahead and look at the hover and
the focus so we'll say anchor hover
comma and then we'll also have anchor
focus
and then inside of those we'll apply a
filter and there are filter functions so
in the past actually before we do that
let's look at what we were doing in the
past we were choosing a color maybe hsla
and putting that transparency in there
or if we could just leave it the color
it is and just put in opacity and maybe
we'd put that to 0.8
and then when we mouse over
it just gets a little fainter you can't
tell as good with the fire brick maybe
i'll take that down to 0.6
yes now it gets a little weaker when we
hover over it's a little transparent so
that's how you can do that on its own or
you can provide that fourth value inside
of hsla
and choose the color as well
but what we want to do now is provide a
filter and filter has several functions
so one thing i like to do with filter is
use the brightness and here i'm going to
say 150 percent so instead of adding
transparency now when i mouse over the
link gets brighter i actually really
like that i just wasn't able to do it
earlier in the lessons so i frequently
do that for the hover focus i like the
filter brightness now something else you
can do that is a cool effect instead of
brightness is choose hue rotate and
you'll always get a complementary color
if you say 180 degrees so if we save
that let's see what is 180 degrees
difference in the color wheel if you
think about colors than firebrick and
it's this kind of teal or green i don't
know if i like that one there so some
will have better luck than others and
you could play around with the degrees
with that as well myself i'll probably
go back to brightness so i'm just going
to ctrl z to undo until i'm back to that
brightness and i like how that works
okay one more function to work with
while we're working with these
paragraphs let's jump to the html again
and inside of our aside we have this
lorem text and notice we provided a span
element that is an inline element and
it's wrapping around it and then it has
a class of tool tip and then it also has
an attribute that is data dash tool tip
and we can really provide custom
attributes as long as they all start
with data dash and then we can name it
whatever we want so we named this data
dash tooltip and it says this is latin
so now let's make a custom tool tip that
will show when we hover over lorem
inside of our aside over here so we
should see it right up here in the top
right let's jump back to the css
and then just underneath the well let's
do it underneath the content there we
are
so now let's put in a
tooltip class
and inside this tool tip we'll say
border dash bottom so this will indicate
that a tool tip exists we'll say one
pixel dash and let's try orange to see
how that looks if we save we see the
little dashed border under lorem that
indicates there is something about that
now we also want to get this position
relative because we will be using a
position absolute when we choose where
the tooltip shows up
so after we've applied those styles to
the tooltip class then we need
tool tip
hover pseudo class but now we can stack
a pseudo element and this is the before
pseudo element so now we've applied the
tooltip class the hover pseudo class and
now the before pseudo element and with
that i'm going to choose content
and here is where we can use a function
it's the attribute function and now we
just name the attribute so this is our
data dash
tool tip
and if i save this we'll notice this
appear when i hover over
and now it just appeared at the
beginning in front of lorem it says this
is latin lorem
when i hover over and that's not what we
want but you can see how this works okay
let's go ahead and style the rest so
we'll say
position
absolute let's put the position at minus
20 pixels which should put it up on top
if we save now and i mouse over it shows
the top but now it's all scrunched and
it comes down in there so to get it to
avoid wrapping on each of those words we
can say
white dash space and then say no wrap
now if we save and look now it says this
is latin up above
okay from there let's give this a
background color
and now we could use our
var and say
dark color there it is which was black
if i remember correctly
and after that we can give it padding
and here we could say
var and give it our padding as well so
there we go
and then finally let's give it a border
dash radius of 15
pixels and save now when we mouse over
lorem
we get a this is latin tooltip that pops
up we've learned a lot about css
functions with these paragraphs and this
layout but now it's time to go back to
grid and learn about some of the grid
functions so first i'll go to the html
and i'm going to select both our section
and our aside element inside of the main
element i'll hold down shift and click
and now i'll press shift alt and the
letter a to comment that all out and now
i'm going to select the divs from the
previous lesson once again hold down
shift alt and the letter a to uncomment
those and now we should have those back
on the page when we save we should
definitely see a difference but we need
to make some changes to the css also
back in the css file i'll need to scroll
up to the main section and we can
comment out the flex flex flow or
display flex flex flow and justify
content
and now we will uncomment what we
previously had here but now we'll change
some of this and we'll actually just
delete these three middle rows as well
okay we want this to be a display
grid instead of display flex
after that we're going to apply grid
dash template columns and now we can use
a grid function and we used this when we
learned about grid in a lesson and that
is the repeat function so we're going to
say repeat this 4 times so that will
give us four columns and then we're
going to use a math function that is
specific to grid and that is min max
and here we provide a min and a max so
i'm going to provide 100 pixels for the
smallest grid item that we would want
and 300 pixels for the largest now after
that i also want to adjust this gap i
did this in a previous tutorial as well
but four viewport width units are almost
always going to be bigger than 15 pixels
so min's probably always going to select
15 pixels here so i will change this to
and then i will also switch this to 20
pixels and it should probably adjust
now based on that and after i save you
can see the changes on the page over
here on the right but we will resize the
page and look at some more changes there
as well but the reason we're not seeing
the grid adapt to the page the way i
would like it to is because we still
have in a size for the squares we had in
a width and height previously so let's
select both of those lines
shift alt and the letter a to comment
those out and save once again and now we
see the grid is filling up the entire
space that is available i think we
should probably provide just a little
bit of padding inside that main element
as well so let's scroll back up to where
we were and just above here the display
grid and below the flex grow let's say
padding and let's provide the padding
that we have already defined
and now once we save we should see it
give just a little space and that looks
better and it should adapt to all sizes
so let's go ahead and drag this over and
see how everything has applied now it
did adapt to this size so we see all 12
grid items and you can see once they've
reached that 300 width
then the gap here between the columns is
going to get larger as the page has to
adapt but it kept whatever gap we had
defined between the rows now as we
resize we'll see that change so i'm once
again going to right click and choose
inspect
remember you can also get into dev tools
by choosing control shift and the letter
i all at the same time or pressing those
all at the same time okay now that we're
here i will select one item
and inspect so we've got a div square
highlighted and we can see it has a
width of 300 pixels as i mouse over that
but we can also go to computed
scroll down and see that width as well
now let's resize
and as we get in here to a size where
they're not the grid items themselves
aren't changing right now it's the space
between the columns but as we squeeze
them in now they're changing and now we
can see that width here is changing as
well so if we scroll down it should be
that same number well it's close
251.8 right now and as we continue to
squeeze and it keeps scrolling on me but
as we continue to squeeze it will go
down until they are 100 pixels and we're
getting close i think
and let's take a look now
and now we're at 105 so we're very very
close and now the page starts to shift
as we'd have to put in a media query to
get it to adapt
after that because
they will no longer shrink in any way
they at this point when the page starts
to break essentially is when they have
stopped adjusting so they are at 100
pixels
right there and if i bring this down we
should now see that 100 pixels and if we
bring it out they begin to grow so now
250 pixels apiece all the way up to 300.
now notice our grid gap that we defined
and it stays what we defined it as until
they stop growing and after they stop
growing then they start to separate the
columns because it needs to fill out the
page
but as they are scrunched in it keeps
that space between the rows and the
columns because remember the gap
property is both a grid gap and a row
gap value it's a shorthand so we can see
how all of that works together so we
provided the min max we used repeat as
well and then we used min once again on
the gap property
let's move on to css transforms
transitions and animations and before we
finish today we'll make a css only
animated hamburger icon and drop down
nav menu as you see here let's look at
our starter code today you can see i've
got an
index.html file and inside this
index.html file i've just got a main
element and it contains three divs i
don't usually use divs but for this
example they're good we're just creating
squares with all of them and you can see
i have a class of squares set on each
one the final div also has a class of
animate and then i've got a different
emoji inside of each div and then in the
file tree you can see i've got some
other files as well but for these first
examples of transforms transitions and
animations i'm just going to use the
index.html file and then the style.c
file after this though we will go ahead
and create an animated mobile menu and
it will have an animated hamburger icon
as well as the drop down navigation menu
inside of it but for now let's just
learn about the basics of transforms
transitions and animations now inside of
the style.css file you can see i'm
importing the nunito font from google
i've got a basic css reset here inside
the html element styles i've set the
font just a little larger to one and a
half rims and we're applying the nunito
font that we've imported and then the
body element is set to a min height of
100 viewport units it's a display of
flex and a column so the main element
that's inside of the body is set to flex
grow one so it also extends to the full
visible page that we see the body take
up and from there the main element is
also set to display flex for anything
within it and it's set to a column as
well and everything is centered and then
there will be a gap of one rim between
the flex items within the main element
and those flex items are the three divs
that we previously looked at inside of
the html file they've got a width and a
height of 200 pixels so they're squares
they've got a border of one pixel solid
black and then i set each one to display
grid so we can center the content easily
just by saying place content center so
it centers those emojis i'll drag our
code over to the left side of the screen
and we can see this page right now with
our starter code here on the right we've
got our three divs each one is 200 by
200 pixels and then we've centered the
emoji inside of each one now we're ready
to apply some individual styles to each
of these divs so i'm going to scroll for
some more room inside of the css file
i'm also going to press ctrl
b to hide the file tree so i have a
little more room to type and we'll
review some pseudo class selectors to
select each one of these divs so first
i'll put in div in lowercase and then
the first pseudo class i'm going to use
is first child so this should select the
first div and we can test that by
changing the color change the background
color to dodger blue and save and
using the live server extension it
updates automatically when we save and
we can see that first div gets a
background color of dodger blue so i'm
going to highlight this div selector and
press shift alt and the down arrow twice
so i get it twice more inside of our
code and then i can just change this to
nth child and then we need a parenthesis
and i'll put in the number two and now
i'll switch the second div
to yellow
and then finally we can use last child
for the last div and we just need one s
there we go and i'll change this one to
lime green so now let's save and see if
the colors change and they do so we've
successfully selected all three of these
divs individually now the first property
we'll look at is transform so inside of
the first child
i'll select that and use transform
and then what we'll put in for a value
first is translate x you can see we have
different choices here that visual
studio code gives us now x will move it
left or right and if we use percents it
bases the percent on the size of the div
so when i put in 50 percent it should
move it halfway over and we can compare
to the other divs to see if this is
correct and yes it moves our first div
of the way over of the width of the div
not of the page or the element that it's
within but of the element itself so that
is the 50
and the positive number moves it to the
right
a negative number would move it to the
left now we can use other units besides
percents so in the next div i'll say
transform once again
and then i'll use translate y which
should move it up or down and here i'll
use two rim and let's see what happens
it moved it down to ram so likewise if i
give it a negative two rim it should
move it up and as you might have guessed
instead of just translate x or translate
y
we can use the shorthand and use them
together so in the third one i'll say
transform
and then i'll just use translate and now
the first value is the x value so i'll
say 100 percent
and we can combine different units so
here i'll say minus 2 ram
and save
and now you can see it moves it to the
right 100 percent
and then the minus 2 rim did move it up
so now we're back to our original gap
between the second div and the third div
because we also moved that second div
minus two rims so if we were to just
switch this to translate x and then
remove the -2 room you can see that the
gap is larger so if we wanted to move
this up even more to make it obvious i
could just delete the translate x go
back to translate and let's say
minus
5 rim and save and now you can see it
moves way up so it's a little easier to
see that it's working so we now know
that translate x moves things left and
right and translate y moves things up
and down and we can use them both
together but for now let's just comment
these out so i'll press shift alt and
the letter a to comment them out after i
have highlighted them
and do that for the third one as well
and we'll move on to the next value that
we can use for transform which is rotate
so i'll once again put in transform and
i'm going to leave these commented out
values in here so you can play around
with them from my source code if you
want to so this transform will be
rotate and you can see once again we
have choices like x y and z so i'm going
to choose x and now let's say rotate
180 degrees and this will of course
apply to the first one and when i save
these other changes will revert because
we've commented them out too
so there we have now rotated
180 degrees let's do a smaller rotation
and you can see what happens as well so
something looks a little strange about
this box doesn't it that's because it's
rotating
from the top
backwards so it's kind of like a pizza
box if you consider it that way this
bottom part is coming towards you and
the top part is moving away from you as
far as that rotation and that means once
we get to 90 degrees
it disappears because
you are now at eye level with that flat
top or the card consider this a card as
well instead of just a pizza box and
you're flipping it over from the top and
so once we go 180 degrees it has flipped
all the way over
and now notice the rocket is pointing to
the bottom right instead of the top
right and that's because that card has
been flipped over
from top to bottom so as you might guess
then if we apply transform
and then rotate
y
let's choose that out of our list here
and now if we sit this to say 45 degrees
so we can see what's happening first
it will be just the opposite so
this now looks a little skinnier because
we're flipping it i believe from left to
right let's go ahead and do the 180
and yes now the flame is just the
opposite so we took the right side and
made it the left side but it's flipped
over so imagine having the same image on
both sides but it's the opposite of that
so we're flipping this side to this side
and then of course what was here over to
this side so we're seeing this from the
back as if the image was burned all the
way through and so
left to right
would be the way to consider y as far as
the rotation and top to bottom would be
the way to consider x for the rotation
and now let's apply one more down here
to our final div so we'll say
transform and now we'll use rotate z
and let's go ahead and choose 90 degrees
with rotate z and see what happens
it didn't disappear did it it turned so
we did have our taco facing the normal
way and now it is turned over here so
this might be clockwise let's see what
happens if we do 180 yes and now it's
upside down so that's actually what this
is doing is rotating clockwise with a
positive number a negative number of
course would take it counterclockwise
it's worth noting that although we can
use rotate z it is just the same as if
we just said rotate so if i save this we
won't see a change likewise if we make
it 135 degrees it'll move on around and
yes we did see the change now you can
tell it rotated because of the taco has
a different position here in the middle
but we could put this some odd number as
well and it won't have such a perfect
rotation to see the change so there we
once again go it does rotate the full
box not just the emoji okay i'll once
again comment these out but leave them
in the code so if you do download the
source code you can see these in there
and we're going to move on to the next
possible transformation
and that's going to be scale it's very
useful at times i meant for this to be
on the same line here for the comment
okay for scale we'll say transform once
again and then we'll say
scale x as you might guess and let's
make this 120
and see what happens to this top box
it got bigger but only to the left and
the right as with x which is a lot like
the translate x but now it just grew to
a hundred and twenty percent of the size
but it only expanded
on the horizontal plane here to the left
and the right not up and down at all so
as you might guess if we apply the
opposite to the second div transform y
oops i transform and then we need
actually
scale y there we go put that at 120
percent we'll see the growth goes to the
top and the bottom and it doesn't expand
on the left and the right at all and
finally if we look at this last child
and now i'm going to scroll for just a
little room i'll put in transform once
again and here i'll just put scale and
like translate we can put in both the x
and the y values so i'll say 50
x
and 50 y and save and we can see
instead of growing it actually shrank
because it's just half the size that it
was now before we finish with transform
there is one more possible thing to
cover with it and i'll comment all of
these out as well
and what we want to do there it's called
skew oops i selected that below there it
is
and now one more to select before we
move on to transform sku
so now once again on this first div
we'll say
transform and we'll say
skew x and with that we'll say minus 10
degrees and let's see what happens
and you can see now we've got a leaning
box instead of the normal box that we
had and that's kind of cool sometimes
when you want to get that effect now
let's do the opposite with y so
transform and then we'll say
skew if i could spell skew correctly and
here we'll once again say a degree but
let's choose a different value maybe
minus 10 degrees instead of 10 no we
said minus 10 before maybe i should go
10 degrees let me go ahead and try that
and yeah we can see we get the opposite
if we use a positive number instead of
the negative but we skewed this y also
so it's leaning a little differently
than this one here on the top where the
sides tilted now the top line's tilted
at the top and the bottom actually
instead of the left and the right and
finally as we did with scale and
translate we can provide both in the
same so transform and now we'll just say
skew instead of skew x or y and here
i'll say minus 10 degrees and now i'll
stick with minus 10 degrees here as well
and when we save we can see that applies
to both so it's leaning on the left and
the right and the lines have changed on
the top and the bottom as well now i've
touched on some of the basic uses with
all of these transformations and there
are many more that you can reference in
mdn and so as always i'm putting the mdn
link for transform and all of these
different possibilities in the course
description inside of the resources so
you'll find that on github when you go
to the course resources and now that
we've covered everything you can do with
transform i'll reset these back and
we're going to start looking at
transitions let's apply a transition to
when we hover over the divs so we'll say
div and then use our pseudo class
selector hover and then inside of this
we'll change the background color when
we hover over that will be easy to tell
and let's use the color midnight blue
next we need to provide the transition
property that we are changing and that
is the background dash color
from there let's set the transition dash
duration and we'll set that to two
seconds and save so now when we mouse
over one of these i'll do the middle one
it takes two seconds and it changes to
midnight blue the same with the top
and the same with the bottom now we can
also provide a transition
dash delay there it is let's set this to
just a half second we don't want to wait
too long and now when i mouse over it
doesn't change immediately but then it
starts to so it waits that half second
first now this is important to know if
you put two transitions together that
transition delay does not go between the
transitions it's just before it starts
so we have a half second delay and then
it goes ahead and does the two second
transition to midnight blue now i
mentioned having a second transition or
a second transform that we're providing
here so let's go ahead and do one other
pseudo selector i'll say div hover again
but now we'll only apply this to the
last child actually i need to say last
child first
and then hover there we go
now for this i'll say
transform and we'll just rotate
and let's rotate 180 degrees so this
would just apply to the last one but we
don't have a transition applied to that
yet either but we can up here if we want
to in the same line so after background
color i can just put a comma
and say
transform
and then during the duration if i want
that to be a different duration i can
just say three seconds here and then if
i don't want to delay or i want the same
delay i could just leave it as is so
let's just leave it as is so we've got
background color two seconds transform
three seconds and we'll save and now if
i hover over this last one it waits that
half second and then it begins to rotate
and notice it takes three seconds to
rotate but only two seconds to change
colors once i'll do this again you can
see the color is fully changed before it
stops rotating okay but that is a lot of
different lines here we've got
transition property transition duration
transition delay
and as you might guess there is a
shorthand so i'm going to comment all of
those out with shift alt and the letter
a
and now i'm just going to say
transition
and here i can say
all of the transitions
instead of any specific one i'll say i
want them all to last two seconds and
all of them to have a half second delay
and i can save that and handle it all in
one line so now when i mouse over
it just takes two seconds and it
finishes these still apply the same
just a two second switch to the color
now we can also provide a timing
function here and there are some
definitions or other ones that are
already defined essentially that we can
put in here so the default
is ease but we could also put in some
others let's go ahead and set this up by
saying
transition and now let's see timing
function this is what we would be
looking for a lot of different values
that could go in here but the default is
ease but once i start typing ease you
can also see there's ease in ease in and
out or just ease out now what this means
and i usually can't tell much of a
difference between ease and ease in and
out but it starts slow and then it
speeds up and then once again it slows
down at the end so i'll just choose ease
even though that's the default
and let's go ahead and look at this now
well we can see more in the rotation so
it starts slow it speeds up and it ends
slow now the opposite of that would be
to say linear so it does everything at
an even pace and now you can see
it just there's not a huge difference
but there's a little bit of difference
so you can provide this function and if
you do so you can provide it right here
after how long the transition will take
so right here is where we might say
linear and of course move this comment
over here
and save and now this should still apply
the linear see it's not as fast as the
e's i kind of like the ease or let's try
ease in and out and see if we notice
much of a change i don't usually but
let's see what we get does speed up and
slows back down so i do like that a
little bit better personally than linear
but both are available and remember if
you don't apply one ease on its own is
the default so even if we didn't say
ease in and out or linear or anything
and we just left it as this it would
apply the e's timing function as is now
we've learned about transform and
transitions that can help us make a
little more impact with the
transformations let's scroll for some
more room and now learn about animations
that's just a little different so i'm
going to go ahead and start defining the
class animate if you remember we applied
this class to this last div
inside of the html so for animate the
first thing we need to do is name our
animation so we should have animation
dash
name and here i'm just going to name
this slide
then an animation
dash duration and i'll give this five
seconds
an animation let's spell that correctly
again
timing function and thank goodness
visual studio code helps me spell here
i'll say ease in and out so you can see
this is a lot like a transition so far
but you will notice a difference as well
and we can provide an animation delay
let's let's delay this by one second
that's just a little bit longer we can
also give an animation iteration count
so i'm going to have it repeat this
animation
five times now let's go ahead and just
go with those properties for now
but this in itself won't apply the
animation we need to define key frames
for the animation so we say at
keyframes and then we need to have an
identifier here and the identifier is
the animation name slide
so now inside of this we'll say at zero
percent essentially at the beginning of
the animation we will
transform
and then we'll translate x
and here inside of translate x i'll just
say zero so we're starting at square one
we're not doing anything right when it
begins but then at 33 percent or one
third of the way through we'll once
again say
transform and now i'll say translate
x
and we'll move this 600 pixels to the
right so this will probably go way off
the screen
and then we'll rotate
degrees and notice there's no comma
between those which is strange but
that's the way it likes it in css so
we'll just leave it like that after that
i'm going to highlight this and do shift
alt and the down arrow we'll change this
33 to a 66 so now we're two thirds of
the way through and now i'll switch this
to a minus 600 pixels
and a minus 180 degrees so we're
applying more than one thing here again
no comma
and then finally we'll get to a hundred
percent
and at a hundred percent
i'm going to go ahead and say
transform
and our translate
x once again will be back to the zero
position
and after that let's change the
background color when we get to the
final position to rebecca purple and
there will be a reason we want to see
this and how it changes so notice now it
started animating right when i saved it
didn't wait for a hover it's an
animation and let me go ahead and pull
this over to the full screen so we can
see the full animation
and there's at least three
now notice it changes back to green when
the animation starts again and that's
something else to discuss
but let's go ahead and let it finish the
five times and you can see it's going
the 600 pixels in each direction it's
rotating as we want it to and it changes
colors at the end but then it changes
back to green and it's back in that
starting state so since we have a
smaller screen over here let's maybe
change these to 300 it'll probably still
make it to the edge or beyond of the
screen but we'll leave it at that and
then let's go ahead and add some more
animation properties above and the next
one that i want to add is the animation
dash direction now the default here is
just normal
but that's not exactly what we have to
choose so let's get those back up here
and there's alternate alternate reverse
reverse let's say alternate so that
means it's going to go forward the first
time and then it's going to reverse the
next time so when i save this it will
start again
had that one second delay it went a
little to the left a little to the right
and then it stops now it went to the
left instead of the right first back to
the right and stops and so on so now
we've seen those changes the next
property to look at is animation fill
mode so we'll say animation dash
fill mode and now what happens here is
we are talking about the actual ending
state so the default is backwards as you
see visual studio code brings up and
that means it goes back to the original
state it now has that green background
again but if we say
forwards
when it stops it should now go to that
other state then i'm going to shorten
this up so here we'll save it so it goes
forward once and then backwards once and
then we'll be at the ending state so
there was our forward now we go backward
but when we get to the very end let's
see if it goes back to green or not well
it did because we alternated so let's
switch this alternation back to normal
because
it was the opposite when it did the
alternate the second time so there we
end at purple
then it goes back to green and starts
again and now we're back to purple and
it stayed purple that's the point of
this animation fill mode since we set it
to forwards instead of backwards it
keeps the ending state so it stayed
purple now again there are some other
animation properties that you can dive
into the mdn link that i'm going to
leave in the course resources because
there's a lot more you can do i'm just
touching on the basics here today but
once again look at how many properties
we had to use and we can use shorthand
instead of all those so i will comment
all of those out and now let's just
apply the shorthand we'll say
animation
that's going to last five seconds let's
use ease in and out and then we'll say
one second delay and then let's do the
animation twice
let's say normal so it does it the same
way both times and then the ending state
will be forwards
and the animation name of course we have
to provide and that is slide
so if we do that this should apply the
same as we had all of these properties
above but this is shorthand so you can
see how all of these values fit into
that one shorthand line here for
animation now we've completed the basics
about transformations transitions and
animations so let's go ahead and begin
working on that animated mobile nav menu
that will give us an animated hamburger
icon and animated drop down menu that
users could apply so to do that we need
to look at our other starter code i'm
going to show the file tree again i'm
also going to stop live server for now
because we'll launch a different html
file and i'm going to drag this back
over to the full window
and then we'll look at the menu.html
this will also be in your starter code
and for the menu html we have got a
basic page here but there's a little
more than in the previous example we
have a header element inside of the body
and you can see this header element has
a section inside of it and it has the
class header title line and here we have
our h1 that says acme co and then we
have a button as well and inside this
button is a div
and it has the class menu icon the
button has the class menu button and
then we have a nav element and inside
the nav element is an unordered list
with four list items now they are
basically fake links with just the
hashtag that you would use as an anchor
for the same page but i am going ahead
and passing one link to a products page
and this products page is basically just
like the menu.html page but of course it
links back to the menu.html page just so
we can see the difference there i have
absolutely nothing in the main element
this is all about the header and
creating the menu around this header
structure so from there let me close
this style css and the index.html let's
look at the menu css that is being
imported and what we have for starter
code before we really start animating
this menu so what we have again is the
import of the font basic css reset and
then we're setting two css variables
just for the colors that we'll reuse in
different areas the background colors of
flat black and then white smoke for the
font color
and then the html itself once again just
like the previous example has a font
size of one and a half rim set the font
family to nanito so that's all inherited
the body has 100 viewport units min
height and then is set to flex and a
column again and then the header itself
has a background color that's the header
background color and we set the basic
color here so we don't see a whole lot
of difference but i'm going to go ahead
and launch this page now with live
server and drag visual studio code over
to the left and it looks like it
launched the other page so i'll need to
change that
and then inside of here i'm going to say
slash
menu dot html now right now this doesn't
look too great we don't have a whole lot
that looks good for sure we have our
acme co here and then we've got our
links here as well and maybe a little
something odd there but now we'll start
to apply some other styles i'm going to
do control b again to hide the file tree
and we can start with that header title
line and if you remember i believe
that's what this is is the button we had
the acme co h1 and then we had a button
all inside of that section element that
had the class header title line so i'll
put
header dash
title dash line
and we'll start to apply a few styles
there let's give a padding
0.25 rim on top and bottom and 0.5 rim
on the left and the right we'll set it
to a display of flex
and from there let's go ahead and set
the flex dash flow
and this will be a row instead of a
column and we'll say no wrap again
and then after that let's justify the
content and we want space between so we
go hard left and hard right with the
content we have which should be the h1
and the button i'll save this much and
we do see the change so now we see a
line over here that would be the button
we didn't really do much with it yet and
we've got our h1 over here okay after
our
header title line class let's get the
next class which was menu dash button
this is the button itself and i did use
a button element so we don't have to
apply some other things and it's great
for accessibility such as hitting the
tab button it will automatically get
focus on a button element if we used a
div for example we'd have to put in a
tab index and there's some other
advantages as well but that's a big one
okay for the menu button we'll say
background dash color
and now we'll set that to transparent
because we don't want that normal button
color that we get and then we'll also
set the border to none because buttons
usually do come with a border now let's
go ahead and give this some shape with
the width
of 48 pixels and a height
of 48 pixels which is kind of thumb size
i'll save this much and we definitely
see a change it's gone we don't see the
48 by 48 because we haven't done
anything else with it yet at this point
let's set the display
to flex
justify content and we want that
center
we also want to
align the items
center
and i'll scroll just a little bit and
after that we're going to set a position
to
relative if you remember the position
tutorial earlier in the css series that
means we're probably going to position
something absolute inside of the button
but those are the button styles and if
we say we really won't see a change at
this point because we don't have
anything inside of that button and we've
set it to be transparent
okay now we want the menu icon which is
the div
inside of the button but we're also
going to select the menu dash icon
before pseudo element and the menu dash
icon
after pseudo element so all three of
these will be affected by this
and we'll say
background dash color
now let's use our variable
and we want the header color just it's
that white smoke color that we defined
above now here we'll set the width
to 40 pixels and we'll give this a
height
of 5 pixels
and then i'll go ahead and save so you
can see what we have we have one line
essentially here a big dash that's 40
pixels wide and 5 pixels high so now
let's go ahead and set the
border
radius and we'll set that to 5 pixels
and now this is going to be position
absolute i'll scroll again for a little
more room and after that we're going to
go ahead and set our transition
right here because it will apply to all
of these
so we'll say all instead of any specific
property and then we want it to apply
faster than we did in our examples in
just a half second
and we'll save that much now notice we
only have
the one line and it does have the
rounded edges so it's one of the three
lines we expect in our hamburger menu
but we applied this to all so where are
the others well the quick answer is
they're all stacked on top of each other
right now so we need to make a few more
changes before we see them the first
change is just going to apply to the
menu icon
before
and the menu dash icon
after but not the menu icon itself and
here we just need to set the content to
a blank basically an empty quotes here
because
if we don't do that they won't be
visible so even though we didn't put
anything in there we need to set the
content to empty value and then we can
go ahead and set the menu dash icon
before
and we're going to need to transform it
now so we'll say transform
and now we'll translate and we're going
to provide two values here so
i guess i could just do one first let's
do translate
y and i'll show you why we need to do
two values so i'll say minus 12 pixels
and save
and now look they're not even up here at
all that is not what we want so
really it starts in the middle and since
this is 40 pixels we need to have
translate because the x value needs to
be minus
20 pixels and then the y value can be
the minus 12 to put it up above
the actual one that was in the middle
defined by menu icon so now when i save
it gets pulled back over and i was
expecting them to be the same length let
me make sure i put everything that i
thought i did and i'll come back and go
over that but right now two different
links of lines however
what i expected here did happen we've
got the minus 20 pixels to pull it back
even and the minus 12 pixels to put it
on top i'm going to select this now do
shift alt and the down arrow and then
change the before
to after
and now i'll also need minus 20 pixels
here but now i'll need a plus 12 pixels
to put this next one underneath
and save and now they have straightened
out that's what i needed was the
hamburger menu all three the same so the
menu icon is the one in the middle and
then the top one is the before and the
bottom one is the after pseudo element
and now i know why it was longer before
because they were stacked on top of each
other but this bottom one started in the
middle which then made it look like it
extended the middle line which was
actually the two together but not
starting at the same place
okay from there we can go ahead and
apply some more styles to the nav i'm
going to scroll for some more room and
we'll select the nav element now the nav
element is going to start out with a
display of none but i'm going to go
ahead and set up block here first so we
can actually see what we're doing with
the nav element and then i'll come back
and change it we also want a transform
dash origin telling the transformation
where to start and we want it in the top
and center because it's going to drop
down and now we're going to apply an
animation but we haven't defined that
animation yet so let's go ahead and
define it first and underneath here
we'll say
at
keyframes
and then we'll say show menu
and now we'll say at the zero percent
we will transform
and then we want scale
y
and we'll set that to zero
and then after that we want the next one
to be at 80 percent
and that's going to also be a transform
and this will also be a scale y
but this will be 1.2 notice we don't
have to just stop at one so it actually
will go 20 percent beyond the intended
size and that's going to give it just a
little bit of a bounce like kind of like
stretching a blind down and then letting
go of the blind and it snaps back up
just a little bit
so then we'll say at one hundred percent
we use
transform
and we'll say scale y and now we'll just
put it back to one and then after it
snaps back up it will lose that twenty
percent so let's save that and that will
be our show menu keyframes for how this
transition will work i'm going to come
back to the nav and again like i said
change the display to none and i'm also
going to apply that animation but right
now we just want to see what we're doing
and not really have the animation or
have the nav hidden so we'll go ahead
and come back to both of those things
right now we'll grab that unordered list
inside of the nav
we'll say list style type but not disk
we'll set that to none
and then we can set that unordered list
to a display
of flex
and then we'll set the flex flow there
to
column and no wrap
and after that we can select the list
items so nav and li
and then we'll give them a padding of
0.5 ram all the way around
and let's put a border on top
to one pixel
solid and here i'll need var so i can
set that
header dash color
let's save this much and see what we've
got well we can see the menu is coming
together we haven't really styled the
links or positioned these at all but we
now clearly have a menu that would drop
down that has individual sections to it
so let's go ahead and style those links
now so after the nav li we'll have nav
lowercase please and the anchor tag so
all of the links will be
display
block instead of what they normally are
which is inline
and then we'll say text align and set
them center
and then i'm going to give them a width
of 80 percent
if i were to not be applying an
animation if i did not apply an
animation to these links
then i would probably set them to a
hundred percent and just change the
background color and the text link so
they would take up the whole space
but
because i want to apply an animation
today i'm setting these to 80 percent
because the animation will make it grow
so that is the consideration there and
because of that i'm also setting the
margin to
auto so it will center these block
elements that they are now block
elements when they normally aren't but
what we get
are centered links right now we don't
have an animation or a transformation i
should say applied to any of these yet
but we will
after that we'll go ahead and select
the nav
we need the anchor and there we go the
any link pseudo selector which is a
pseudo class so this applies to both the
non-visited and visited links
and we'll say color we'll set our var
to the
header color once again so they stay
that same color whether they've been
visited or not
we'll set the font weight
to bold
and text
decoration
to none and that will remove the
outlines we have under those words now
when we save they're nice and bold and
they are that white smoke color that we
expect them to be and finally let's go
ahead and apply this transformation
which will animate the links just a
little bit so we'll say nav and then
hover
and then we'll also apply this to the
nav and if they have focus both of those
we'll say transform
and now we can say scale and we'll go to
1.2 which is essentially saying 120
so they should grow 20 percent
and then we can set the transition right
here as well so i'll just say all
0.3 seconds so we don't want to wait too
long and now when i mouse over
notice how they grow
and that works just great and this will
also happen if we tab through the page
you can see the outline and this is good
for accessibility we'll select each one
of these as we go through so you do not
want to remove the outline you could
change the colors or style it if you
want to but i usually leave it basically
as the default it does help with
accessibility so you definitely want it
there so you can tab through these as
well now let's go back to our nav menu
and make those changes i talked about so
nav instead of display block should be
none to start out
and then we also want to apply that
animation which will be animation
using the shorthand here so we'll say
show menu that's the name of the
animation
0.5 seconds is the duration the default
would be ease so we could say ease or
ease in and out again i can't tell much
of a difference between the two and then
we'll go with forwards so it leaves it
in that finishing state as we noticed in
our example before
the square changed to purple and stayed
purple at the end instead of reverting
back to green so we'll say forwards here
now this won't apply a whole lot yet but
when i save it will disappear
so now we need to do some other things
so it will appear when we hover over the
header or when we have focus anywhere in
the header i'll put these final styles
right above the nav here in our css and
they're going to start with the is sudo
selector which will save us a little
space i'm going to say header
and then hover but this will also apply
to the header
focus dash within
and now after that we can specify
the menu dash icon so you can see what
the is sudo selector helped us with
otherwise we would have had to say
header hover menu icon header focus
within menu icon so it saved us just a
little bit so what we're going to do say
background
color and we'll set that to transparent
and then we'll also
go ahead and say transform
well let me hold off on the transform
i'll come back to the transform let's
just go with background color
transparent to start out with for the
menu icon
and after that i'm just going to select
this
and drop this down now remember the menu
icon itself is just this middle line
which means we'll be
losing the middle line when we mouse
over
now after that we'll say menu icon
before
so now we're selecting just the top line
and instead of background color here i'm
going to want
transform
and then i'm going to set a couple of
things one thing is the translate x and
that is because remember we already had
to translate x back minus 20 pixels we
need to do this again or it will end up
in a different area so we'll once again
say minus 20 pixels for the translate x
and then we're going to rotate and we'll
rotate this line 45 degrees
and we'll leave it at that now i'm going
to select all of this and do shift alt
and the down arrow again i'm also going
to press alt z just so you can see what
isn't showing over there so it's is
header hover header focus within and
then we're selecting the menu icon
before
and now i'm switching this one to after
once again i need translate x minus 20
pixels but now instead of 45 degrees i
need minus 45 degrees
finally i'm going to copy this one more
time
select all of that down but instead of
the menu icon before or after
i'm going to switch this
to the nav element itself it's not a
class this is going to be the element
there we go and now we need to change
that display to block so it actually
shows up because before remember we had
none
so those are the different changes we
have made for when we hover over the
header or when we have focus within the
header which is important if we're going
to tab through so now let me hover over
the header
and you can see our hamburger menu
changes to an x and that's usually
desirable so the middle line disappeared
we set that background color to
transparent then we rotated the other
lines the before and the after so now
they form an x and of course we also had
to set this to display block for the
menu to show and now as i hover over
these that other transformation of
course makes each one of the words grow
by 20 so we can tell what we're hovering
over and then likewise if there's focus
within here now i remove this and it
changes so there we go and we can see
that little bounce at the bottom too
there we go
now maybe we want to set a background
color on the nav itself because i'm
noticing that's bouncing a little bit
lower and going into the white there so
let's go back to the nav
and find where oh it was actually
underneath here so let's set a
background color on the nav itself
and here we'll say
var and grab that same
header background color
and save now let's check out the bounce
with the menu and yeah now we see that
color stays with this last word instead
of dipping into the white there that
looks good but there's one more
transform that we can apply and it's the
one that i didn't before this goes to an
x which is great but let's apply this to
the hamburger menu as well so this is
the
menu icon and right here we'll say
transform and now let's rotate
and let's do
720 degrees so that's going to be
a few full turns there at least a couple
so now when i hover over you get the
spin and then we have the x
and that's a nice little effect as well
so there everything is complete i hope
this has helped you learn a lot about
transformations transitions and even
animations because they're very useful
but you don't want to overdo it too many
on a page can just be too much
before we get to the final project in
this css for beginner series there's one
more topic to cover and that's
organizing your css i've included a
markdown file with this lesson and the
sample code and it just is going to
contain an outline of suggestions to
organize your css and i say suggestions
because there are no hard and fast rules
there are different theories and
different takes on this but the first
one
is possibly the most important and that
is follow
your team
that's a very important rule to go with
because if your team has already
established how they're organizing the
file you need to follow that pattern
you're probably a junior dev getting
started with them and you don't really
want to rock the boat there just follow
and
of course use the pattern that they have
and i'm sure there are reasons for that
pattern
after that we're going to have code
examples to look at so our second reason
here or second suggestion is to use
comments to create headers or you might
call them dividers as well labels if you
will inside of your css now we've seen
this already throughout this series as
we've done a few mini projects and
you've seen that i've provided these
headers which are much like what mdn
suggests throughout the css so here's
our reset labeled and then i have one
for the variables and then inside of the
root pseudo selector here you can see i
labeled colors there might be other
variables that i would create and so i
might have sub labels here inside of
that pseudo selector for that then i
have utility classes general styles and
now we get down to blocks which is
something we're going to talk about in
just a little bit but this is just our
starter css for the day but you can see
how i've already organized it and those
comments will really help you get back
up to speed if you come back to your
project a month later or anybody else
that's working with you they'll easily
find the section that they're looking
for
okay the third suggestion here is to
sort properties
and typically you sort those properties
alphabetically but this is not
everybody's choice some people prefer to
sort properties in their own groups that
they have
chosen and mdn has some suggestions for
that too so i'm going to put a link in
the resources to that mdn page that has
those other suggestions and also a link
to an article that discusses sorting
your css properties alphabetically now
that's not how we write them so i'm
going to show you what i do here in just
a second but i want to give you a memory
technique to remember this by sorting
alphabetically at least in the english
language we usually say that abc's which
would be our alphabet so just remember
abcss and that will help you remember
sort alphabetically so a b c
s s if you will okay i'll save the
markdown file now let me show you an
example of this and how to do this in
visual studio code typically in a small
project it's easy to find these and
really i don't sort them so you can see
i have margin padding and box sizing now
if i did this alphabetically box sizing
would be on top but that's not how i
write css it's not what i'm thinking of
when i write the properties like if i
create a flexbox for example and we'll
see that as we get down here to the body
i have these properties i had display
flex and then flex flow justify content
and then align items well that starts
with a but i don't think of it in that
order i would write my css in this order
but then to sort it alphabetically say
when i'm done if i'm working with others
and or i want to come back to the
project later and of course just find
the properties easily select all of
these properties
and then control p now i'm on windows
that may be a little different on mac
but control p to open up the command
palette in visual studio code and then
the greater than symbol and type the
word sort you can see it shows mine says
recently used sort lines ascending but
you may not have that so type the word
sort and then you'll see the different
sort choices choose sort lines ascending
and you can see it sorted these
alphabetically for me so sort lines
ascending is what you want from the
command palette now they're sorted and i
know what property say the specific
property i'm looking for maybe align
items it's right at the top or gap i
know it's going to be right here
alphabetically
likewise this helps you find issues say
you had a second
gap or a second
min height or display just you
accidentally put the property in twice
and one was defeating the other due to
the cascade well you would find it when
you sorted because then it would say put
both displays on lines right beside each
other so you would find those issues so
sorting alphabetically the abcss is a
good way to go now i'm going to press
ctrl z to undo that because i'm going to
come back and change this in a little
bit and once again i'm thinking about
these flex properties especially justify
content and align items in that order
and i know right where to find those
again small projects it's much easier to
just leave it this way
okay back in the markdown here's the big
one that we're going to spend most of
our time on today and this is for larger
projects you wouldn't typically do this
in a small project but on a team larger
projects they usually have a naming
convention
methodology so i'll put
follow a
naming
convention
methodology if i could spell that right
there we go
methodology and a very popular naming
convention methodology
is b e m which stands for block element
modifier so block
element
modifier there we go so there are others
this is just a popular one so i want to
go over
this popular version and of course your
team may not use this they this may not
be the one you adopt going forward but
do know it exists and know that it is
used a lot so you may see it out there
in code example so now let's go back to
our code
and besides what we have here we start
with a block here at the bottom so you
can see i've defined a button class now
typically even frameworks and libraries
that you may learn later to work with on
larger projects will apply classes to
put most of the styles on the page and
you can see other than the html and the
body i'm really starting out here with
the class and now above i have a utility
class here and some variables but other
than that just here in the reset i had
of course the button and i might put an
image here and set the display to block
or anything else i'd want to do in the
reset but after i get past the big
elements of html and body i'm probably
going to use classes and these naming
conventions other frameworks and
libraries that have been built by third
parties those usually apply classes as
well so we start out with a block
and here it is also it says aka
components you may hear some people
refer to these as components instead of
blocks but they're talking about the
same thing now this has a semantic
meaning it's important it's saying we're
defining a button so the button has a
width of 100 a height of 100 pixels both
and a border radius of 15. this is our
basic button style that we want to use
on the page and when we go to our html
we see three buttons and they all have
that class button and of course they can
have different content but then we get
to the next part of block element
modifier methodology and we're first
going to look at the modifiers i'm going
to scroll for a little more room here
and i'll get that just right up to the
top of the page and underneath i'm going
to paste in some code and we can see
those changes but notice what i've done
i've i put another
comment here that says modifiers now
this isn't something you would need to
do in your code i am just identifying
these for you for the tutorial but what
modifiers are about
are about incremental style changes so
here we're going to have blocks with
modifiers so our button is the block
and then we have two dashes not one if
we were to name something
we might have two words in the name and
we could put one dash in between and
this is why bem uses two dashes and
later we'll see two underlines but these
two dashes indicate that this is going
to be a modifier and then you can see
i've got the name secondary
the other one i've got the name lean and
the third one i've got border and here
you see a name that has
one dash in it so border and then lg
stands for large so a large border so
these are incremental changes we can
make to the blocks with modifiers now we
don't replace what we previously had the
button class we add this in addition in
our code so for example here on our
second button
we could put
btn-secondary
[Music]
and i'll save once i spell secondary
correctly and now you can see we have a
yellow button notice in the html we've
applied both the button class and the
button secondary class likewise on the
third button we could put our button
dash dash
lean
and now we have applied that modifier as
well to our block so our button lean
modifier and the third button here is
leaning and i believe we had another one
let me look back yep
border large so we could apply another
class you can apply as many as you want
to so we have button dash dash
and then we said border dash
large and save
and of course now it's outlined in white
so it's a little harder to see than what
we had with the black border before but
we'll change that here in the future but
it did of course make it a little harder
to see right now i could press alt z so
that wraps well it didn't there it is
it's already wrapping it just wrapped on
part of that closing element but there
we've applied
modifiers to the blocks and these
modifiers have provided incremental
changes to our more important semantic
blocks our buttons and those are the
starting styles that we want and then of
course we can modify them with each
class that we apply okay let's move on
to elements now but before we do that i
need to add some html over here we're
going to turn our three buttons into a
header so i just need to add the rest of
the header so i'll type header and add a
class of header to start out but that
closing header tag is going to need to
come after all of our buttons as well
so we'll add that much and save and you
can see the changes will be over here to
the right
after that i'm going to add an h1
and it's going to have a different class
so it's going to have header two
underscores
and then title
and there we go and then for the title
i'll just put b-e-m for our block
element modifier lesson and save that
much now we see bem on the page
after that i'm going to add a nav that
will be wrapped around these buttons and
it's going to have a class also that is
header two underscores and nav and of
course i need to put the closing nav
after the buttons as well
and i can save now we could say we're
finished with this and apply some
classes but let me first describe what
i'm doing here so you can see
our component is the header it is the
important semantic element
and now what's within it depends upon
the header so we have a header with two
underscores and then a title this is the
element the e in bem the block element
modifier methodology
and then we also have another element
that is dependent on the header and that
is the nav
now inside here we could say
are these buttons dependent on the
header or not because if we have a
button style we're using throughout our
site and not just in the header
we would want to leave this as it is
because this would be important so we
don't have to redefine the same button
style somewhere else however if these
are buttons that we're designing a
specific way
just for the header then they would
become dependent on that header and if
that was the case then we would say
header
two underscores
button and of course we would change
everything else here so i'm going to
select one button
and then ctrl d to get the next
and the next and there's one more there
i've got all five of them now
and now i'll arrow to the left and i'll
put header
two underscores
and save and you can see we've changed
each one of those classes now because
they are dependent on the header it's
also important to note that this does
not display the structure so you might
think you need to put header two
underscores then nav and two underscores
and then button that is not the case you
only wanna start out with the major
component the block name the b here so
header
two underscores and then whatever the
actual element is so in this case it's a
button in this case it's a nav and in
this case well it's an h1 but we're
going to call it title because that
semantically makes more sense to me and
you can do that again there are no hard
and fast rules but if you're following
this pattern
the actual rules for the pattern are two
underscores and then element likewise
for the modifier two dashes and then the
modifier so i'm going to save these
changes and then let's go back and
modify the styles that we have over here
and include those elements as well so
there is our block section and we
actually need to include the header
itself now inside of our block so i'll
start here under our comments and say
header
then we're going to have a background
color and i'm going to say var and
change this to our
header color or background color that
was defined before so there's the b
after that we would also have a color
there we go color
and i'm going to put another var
two dashes and
choose
color
after that we're going to have some
padding i'm going to say one rim
on the top one rim on the left and right
and one half rim
on the bottom
we'll make this a display
of flex
flex
dash flow
whoops flex dash flow is going to be row
and no wrap
and then we'll justify content and we'll
say space dash
between
we'll save that we definitely see a
change but not everything we want yet
let's go up and remove some things from
the body all we really need to keep
are the first three properties let's get
rid of these bottom three
and we'll save that and we see a few
changes at the top not exactly
everything we want yet but we're getting
closer and i think i see i forgot the
word header on the color so if i put
that
should change those to white letters
that looks a little better as well and
now let's add an element section that
i'm going to put right after our button
class and i'll just put the comments
there it looks like it's wrapping here
but what i wanted to add along with just
the elements editor is
the comment no standalone meaning in
other words they're semantically tied to
the block they are dependent upon that
block so it's not just a button it's
going to be the header button style and
likewise it does not represent the
structure so what we do not want
is the header underscore two underscores
nav to underscores button you would not
want that you would just want header
underscore button and i don't know why i
have the period there looks well that's
weird i'll control z to change that
again maybe that's marking something
let's see if i can just back up one
not
header nav underscore button and save
okay i've got the comments there now i
actually need to put in the style well
it's going to be the same as the button
so i'll just copy this
control x to move it down put it
underneath
and paste it in but we're going to
change this now to our
header to underscores and button now we
have our button style back in place for
the header but we don't have any of the
modifiers in place that we applied to
the html so i'm going to select
all three instances of the dot btn here
arrow to the left
one arrow to the right and type header
two underscores and now they should once
again be applied and we can see that so
we have the yellow background here
and we also have the leaning button here
on the third one let's check that border
large maybe we just need to change that
color to see it better or we could apply
another class that would help us see it
better so besides
the button
lean and border large let's go ahead and
apply the
header to underscore
button dash dash
secondary to this third button as well
and now we can see the yellow color here
and then we see the white border as well
notice there is a space between each
class that we apply to these elements in
the html okay jumping back to the style
now we have modifiers that are applied
to the elements instead of the blocks
you can apply a modifier to either one
but just know an element is going to
have the two underscores and of course a
block is just going to be the class
defined such as header or previously we
had dot btn for button now this all
helps with organization and like i said
when you're working on teams it's great
to have that document communicate what
you're working on as fast as possible
and follow the pattern of the team and
if you just have a large project on your
own this may help as well one other
thing this can help with and i want to
show this with the element section is
when we're selecting something
it's good to say a class like dot header
has a specificity of 10
and we've seen that with the specificity
calculator that should still be linked
in the course resources however if we
did this and then instead of using an
element selector such as bem which is a
class when it's all said and done this
is just a class a header two underscores
button instead of
header space button if we did this which
says the class and then the element
within the class or any button elements
within the class this has a specificity
of 11 instead of 10 it's much better to
keep that specificity even and using
classes like this helps you do that as
well so that is just an added bonus that
i wanted to go ahead and mention i hope
all of these suggestions help you
organize your css in the future and i
plan to use some of them coming up next
on the final project
welcome to the final project of this css
for beginners course at the end of my
html for beginners course we built a
full website for the little taco shop
that you see here
it's a basic website with very minimal
css applied but it provides a great
foundation for our css final project
we're going to take this basic html
website and turn it into
this modern website with responsive
design by applying much of what we've
learned about css
let's get started today by looking at
the starter code and this is available
in the course resources you'll want to
download this code because it is the
full website that we completed at the
end of my html for beginners course and
it will give us a great foundation for
this project now if you completed that
you already know what all is in the code
however if you hadn't let's quickly go
over it we have a few html pages and
we're going to make a few changes to
those not many though
and then we have an image folder img
inside this image folder i've included
some larger images today so we will be
able to delete the smaller images i left
those in as well though in case you
wanted to launch the project as it was
in the beginning as we finished it in
the html for beginners course but the
top names when you see the double names
they end with the dimensions and of
course the width on the smaller the
older images is 400 pixels
the width on the newer images is 1000
pixels and i've included those
dimensions in the file names so for the
duplicates you always want to choose the
one on top
and then i have a fourth image that does
not have a duplicate because we will add
one page today
but let's
select those duplicates and then i'm
going to press the delete key and now
we're left with just our larger images
likewise there was an examples folder
and this just gave us example images
of what the project looked like at the
end of that html course if you wanted to
complete the challenge at that point you
were welcome to try to look at these
images and complete that and then look
at my code so let's click that examples
folder and also press delete as we no
longer need those files now there is
very very minimal css applied to this
project so we will be cleaning out
everything that is in the css file you
can press ctrl a to select all and hit
backspace and delete those 19 lines of
css that did exist so that gets us
started now let's go to the index.html
which is the home page and we'll start
by looking at the head section the head
section contains all of the meta tags
that we would need in a project you can
see author and description however there
is one missing that we're going to have
to add but since we're creating another
new page and we're going to just include
the about content that is currently
in the index html we had an about
section we're just going to make that a
new page and abstract that just remove
it
from the index and put it in its own
page today so let's go ahead and do that
and then i'll show you what's missing
from the head section in all of the
pages we already have so let's click the
new file icon
then type well it looks like maybe i
already included it here before i
actually do that but you would want to
click the new file icon because the
about page would not be in the starter
code i guess i typed that in earlier but
now we have a blank html file i'm going
to type an exclamation mark which is an
image shortcut but if the shortcut
doesn't pop up for you you can press
control and the space bar and then you
should see the shortcut menu and select
this top
abbreviation
and this gives us the outline of a page
now there's a couple of things it
includes that we don't have in the other
html files from that html beginners
project one is this meta tag that has
xua compatible ie equals edge
they still include that with this image
shortcut but it's not really necessary
unless you're concerned about possibly
supporting internet explorer which at
this point
has been discontinued and for the most
part is no longer in use but you could
include that the one that i want to make
sure we include today is the next one
meta with the name equal to viewport
then the content is equal to width
equals device width and initial scale of
1.0 we absolutely need that meta tag in
the header of all of our html pages so
we can make them responsive so i'm going
to copy this and then i'll go back to
that index.html
and i'm just going to put it right
underneath the utf-8
that we have in the medic
care set which is character set here in
the head and of course we can remove
that space and save and then i'm going
to want to do that in the hours.html as
well
so i'll put that in get rid of the blank
line ctrl s to save
one more time in the contact dot html
and we'll put it right after the utf
dash eight line and save so now that
we've done that back here in our about
we could fill in all of these blank
things that we have or we could just
copy the pattern that we already have
inside of the index.html so i'm just
going to copy
the full head section here the entire
head element with the opening and
closing tags
go back to about
and then i'm going to select it here
and paste it in now i'll just change
some information now i can see some of
that's going off the screen so i'll
press alt z
and get that code to wrap so i can see
everything you'll want to change of
course my name in the author meta tag to
your name
and now for the description instead of
the official website here we would just
want
about the little taco shop
so this is the about page and that's
what we have and we could put the same
in the title about the little taco shop
everything else is pretty much as we
need it for now so i'll press ctrl s to
save that
and of course we see a little auto
formatting now where it included the
lines the spaces that you see here but
we'll just leave it as is and then we
will come back and get that information
or abstract that out of the index dot
html when we get to that point now
moving back to the index.html file i'm
going to scroll down and we have a
header section already clearly defined
but we can see it goes clear off the
page i don't have the closing tag here
yet however everything we see here is
really all i want in the header now we
had a figure here with an image but
we're going to pull that out of the
header and put it inside of its own
section so select everything from the
opening figure to the closing figure and
i press control x to cut
and then i'm going to backspace and
remove those spaces and then i'm going
to type
section and press tab and so i get a
closing tag as well
and then press return
or enter so i get a new line and then
i'm going to control v to paste that
figure in so now the section contains
the figure and the header contains the
nav and the h1 and i'm going to do that
on all of the pages
but and i'll remove that hr which was
the horizontal rule
however i want to apply some classes
here as well that will help us format
our css so before i make these changes
to the other pages let's apply those
classes in the final lesson before this
project we learned about the bem block
element modifier naming convention and
i'm going to use that sum today for each
section of the page so we'll start here
with a class and we're going to set this
equal to
header the same as the element name and
it will be the parent class for
everything inside so when we label the
h1
we'll say class
and here i'm going to say header two
underscores and h1
likewise for the nav we'll say class
equals and then we'll have header two
underscores
and nav
and when we get to the unordered list
we'll say class equals
and then we'll have header
two underscores if i could find that
underscore key again and then ul
but then i'm not going to apply classes
to the list items some may want to do
that and that would be okay this is a
small project and i don't have any plans
to put styles directly on these list
items so i can accomplish everything
we're doing today without doing that so
i'll leave that as is however we do need
to rearrange some of the menu so i'm
going to select this top list item for
about and press control x to cut it out
we'll leave the menu as the first
selection the second selection will be
the hours page the third will be the
contact.html
so at the bottom i'm going to paste in
the
what was the first list item it's now
the last list item but it will no longer
be an anchor tag that goes to part of
this page it's going to go to the
about.html page so we'll switch that
over
and we don't really need to have the
whole abbreviation here so i'm going to
remove that it was good to learn about
abbreviations in the html course but now
we'll just use the word about because
that pretty much sums it up likewise we
can change contact us to contact
and store hours can just simply be
changed to hours likewise our menu
can just be menu and that will still
indicate what these pages are all about
now let's scroll down to our section
that contains the figure and we're going
to call this a hero section it's the
part of the page after the header where
you usually see a large image or an
attention getter that's often referred
to as the hero section so let's give
this section a class
and we'll just set it equal to hero and
then inside we're going to put an h2
element that is not currently there so
we'll type h2 press tab and we can
complete the closing tag that way
now let's give this h2 a class equal to
hero two underscores and h2 and we're
going to put a welcome here that the
owner of the little taco shop wants us
to add and it's going to say
bien
benitos which i believe is saying
welcome in spanish as well so we'll just
have that h2 there and this won't be on
every page it's only going to be on the
home page after that we have some
changes to make to our figure itself now
the figure can just stay there as is so
really what needs to be changed is the
image and maybe applying a new class to
the fig caption so we're going to start
off with the image and it's still the
tacos and drink image but the dimensions
have changed so we just need to change
the name so it's going to be 1000 and
you can see vs code knows what's in our
image folder and it wants to help us
complete that the alt will stay the same
the alt attribute the title will stay
the same but now we need to go ahead and
supply the actual dimensions so we can
avoid that content layout shift
that may happen and that was discussed
previously in a lesson as well of course
we will be styling this image to be a
responsive image too
and then we're going to give the fig
caption a class while we're here and
this class is going to be off screen
and what that does if you remember when
we had covered that in a previous lesson
is it will take this caption
off the screen but it will leave it
available for screen readers for
accessibility so that is important as
well so it won't be viewable but it will
be readable and now we need to structure
these top two sections the header and
the hero section in all of the other
html files as well so we have a good
foundation before we start in on the css
so i'm going to scroll up for now
and select
this header on line 15 and scroll all
the way down to line 44 where the
section ends i'll hold down the shift
key and click my mouse
select all of that because right now our
about.html does not have any of this
content so i'll press ctrl c to copy
and now i'll go to the
about.html page
and inside the body element i'm going to
paste all of that in now it will
currently be the same as we have on the
index page but we can make some changes
here and the first change we're going to
make is to select this last list item
and control x to remove it from the
bottom of the list and it will now go
once again
at the top of the list so ctrl v to
paste but it's not going to go to the
about page we just want to put in a
slash which means it will be the root
page that will take us back to the home
page so we'll type home there
and then the next one should go to not
just
hashtag menu because that means it would
be on the same page it should go to the
home page which is the slash and then
hashtag menu and that will take
the
visitor back to not only the home page
but then to that particular spot on the
home page which is the menu so now we've
completed or adjusted the menu
for our about page but then we also need
to change this header so instead of
welcome to the little taco shop let's
just put
little taco shop at the top of our about
here
and then after that we can scroll down
and change our hero section just a
little bit as well so we're not going to
have the h2 bian benitos on
the about page we're just going to have
the figure and this is going to be a
different
image here so this one will take the
last part of this image file because
this is named taco delicioso tacos
delicioso if i could pronounce that
correctly and then we'll have a
different caption here as well which
should say
tacos
delicioso
i could double check my spelling on that
as well
and let me go ahead and check the title
tag the title is basically the same so
i'll copy that but we'll put an
exclamation mark in there because the
title and the alt do not have to be the
same the dimensions are the same 1000 by
667 we're once again going to have a
class of off screen on the fig caption
but the caption should be different so
this will be try these
delicious
tacos and we can save and now we have
the header
and the hero section complete
on the about page so now we can make the
same similar changes to the other two
pages we have but we won't need to paste
in the content we really already have it
there so let's go to the hours page
and we can scroll down
and look at that menu and what we're
going to have to do is apply those
classes once again but we essentially
already have the menu that we're going
to need to have on the hours page we're
already linking to home
however the next one should be menu so
let's cut out that about with the
control x
and we will link to the home page and
then the hashtag menu
and then we'll have hours after that i'm
sorry we won't have hours after that
we're on the hours page we're going to
have contact and then we'll have the
about page which once again
needs to remove the slash in the hashtag
and we'll say about
dot html
and alt z to wrap this code because we
no longer need the about lts it will
just be about and then we'll make those
similar changes here no longer contact
us it will be contact no longer our menu
it will just be menu
and then home so we can save now let's
scroll down and we'll take that figure
once again ctrl x to remove it
and then underneath the header
create just a little space i'll
highlight that hr to remove it we'll
type
section and now in the section we'll
paste in our figure
and then i'll give just a empty line
after the section and we're now ready to
apply the classes as we expect to have
them here on the hours page as well or
we i guess we could go ahead and change
the details on the figure it's going to
be tacos tray again but it's going to be
1000 by 667 i believe but let's check
this because vs code will help us so
tacos tray there we go 1000 by 667
and then the rest of this won't change
except the dimensions so 1000 by 667
and then the fig caption once again is
going to need that class
equal to
off screen
there we go now we need to add the class
up above which is hero
and save now let's go ahead and scroll
up and we'll apply those header classes
once again at the top for the hours page
so we have
class equals
header and then i'm just going to copy
this to save just a little time
paste it into the h1 paste it into the
nav and paste it into the ul
and now this first one is going to be
two underscores in h1 the next one is
going to be two underscores and nav and
the last one is going to be two
underscores and ul and now we've added
the classes we need one more time let's
make those same changes to the contact
page now so our starter will be the
header with a class of header the h1
will then have a class of header
two underscores in h1
the nav will have the class of
net our header two underscores and nav
and the unordered list will have a class
of header
two underscores and ul for an ordered
list looks like i put some extra spaces
in there i'll remove but we've applied
the class to the header let's look and
see if we have the menu in the order
that we want it as well so we want to
start with home and then about is okay
but once again it needs to be to the
about page here so we'll say about
dot html
and we're going to remove the
abbreviation alt z to just wrap that
code so we can see it all remove the
abbreviation so it's just an about link
which we will select with control x then
and remove
and put it at the bottom of the list
and the second one should be menu which
is where we really want customers to go
then hours
and about there so that is in the
correct order we'll remove the extra
wording so we just have menu
hours and about and save and now finally
one more figure to remove to put in its
own section element so highlight that
control x to remove it
we'll leave the header to itself i'll
delete that horizontal rule element
then above here we'll add the section
element inside we'll go ahead and add
the figure the section will be a class
equal to
hero
and then here we have tacos close up so
this is going to change as well so we'll
say tacos now we've got close up 1000 by
649 which is just a little different so
delete that and now the height here is
6.49
the fig caption once again gets the
class
equal to
off screen and save and now we are
finally ready to write some css and what
we're going to do at the top is what
you've seen me do at a lot in a lot of
different tutorials and that is import
some fonts from google i'm going to
control b so you can see this full line
for just a second
and notice i'm importing two fonts here
so after the url you see family equals
and there's fugaz one and then there's
also nunito that you've seen me use in
several tutorials using both of those
fonts today and if you remember from the
typography lesson of how we can go get
those fonts from fonts.google.com
you can do that and then import those
into your css as i have after that we're
going to have a css reset it will be
fairly minimal
and you have seen minimal ones
throughout some of the lessons but let's
go ahead and label our sections as we
create our style sheet today it's going
to start out with the everything
selector the all selector but then a
couple that you may not have seen that
are commonly in resets that i did not
add in the lesson on sudo elements but
you see these pseudo elements so you
also see the all selector with the after
and the all selector
with before so we're going to do that
for all of those
and then we'll put in what you typically
see me put the margin
zero padding of zero
and then a box sizing of border box now
that's not all of the reset that i want
to use today but that's a great start we
also need to put something in for the
images and this will make all of the
images display block which gets rid of
that minimal little space below the
images that they were originally
designed to be in line so they have that
little spacing problem and that will
remove that then we'll set the max width
to 100
and we'll set the height to auto and
this will make the images responsive for
our project
i'm going to ctrl s to save that much
and then scroll just a little bit
there's a few more styles to add to this
reset
the
form elements like input text area and
button for example the ones that we're
going to use today so we'll say input
button
text area all three of these and other
form elements that you may use do not
inherit font properties
like other elements do so we need to say
font
inherit if we want that to happen and
when i save we'll probably see them
formatted yep on three separate lines
there but that is the end of my reset
for this project
okay after that i'm going to add another
section and this is where i will define
css variables now i'll define these as i
need them and then be able to come back
and reference them so i'll just say
variables here
and then as you know that starts in the
root selector so i'll just have a
selector here and then inside i'm going
to have some labels too and the first
one that we will do today is font and i
know what i'm already going to do for
font so i can at least add one variable
now and that will be ff for font family
and the main one that i'm going to use
is that
nanito font and then after that i'm
going to have the fallback of sans serif
and then for the headings on the project
is where i'm going to use the other font
so i'll say font family headings and
here i'm going to use
let me spell this correctly fugaz
and then it has a fallback of cursive
okay i can add just a few more variables
that i know i'm going to use right away
and the other one for fonts is the font
size so i'll just call that fs and i'm
going to use the clamp function that we
learned about so the font can grow and
shrink and this is modern css this helps
us
prevent adding it prevents us or keeps
us from adding
many media queries as some older css
might have done so our page can stay
more responsive without having an
abundance of media queries attached to
it
so our minimum size today will be one
rem
and then we'll allow it to grow
at 2.2
viewport units based on the height
and then the max size would be 1.5 rent
that's what we'll put in and so that
will allow the font to grow as the page
gets larger and of course it will stop
so it doesn't get any smaller than one
rim okay after these fonts variables i'm
also going to put in another
note here for colors i like to define
all of the colors
in variables and that way i can just
change them in one spot and see how they
work together i will be coming back to
add more colors here but i'm going to
start off with a background color and i
just want a basic
orange it's going to match something
that's in the photo that we have
and i think that's going to look good
then i'm also going to use a background
color dash
fade and that's because we're going to
use a linear gradient now i've picked
out this color it is a
fade of the orange color so i'm using
rgb and that's 2 5 2 2 two zero
one six zero
and you'll see it's a faded orange
after that
i'm going to use background image to
create this gradient that we're going to
fade with
so here i'll say
linear gradient
and then we'll go to the bottom
and then we'll put in our variables that
we just created above so we'll start
with the background color
and after the background color we'll put
a comma
another variable
and we'll start in and we'll go to the
background color fade so we'll start at
the top with the full orange and we'll
fade down to that faded color
okay that's looking like a pretty good
start but i could put in just a couple
more for the body so
just underneath this i'm going to put in
two dashes
and
body dash
background color so i'm planning on a
different background color for the body
element than i am the html element and
you'll see how that works here i'm just
going to put in a basic white with
hexadecimal code
and it looks like i left out the
semicolon over there there we go so now
everything formats better
and then we'll just have our standard
font color i don't even need to say body
font color it's going to be the main
font color
and this will just be a black with
hexadecimal code as well okay i will be
coming back to add more variables but
right now i want to move on to the next
section and just add a few
utility classes that i always use so i
know what i need to put here i'll put in
utility classes normally i would
probably just copy and paste these from
a file that i would already have written
them in before but we'll go ahead and
write these out we've got our
off-screen class and this is a style i
use to move elements off the screen but
yet keep in the document flow so a
screen reader will still read the
content but maybe i don't want them to
appear visually on the page so i'm going
to say
position
and we'll set that to absolute
and then i'll say left and we'll say
minus 10 000 pixels so it will be way
off the page
the next class i need is no wrap and
this is when i want to ensure that some
of the text does not wrap in an area
that is awkward and we can do that with
the white space property and then we'll
just set that to no wrap and we'll see
how we apply that class later and the
final one is simply a center when i want
to center text that say in a paragraph
or in a heading we need the
text align and we can set that to center
with the utility styles complete we're
now ready to finally start applying some
styles directly to elements and classes
so i'm going to bring vs code to the
left and go ahead and launch the project
to the right now remember we removed the
few styles that did exist
and everything we've created so far
really doesn't apply to the page except
for that reset at the beginning so we
have removed more than we have added to
the current project but we now have
variables ready to apply and utility
classes ready to apply but we also want
to add what i would call general styles
so let's put in a section here
and we'll
label this the same way we have the
other sections are in the same style
and now with our general styles heading
we'll start with the html element itself
now i'm going to use a different color
on the html element that will be the
background for the body element but if
you remember from some previous lessons
we also use scroll behavior on the html
element and we'll set this to smooth and
this allows a smooth transition to when
we
link to other parts of the page and
we'll still be doing that on the home
page this index.html
when we go to the menu that will be
located
below the big image and so in the second
half of the page so we'll have scroll
behavior smooth
and if i save that you won't see any
changes to the page because that affects
more of a behavior but i'm going to try
to save after every property applied so
you can see those changes the next one
we'll apply is font size and we'll use a
variable for font size that we already
created
and now when i apply that we'll save and
you see the font size instantly got
larger and that reminds me earlier when
i applied the font size variable above i
believe or that was in the background
color fade let me bring this back to
full screen quickly because i think it's
in the linear gradient
vs code tried to help me out and it
accidentally added a second var to each
of these that should have been noted
when the video was created as well so
hopefully you've already caught that
error but i need to correct it here so
now we just want one bar each in that
linear gradient and we'll save and if we
come back now to the page
we don't see a difference yet because
that's not applied but it will be
applied here very soon so down here in
the general styles once again in the
html we have increased the font size now
let's say font
family
and we'll use the other variable we
created there which was ff
and if i save again we should see the
font family has changed and it does for
the page
after that we're going to set a
background color
and this will be a variable as well and
it's the bg color we see here in the
list and i just want to make sure vs
code doesn't add a second var
now you can see we've changed to that
orange that we set but now this is
actually the fallback because we're
going to use the background
dash image
and here we're going to use that
background image variable we created
and we'll find that here in the list as
well and save and now we should see it
go from orange to that lighter orange as
we scroll down the screen and that's
what happens so it's a linear gradient
from a full orange to a lighter orange
but this will change as well as we apply
some styles to the body so we'll see how
this is going to be applied to the
overall page now here we're going to
have a background dash color as well and
this is the variable
and here we started this with body so
it's the body background color
and now we'll go to the next line and
save i can see this is wrapping just a
little bit so i'm going to press alt z
so anytime it wraps it'll just go down
to the next line for us so we can see
everything
okay now we want to set a font color now
currently you notice it changed
everything because the body is
completely over the html element that
will change when we adjust the width of
the body as well but for now we'll just
see white again so now the color for the
font will be
variable and this will be the font color
variable that we set
and really we shouldn't see a change
because it's basically the default font
color of black
now let's have a min height for the body
and we'll set that to 100 viewport units
of height
and if i save we shouldn't see much of a
change because it's already taking up
over 100 viewport units of height
already
after that we'll set a max width
to 800 pixels now i'm not sure of the
width here to the left but we can see
really 800 pixels is still within the
range of this so let's drag this over
and look at the full page expanded now
and now we can see here was the 800
pixels and now we see the html element
behind that goes ahead and expands to
the full width of whatever
viewport is available so we see that
orange that linear gradient fade here we
will change this so the body will be in
the middle and we'll see orange to the
left and the right
i'll move this back to the right for now
and now underneath this we need to
define a couple more things one is going
to be the margin for the body zero on
the top and bottom but auto on the left
and right will center this so when i
save again we don't see the change here
but when i drag this over we now see the
body is centered bringing this back to
the right we want to add some borders a
border on the left and the right so i
need to set a borders variable and a
border color variable so i'm going to
scroll back up here to the colors
and let's set this border color variable
first so we'll say border
dash color
and this is going to be a flat black so
333 for the hexadecimal you can see it's
a flatter black compared to the true
black that's above it here with zero
zero zero then i'm going to put in
another comment here and just put
borders some might put the border color
under borders but i want all of the
colors grouped together so that's just
my preference
now here four borders let's go ahead
and set this borders variable that we
might use more than once in our project
as well
and this is going to be
one pixel
solid
and now let's go ahead and use the
borders color variable that we created
now vs code once again put in
two vars so i have to watch out for that
when i've already typed var sometimes it
wants to insert that for me okay we've
created a border color variable and a
borders variable we'll scroll back down
to the body element
and to finish out the body element we're
going to say
border left
we're going to set this to
borders
and now i'm going to press shift alt and
the down arrow so it just copies that
down because i also want a border
dash right but i don't want it on the
top or the bottom and then i'm going to
set well let me go ahead and save and if
i bring this over you can probably see
the borders
just barely outlining the left and the
right
but now i want to set a box shadow as
well on the body
and that will be 0 0
so what we would typically see for the x
and y but then there's a blur and i'll
set that to 10 pixels
and i'll use that border color again
there we go
and
save
and now of course we can't see it here
but when i drag this back over we can
see there's a little bit of blur
along each side and that's what we want
just a nice subtle effect so as we
scroll the page and we'll see it stand
out even more on this lighter orange at
the bottom you can see the blur
along the left and the right of the body
here where we have our center column
okay dragging this back i'm going to
scroll for some more room and then we
have just a few more general styles to
apply before we get to classes and the
different sections of the page let's
have our and i'll want lower case here
h1 h2 and h3 headings on the page
we're going to apply the font family
which was for the headings so that's
dash dash ff and then we'll select
headings
and that will change
the headings font you can see that
change on the page immediately and then
we're going to apply some letter spacing
now we could do this with pixels or
different values i'm going to use ems
which would essentially be the same
as referring to the font size that's
already on each heading so the spacing
will vary
based on which type of heading that it
is
and if we looked at this as a rim
instead of an em
then it would be one tenth of that
setting so what we have for the font
size already at the smallest was one rim
but at the largest it was one and a half
so that could be anywhere from 16 pixels
to 24 pixels so one tenth of that would
be anywhere from 1.6 pixels to 2.4
pixels but this will just space out this
font i think this heading font
needs just a little extra space so when
we save you can see the letters have now
spaced out just a little bit more
now i'll select the h2 and the h3 but
not the h1 we have a couple of styles we
want to apply here so we have a margin
dash
bottom
so on the bottom only we'll set that to
1 m
and now we're going to use a separate
color so i need to define a highlight
color up above in the variables again so
here we have
dash dash and i'll say highlight dash
color because we might highlight other
things on the page besides headers with
this variable as well so i called it
highlight color it's a color i've picked
out to go with the orange but it's not
orange it's 51
178 51
and save and you can see it's a green
color much like we'd see here on the
bottle of giarito's
over here this mandarin has a nice
orange but it also has a bit of a green
in the label so let's try that with the
highlight color as well so now using
this highlight color
and scrolling back down to the h2 and
the h3 we'll set the color here and
we'll be var
and we'll use
highlight color
now that we have that and saved we
should see that change on the page and
yes our bienvenidos
and about lts and taco trivia has all
changed as well as our menu and remember
this about section is going to get moved
to the about page we just haven't moved
it yet
okay after the h2 and the h3
i'm going to select the paragraphs on
the page
and set their line height which this is
something i frequently do it looks a
little bit better
and
we'll just set it to a little bit larger
value it doesn't have to have a specific
m or ram or pixel here line height going
way back to our typography lesson can
just be a numerical value here so we've
set it to 1.5 you might not see much of
a change from that but there's a little
bit let me take it away
and save
and yeah you might see just a bit of a
change there but not a whole lot but i
like something i do like to add okay the
paragraph has the line height
let's look at our links on the page up
here so these are going to be our main
links
on the whole project really we don't
have a whole lot of extra links so i'm
going to select
the anchor which would be
a link of course you have to have an
href with it but just to select the link
itself and then we can say
any link which is a pseudo class
selector
and this any link pseudo class selector
if you remember selects both the
links that have not been clicked and
links that have already been visited and
so here we'll say color
and now we're going to need to set a
link color variable as well as hover and
active so i'm going to scroll back up
and find that colors list of variables
and we'll go ahead
and set the
link color variable link
dash color
this will just be a black color again
and then we'll set also
link
dash hover
and here we'll use hsla which will allow
us to
have a black color but then we'll also
have this transparency and i'm going to
say
0.6 so it's 40 percent transparent
and 60
visible essentially
after the link hover variable we'll also
set a link dash
active
and for that we're going to set it to
orange which is the same as that html
background
let's save those three variables and
scroll back to our links that we're
styling and here for link color we'll
say var and then dash dash
link and it is our link color that we're
selecting
and then the next one we'll have would
be the anchor
with a hover
but then also let's say anchor and you
could say focus but here i'm going to
use focus
visible which the difference is
the focus might remain on the selected
element
however focus visible after it's used it
will change and it might not not make
much of a difference in this project but
it's something i've started to use more
and more instead of just using focus so
here i'm going to say color
var and we'll set this to once again
link but it's link hover
and we'll put the semicolon after that
as well we can save those changes we see
we've got black links here the hover of
course is already working so you can see
it fade now as we hover over each one of
those but then after both of those we
still need the active state as well so
we have the active pseudo class selector
and here we're going to say color
and not color with parentheses color and
then var
parentheses dash dash
link and it's going to be active there
we go
save and so now if we were actively
selecting a link so when i click on it
you can see it turns orange and menu is
still fairly small up here
but when i hold down the mouse button
the link turns orange and now our
general styles are finished for the
project so we are ready to move on to
the header section so i'll add a label
inside of our style sheet for the header
and then we will start applying styles
to the header section i'll scroll up so
this header is at the very top here
and well at the very top there we go and
then the first style will apply is now
to the header class because we started
using bem the block element modifier
naming convention when we get to the
sections and the first one we applied
that to was the header so we'll say
position
and we'll make the header a sticky
positioned element
we'll put the top at zero so it's at the
very top and then we need to put the z
index to a setting of one so it stays on
top of everything else that might scroll
under it and when i save
we don't see much of a change yet but we
certainly will soon
the next thing we'll style is the header
two underscores and the h1 so the title
of the page itself and here we're going
to say
text
align
and we'll set that to center and save
and you can see that text did center now
we've got just a few more variables to
add so i'm going to scroll back up to
the variables once again and we're at
the colors list and i'm going to add a
header dash bg color
and here we're going to set that
background color to black as well
after that we'll set a header dash color
and i'm going to set that to white
and then after the header color while
i'm here i'm going to go ahead and set a
nav
background color and set that to white
also so we've set three new colors there
then underneath the border section i'm
going to add another label and say
standard
padding
and i'm going to create a couple of
variables here so
padding let's say dash tb and that means
top bottom so you might want to
abbreviate that differently to
communicate that better i just happen to
use that abbreviation this time i'm
going to set this just a 0.25
em
and then the next one is
padding dash side not size but side so
on the left and the right and
differently here i want this to be 2.5
percent so total if i apply this to both
sides it will take up five percent of
the width i'm going to save that you
won't see a change applied because we
haven't applied any of these variables
yet and then while i'm here one more to
add will be a
standard margin
and underneath that we'll just say
margin variable and i'm going to use
clamp again here so
at the smallest it will be 1 em and then
we'll set it to 2.5 viewport height
units and then 1.5 em will be the
largest it would possibly be now that
this is for the top and the bottom on
the left and the right i'm going to set
it to zero so even though that wrapped
what we did was apply clamp to the first
value of the margin shorthand and then
we applied 0 to the second value which
would be the left and the right
okay with those variables defined now
let's scroll back down to that header
section where we were applying other
styles so we had the header and we were
at the header h1 i'm going to apply the
background color now so i'll say
background dash color
this will be var and then we'll have our
header background color that we could
select
and i'll save and we can see that change
now it is all black so we need to apply
a color
and this will be var as well two dashes
and header color
and now that we've selected that we will
save and now we can see welcome to the
little taco shop across the top once
again
after the color let's apply some padding
and we're using the shorthand here for
padding so we'll say var
two dashes and padding and this will be
top and bottom first and then we'll say
var
two dashes for
padding and this would be the padding on
the sides and we'll save and we got just
a little bit of padding now to apply
itself to the top and the bottom left
and the right
for the header it looks like i'm not
closing that out properly so put that
extra curly brace there we go and we're
finished with the header h1 now so now
let's move down to
header two underscores and nav
now for the nav we're going to have a
separate background color variable that
we created so var two dashes
and here it will say
nav background color
and now something to discuss quickly you
may be wondering why i created these
extra variables and yet some of them
have the same color values well i'm
specifically naming them so i know where
they apply and later on when we create a
dark mode they may vary more than they
are varying now in the light mode so
it's good to have that extra control and
extra labeling over these color
variables
okay now that i've applied that
background color let's add a
border i want lower case here border
dash bottom to our nav
and there i'm going to say var and apply
that
borders variable that we created so
there's borders
and i can save that and we now see a
line across the bottom here of the nav
because it's also within this header
element
and then after that border let's say
font dash weight we'll set that to bold
when we save we should see those links
change a little bit the font definitely
changed there
and what else can we apply let's say box
dash
shadow
0 for the x 6 pixels for the y
5 pixels for the blur but this is going
to be a shadow that looks like it's
coming straight down so then we'll also
set a minus 5 pixels
and that offsets that blur and then
we'll have
var and we'll set the color here to the
border dash
color and save
and now we get this nice little straight
down shadow underneath that bottom
border
of the nav the navigation but also
essentially the header itself and
finally we need to style the unordered
list so adding the
header to underscores unordered list
and here we'll start out with some
padding and i'll say var
dash dash
padding and this would be the top and
the bottom and then once again we'll say
var
hash dash padding and this would be the
side value
save that now you can see those dots for
the unordered list were brought back in
so we know we've added that extra
padding it has just a little more room
but now let's say list
style
type we'll set that to none which should
remove those dots beside each list item
now a display of flex and when i save
you'll see that change because it
instantly makes it a row by default
we'll say justify content
space
bash
evenly
and we'll save and now it spaces out
those items
and then let's add a gap
and let's call the gap one rim so
what we expect there and so we
definitely have
a
gap between those items even if they
were all squeezed together if the screen
got smaller and now a couple of quick
notes on the header before we move on
one is we did learn how to make an
animated mobile header but we're not
applying it to this project because it
would essentially be overkill we've just
got the four links
and four pages to the project and we can
easily link to those on mobile or in
desktop by just listing them out here on
the page so you don't always have to
apply everything you know how to do to
every project and i didn't want to do
that to this project and it's worth
noting why
also we previously had welcome to the
little taco shop across here but that's
really a lot so quickly i will open the
file tree
go to the index.html
and bring this back and let's scroll up
and find our h1
welcome to the little taco shop and
let's just remove the welcome to the
because what we really want is just
little taco shop across the top after
that we can go back to the file tree
once again select the css and hide the
file tree i know we're squeezing all the
code over here to half the screen so we
can see the page more often but when i
bring it back you'll find that it's not
wrapping and it may be a little easier
for you to read so if you're working on
it with me maybe you're just viewing the
code like this so you can see those
longer lines where we've used some
variables are not wrapping to a second
line now when i bring it over and look
at it like this
so i just wanted to show you that i'm
going to bring this back to the left and
now likewise we can bring the project
over and look at it in full screen as
well and you'll see it's coming together
a little bit better we've definitely got
some changes to make yet however this
has certainly helped and if we look at
the other pages since we put in that
work ahead of time to put in the correct
image
changes to the html to create those hero
sections
and of course apply the classes to the
header and the nav as well we see those
changes applied as we go to each page
already so we're making a lot of
progress we just have some more progress
yet to make so now i'll drag this back
to the right and we can begin the next
section and that next section is our
hero section so right underneath our
last header style we'll create a new
label and we'll call this the hero
section with the label
and for that we'll start out with our
hero class which if you remember is
applied to that section element and
we'll say it's position relative because
we're going to place something absolute
inside of that hero section as well
after that we have a hero h2 and if you
remember this is only
on the home page our index.html and that
is our bienvenidos welcome here so after
that we can go ahead and apply some
styles to that and the background dash
color
for that h2
is going to be a new variable i need to
create so let's scroll back up to this
color that will have in our variables
list once again there's all the colors
so at the bottom here we're going to
call this two dashes in hero dash color
and now this color is very much like our
highlight color so it's rgb
but then we also need
a transparency color here so we could
make this rgb a so we can have that
transparency and then this will be 0.75
and i don't need the extra parentheses
so that means it will be 75 viewable and
transparent so when we scroll back down
let's apply this to that hero background
color here so we'll say var
dash dash hero and there's the hero
color
after this hero color and i can save and
we're not seeing much of a change right
now but we will here in the future we'll
say a color and actually i'm realizing i
just labeled that wrong and i also need
a hero color but i also need a hero
background color so if i could label
those correctly in my mind it would
definitely help us out so let's go back
up here this should be the hero
background color that i just created
instead of the hero color so let's label
this
bg there we go underneath this we're
going to have a
hero dash color
and the hero color itself should just be
white once again for now okay now we
should apply these correctly you can see
when you get many colors it can be very
helpful to label those and think about
them in
a good order and i'm not always doing
that even when i do take all the other
precautions so now i've got a hero
background color for the background
color and here
this should be var
dash dash hero
color for the font and now save and
since it disappeared i think i may have
possibly applied something incorrectly
even now so let me shoot back up to the
top and take a second look at these hero
colors here and i see what i've done
wrong i have rbga instead of rgba so it
just takes one typo to set something off
rgba and now we should be good and we
have the green color there and you can
see our green background now for that h2
with the white lettering here at the top
and of course we're going to change this
some more if you remember when i
previewed the project at the beginning
we saw this is really an animated
drop down let's add some more styles to
this h2 before we approach the animation
so we'll say padding
and here we'll have 0.25
m and then 0.5 m on the left and the
right we save that we can see that extra
padding applied
letter spacing
and here let's give this a 0.1
rim so again just that 10 percent which
should space it out just a little bit
after the letter spacing let's say
text dash shadow
and so we can apply a shadow to this
lettering we'll say 2 pixels x offset 2
pixels y
5 pixels blur
and now let's use that border color
variable
that we have used in the past for
shadows and we save now that helps that
white stand out just a little bit it
lifts it up off of that green background
just a bit because of that shadow
now we need to say position
absolute
and we're going to move this to the top
and it's going to be
minus 100
pixels
and first let me save this before i move
it so you can see what changes it
instantly
makes it
an element that is not in the document
flow and a block element would of course
span the 100 width but now because it is
removed from that flow due to position
absolute it does not have 100 width as a
block element normally would okay now
let's go ahead and move it off the page
to start out when the page loads so this
would be minus
100 pixels but before i do that even i
guess i should show where we're going to
place it to the left and the left would
be 20 pixels this value will not change
so it's just moved in just a little bit
but now
the top will be minus 100 pixels and now
it should disappear
and it will disappear it has disappeared
but it will of course be animated and
drop down and reappear once we apply
that animation
and now we need to create the animation
itself and then we'll apply it so here
let's say at
keyframes as we learned in our animation
lesson
and let's say show welcome is the name
of our animation
we'll start out with a zero percent so
where it starts out at the very
beginning
we'll say the top is going to be minus
20 pixels instead of that minus 100
and now we'll transform we're going to
do two transforms we're going to have a
skew
and that will make that lean just a
little bit we'll say zero degrees
and then minus five degrees
after that we'll also have a scale y
and we'll set that to zero to start out
with
okay after the zero percent now let's
say at eighty percent
and this is where i like to give it just
a little bit more than it actually ends
up with so it gives it just a little bit
of extra movement or bounce so we'll say
the top is 30 pixels now will definitely
be visible
the transform it needs to start out
essentially with the skew again and
we're going to move the skew just a
little bit so i'm just going to copy
these so we can just change the values
inside
paste those in and so now instead of 0
degrees it's going to be 10 degrees here
we'll leave that at -5 degrees and the
scale instead of 0 is going to be
1.2
and now let's get our finishing values
at 100 for the animation
here this will be a top at 20 pixels
and then we'll once again have the
transform and i'm just going to copy
that down
and this would be a
minus 10 degrees and a minus five
degrees and then the scale is going to
be one instead of 1.2
and when i save you won't see anything
yet because we haven't applied the
animation but now let's go ahead and
apply that animation here so we'll say
animation
and this is the show
welcome animation
we'll make it take a half second to
complete we'll start with the ease in
and out transition
and let's give it a delay now i could
make this longer to be more dramatic but
let's give it say a
one second delay so we see the page load
and then we get a little welcome drop
down
and we'll use the forwards property here
which means it will keep the state
of when the animation ends so it will
remain visible as well let's save and
see what happens
there's our welcome now to see it again
we'll have to of course navigate away
and come back to the home page
but then we see our welcome drop down
that's a nice little animation to go
with our project now let's move this
over to a full screen
and of course this is how it appears
here but if i go ahead and press ctrl
shift and i or we were to right click
and choose inspect let's choose a mobile
device like the iphone 6 7 and 8 and
make sure it's still positioned
correctly i can go to a hundred percent
view we can see it a little bit better
let's reload
and there's our welcome so yes it's not
crowding into the image too much and
everything looks good it's always good
of course to check your mobile design as
you go and i've been leaving the screen
open so we can see everything but
typically i do design for the smallest
first and you do want to check this
along the way and we will continue to
check it so for now i'm going to go back
to full screen
and drag this back over to the right
with the animation complete i'm going to
drag vs code back over to full screen
now and we need to look at a couple of
sections in the html that are on every
page before we get to specifics about
each page and those remaining sections
are the main element and the footer
element so let's go to the footer of the
index html first
because i usually like to style that
after the header so once we get down to
the footer itself we can see we have
footer here with no class currently
let's go ahead and add the class of
footer as we did with the header before
and then let's also apply some classes
here to our copyright line so we have
copyright and then the html entity which
is the copyright symbol right here and
then we have the little taco shot well
we want to wrap this in some span
elements inside of this paragraph so
these lines do not break where we do not
expect them to we don't want the little
taco shop or we could just put little
taco shop we don't want this line to
break so let's put a span element here
and now of course it generates the
closing span element immediately i'll
put the closing paragraph
tag on a separate line and paste the
closing span afterwards i'm going to do
the same here too for copyright
i guess i need to create the element
instead of just typing span there we go
we can copy that
closing span and put it here so we've
wrapped both of these in span elements
now let's give them both the class
equal to no wrap one of those utility
classes we created that ensures
that this line will not break in the
middle of this content and this line
will not break in the middle of this
content
so that helps us by
ensuring this presents itself in the way
we want it to this will not
prevent it from being all on one line
but if we're on a smaller device and it
needs to wrap the lines it's going to
break where we want it to and not in the
middle of that content somewhere else
let me go ahead and remove that extra
line there
and then let's apply some styles to the
footer but we can also put this footer
in each of the html pages so after i
save the index and copy the footer i can
go to the hours page and i can replace
the footer that is here and we will not
need that hr that horizontal rule so
i'll highlight it as well just to remove
it when i paste that in let's do the
same for the contact page
and put that in here paste and save and
then we'll also need to do that in the
about page but if you remember the about
page doesn't have everything else yet so
it doesn't even have a main element that
we will be adding but let's save this
for now and now go back to the index now
that we've updated the html for the
footer let's do the same for the main
element and this will not take much at
all
right now we have a main element with no
class and as you can expect we'll put a
class equal
to main here
and then here we have an article that
has the id of about well this is going
to be moved to the about page so let's
select this full article here
down to the closing tag and then i'll
control x
i'll go to the about dot html
and this is going to go inside
of a main element that has the class of
main and you can see i created that with
the image shortcut by typing main dot
main and it instantly created the main
element that has a class of main
inside we'll paste that article which
will be the content inside of this main
element now i'll save this much and
we'll come back but now let's go back to
the index.html
where we need to label the article
that's inside of this main element so
i'm going to highlight that hr and
remove it as well
but now the article that's in here has
an id of menu but it also needs to have
some classes and the first class we're
going to apply here is going to be main
two underscores
article because each main element on
each of these index pages in the project
contains an article if not more than one
article so we will label that and we'll
make sure that this is the only article
that's inside the main and if it's not
we will need to change it but it looks
like it is and that's fine it contains
the menu which we will come back to as
well but those are the two main classes
that every html page in the project will
need so let's go to the hours now
scroll up to the main here and it looks
like it doesn't currently have an
article but we need to apply the class
equal
main and to stay consistent here let's
go ahead and add an article element to
this html page so we have article
i will go ahead and cut out the closing
tag and paste it above the closing main
tag and now let's give this the class
that is expected as well so it is
main two underscores
article
and save that now let's go to the
contact page
and here in the contact page you can see
we have two sections
and an h2 so let's go ahead and apply
the
class equal to main and let's change
these section elements to articles to
stay consistent with the rest of the
main content here and you can see we
have
a opening and closing and we have two
section elements so i'm going to press
ctrl d and i got the closing ctrl d
again to get the opening of the second
one and ctrl d one more time to get that
closing tag now i can just type article
once and it changed all of those
but now i need to select just the
opening article so i'm going to select
the full thing including the less than
and greater than sign ctrl d again and
it just selects the opening article of
the second one
the right arrow to get to the end the
left arrow wants to get just behind the
word article and now i can add a space
type class
and then set that equal
to main two underscores
and article and now this should be
applied to both so we've got it here on
the top article and we've got it on the
second article that is on the contact
page one other quick change to the
contact page is i want to put the our
location information above the contact
form so let's control x
and then just move up here above this
article
and paste in our other article so we've
just switched that information around so
now that our location information with
the telephone is on top and the contact
form is on bottom and finally let's go
to the about html and you can see we
have a class of main that we applied
already but now
let's apply the same class here that is
main two underscores and article and
save because i believe if i remember
correctly there was only one article for
this page as well so now we've made all
the adjustments for the main element and
the footer element on each of the html
pages let's select the
style.css file once again and pull our
code over to the left so we can see the
project on the right and now we can
continue to make some more changes after
we have styled the hero section we're
now ready for the footer section so i'm
going to put in a label in the style
sheet for footer
and now we can apply those styles with
the footer class
and here this is going to be
position
sticky as well as the header because we
want it to stay in place so the bottom
will be zero so that will put it
directly at the bottom
and i'll save that much and let's go
ahead and scroll so we can see the
footer down here it's our copyright with
copyright symbol and the little taco
shop
now let's go ahead and add a background
color
and this background color
will be the variable and we'll just
apply
the header background color so it stays
in sync with the header
and if i save yes it all turns black so
we need to of course apply the color
and this should be the header color as
well
and we can save that and now we see the
font is white they're on top of the
black background
let's apply some padding as it looks
pretty scrunched right now so we'll say
padding top and bottom we are using that
shorthand again so the next one would be
padding side
and now we'll go ahead and save that so
there's just a little extra padding
around that
now let's put text
align
and set that to center and save and so
now we can see our copyright with the
copyright symbol and the little taco
shop is centered and we have our footer
across the bottom it stays in place when
we scroll as does the header i'm going
to copy this heading we put in here for
the footer and then i'm going to scroll
up and put in a very similar heading for
the main element so i want all caps
again to make that change after that
let's directly style that main class
first
and speaking of copying it's going to
get the same padding that we had here so
i'll just copy that
and put that in for the main and when i
save we'll see we get a little extra
space here with our menu our menu is not
looking so great right now and it's one
of the last things we'll do so let's
start looking at some of these other
pages the hours look pretty good they
got just a little bit of extra space
from that padding or the about has a
little more information on it as well
and so we can see some of that there
let's go back to the hours for now okay
after we've applied that basic padding
to the main element itself
we have the main
two underscore
article class
and here let's apply a scroll dash
margin dash top
and this will be 6.5 rims you usually
have to play around with this value to
see what works based on your project and
how much space possibly your nav is
taking up because what this is going to
do is enable the article information to
show instead of scrolling underneath the
header and then let's set a margin here
and we'll just use our var
and margin and save now this is
something we actually would see back on
the home page now if we choose menu and
it scrolls well we're not on a device
right now that would actually use up the
page or we haven't expanded this menu to
take up more room but what will happen
will
be it will prevent the menu from
scrolling underneath this header if we
have a taller menu or we're taking up
more room by the time we have finished
the styles that's probably what will
happen
okay a couple of extra things to put now
and one of these at least we'll see
differently on maybe the contact page
because it has some extra room here
already
so let's go ahead and apply these styles
let's say
main and we'll select the article as
well and now let's say the first
child pseudo selector
and we'll give this a margin dash top
of 1 em so this would be the first child
that we would see here the first article
and that would be the same on any page
it gives just a little more room between
that hero image and the rest
and now i'm going to copy this down so
shift alt and the down arrow
add the extra space and this will be for
the last child and we do have the one
page that has
two different children and that has the
our location and the contact form so for
this last child we want to calculate
some height here so
let's say min dash
height we're going to calculate
we'll take 100
vh which would be 100 width or 100
height pardon me of what is available
now let's just subtract 20
rims from that and save
to give it just a little extra room to
scroll and this might be more visible
when we don't have as much content such
as well the about page has some if we go
to the hours page
let's see now we have some extra room
here as well so if we remove this
and then save
we don't have that extra room it's kind
of scrunched it's nice to have that
extra scrolling room and that's why that
is being applied so again preference as
a lot of cs css is a preference
now we have just a little extra room
there for the scroll and now we're ready
to move on to individual page sections
i'm going to drag vs code back over to
full screen i'll scroll up here and
copy the main comment divider that we
have or label if you will
and here i'm going to switch this
to
about and save so we'll start in on our
about page in the about section i'm
going to do something different here
that some may agree with or may not
agree with with bem but i don't want to
refer to the main
as the parent for the about information
i want the word about there so we know
it's on the about page so i'm going to
add another class here
that is just called about and that goes
to the article so then what i refer to
inside of this article instead of
referencing main as the parent i'm going
to reference about it just makes more
sense to me for these classes in
particular and i've only got a couple to
apply but i want class
about and then i'm going to use two
underscores trivia
and then on the paragraph that has the
answer i'm going to say class
and then equals this will be about
answer so we have about trivia and about
answer and even better than that i think
i might put the word trivia here as well
so trivia dash answer it's just a two
word label but that makes more sense to
me as well so we've got about trivia and
about trivia answer and i did want
two underscores
there as well so there we go
now let's switch back to the style css
and put those classes in here
so we'll have our about two underscores
in trivia remember i put in about class
in there but i don't really have any
styles in addition to apply there i just
wanted to refer to that about class as
the parent
and so we'll leave it at that margin
will be that variable that we defined
for a margin
and then for the about trivia answer so
we'll have about two underscores trivia
dash answer
and here we're going to set a margin
dash top
equal to 1m and save let's pull this
over and see those changes applied to
the about so here we go
and see we've got a little extra space
here too which also helps our scroll and
then when we show the answer
that is nicely formatted as well moving
on to the contact form so i will focus
on that and let's scroll up to see this
content that we have on this page we
definitely have enough height here when
we have two different articles working
with forms can be difficult but let's
see how we can apply the styles here i'm
going to put in a new label in our style
sheet
and i will put
contact right here and then let's scroll
up to make that the very top of the page
and now let's start off with our
contact two underscores in h2 but i
don't believe we've applied these
classes yet so let's drag this over to
full screen
look at our contact page and see what
classes we need to apply to the rest of
this html i'm going to leave the address
as is it needs no further classes
however the contact form itself does and
i'm going to apply that same philosophy
that i did to the about page where i
have main article but i don't want to
refer to the main element as the parent
i want to refer to contact so i'm going
to put a contact class here at the
beginning for the article now for the h2
i'm going to put class and i'm going to
set that equal to contact two
underscores nh2
likewise for the form we can make this a
contact form so i'll put class
equals
contact two underscores and form we'll
do the same for the field set i'm going
to start copying this so i just have to
change the one word
and instead of contact form this would
be contact
field set
and now for the legend we're not going
to apply that class but we're just going
to put this off screen and we already
have a utility class for that so this
class will be
off screen
for the p here we'll go ahead and put in
this
contact form once again but we're just
going to change the word form
to p for paragraph and it looks like i
should have selected the full element
and then the next one as well and now
i'll arrow to the end one arrow to go
inside
and paste in this class and now i can
change
both at the same time and put in the p
for paragraph we'll save now we need to
do something similar
for the label so let's go ahead and
select all three of the labels
and then we can arrow to the end
paste in our class
and then once again arrow over
change form and change this to contact
label now let's do this for the inputs
so select the first one ctrl d and
there are only two inputs so that's all
we need arrow to the right
and paste in the class and then change
the contact form once again and i
shouldn't have done that but now i can
control d to select it as well
and then we have contact input as well
but now we're going to have a contact
text area so i just need to paste that
in and switch this
to text area
and i believe nope there's one more and
that would be the button and we have two
buttons so ctrl d to select the second
one
arrow to the right to be at the end
paste this in
and this class is contact button so ctrl
d to select both of those now that we've
applied all of the classes that we're
going to use in the form let's go back
to the style sheet and drag it back to
the left and we'll be looking at the
form here on the right for the h2 we're
simply going to set the margin to zero
and save that
now the field set and notice the label
of the field set is already gone because
we applied or the legend because we
applied that off screen so it no longer
had the contactless words here but we'll
put in
contact two underscores and field set
and this will be a border of none so it
will just remove that look even though
the field set is still there
after that contact two underscores
paragraph here we'll set a margin to one
m on the top and bottom zero on the left
and the right that gives us some more
space we can certainly tell that
difference
then the contact two underscores label
here we'll say display
of block
and font weight
of bold and we'll definitely see these
changes
makes our form look better as well
now we'll select both
the contact two underscores input
and the contact two underscores
text
area
for this we'll say padding is 0.5 m
you can save and we'll see some change
there the inputs got a little larger
then we'll say a border dash
radius of 15 pixels save and you can see
they're rounded i'm going to scroll now
that the form has grown a little larger
so we can see everything again
okay after the border radius we're going
to have a border dash
width of 2 pixels to just make it a
little larger around each of the inputs
and then a width of 100 percent and save
and now those inputs take up the full
width that they have available to them
our buttons down here still need a
little bit of help so let's say dot
contact two underscores
button
now we'll say padding
0.5 m for those and save we can see the
padding gets a little larger for those
now
and then we'll apply a border radius to
match the other border radius 15 pixels
and this should possibly be a variable
that i have not created but that would
allow us to just change it in one place
and it would change it for the form as
well as the button
underneath that we should have
border
width
and oh not border width on the buttons
i'm sorry let's have a background
color
let's say bar and let's pick that
highlight color so we can have a
different color on these buttons
that looks good except the font doesn't
look so great there so for the var let's
say the header color
and that should turn that white and make
it stand out just a little bit more
those buttons definitely look better
than they did before so a quick check
let's take the border radius property
and control c and then i'm going to do
control f to search for it and let's see
how many times it has occurred
it's just twice here inside of our
project so if you wanted to
you could absolutely make a contact
border radius
variable and then you would just change
it in one spot and of course the form
the inputs and the buttons would match
but you don't have to i did not clearly
at this point but that would be an
option so now before moving on to the
menu let's look at each section that
we've already styled for our page and
here's the full page so our about page
has a nice huge hero image
and we see the about lts some
information and our taco trivia that
looks good the hours page another nice
hero section and a simple bit of
information about the hours
and let's look at the
contact page
we scroll down we see the our location
information after the hero and the
contact form as well so that all looks
good i think the menu is still going to
need some work and we might apply
another style or two yet that we haven't
but we're making a lot of good progress
let's go ahead and ctrl shift i to see
how everything's looking in a mobile
device as well so maybe we could choose
fit to window and we see this iphone 6 7
and 8 let's look at the iphone
5 and that also looks good let's reload
and see how that animation works
that works as well so yes the menu needs
some help but how do the other
pages look oh the other pages still say
the little taco shop hours instead of
just little taco shop
or something similar and again we're on
the smallest device that we might ever
see right now which is the iphone 5 se
things may have changed in the future of
course if you're viewing this at a later
time so here
it wraps the two lines on the header but
anything larger than the absolute
smallest device it looks like it won't
as long as we adjust our headers here
instead of say the little taco shop
hours we can just say little taco shop
here it just says contact us
and on the about page once again it just
says little taco shop i think we want
our header to be consistent and say
little taco shop
no matter which page
we go to so let's go ahead and make
those changes as well in the html as we
go back to the code so i'm going to
close this back out
drag this back to the right
and bring the code over to the full
screen quickly going to each html page
we'll make sure that the heading matches
so it should just say
little taco shop where we have the
header h1 for each page
scroll to the top of the hours and we'll
see what we have here it says
the little taco shop hours so we'll go
ahead and remove
the and ours
save that file the contact page
said contact us well we would prefer it
still say
little
taco shop here and of course the h2s
will handle the other labels on the page
so
we had our location and below that we
should also have the contact form as
well there we go let's see what was here
yep our contact form so that looks good
and the about html
should also just say little taco shop
and it does and of course the titles of
the page say more about the page as well
so about the little taco shop here
the title at the top of this says
contact us lts i guess to keep
consistency we could say about lts on
this other page as we're going with that
abbreviation several places so
about lts there the description can
still say about the little taco shop
and then hours let's see what the
title is here lts hours that's great and
of course for the index we want the
title to be the little taco shop so
everything is looking good once again in
the html let's go back to the css and
start working on the menu now before
applying styles to the menu i want to
pull up an mdn reference so i'm just
going to paste this link in and i'll
make sure it is in the course materials
as well so the course resources but here
on the grid layout and accessibility
page in mdn it says grid and the dangers
of markup flattening so what we're going
to be doing is taking the html table
that's in the index page that comprises
the menu that is displayed and we're
going to make it a grid
too often
many people just use div elements to
make their grid and a grid needs
that flat structure essentially for the
grid items so it can review or refer to
each grid item
in that regard because it's not going to
look at subgrid items subgrid is a
proposal they're discussing here but
it's not implemented as well so
we want to avoid that dangers i'm going
to pull the code back over and bring up
the index.html
and we can see our table and right now
the table is not flat notice how it has
parent
elements like the t head element and of
course table row elements and then
inside
we get the
th and td elements for those table cells
whether they're a header element or
they're just a table data element and so
grid doesn't work that way it needs flat
elements but we can still work with this
we don't want to remove the semantic
markup of a table to further illustrate
my point
instead of just having this here
underneath i'm going to paste in what
you might see a table constructed of for
a grid using divs
now this is a flattened markup table
essentially that would be applied to
grid and notice how i just used divs and
applied all of these classes
and this is what you do not want to do
but i guarantee you will probably see
this somewhere when a grid is applied
and you see a table on the page i'm
going to press ctrl z though because
this once again is not what we want to
do and you can tell by this markup
it is not flattened however there is a
solution for this and it is a display
setting that we can put in the css that
will help us convert
our table to a grid i'm going to drag
this back to the left so we can look at
one more web page and i will link to
this as well in the course resources and
it's the can i use web page and i'm
looking at display
contents
notice what it says about display
contents it causes an element's children
to appear as if they were the direct
children of the element's parent
essentially
that ignores that parent element and
that will flatten the elements for grid
to use without removing those elements
so we just need to put display contents
on some of these parent elements that
grid will not use it says this can be a
useful
or this can be useful when a wrapper
element should be ignored when using css
grid or similar layout techniques
and then when we scroll and look at
everything as far as how well it is
applied now let me pull this out to the
full page so we can see everything from
can i use
you can see it's got basically 95
percent acceptance here and we're not
going to worry about internet explorer
again and most every other major browser
is accepting that use here opera mini is
one that's not in uc browser for android
but chrome safari
safari on ios chrome for android we're
good in almost every major use case here
so i'm comfortable with using that as we
switch our html table over to a grid and
again i will link to both of those for
you back to our website here
back to the right and now i will pull
this back over to look at our code in a
full screen so we can get the ideas of
what we're doing with the table as i did
with the contact and about pages i
applied a separate class here to refer
to as the parent and i'm going to do the
same here it's going to be the menu
class
and then i will refer to these
again with bem notation but i'm going to
refer to menu as the parent so here
we're going to have a class i'm going to
set this equal to menu two underscores
and h2
for the our menu heading then the table
itself
say class and then menu two underscores
and container because this is going to
contain our menu for the caption for the
table
we'll use this class
and set this to off screen our utility
class once again as we will not want to
view this caption on the page but we do
want to retain it for accessibility now
we will be setting the table head and
the tr element the table body element
and the table foot element to that
display contents so grid actually
ignores those the content we want for
the grid and the content that we
actually want screen readers to read
will be inside of the th
and td elements so that's where we'll
apply the classes here so all of the
opening
th's that we have here i'm going to
select
three right there and we might even have
a fourth but i think we just want three
right now for the menu headers so
we'll take this over with the arrow to
the right and i'll say class
equals and this is going to be menu two
underscores and header now something
else i want to do here one thing i
noticed and i must have done this in the
html course as well so if you went
through that you can apply the scope
column to this first cell as well and
i'm not sure why i didn't before it
might have just been an oversight the
second thing is
we were looking once again at how to do
abbreviations in html but i want the
full word quantity here now so i'm going
to remove the abbreviation
and just have the word quantity in the
second th cell for the table
okay after we have got the menu headers
now we're going to have menu item
classes so we will come through here
and then whether it is the th or the td
in these other cells i'm going to make
it a menu item so i'm going to start off
with the remainder of these
table data cells
because there are several i'm pressing
ctrl d to get all of them selected
and i think that's going to be it nope
one more maybe there we go one more so
at the end of that i'll arrow to the
right i'll put class
and i'm going to set this equal to menu
two underscores and item okay scrolling
back up to where we have the crunchy and
then of course we have the soft label
down here we're going to apply classes
here as well i'll have a class
i'm going to set this equal to menu two
underscores item and then i want a
second class here that is just going to
be menu two underscores and cr for
crunchy as we'll need to refer to that
later for the grid possibly
and then for soft we're going to do the
same thing so it's going to be a class
equals menu two underscores item and
then menu two underscores sf for soft
and finally let's scroll down to the
very bottom where we have chips and
salsa it spans three columns so besides
menu item here i also want menu two
underscores
and cs and i believe i have now applied
all of the classes that i wanted to
apply for the menu itself one other
thing i am going to do while i'm here in
the html is remove this line break
and then we have a paragraph here and
i'm going to apply our utility class
of center
to this paragraph that has our back to
top link that should appear underneath
the table let's go back to our style
sheet and let's drag this to the left so
we can see changes applied to the table
now as we apply these styles i'll start
by scrolling up so we can start at the
very top of our available space and i'm
going to put in a label for the style
sheet for the menu
now underneath this the first thing i'm
going to do is select the t head element
the t body element
the t foot element
and the tr element and this is the only
table in the project so i feel safe
doing this without classes if it was a
larger project i might have made a
display contents class and then applied
this to each that class to each one of
these elements so here i'm going to say
display
contents it also
took those parents out of the flow so
now
even though they're still in the page it
made them all run into one line so we
will definitely see changes now as we
make the table
so or the grid i should say
let's create that menu container class
if you remember this is applied to the
table element itself so we'll say
display grid and if i save after each
change we should definitely see changes
as we go so now just by applying display
grid
it changed how that viewed after our
display contents
was applied now let's say grid dash
template dash
columns
and we're going to use the repeat
function
we want three columns
each with
one fragment so let's save now and we
once again see changes to that table
now let's go ahead and map out our grid
template
areas but we really haven't assigned any
specific classes like those that we
applied to crunchy or soft so it might
still look a little strange when we do
this
essentially though
we only need to assign
the labels to the ones that are going to
take up more than one grid square so
other in other words i can just kind of
create the other labels without
assigning them to elements so i'm going
to have hd1 hd2
and hd3 i won't end up assigning those
to classes at all
then i'm going to have cr
cr1 this is crunchy as you might guess
the abbreviation hd was for header and
then crunchy one price for one taco now
i'm just going to
ctrl alt
and the down arrow a couple of times
because one here is going to get changed
to
two and then one here is going to get
changed to three
okay after that let's create one line
here for soft so we'll have soft taco
soft one
and then
soft
one price
after that
shift alt down arrow shift alt down
arrow
select one control d change those to a
two select one control d change those to
a three
and save and so now we have the
crunchyrose and the soft rose and the
header so at the very end we're going to
have the chips and salsa row so cscs cs
because it had a row span of three
after that we have essentially mapped
out those grid areas it doesn't look
like we want it to yet though because we
haven't assigned
that crunchy label to the crunchy label
that we or class that we have and the
soft label to the soft class or the
chips and salsa label to that class so
we still need to add those
likewise let's go ahead and add a small
gap 0.1 em so as we discussed before
that could be as small as 1.6 pixels or
about as large as 2.4 depending on the
font size applied
then let's give a margin bottom of one
em as well now let's apply some of those
labels so our grid looks a little bit
better so we'll start out with the menu
two underscores cr for crunchy and here
we'll apply the grid area label of cr
when we save we don't see much of a
change yet but i hope to in the near
future
menu two underscores and sf for soft and
here we'll say grid area
sf
save again so we see a little bit more
of a change
and then we'll say
menu two underscores cs
this will be grid
area cs
and save we definitely have seen some
changes in the grid it's not what we
want yet but we're getting there let's
make the color
here a
var
dash dash
highlight
color for this
okay so we've got a chips and salsa that
is now green and then we'll say font
weight
bold as well and save that looks good
now let's go ahead and apply some of
this to the other areas as well so let's
say
menu two underscore cr and
menu two underscores sf
here i'm going to take these two and
maybe i should have organized this
differently on my thought pattern but i
want both of those there as well however
there's also some other styles so i want
a height
of 100
as it takes up some of that extra space
why is that not applying to crunchy i
may have to go back and see what i did
wrong there
but let's go ahead and say these are
also grids
and then we want to
place the content
center which is the point of making them
a grid so we could do that yes the
crunchy style is not being applied so we
have menu cr
and that is what needs to be applied
there let's go back and look at our
html
and see if that class was applied
properly
to the cr section oh it's just one
underscore it needs to be two
save and now
go back to style and bring this over and
now crunchy and soft both have that same
style and everything is aligned better
that makes more sense as to why it
wasn't coming together quite as quickly
as i expected and before we move on
let's see if we could apply this
differently now we still need the grid
area here for menu cs but we could
possibly remove these
and let's see if we could include
the dot menu to underscore cs without
really making something strange there i
think that's fine and it's a little more
efficient we aren't repeating those two
lines and now let's look at these
headers and we could possibly add those
in as well so one more comma and we'll
say menu two underscores header
and save and yes i think that style is
going to work out as well however we
still need menu to underscores header
because we want to add a border dash
bottom
to each of those so we'll say bar
and bring in our borders variable that
we have created
and save so now we have a border across
each one of those headings now let's
scroll for some more room and we're
going to select that menu header again
like it's fill menu two underscores
header and then we also want
menu two underscores item
now for both of these we want a width of
one hundred percent
and then we'll set a padding to one em
and let's put a
border
and then let's set medium
[Music]
ridge and we'll set the var equal to
border color there we go
and when we save that we've got borders
around everything so in that regard
maybe we could remove
that border bottom
and still be good and we save yes and it
looks the same so one was just
overriding the other and now let's
select just the menu items
and here we'll put a display of grid and
we will once again place the content
in the center and when we save that
looks good as well now we didn't apply
that above to the menu item where we set
the same grid and center because we also
really didn't want to apply these other
styles to those menu items we wanted to
keep them this separate color and not
have the font be bold but that's looking
pretty good right now as far as
converting this menu table and leaving
that semantic html in place we can apply
some final touches to this menu as well
but earlier when we were referencing the
border
dash radius property we said we were
only doing it twice
and therefore i didn't go ahead and
create a variable but now i want to use
it again and so now that i'm using it in
another place i definitely do want to
create that variable so i'm going to
scroll back up
to the variable section and underneath
borders
i'm going to create a
border dash radius variable
and just set that to 15 pixels so now
that i've created that we can use that
variable
in all of the places that we are
applying a border radius so now let's go
ahead and change
these two that currently exist to var
dash border
radius there we go
and save that so no other changes will
be made there but now we can apply these
final touches to our menu table as well
and we can use that border radius
property now i could apply classes to
the header and the footer but i'm not
and they are being ignored for some
things concerning the grid when we set
that to display contents however they
are still part of the document so we can
still use them for selectors so i'm
going to select the t head
and then the th inside of the t head and
say the first
child which should be the very first
cell that says tacos and here we're
going to set the border dash top
dash left
dash radius
and now we'll use our
border radius variable once again
and when we save we can see this now has
the border radius of 15 pixels
so likewise i'm going to just copy this
down so i don't have to retype
everything shift alt and the down arrow
this is going to be the t head th
last child and instead of the top left
it's going to be
the top right everything else should be
the same and now we see that same border
radius applied over here to the right
finally we have this one large chips and
salsa cell along the bottom of this
table for the menu
so here this will be the
t foot
and then we'll select the table data
cell inside here we can set the border
dash bottom dash left dash radius
and this will once again be var
two dashes border and use that border
radius variable
and once we save this we see
that applied to the left corner so it
just needs to be applied to the right
corner so inside this same
selector here for t foot td we can now
also
apply this
to the right corner and save and there
we have our rounded corners for our
table as well we're getting near the end
but there is a little more to do let's
go ahead and look at the page in full
screen or at the full site now and
here's our back to top we can click we
have the smooth scrolling that goes
there
we can go to the hours page everything
looks pretty good there
the contact form everything is good here
the about page and the trivia
that's all working well and our
animation shows here let's look by shift
control and the letter i to go into a
mobile view
notice how well our grid conforms it
automatically adapts we didn't have to
apply a media query the grid just works
in this mobile view and that's great
let's look at some other views here's a
little bit maybe larger phone there we
go so it is quite a bit larger it is the
iphone 6 7 8 plus
and there will size it down to 75
percent
let's go ahead and look at the iphone x
that gets taller so that should also
make our text just a little larger based
on how we used clamp with that
everything's still looking pretty good
the form
still adapts to the screen size the menu
looks good and it took us right to the
menu when i click the menu link the
about page
the hours
all is looking pretty good i think we
could apply possibly a little bit of
space or a class we might have to back
to the top that we applied
down here i think we at least centered
it so we might change something there
but overall it's good to just evaluate
your project and see how everything
looks to you as you go and you can tell
it's looking good on mobile as well so
let's go back to full screen view and
we're going to make just a couple of
changes there is one media query i would
like to apply to this project although
using modern css for the most part we've
been able to avoid media queries we are
going to put this media query at the
bottom of the page so we'll say at
media
and then we'll say screen
and now say min width
and we'll say
576 pixels which is our small break
point and that is similar to what
bootstrap uses the css library or
framework if you will
and here we have header
200 scores h1
now let's select the pseudo element here
and this is the before pseudo element
and we're going to set some content
on this h1 let's give a space and what i
want to do
is put a taco emoji in here and actually
i want to put the taco emoji and then
the space so we have a taco space and
then we have the heading as you might
expect i also want to do this
with the after so i will just copy that
down again shift alt and the down arrow
will switch before to
after
and now with the after
we want the space to come first and then
the taco so we've got taco space heading
space
taco so this should show up on any
screen that's larger than 576 pixels in
width so when we save
now we have tacos in the heading as well
and that's a great addition for the
little taco shop and it applies to all
the pages where we set up our classes
correctly but if we go to a smaller
screen
where we might not be able to fit all of
that in
they disappear and that is great too so
that only shows in larger viewports
let's go to an ipad
there we have the tacos so just mobile
it will not try to squeeze those tacos
in and that is fine let's drag this back
over we can apply just a little bit more
to the
media query as well and this is just
something i want to do for the
menu 200 scores header
then we're also going to have it in the
menu to underscore cr which was the
crunchy
menu two underscores sf which was the
soft
menu two underscore cs which was the
chips and salsa we're going to set the
font size to 125 percent so just a
little larger
on these larger screens for the headings
you really if you wanted to you could do
it to all of these but i just really
wanted to make the headings stand out
and so everything we've wrapped around
here that you see in green
has applied that larger font now just
another 25 larger than it was there is
one more media query to apply but it's
not based on the width it's based on the
preference of light and dark mode we
have styled our light mode this would be
our normal viewing for the website but
many prefer dark mode these days and
that includes myself so i definitely
like to add dark mode when the
preferences are set for that so if your
system preference is dark mode that's
what will display my system preference
is dark mode so i'm going to put this
media query directly under the variables
we defined so
it will be applied right away because
all it really does is change the
variables
for those colors that we're using on the
site so we'll say at media put our
parentheses then put prefers dash
color dash scheme
and here i'm going to say dark so that
is what my system is already set to so
anything we put in here we'll start to
overwrite what we already have for those
variables so we need the root pseudo
selector it's the pseudo class
and now let's overwrite
the background color
and this is going to be
black now we will not really see the
change here because we're not seeing
that orange color until we drag this
over to full screen so if i save
drag this over to the full screen now
you can see it's dark but it's still
fading to that light orange because we
haven't changed that other variable yet
either so let's change the
bg
color dash fade variable as well
and i'll just make that gray just like
my last name i'll save and now let's
drag this over once again you can see
it's fading to a gray instead of the
orange to a light orange
the next color we'll put in here will be
the header background color now we'll
start to see these changes so
header bg color
oh i'm sorry just header color not bg
color
let's make this
white smoke
and save
and then let's go ahead and change the
nav
i said color now i need background color
and by the way the white smoke i just
find that to be easier on my eyes than
the pure white that we've used in other
spots let's set this to
rgb
20 20
20 which is just a different shade of
black essentially and now you can see
that background color for the nav menu
definitely got darker
okay so we're going to have to change
that text eventually too
let's set the hero color and this is for
our little animated part that drops down
so our hero color is going to be a
different flat black now when it drops
down you can see that has also changed
now let's set the body background color
itself so this will be a big change when
we first see it that will also be this
flat black
and that has made a difference
now let's go to the font color itself
which is what's being used on most of
the page and we'll go with that
white smoke that's just a little easier
on the eyes than the pure bright white
and so let's find a page that's using
well here we see it inside of these
table cells here but if we go look at a
different page you can see it is being
used right here as well
okay after the font color
let's apply the
highlight color
and where this was that green let's use
white smoke here as well so when we save
i believe that's in the animation
and i'm not seeing that applied right
now i'm not seeing the animation because
i'm not on the right page here we go and
oh no it wasn't in the animation because
that has the separate uh background
color that is slightly transparent but
it is in some other areas like we were
using it for
the h2s and h3s and the table headings
so we can see that's now using white
smoke as well
okay now let's switch the
border color that's being used let's
also make that white smoke
now our table is standing out
and now that border color was a bit of
the shadow behind the lettering so now
we've got a little bit of white shadow
behind bienvenidos and that stands out
on that green as well helping the dark
lettering stand out and we still need to
change our link colors so
link dash color
we'll make that white smoke you can see
we're really making use of that color
for this setting
also say link hover is now going to be
orange
and then
link active
is going to be the lighter orange so rgb
252 200 103.
and save so now when we hover over a
link
it becomes orange
when i hold down it's a lighter orange
and then we go to hours
everything looks pretty good now you may
have your own preferences for dark mode
as well but just scan over the site see
how you think it looks does everything
look like you want it to oh these
buttons need a little bit of help yet
let's check our other page and make sure
everything else looks good and then we
might need to change something about
those buttons we'll have to see what is
going on there
and that might be a correction that
needs to be made in how they're
initially
being set as well so let's find
where we had a
button which was a contact button and
you can see the header color which
remained white or white smoke was being
used but then that highlight color was
the background and that has changed i
think we need to change this from header
color to button color and give us some
or give ourselves some control over what
color
is the text on top of the buttons so
we've added a button color variable now
we need to define that above and then of
course change it when it gets to dark
mode as well so we were fine with it at
first when it was the same as the header
color so that's what we'll start off
with and i believe that is just white so
we'll put that and also put it in as
white here but now we need to change
this when we get to dark mode so let's
bring this down into our dark mode
definitions
add this and let's change it to black
right here
and save now let's go ahead and go to
our contact page
scroll down and now we can see the text
on our buttons and so that looks good
the about page is looking good let's
make sure the answer looks good for
trivia that's fine here's an additional
link in our page
to the reference for the trivia
the menu we scroll right to that
everything looks good there
hours
pretty good i still might want to create
a little space here with the back to top
but other than that it's fine
and back to the home okay so we are down
to the final touches of the project so
one of those things might be to organize
the css now this is your own project but
if you're working in a team for example
you might want to organize that i'm
going to drag this over to full screen
for this discussion let's say the colors
we have here there's there's probably
the largest list that we have of
anything
in this project is the colors it might
help to just use the abcss
technique here to organize these so if
we highlight all of those press control
p
and then the greater than symbol and now
we might choose sort lines ascending so
now all of our colors are ordered
alphabetically and i could find them
probably much faster now that i've done
this so considering that maybe we should
do the same thing for our dark mode
we'll highlight all of those
control p
greater than symbol and choose sort
lines ascending now you're welcome to do
that for any or all of the properties
and styles that are within this project
if you so choose now before we finish
this project there's one more thing we
can add that would be a very nice touch
but it is a preview of what's to come
for you yet and that's because it's a
touch of javascript
just a little bit and i'll show you what
it does it will update the year so
it will put in the current year no
matter what year it is and you will not
have to come back and update the
copyright on your site so let's put in a
time element right here i want lowercase
so i'll give this a time with an id
attribute of
year
so there is our time element and we
don't really need to put anything in it
we'll just leave it as is
with the id of year right there now
let's go over to our file tree
and inside the file tree let's create a
js folder
and inside the js folder let's create a
new file name it main.js
now we only have a few simple lines to
put in here so i'm going to type
const which will help me define a
variable and i'm going to name that
variable year i'm going to set that
equal to document and when i refer to
document i am referring to the html
document
and then get
element by id and this will be year so
you know we just set that attribute
and then we are selecting it so we're
selecting that time element on whichever
page we load this javascript into from
there i'm going to define another
variable and i want it to be called this
year notice i'm using camelcase to
define that i'm going to set this equal
to a new
date
and then i'm going to call the get full
year method for that date so now i have
the current full year in the this year
variable
and i have the element that we just
created the time element in the year
variable so i'm going to say
year
set
attribute and then i'm going to select
date time
and i'm going to set it
to the this year variable
and then to display it on the page i
once again want that year element and
now i'm going to select the text content
that's what's displayed on the page
and set it equal to this year and save
that's all i need are these four lines
of code
and with that we can import this into
our page so we'll go back to the index
let's scroll to the top because we want
to load the javascript last after the
css
and we do that with a script tag and it
will have a source attribute and there
it is so we'll say js slash
and then we'll just pick our main js
nothing goes between the opening and
closing script tags however you have to
put it this way it always has a closing
script tag it's not like some of the
other elements that just has a slash to
close out the first one you always see
it this way we want to add one other
attribute though and that is defer and
that tells the script to wait until
everything else is loaded before
loading the javascript and we will save
now if we go back
to our page
notice it says copyright
2022 little taco shop
if you're watching this in a different
year and you add this same code it will
say whatever the current year is there
now if we go to our other pages
notice it still just says copyright
symbol in little taco shop because we
haven't added that javascript to the
other pages yet but we can do that now
so let's drag this over
and we also need to make that same
change to the footer on every page so
inside of our copyright line here that
has the span class
let's select that with the c
and then we'll go to the hours page
scroll down
and we will select the same line and
paste in the new line and save
the contact page scroll down select the
copyright line
paste in the new line and save
and we also need the about page i
believe so now let's scroll down
and here we'll select that same
copyright line
and we'll paste in the new line
but we haven't added the javascript yet
so let's go back to our index html now
we could just copy this same script line
and we can use the same javascript file
for every page so back to the hours page
paste it in underneath our style sheet
line
back to the contact page we should do
the exact same thing
and then finally the about page we
should do the exact same thing
then save and now let's once again look
at our site
and notice that no matter which page
we're on we now have the year referenced
in the footer along with our copyright
notice and everything looks
just as it should okay guys just a few
closing notes and you could call them
corrections if you want to i just want
to adjust a couple of things we're
currently on the hours page for the
little taco shop and i previously forgot
to put in an h2
for this page so i'm going to do that
here on line 48
and i'm just going to put hours in there
and save something else that's been
bothering me about this page the whole
time was the back to the top
link that we really don't need anymore
there's not enough content on this page
for it really to even be there so i'm
going to remove that
back to the top link on the hours page
other than that i'm happy with how this
page turned out of course
everything is preference when it comes
to css your design choices your
preferences may be different than mine
so feel free to make your own changes
also at the
contact.html page i previously removed
every hr the horizontal rule element but
i think i'd like to put one back here
just between the two sections on this
page or between the two articles if you
will so i'm going to put this
horizontal rule back
between those two different articles on
this one page one other thing i want to
do
is just change the text a little bit on
the buttons so i'm going to click the
file tree quickly go to the style.css
file
and here under the contact to underscore
button class
i'm just going to add a font
weight
of bold and save and now once we want
look at these buttons i just like how
they look a little bit better with the
bold font always go back and re-evaluate
your code make your own choices and of
course you don't have to agree with my
choices the best way to learn is
experiment and see how it works out for
you so that's the end of the project
congratulations you've completed a large
overhaul on the little taco shop website
and styled it with modern css
very few media queries necessary we
added a nice animation and it does work
in mobile devices as well even though we
didn't need those extra media queries so
if we go back to an iphone 6 7 and 8
style we can now see how all of this
looks in a dark mode and it is still
working
as we expect it to great job completing
the project and completing the full css
for beginners course